AGAIN. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COLBERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY HE'S
ME THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER WE'LL START WITH THAT. IN
RESPONSE TO THE COLBERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING THAT IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND HAS MADE
NECESSARY JUST MISSED THE
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH. AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. ARE POUNDS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE LA
WILL BE PARTICIPATING TO THE
USE OF A VIDEO CONFERENCE
SERVICE. FOR THE PARA
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONE THEIR
COMPUTERS. REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING
IN UNDER THE THEMSELVES WHEN
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THIS WILL
GREATLY AIDED ELIMINATING
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT
QUESTION YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE THE PROGRAM. WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THE SPEAK PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME BEFORE YOU
SPEAK. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE AN ACCESS CODE TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT'LL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST NHI<c.cyan> THE DEVICE YOU</c>
WERE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. ALL WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY BUT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION TO DO THAT. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT THE HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES TO THE PRINCE
WHO ARE JUST INTO THE USE OF
NEW ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENCE TO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HER.
WE HAVE. TWO BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. INCLUDING THE BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR ANNUAL FEE- IN YOUR
PACKETS ARE I'M ASSUMING YOURS
LIKE MINE IS A GOLDEN ROD WE
HAVE ADDED AN ADDENDUM- SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
WHICH IS TECHNICALLY NOT A
TRAILER BILL BUT IT IS A PART
OF THE OVERALL FREEWAY PARTY
AGREEMENT. FOR TODAY'S HEARING
WE WILL HEAR ALL THE BILLS
PRIOR TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT AND VOTING BLOC WE'VE
DONE PASSED COLLEAGUES WITH YOU
ALL THE BILLS HERE FROM
DEPARTMENT FINANCE LA YOU KNOW.
AND WE'LL BOTH AFTER HEARING
PUBLIC COMMENT. SUBSEQUENT TO
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD WE
WILL VOTE IN THE BILLS. BEFORE
WE GET INTO THE AGENDA ITEMS
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HERE NIELSEN. WELL VIETTEL
THERE DOLLY HER TAUGHT AT THE
DOOR ALSO HERE FOR TITLE HERE
LEYVA YOUR MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MY
NAME. MORE LUCK RESIDENT MORALE.
PAN ROTH SKINNER AIR STERN I
KASKI HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
MADAM SECRETARY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- COLLEAGUES TODAY BEFORE
US WE ARE MEETING TO TAKE
ACTION ON THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET PACKAGE THAT REPRESENTS
THE AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
THIS PACKAGE MAKES AMENDMENTS
TO AND BILLS ALL OF SB SEVENTY
FOUR WITH WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET AGREEMENT HEARD BY THIS
COMMITTEE AT OUR JUNE TWELFTH
HEARING AND PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE ON JUNE FIFTEENTH.
THIS BUDGET AGREEMENT MAINTAIN
THE NUMBER OF PRIORITIES FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
AGREEMENT INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO. FUNDING SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AT A LEVEL
THAT IS ROUGHLY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS HIGHER THAN WHAT WAS
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVIVE. IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE DRAONIAN
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES CUTS
TO EIGHTEEN PROGRAMS I HSS
EMPLOYMENT AND OTHER SERVICES
IN THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM. MEDI
CAL OPTIONAL BUT BENEFITS PROP
FIFTY SIX AM SERVICES FOR THIS
IS THE DISK THE- DISABILITY
SERVICES. IT PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS A
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR COUNTIES BY
BACK FEELING A REDUCTION IN
REALIGNMENT REVENUE. IT EXPANDS
THE E. I. T. C. TO CERTAIN- HI
TEN FILERS AND IT EXPANDS THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM BACK TO THE
SIXTY MONTHS TIME CLOCK. THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED AS A RESULT OF
WELFARE REFORM DONE BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND WHICH
EXISTED IN THE STATE PRIOR TO
THE GREAT RECESSION. LEARNING
FROM LESSONS FROM THE LAST
RECESSION IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE DON'T CUT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
RESIDENTS RELY MORE HEAVILY ON
DURING ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS.
HOWEVER WE'RE STILL GRAPPLING
WITH THE BUDGET SHORTFALL IN
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT CONTINUES
TO ANTICIPATE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS IN ORDER TO
RESTORE OR AUGMENT FUNDING FOR
CERTAIN PROGRAMS INCLUDING.
HIGHER ED THE COURT. HOUSING
AND STATE EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION.
AS SUCH WE MUST ALL CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE FOR BOTH STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS WE
CONTINUE TO DIG TO DEAL WITH
THE IMPACT. OF THE COLBERT
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC PANDEMIC. I'D LIKE TO
THANK OUR LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
IN THE GOVERNOR FOR ALL OF THE
HARD WORKING COMPROMISES THAT
WITH INTO CRAFTING THIS
BALANCED AND RESPONSIBLE
APPROACH TO BUDGETING. THIS
BUDGET IS CRITICAL IN ENSURING
FISCAL STABILITY AND CONTINUITY.
HOWEVER I RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
JOB ADDRESSING THE FISCAL
RAMIFICATIONS OF PUBLIC
NINETEEN ARE NOT OVER WE MUST
CONTINUE TO WORK ON DEVELOPING
WAYS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS AS WE MANAGE AND
EVENTUALLY OVERCOME THIS
CRISIS. WITH THAT MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN YOU HAVE COMMENTS NO.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR LET ME SEE A
BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING COLLEAGUES
ARE AS YOU SEE ARE RATHER
EXTENSIVE AGENDA. OF TWENTY
BILLS IN THE LATENESS OF THE
HOUR I'M GOING TO KIND OF
MONITOR OUR PROGRESS AS WE GET
THROUGH THIS AGENDA- WE WILL
TAKE A DINNER BREAK THIS
EVENING. I'M GOING TO SUGGEST
THAT WE TAKE IT AT SIX O'CLOCK
BUT WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW WE
ARE GOING IN THE FLOW OF OUR
BUSINESS SO I WANTED TO TELL
YOU THAT. SO YOU CAN PLAN
ACCORDINGLY DINNER IS BEING
BROUGHT IN- BUT IF IT'S NOT
RIGHT AT SIX O'CLOCK ALLAH NOW
TO JUST KIND OF LET YOU KNOW
THAT IT WILL DEPEND ON WHERE WE
ARE IN THE- ON THE AGENDA. WITH
THAT. LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
FIRST ITEM ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
A. B. EIGHTY NINE THE BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR. I'D LIKE TO NOTE
THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL
BE PRESENTING THE BILL TODAY.
AND THE LA OLD OFFICE IS
JOINING US TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. HOWEVER THE LA- WILL
NOT BE PRESENTING ON ANY OF THE
BILLS BEFORE US TODAY. THE
PRESENTATION WILL COME FROM
FINANCE. LA L. IS AVAILABLE IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO POSE A
QUESTION TO THEM. WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME MISTER THIS ONE
OFTEN FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT AB EIGHTY NINE SIR. MR
THIS ONE OFTEN YES SORRY ABOUT
THAT I JUST REALIZED I WAS
MUTED. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND HAPPY PRESENT EIGHTY EIGHTY
NINE AND I SHOULD MENTION I
HAVE A NUMBER OF. MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR
ON THE VIDEO AS WELL. AS YOU
MENTIONED WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
A PRETTY EXTENSIVE A JACK AND
US SO WE WILL DO OUR BEST TO
KEEP OUR PRESENTATIONS VERY
BRIEF BUT OF COURSE WE'RE HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM.
YOUR ANY OF THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AS WE GO ALONG.
SO THE FIRST AT BELL IS THAT
WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR WHICH IS AND AMENDMENTS
JUDY BUDGET ACT THAT WAS PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE. THIS PAST
WEEK THIS IS B EIGHTY NINE.
AND UNDER THIS BUDGET
AGREEMENT- THERE OF COURSE THE
REASON PROVISIONS IN
EXPENDITURES. WHEN YOU SOME
THEM ALL OUT- WE ARE PROJECTING
THAT TOTAL GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR UNDER
THIS VEIL- IF THE BUDGET WORLD
TO BE SIGNED. IS A HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS THE GENERAL FUND. IN
ADDITION AND WE'RE PROJECTING
THAT AT THE END OF THIS YEAR WE
WOULD STILL HAVE. RESERVES
INCLUDING TWO POINT SIX BILLION
GOING INTO THIS YEAR AND THE
SPECIAL FUNDS FOR ECONOMIC.
ECONOMIC UNCERTAIN
UNCERTAINTIES. WE ALSO HAVE
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE STATE'S. RESERVE
HAVING WITHDRAWN FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THERE. AND WE HAD AN
ADDITIONAL. POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE RAINY DAY FUND.
HAVING WITHDRAWN SEVEN POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS UNDER THE
BUDGET ACT BUT- THAT'S THE
OVERALL FRAMEWORK AND THEN THE
OTHER THING THAT I SHOULD
MENTION. IS THAT THE CHAIR
DISCUSS BRIEFLY THE COURT. THAT
MISSIONAL FEDERAL. AND UNDER
THE BUDGET. AS WELL AS THEY CAN.
SECTION LANGUAGE ASSOCIATE WITH
THAT WE PUBLISHED OF MEASURES.
IT'S WE RECEIVED FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS. IN ADDITIONAL.
FUNDS A SERIES OF CUTS THAT ARE
INCORPORATED INTO. BUDGET AS
WELL AS DEFERRALS WILL BE
RESTORED AND THIS INCLUDES. AN
EDUCATIONAL DEFERRAL ARE
DIFFERENT EXPENSES INTO THE
FOLLOWING FISCAL YEAR. IT
INCLUDES- CUTS- COMPARED TO OUR
JANUARY BUDGET FOR THE
UNIVERSITY F CALIFORNIA. AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. IT
INCLUDES- HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLAR CUT TO COURTS AND DERES
OTHER PROGRAMS. THAT ARE
INDUSTRY- RELATE. SO WE ARE
HOPING. THAT WE WILL SEE. ALL
FORTY MILLION PERCENT. BY
OCTOBER EIGHTEENTH TWENTY
TWELVE. AT AND IF. RECEIVED AN
AMOUNT THE FEDERAL. THAT IS
LESS THAN THAT AMOUNT. AND
SUMMIT. BECAUSE YOUR PARTIAL.
BASIS SO THAT'S THE. OVERALL
FREE MARK THE BUDGET BELT BUT
TO TAKE ANY. AS ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR. QUESTION FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR Y. QUE.
WHAT PLAN IF WE GET LATER OCT
FIFTH NO FIRST NOW TWO SEVEN
DECEMBER TWENTY FIFTH SOMETHING
LIKE THAT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
WITH THOSE TRIGGERS. SO
BASICALLY AT THAT POINT WE
WOULD HAVE THAT COUPLE OF
OPTIONS SO UNDER THE- BUDGET
LANGUAGE YOU ARE CORRECTED THAT
AND A CONTROLLING WHICH ONLY
APPLIES TO FIND SO SHE'S.
COVERED FIFTEEN SO AFTER THAT
BASICALLY ADDITIONAL MONEY THAT
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THERE ARE
SEVERAL OPTIONS FOR HOW YOU
COULD DEAL WITH THAT- ONE
OPTION WOULD BE IF IT LOOKS
LIKE THE FISCAL PICTURE FOR THE
YEAR AFTER THIS COMING YEAR. IS
LOOKING AT NOT AS HOPEFUL AS WE
EXPECT. THAT MONEY COULD SIMPLY
REDUCE THE DEFICIT THAT YOU
WOULD OTHERWISE BE FACING IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET AT
UP PERHAPS FISCAL YEAR IS VERY
BRIGHT AND WE MADE A LOT OF CAR
PRESS. ENTER THE RIVER I CAN
RECOVERY. MAGIC BUT THAT'S
FINDING BEING YOU FOR COOPER
YOUR PROGRAMS AND TO FINALLY IF
THERE IS AN URGENT NEED
ALTHOUGH THE LEGISLATURE'S WE
ARE SESSION I IN THOSE MONTHS
THAT YOU MENTIONED. YOU CAN
MATCH AND- YOU KNOW IT ANOTHER
CASES THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER
SESSIONS WHERE PEOPLE COME INTO
THE MANY DIFFERENT
POSSIBILITIES BUT THAT'S ALL
LONG WAY SAYS IT WOULD BE
OPTION LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR WORKING TOGETHER AND
NOTHING WOULD HAPPEN ON THE
ACTUAL. A DISH QUESTIONS. SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ARE
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES WILL MOVE
ON TO AB SEVENTY SEVEN OF THE
K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION THE
SERVICE WHEN OFTEN. YES THIS IS
THE ARMY BUS TRAILER BILL OUT
RELATED TO K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION AND I ALSO HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE JESSICA HOMES ON THE
LINE WHO CAN SPEAK TO QUESTIONS
AS WELL BUT SOME OF THE KEY
HIGHLIGHTS HERE THERE'S A LOT
IN HERE SO I'LL JUST MENTION
JUST A COUPLE POINTS. THE FIRST
IS THE OVERALL WEB THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE WHICH WE ARE
PROJECTING FOR THE COMING YEAR
SEVEN POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT'S OF COURSE
CASE FOR FOURTEEN. APPLE BUT
IT'S IN. TO NOTE. AS WE'RE
DISCUSSING EDUCATION IN THIS
BUDGET- THAT THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL SIGNS BEYOND
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
EXPENDITURES. THAT ARE
SUPPORTING DUCATION ESPECIALLY
AS WE ENTER A VERY UNCERTAIN.
WHEN IT COMES TO YOU AT SINCE
THE FALL AND THE RE OPENING OF
SCHOOLS AND MITIGATING MORNING
LOS. THIS INCLUDES FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
CORONA VIRUS FOR WE FIND THIS
WAS THE- FLEXIBLE FINDING. THAT
WE GOT FROM THE CARES ACTIVE
WHICH CALIFORNIA AT THE STATE
LEVEL WAS ALLOCATED NINE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS IT ALSO
INCLUDES OTHER FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE PROVIDED FOR FEDERAL
LEGISLATION. AND I SHOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT WHILE AT THESE
EXPENDITURES ARE FOR THE COMING
YEAR. THIS BILL ALSO INCLUDES A
COMMITMENT STARTING IN THE YEAR
AFTER THE COMING YEAR. TO
RESTORE ADDITIONAL PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT BASS FINDING A
CUMULATIVE TOTAL OF TWELVE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS. AND
THIS WOULD BE BY PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL ONE AND A HALF
PERCENT. OF STATUTORY
CORPORATION THE GENERAL FUND
REVENUE IS. YEAR HELP. OUR WE
ARE STORED BE PROP NINETY EIGHT
DAYS AND- RAY. REVENGE AT FORTY
PER. HAVE JENNA FUND A TEST
YEAR. THE ALSO. DAIRY OTHER
PRINT. FOR TO HARM FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT AS WELL AS GUIDANCE ON
ATTENDANCE AND RE OPENING- AND
WE KNOW IT'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING HOW
THAT WILL WORK. I'M JUST. HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
OVERALL BILL. IF I COULD ASK I
SEE MEMBERS IF YOU COULD- SPEAK
TO THE- ISSUE WITH. REGARD TO.
EXCEPT TERMS. NOT HAVE THE TEAM
THE SCHOOL YOU COULD YOU THAT
EXCEPT YES ME ACTUALLY TURNED
OVER TO A CHEST HOME AND SHE
IT'S TO THAT THANK. YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GO HOME
DEPARTMENT FINE. SO THE BUDGET
INCLUDES AT EIGHTY HOPE
HARMLESS ALL DESTROY. IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR
I'M TO FILL OUT AN TO USE THEIR
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY- AT IT. AS HAVING TO
TAKE OUR ATTENDANCE PROPORTION
OF. TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND WE
HEARD FROM THE LEGISLATURE THAT
THIS IS A BIG PRIORITY TO
ENSURE THAT- REGARDLESS OF WHAT
HAPPENS IN TERMS OF. COMING TO
SCHOOL NEXT YEAR THAT UNCLE HAD
A STABLE SOURCE THE FUNDING IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I'M BECAUSE
WE ARE AN A DECLINING
ENROLLMENT- SITUATION IN THE
STATE CURRENTLY- PROVIDING AN
AGING A HOLD HARMLESS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT'S LIKELY TO BE
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE- FOR
PURPOSES OF THE LCS THAT THEN
YOU HAD OTHERWISE BEEN
PROJECTING IN THAT WE'RE PAYING
VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO WHAT-
WE'RE GOING TO ENSURE THAT. I'M
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH LCS AT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND GIVEN
THAT I'M WE UNDERSTOOD THAT
THERE WAS SOME- THERE WERE SOME
BOTH AT SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT WERE-
ANTICIPATING GROWTH HOWEVER.
AND THE BUDGET THE BUDGET DOES
NOT INCLUDE LANGUAGE THAT
ALLOWS FOR THOSE- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
EIGHTY EIGHT PORTION MEANT-
RELATED TO THAT GROWTH- SIMPLY
BECAUSE- THAT COST. ABOUT YES
THAT WOULD BE VERY SIGNIFICANT
WE'RE NOT A 100% SURE. EXACTLY
HOW MUCH THAT WOULD BE WORSE
WELL I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE- WHAT FAMILIES ARE
GOING TO BE THE NEXT YEAR BUT-
IT HAS THE- POTENTIAL TO BE IN
THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. INTO THAT BUT THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IN THE
BUDGET AND THAT WAS. BEHIND IT.
THANK YOU FOR FIRST SENATOR
WHILE FOLLOWED BY SEVEN TO
NIELSEN. ON THAT LAST POINT IN
THE RESPONSE IS THERE ANY
FLEXIBILITY BUILT INTO OUR
SYSTEM GIVEN THE
UNPREDICTABILITY UNCERTAINTY
AND RATHER NOVEL SITUATION OF.
I GUESS I SELECTED THAT
INTENTIONALLY PRESENTED BY THIS
NOVEL CORONAVIRUS SITUATION
WHEN IT COMES TO EDUCATION WHAT
HAPPENS WITH RESPECT TO THOSE
CHARTERS ARE PERHAPS THE NON
CHARTER SCHOOLS THEY DO HAVE A
SPIKE. IN ENROLLMENT
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT OFFER
PERHAPS A MORE EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT- CUTTING EDGE OF
DIGITAL ONLINE A LEARNING
PROCESS THAT OF SOME PARENTS
FIND MORE ATTRACTIVE. IS OUR
SYSTEM FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO COVER
THOSE ADDITIONAL COST WHETHER
THROUGH. A MID YEAR ADJUSTMENT
OR A LOOK BACK. AND THOSE ARE
DIFFICULT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO THE LPS AFTER THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION- HOWEVER AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION DECIDED
THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDS WERE
NECESSARY- YOU KNOW. THERE
THERE WOULD BE YES CERTAINLY
THE BASED ON THE PROBABLY THE
LEGISLATURE YOU COULD GO AND
LOOK BACK AND PROVIDE- FUN- TO.
AS BOOK LEGISLATION AGENCIES
THAT HAD AN INCREASE ENROLLMENT
THAT WOULD NEED TO BE DONE-
THROUGH THE CONTEXT THAT THE
BILL WILL RESOURCES AT YOUR
THROUGH THE NORMAL BUDGET.
THANK YOU. THIRTY NIELSEN. THE.
THREE FOUR FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION ONE TIME FUNDING NOW
THAT IS TO- PROVIDE HELP FOR
THE CORONA VIRUS IMPACT. DO THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS EQUALLY
QUALIFIED TO DELVE INTO THIS
FUND. BECAUSE THEY FACE THE
SAME OBLIGATIONS AND CHALLENGES
THAT THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS DO WILL
THEY BE ABLE TO THE RECOMPENSE
TO THE BLACK FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SENATOR NIELSEN
JACKALS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ABSOLUTELY CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND- TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY NEED THAT THE
CRITERIA- BILL FOR PART PART OF
THAT FUNDING DEPENDS UPON AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION ROMAN FOR TO
THE EXTENT THEY HAVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS. ANOTHER
PART OF IT ON THE DEPENDENT
UPON MENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANT. YEAH ELIGIBILITY AND
FUNDING AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEY RECEIVE THE FUNDS THEY
WILL RECEIVE AND SOMETHING
COULD NOT PORTION. AND THEN THE
LAST PIECE IS JUST TOTAL
ALTHEA. ON ENTITLEMENT AND BE
AT ALL OF THEM WATER ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT AND THE
THROUGH. PEOPLE PART OF THAT AS
WELL YES THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
EACH PIZZA BACK MONDAY AND
THANK YOU AND ONE OTHER
QUESTION THEN. OF WHAT I'M IN
FOR. IS THAT THE DISTRICTS AND
THEY COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION- CANNOT UTILIZE
LAYOFFS. NOW IF. A PERSON NOW
IS SOME 80% I BELIEVE USED TO
BE ALWAYS ROUGH RATE ROUGH
AVERAGE OF ALL OF THESE
OBLIGATIONS THAT DISTRICTS.
HAVE WHY WOULD WE- NOT ALLOW
THEM THAT VERY IMPORTANT OPTION
THE LAYOFFS. JUST TO CLARIFY
WHAT AND IT'S IN THE BUDGET ACT
SO THERE IS A PROHIBITION ON-
LAYOFFS FOR CLASSIFIED WORKERS
THAT SPECIFICALLY WORK IN
NUTRITION CUSTODIAL AND
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES. BUT
THE BE THE AREAS THAT WE WOULD
EXPECT- THE- A GREATER NEED AND
GIVEN THE CONDITIONS A CO THAT
NINETEEN- AS WELL AS- LIKE FOR
INSTANCE IN THE IN THE-
NUTRITION SERVICES- THOSE
POSITIONS ARE GENERALLY FUNDED
THROUGH THE NUTRITION
CATEGORICAL WHICH IS NOT BEING.
A PROPOSED TO BE CREDIT THIS
TIME. IN AT THE THREE. FIVE AS
OUR- THAT PERSONNEL PICTURE
THERE IS- A SUSPENSION OF THE
AUGUST FIFTEENTH LAY OFF STATE
OR TEACHER CERTIFICATED STAFF-
BUT THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE
ADMINISTRATIVE CERTIFICATED
STAFF- THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT-
BILLING WHICH CLOSES OFF THE
NORMAL MARCH FIFTEENTH AND LAY
OUT. PETER NOTICED STATE- BUT-
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT A COMPLETE
PROHIBITION ON LAYOFF- BUT HE
DOES RECOGNIZE THAT. AND
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR TEACHERS
AND- ARE YOU KNOW WHAT THE BITE
THAT CONTENT TO BE THE MOST
VULNERABLE DURING OUR SESSION-
THAT THE- RECEIVE SOME LAUGHTER
CAPTION- DURING CC AT
NINETEEN. AND WHAT IS THE
CIRCUMSTANCE WITH DECLINING
ENROLLMENT SCHOOLS. FOR
PROTECTING FOR CERTIFICATED-
EMPLOYEES AT THERE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT HOW CAN THEY JUSTIFY.
HOLDING ON TO MORE OR STAFF.
SHE'S AN EXCELLENT QUESTION AND
I WOULD JUST RESPOND THAT AND
WE ARE HOLDING EIGHTY A
HARMLESS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SO- REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR
NOT YOU'RE YOU'RE EXPERIENCING
DECLINING ENROLLMENT YOU WILL
RECEIVE THE SAME EIGHTY EIGHT
YOU RECEIVED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY- IN ADDITION HEALTHY
AFFECTED NOT BEING REFUSED-
BEGIN TO AGREEMENT THE
LEGISLATURE TO REMOVE ANY
PRODUCTION ALTHEA THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT. A CHARTER
SCHOOL IN COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION- SHOULD BE THE SAME
ALTHEA HALF LEVEL THAT THEY
FALL IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN. I THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
AND SORT OF- FOLLOWING UP ON
CENTER ROCKS- QUESTION- SO I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT I AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
GROWING AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE SHRINKING IN TERMS OF
ENROLLMENT AND SO I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE- REASON FOR THE
HOLD HARMLESS THERE'S- THROUGH
BLACK CAST GOING BUT- THERE IS
A CHALLENGE FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS I KNOW PEOPLE
REFERRED MORE CHARTER SCHOOLS
BUT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO.
ARE AREAS WHERE THE
POPULATION'S GOING ELK GROVE
THE THOMAS THOSE TYPES OF AREAS.
THE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
STRUGGLING WITH THE FACT THAT
THEY WERE MADE SO THERE'S GOING
TO SHIFT BECAUSE A COVETED BUT
THERE WERE READY DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGES THAT WERE HAPPENING
BASED ON JUST DEVELOP THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SO CAN YOU SPEAK
TO. WHAT THE APPROACH IS FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ABOUT HOW
WE NEED TO HANDLE THIS BECAUSE
IT REALLY PUTS THEM INTO A BIND
I MEAN IF. IT DIDN'T HAPPEN
THEY WOULD STILL BE GETTING AN
INCREASE IN OUR LCF PROGRAM IS
GROUNDED ON THE MONEY FOLLOWS A
STUDENT SO. I GET IT YOU KNOW
WHICH IS A LOT OF CHAOS GOING
ON- BUT FOR. DISTRICT THAT WERE
PROJECTING AN INCREASE JUST
BECAUSE THEY KNEW THERE'S GONNA
BE GROWTH IN THEIR COMMUNITY
THAT. WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO
TO HELP THEM SO THERE'S
POSSIBLY A SPIKE BECAUSE PEOPLE
SHIFT SCHOOLS BUT ARE THINGS
BECAUSE A COVERED RELATED BUT
YEAH OF THE SCHOOLS THAT
ALREADY HAVE A NATURAL GROWTH
ARE THEY GOING TO BE PENALIZED
BECAUSE OF THIS SO IS THERE
SOME WAY WE CAN PROVIDE SOME
ADJUSTMENT FOR THE FACT IS
THERE SOMETHING THAT GOVERNOR'S
LOOKING AT PERHAPS AS WE GO
INTO OUR GUESTS ARE AND TRY TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. IRVING PRISONER CAN
AND WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN TO I'M
HAVING A CONVERSATION IN THE
SUMMER I THINK JUST TO PROVIDE-
THE CONTEXT IN THE PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION- YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT
OUR LIMITED RESOURCES- YOU KNOW
WE- WE- WE KNOW THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO BE CAUGHT. IN EIGHTY
HOLD HARMLESS AND- YOU KNOW WE-
WE WERE. AT BOB THE HOLD
HARMLESS INSURED THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE PROBABLY MOST IN
FISCAL DISTRESS AND REALLY ARE
DECLINING FULL DISTRICT
DECLINING ENROLLMENT SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE REALLY
EXPERIENCING GREATER LOCAL
PRESSURES AND THOSE THAT ARE IN
A GROWTH- TRAJECTORY- DOING
SURE THAT WE ARE- PROVIDING
WHEN WE WERE MAKING A DECISION
DO WE- INSURE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING. AND LEVEL OF
STABILITY FOR THOSE. WHO MAY
EXPERIENCE AND DECLINE IN
ENROLLMENT- OR DO YOU YOU KNOW
WE JUST KIND OF ROLE THAT I SEE
WHAT HAPPENS- YOU KNOW WITH
DECLINING ENROLLMENT FOR THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND DON'T
PROVIDE THE MANY TABILITY. BUT
THEN ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
GROWING- CAN CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE GROWTH THE NAY
ANYTHING FROM FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF AN EQUITY LINE
THAT WAS IMPORTANT FOR US. WHEN
CONSIDERING THE IDEAL HOLD
HARMLESS. TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
WHO- HAD DECLINING ENROLLMENT
HAD MORE STABLE FUNDING DURING
THIS CRISIS- UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE THERE MAY BE EVEN LESS
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR THOSE WHO
HAD- GROWING ENROLLMENT BUT
ALSO UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY
WERE LIKELY IN A BETTER
FINANCIAL- POSITION GOING INTO
THE CUP IN NINETEEN CRISIS.
THAN THEY WERE DECLINING OKAY
THANK YOU I GET THAT SO PERHAPS
MAYBE ADDED MINISTRATION CAN
HELP US OUT WITH DOING SOME
ANALYSIS AND PROVIDING US AND
DATA'S WERE GOING. INTO THE
SUMMER. THAT'S TWO BASSES CAN
WE GET SOME DATA ON WHAT WAS
THE ANTICIPATED GROWTH FOR THE
FOLLOWING YEAR AND A SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE TO DO THESE
PROJECTIONS ANYWAY FOR THEIR-
BUILDING FUNDS AND FOR OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS THAT. THOSE
THERE IS THAT CAN THAT A PART
OF EDUCATION PROVIDE US WITH.
THAT KIND OF DATA IN TERMS OF
PRE CODE OF IT OF WHAT WE WERE
EXPECTING GROWTH OR SHRINKAGE A
DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS. SO
THAT IF WITH THERE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OVER THE SUMMER
DEPENDING ON WHAT HAPPENS. THAT
WE WOULD HAVE THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AS WELL TO THE ADMINISTRATION
TO BE ABLE TO. THE POTENTIALLY
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN MOST
WIDELY DISTRIBUTED WHATEVER
FUNDS WE MIGHT HAVE AVAILABLE.
IN A WAY TO ADDRESS THIS. ISSUE
I CERTAINLY UNDER. AND IN
GENERALLY AGREE WITH WHAT YOU
SEE THAT YOU KNOW WE WANTED AND
I DON'T KNOW STRONG I DON'T
OPPOSE THE HOLD HARMLESS AT THE
MOMENT- BUT I ALSO THINK THAT
BECAUSE WE NEED TO HAVE
STABILITY FOR A SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BUT THE SAME TIME AS
WE MOVE FORWARD THERE'S OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES I WANNA BE SURE
WE HAVE THE INFORMATION TO BE
ABLE TO. THERE'S A IS. AMAZING
THAT WE DO ALSO HAVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT OF THE SUFFERING SOME
DISTRESS BECAUSE- NOT BECAUSE
THEY ACTUALLY ARE GROWING AND
YET TODAY AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
THEY HAVE TO THEY MAY EVEN
ANTICIPATED A BUDGETED FOR THE
IDEA THAT HEY EIGHTY EIGHT WAS
GONNA BE THE SAME OF WE'RE
GOING TO GROW CERTAIN RATE WILL
GET MORE MONEY AND SUDDENLY NOW
THEY FIND OUT THEY'RE SHORT.
RIGHT SO- AND HAVING THAT
INFORMATION AND UNDERSTANDING
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL FOR OUR
DECISION MAKING MOVING FORD AND
I APPRECIATED ADMINISTRATION
COULD HELP US WITH GETTING THAT
KIND OF INFORMATION. THAT AND
OF LA A ONE COMMENT ON THAT AS
WELL. HELLO I CAN GET ON WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD TO THAT BUT
WE'D BE HAPPY TO. WORK WITH YOU
IF YOU WANT DATA ABOUT- HUMMING
JUST DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
GROWING OR DECLINING. ON THE
LATEST DATA WE HAVE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
INDICATES THAT ABOUT TWO THIRDS
OF JUST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
NEGOTIATOR EXPERIENCING GROW.
EXPERIENCING DECLINES. IN ABOUT
A THIRD IT I HAD BEEN
EXPERIENCING GROSS. CRITICAL
BIG NAMES YOU AND THEN MAKE. IT
CERTAINLY MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION TERMS OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF THAT GROWTH OR-
THIS IN ROME IT IS ALSO HELPFUL
THEY SAID WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
SOME DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE.
BE ABLE TO KNOW WHAT THAT
MAGNITUDE. AS WELL AS THE
DIRECTION IS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT THANK YOU. SENATOR
MORE LAW. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I'VE JUST CURIOUS REP FOLLOWING
UP ON SENATOR PANTS LINE OF
QUESTIONING. DO WE KNOW HOW
MANY JUNE'S AGE EIGHTEEN AND
YOUNGER HAVE DIED OF CODED IN
THE LAST. THREE MONTHS. ANYONE
FROM MY FINANCE SAID THAT NAY
IS JUST A PLACE FOR NAS AND- WE
DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO US RIGHT NOW BUT
WE CAN CERTAINLY CHECK. THANK
YOU MISTER THIS ONE OF THE NINE
I'M YOU KNOW GETTING CONTEST
CONSTITUENT REQUESTS AND- YOU
KNOW GIVING SPEECHES AND
GETTING ALL THESE QUESTIONS AND
PARENTS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHEN THEIR KIDS ARE GOING TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL SO I. I'M JUST
WONDERING WHAT IS YOUR
ASSUMPTION A READ ARE WE GOING
BACK TO A FULL CURRICULUM BACK
TO SAY. THE LEAST SEPTEMBER
WHAT BUT WHAT CAN WE TELL OUR
PARENTS. YES A WHEN IT COMES TO
THAT ALTERNATIVE OVER TED
JESSICA HOLMES BUT I WILL SAY
THAT ALL- I'L MAKE TWO POINTS
IT'S AN AND JESSICA CAN SPEECH
ADDRESS. THE FIRST IS THAT A
LOT OF THOUGHT WENT INTO THAT
GUIDANCE THAT WAS ISSUED JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO WHEN IT COMES
TO THE PAST FOR WORDS FOR
SCHOOLS AND HOW THE RE OPENING
PROCESS WILL TAKE PLACE. AND
HOW WILL HAPPEN SAFELY SO I
THINK THAT'S THE FIRST POINT
THE SECOND POINT WHICH I KNOW
THAT THE GOVERNOR AND THE SIZE
EVEN IN HIS PRESS CONFERENCE
TODAY. IS EVEN IF- SOMEONE
ESPECIALLY A YOUNG PERSON WHO'S
HEALTHY IS AT A LOW RISK- FOR
ACTUALLY HAVING A DEBILITATING
IMPACT FROM KOBE TO TERMS OF ON
THEIR OWN PERSONAL HEALTH. DAY
CAN STILL SPREADING TOO MANY
OTHER PEOPLE THEY COME INTO
CONTACT WITH ESPECIALLY INTENSE
FACES SO- AND ALL THE PUBLIC
SPACE IS IT ALL THINGS THAT.
ARE THE STATE OR IS DISTRICTS
ARE OPERATING AND- YOU WANT TO
TAKE A GOOD CARE AND SO THE
GUIDANCE. AND IMPROPER TO
REFLECT THOSE SAFETY MEASURES-
AND POINTS AS THE IMPAIR THAT
YOU. SURE THAT. WE HAVE
STUDENTS ARE BACK IN SCHOOL.
POSSIBLE ME TURN IT OVER TO
JUST DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT YEAH.
THANK YOU YOU I JUST OF HOMES
DEPARTMENT OF MY- SO AND THE
BUDGETING THE DISCUSSION AS-
RENDERS AROUND DISTANCE
LEARNING IN ORDER TO EARN-
WE'RE TO ENSURE THAT THE EIGHTY
ABLE PROMOTED NOT PENALIZE FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND-
SPECIFICALLY WE POINT OUT THAT
IT CERTAINLY THE INTENTION. OF
HE AT EIGHT THAT COOL- AFTER IN
CLASSROOMS. THE LINE BUT IN
EACH AND THE BILLING WHICH IN
THE BY. BUT THE THAT. BUY THEIR
LOCAL AND STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS TO DETERMINE- WHAT-
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING IT
AND TO ENSURE HEALTHY. PERSON
FOREMOST- AND. DURING THE THEY
CAN. IN THAT GUIDANCE WITH SORT
OF DEFAULT BEING IN CLASS BUT
THE EXTENT THAT THEY CAN'T DO
THAT BY WITH HELPING SAFETY.
BUT THEY WOULD BE LOOKING OTHER
ALL. IN THE REQUEST SELL THE
REQUIRED DISTANCE LEARNING
CANCER THE QUESTION SENATOR
MARK AND LOCAL. DISTRICT BOARD
ON CHARTERS CAN YOU BUT. AND
CAN. BY ON THE MATTER ON THE
OFFERINGS AT WELL I WHEN WHO
WILL. ALSO ON ENSURE A QUALITY
EDUCATION FOR CALIFORNIA SO WE
HAVE NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA AT AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
KIND OF IN FORMING ME THAT THE
IT'S A CASE BY CASE COUNTY BY
COUNTY SITUATION. MISS HOME YES
IT IS AT. AS I SAID THAT AND
CATCHING ALLOWED AND THE
LOCALLY ELECTED SCHOOL BOARD TO
MAKE- MANY OF THOSE
DETERMINATION HOWEVER I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT- OF COURSE IN
THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS HAVE A GOOD DEAL OF
THE STORY IN THE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER HAD THE BILL OF
THE THIRTY IN THIS AS WELL SO.
THEY CAN ACTED THERE IS AN
OUTBREAK LOCALLY AND WORK WITH
OUR LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
TO DO SO TO ENSURE THE HEALTHY.
KIDS IN ON A FINAL NOTE- YOU
HAVE SEVENTY EIGHT POINTS. SB
SEVEN SEVEN BUT I DIDN'T SEE
FIX MAD IN THERE ANYWHERE THE-
FISCAL SYSTEMS MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE TEAM- MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS AND MY- DISTRICT- THEY
THERE'D. PRESSING UP THERE
TRYING TO HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
MAKE THERE JOBS. FULL AND I'M
JUST CURIOUS AT. WITH A GOOD
NUMBER OF OURS THIS IN SO. OF
THIS. DECLINE BASED ON THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORTS THEIR A ANNUAL AUDITED
FINANCIAL REPORTS- SHOULD WE BE
THINKING ABOUT FUNDING FIX MAD
A LITTLE MORE TO MAKE LOANS TO
CERTAIN SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
MAY NEED A CASH INFUSION. THANK
YOU CAN HEAR MORE LOCK AFTER
THAT QUESTION. ON THE BUDGET-
THE BUDGET OR THE BUDGET BILL
THAT WAS PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE- ON THE FIFTEENTH
AND IN AUGMENTATION TO STICK
MATT TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO BE
PROVIDING THE OUTRAGE. THAT WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL- FISCAL
DISTRESS- DISTRICTS THAT ARE.
BEING IDENTIFIED DURING THE
RECESSION OR DURING THE CURRENT
RECESSION- WE HAVE THE
EMERGENCY APPORTIONMENT INTO
THEM READY IN PLACE TO THE
STATE- FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
OUR IN. DISTRESS AND MEET THEIR
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS IN THE-
YEAR IN WHICH WE ARE IN- AND
THAT THAT HAPPENS WITH IN.
GRACE BUT NOT. NOT NOT. AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS AS STRICT AND
COUNTY OFFICES HAVE OTHER ME
TO. AND MANAGE THEIR TO FLOW
HOW MUCH IS SPECIALLY IN ANY
LIKE THIS HAVE TO. AND THEY CAN
TAKE OUT SHORT TERM CASH LOAN
AND THEY CAN ALSO BORROW
AGAINST THEIR OWN INTERNAL
FUNDS FOR YOU ON THEIR WIZARD
FOR CASUAL PURPOSES THEY HAVE
MANY OPTIONS FOR THAT AS WELL-
BUT YEAH THERE THERE ARE MANY.
AN AVENUE THAT WILL JUST BE A
CAN GO DOWN- TO HELP THEM THE
CASH FLOW AND DURING TIMES LIKE
THE- HOMES. I DO FOLLOW UP TO
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTOOD SAID YOU.
IN THE ORIGINAL BUDGET BILL WE
DID HAVE FUNDING PERFECT MATTER
JUST. THIRTEEN HERE AMOUNT IT
WAS- AMOUNT OR WAS IT JUST A-
THE PROMISED TO BE THERE. NO
THERE WAS AN AMOUNT AND THEN
THEY'RE MORE LIKE AND I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE THAT
NUMBER AT THE TOP OF MY HEAD
BUT I CAN WORK WITH YOUR STAFF
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT NUMBER IS TEN MILLION.
FIVE HUNDRED. SUMMER WHERE WILL
THE REALITY. FUNDING FOR
STAFFING- AND FEEL AGAIN I
THINK NOT AND DOES NOT PROVIDE
LOANS TO SCHOOL DISTRICT- BUT-
WE PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR THEM TO HELP PROVIDE AT.
FORTY SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
THEIR WORK TO SUPPORT WELL
DISTRICTS- BETTER EXPERIENCING
FISCAL DISTRESS. OKAY THAN ARE
APOLOGIZE. MISS HOMES I'VE
FIXED MATT WAS THE ORGANIZATION
THEY GAVE ME ALL THE SCHEDULES
OF LOANS TO DISTRICTS LIKE
OAKLAND IN OTHERS. SO ALL ALL
JUST FIGURED. THAT AB GOING
FORWARD APPRECIATE YOUR GETTING
BACK TO MY STAFF THANK YOU
MANAGER YOU'RE WELCOME SENATOR
DOLLY THE PADDLE WORK I SAW
YOU. SENATOR DOLLINGER THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. PRESENTER OF A
WHOLE HECK A LOT OF ELEVEN
MONIES IN MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACTUALLY DID A ZOOM. CALL WITH
THE SUPER DISCOURSE TONY
THURMOND- AND MAN MY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT CAME UP ON THE
CALLS WERE LIABILITY. AND I DID
I LOOK THROUGH THE BUDGET AND I
DIDN'T SEE ANY AUGMENTATION FOR
LIABILITY SO LET'S. ASSUME THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BACK TO SCHOOL-
WHICH IS A QUESTION MARK I
THINK. THEY WERE ALL TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT. A VOTE WE HAVE AN
OUTBREAK AND THEN LIABILITY
WHAT WHAT WITH THE- BOY THAT
LOOK LIKE- BECAUSE I KNOW THE
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS. ON THAT
WE SPOKE WITH THE ENERGY THE
DISTRICTS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE OBVIOUSLY IF THEY HAVE AN
OUTBREAK WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK
LIKE- FINANCIALLY FOR THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND SO I AS
THE BUDGET DOES NOT CONTAIN- AS
ANY DISCUSSION OF FISCAL
HOW TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION CAN
CAN YOU REPEAT IT. YEAH WELL MY
I GUESS MY POINT IS THAT. LET'S
SAY THAT A SCHOOL OPENS BACK UP
THEY'VE DONE EVERYTHING THEY
HELP OFFICER IN THE- THEY'VE
HAVE P. P. EASE ALL THE THINGS
THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO AND
THEY GET AN OUTBREAK. AND
THERE'S RISK IN THAT AND THEN
SOME PARENTS. SUSE I ME I IT'S
GOING TO BE I THINK IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO. TO PERSONAL KEEP
A FACE MASK ON OF FIVE YEAR
OLDER AS A YEAR OLD AND THE
WHOLE I MEAN THERE'S LOTS OF
CONCERN FROM. SCHOOL BOARDS
THAT THERE IS A HUGE LIABILITY
AND NOBODY REALLY TALKS ABOUT
THAT IT'S- IT'S THE SAME PLACE
IN BUSINESS AS WELL I KNOW THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION
YOUR BUT BUSINESSES ARE IN THE
SAME BOAT. WHETHER WHO WERE
LIABILITY LIES SOMEBODY GETS
SICK AND- THERE IS A DEATH
MAYBE EVEN AND THEN WHO'S
LIABLE THAT AND THERE'S A COST
THIS. AND DON'T TALK ABOUT. AND
BUT ARE YOU WE HEAR ABOUT IT AS
OUR SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS ARE
HAPPEN TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL ALONG WITH
OBVIOUSLY THERE- COUNCIL AND IN
THE END THERE NEAR THE PDAS AND
THE LIKES. SO YEAH SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT- AND WE CAN CERTAINLY
TAKE THAT BACK AND- AND- YOU
KNOW HELPFUL CONTACT. THANK YOU
I WAS STILL A LOSS- IMAGES
WOULD APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
REACH OUT TO MY OFFICE BECAUSE
IT I WILL SAY ON THE CALL WITH
THE YOU KNOW EIGHT COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND ALSO THE
STATE WIDE SUPERINTENDENT
MISTER BERMAN THAT WAS A
TALKING TOP BIG TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION ON ON WHETHER
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE THAT RISK
BEEN OVER FOR TRY TO CONTINUE
TO DO- SOME. SENSELESS IN AND
THEN THERE'S THE CHALLENGE AT
LEAST OUR DISTRICT THAT THERE
ARE A LOT NEAR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DON'T HAVE INTERNET
OR THE ABILITY FOR THAT TO
TRANSMIT. FOR A DISTANCE
LEARNING. THOSE ARE BIG
CHALLENGES IN AREAS WHERE YOU
HAVE. TO BUS CHILDREN BACK AND
FORTH TO SCHOOLS- ANYWAY YEAH I
JUST WANTED TO GET ON YOUR
RADAR- I KNOW THAT WHEN NOBODY
DOES TALK ABOUT LIABILITY BUT
IT'S THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM.
THAT MANY SCHOOL BOARDS ARE
GONNA BE TAKING THOSE MAKING
THOSE DECISIONS ON SO SOME- AND
THE PUBLIC WILL PAY IF THERE'S
A SUIT. WE'RE GOING TO DEFEND
YOUR SCHOOLS WHERE THE OTHER OR
THE BOARD SO THERE IS COSTA
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER DOLLY- CENTER REQUIRE
WAS YOUR QUESTION- WERE YOU
WANTING TO GO BACK TO A. B.
EIGHTY NINE IN WHICH YOUR
QUESTION ON THIS TRAILER BILL
SIR I APOLOGIZE MEDICARE YOU'RE
RIGHT I WANTED TO GO BACK AB
EIGHTY NINE FOR A QUESTION ON
ONE SECOND THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. ON AB SEVENTY SEVEN.
OKAY SEEN NONE- IF YOU ALL
WOULD MIND INDULGING SENATOR
REQUIRE AND WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO. YOU CAN'T SEE ME
SMILING AND LAUGHING BEHIND MY
MATH OF WE'RE GOING TO RETURN
TO A. B. EIGHTY NINE- THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- ALLOW MISS REQUIRED TO
POSE A QUESTION TO FINANCE AND
REQUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOU'RE PATIENTS VENTURED
MEMBERS I APOLOGIZE. YES I'M
LOOKING. AT THE ISSUE IN
REGARDS TO THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS IN REGARD TO THE
CORONAVIRUS REALLY FUNDS.
COMING IN FROM THE CARES ACCESO
A TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M
STRAIGHT AND IF DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CAN COMMENT ON WHERE
I'M GOING IN THESE NEXT WORDS
SO MY INTEREST IN IS THAT
COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO RECEIVE.
REALLY DOLLARS WILL BE ABLE TO
GET FIVE EITHER THE FINANCE-
BOULDER IS THE COPPER
DEPARTMENT OF. PLAY IN THIS IS
WELL. SINCE IF YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR A VARIANCE FOR EXAMPLE
COUNTIES WOULD NEED TO BE ABLE
TO WORK. WITH OBVIOUSLY THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER T. P. H.
BUT IF YOU COULD JUST DESCRIBE
THAT PROCESS AND HOW THAT WILL
WORK IN THE CERTIFICATION.
WOULD BE GREATLY APPRECIATED
NAY AFTER SHE'D AGAIN THE
PATIENT'S VENTURE. YES THANK
YOU SENATOR I'LL JUST MAKE A
BRIEF COMMENT IN TERMS OF HOW
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST
THINKING ABOUT IT AND THEN I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE.
KRISTIN SHELTON I THINK THE
DETERMINATION IS MADE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT
CERTAINLY IN CONSULTATION. WITH
YOU THE OTHER AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS OF GOVERNMENT
PARTICULAR. THE FASTEST. MOST
UPDATED HEALTH ADVICE AND
GUIDANCE IN TERMS OF HOW TO
DEAL WITH THE SITUATION BECAUSE
IT IS OF ALL. SO CERTAINLY-
WILD FINANCES MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION- IT'S GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH THE EXPERTS WHO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH EVERY
DAY. AS WE ADDRESS THE SPEND
DOWN NEXT THE OTHER POINT I
WANT TO MAKE IS JUST SAID
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR DID. TODAY
AND THE WAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THINKING
ABOUT THIS GUIDANCE IS IN A
SPIRIT OF COLLABORATION SO THE
GOAL HERE IS CERTAINLY NOT. TO
GO OUT THERE AND START
ANALYZING PEOPLE AND GANKING
AWAY. YOU WANT TO MAKE THIS
WORK. WE THE REASON WE ARE
PUTTING THIS IS BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT'S THE BEST WAY
GIVEN THAT SO MANY REALIGNED
AND SERVICE IS OUR DIRECT TO
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND PUBLIC
SAFETY THOSE GOALS ARE. ALIGNED
WITH MAKING AS MUCH PROGRESS I
GET DEPEND AS WE AND AS- BEST
WE CAN THAT'S- RIGHT AND- OKAY.
AT GUIDANCE AND TO. PROVISIONS
THAT YOU JUST. BUT LET ME IT
OVER TO KRISTIN SHAW. YOU
DISCUSS WELL. GOOD AFTERNOON
KRISTIN TO OF NAY ON. I'M THE
BACK ACTUALLY COVER MODE OF THE
KEY POINTS I THINK THE ONLY
THING THAT I WOULD KIND OF
EMPHASIZE A POINT TWO RELATIVE
TO THE PROCESS AS THE
CERTIFICATION- TO USE THE FUNDS
CONSISTENT WITH THE GUIDANCE
STARTS AT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LEVEL SO IT START WITH THE CITY
OR WITH THE COUNTY TO PROVIDE.
THAT CERTIFICATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THEN
BASED ON THE DOCUMENTS THAT WE
RECEIVED- WOULD CONSULT WITH
OUR AND COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
RELATIVE TO WHERE THEY ARE AND
IN THEIR PROCESS IN TERMS OF
OPENING AND COMPLIANCE PROBABLY
WOULD BE- PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
AND GATHER P. BUT I WOULD NOTE
HERE IS. THE LANGUAGE IN AND OF
ITSELF DOES NOT IMPOSE A NEW
REQUIREMENTS ON COUNTIES. ACT
AT FIVE REASON THAT ARE. OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY
EACH AS WE CAN TO COME. THANK
YOU. SO THANK YOU VERY CHAIR
AND THE CHAIR GOING BACK TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO- WOULD
BE SIMILAR TO THE PROCESS OF A
COUNTY JUANITA VARIANCE THEY
WOULD SUBMIT WHAT THEY'VE DONE
LOCALLY IN THAT PLAN WILL BE
REVIEWED BY BOTH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN CD P. H. I. N. DâN
THUMBS UP IN REGARDS A
CERTIFICATION BE GRANTED. OR
pTHAT- I DON'T WANT TO SAY THAT
THE VARIANCE PROCESS IS
INFORMAL BUT IT'S NOT AS FORMAL
AS SOME MAY THINK- IN OBVIOUSLY
ONUS IS PUT ON THE LOCALS IF
YOU JUST GIVE A LITTLE MORE
COLOR ON THAT- AND PROVIDE SOME
MORE LIGHT THAT WOULD BE GREAT
THE END OF THAT WE MY FINAL
QUESTION BUT IF YOU JUST DO A
LITTLE BIT A DEEPER DIVE ON
WHAT WOULD BE EXPECTED OF
COUNTY GOVERNMENT. A AT. THIS
THIRTY THAT I AM PLANNING AND
THE TESTING. SPONSOR ABILITY
WILL BE OUTSIDE OF THIS PROCESS
SO THAT THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
OCCUR OUTSIDE OF THE ALLOCATION
OF THE FUNDING BETWEEN THE
COUNTY AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REALLY WHAT WILL HAPPEN-
RELATIVE TO WHAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GETS AS A FAIRLY
STRAIGHTFORWARD AT THE OUTSIDE-
CERTIFICATION FORM. THAT
ESSENTIALLY. DID ADD NOTIFIES
US- FROM THE COUNTY THAT THEY
ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH DOGS
FRAUD ORDERS AND THOSE
REQUIREMENTS BEHIND THE SCENES
THERE WILL BE- PLENTY OF WORK
CERTAINLY BETWEEN THE LOCAL
INTO T. AND B. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH BUT
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD BE REVIEWING IN TERMS OF
THEIR- PLANNING RELATIVE TO RE.
OPENING HOW THEY CONTINUE TO
MONITOR DO CONTACT TRACING
EXCITED ABOUT IS REALLY LARGELY
BETWEEN THE LOCAL AND HE AND
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WHERE WE WILL CHECK IN- WITH.
PRIOR TO DOING ALLOCATIONS OF
FINDING- IT WOULD BE WHEN WE
RECEIVE THAT CERTIFICATION. AND
THEN- PROVIDING THEM A LIST OF
THOSE ENTITIES THAT HAVE
CERTIFIED AS- RELATIVE TO
VERIFYING WHERE THEY ARE IN
THEIR CURRENT PLANNING STAGES.
THANK YOU. TURNING TO SENATOR
DOLLY. I WANT TO TAKE THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SECOND DISTRICT TO
A SPUR TO THOUGHT TOWN. ABOUT
THAT FUNDING SO JUST GOING TO
GIVE YOU SOME OF THE EXPERIENCE
THAT. I HAVE DEALT WITH IN MY
DISTRICT WE HAVE A VERY
OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA'S VERY
DIVERSE AND ONE SIZE DOESN'T
ALWAYS FIT ALSO A DURING- SO I
GUESS I'M ONE OF EXPAND ON A
SYNONYM ACQUIRES QUESTION IT.
TO THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER THE COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER TO ALL THIS
GIVEN EXAMPLE MODOC COUNTY- MET
ALL THE CRITERIA. HAS TO THIS
DAY ZERO CASES OF CODE. AND A
WANTED TO- X. OPEN AND SO THEY
DID- WITHOUT THE CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTORS A
BLESSING. AND SO THEN THERE WAS
SOME PUSH BACK SO I KNOW IN
THIS BUDGET THAT IT BASICALLY
SAYS. THAT IF YOU DON'T APPLY
DAY WILL CUT YOUR FUND. MAN AND
SO WHO IS WHO IS THAT IS IT THE
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER IS THE
STATE HEALTH OFFICER WHO IS THE
PERSON THAT IS. IS GOING TO
MEET THAT CRITERIA- SO THAT
THEY SO WE CAN GET A- LOT ARE
LOCALS KNOW BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
WHAT HAPPENS IN SAN DIEGO L. A.
SAM DISCO IS A LOT DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IN MAYBE
SISKIYOU OR- MOTOR ARE DEALT.
WITH THE CENTER FROM THE SECOND
IS YOU GOT TO WHERE HE WAS
GOING AND I WON A LITTLE MORE
CLARIFICATION ON. ONE WHAT IS
THE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER- OR IS
IT THE- DAY THE HEAD OF THE
STATE AND I WOULD JUST SHARE
WITH YOU THAT. IN OUT OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. TEN
HEALTH OFFICERS HAVE RESIGNED
BECAUSE THERE ARE CONFLICTS AND
IS A VERY DIFFICULT JOB TO JOB
IN THIS DAY AND AGE. HI KRISTIN
STOCKTON FROM FINANCE. I'M I
THINK THAT IT AT THE LOCAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER BUT WILL
BE WORKING WITH STATEWIDE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND THAT'S KIND OF THE FIRST
STEP IN THIS PROCESS. I AM IN
THE EXAMPLE THAT YOU PROVIDED
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WHILE
AND- SENT INTO TEASE MAY HAVE
ADVANCED TO BEARER ADAM. RE
OPENING STRATEGIES AND MOST OF
THOSE HAVE BEEN ON BACK AND
WORKED AGAIN IN THE SPARE A
COLLABORATION. WITH THE STATE
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE PROCEDURES AND
PROCESS. PLACE TO ATTRACT
EIGHT. BUT. AND AS- OF THAT
COUNTY AND HOW SO THAT WOULD BE
KIND OF FIRST OF IN THE PROCESS
AGAIN AND WE WERE. CONTINUE TO
PURSUE- THIS THREE THAT SPIRIT
OF COOPERATION AND WORK THROUGH
ISSUES WE ARE AND TAKING ANY
MONEY AWAY. WE BASICALLY WILL
HAVE THESE CHECK INS THAT BEN
ALLOW FORM ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE TO BE DISTRIBUTED
ARE ALLOCATED TO THE COUNTY SO
THE SAYS. THIS IS THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO USE OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH PUBLIC SAFETY AND THAT
THAT MANY WILL FLOW BASED ON BE
CERTIFICATION THAT HAPPENS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND THEN WE-
CAN ARE GONNA PUBLIC HEALTH
RELATIVE. FINANCE IS. A GENERAL.
TO THE EXTENT THAT ACCOUNT I
NOT COMPLYING WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM TO GET HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND WHAT PROCEDURES
AND PROCESS THESE NEED TO BE.
PUT INTO PLACE- AS A STATE SO
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WOULD HELP WITH THAT AND THEN
AND THEN WE WOULD RESUME.
TRADING ANYTIME. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS XENON I'M GOING
TO NOW MOVE US FORWARD- TO AB
SEVENTY EIGHT THE I. BANK. MR
THIS ONE OFTEN. YES AB SEVENTY
EIGHT OUR FIRST OF THAT
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BANK AS
YOU MENTIONED KNOWN AS THE AYE
BANK AND THE MAIN THING THAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT
ESTABLISHES A CLIMATE CATALYST
REVOLVING LOAN FUND NOW UNLIKE
THE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAD MADE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY
THERE ARE WILL ANY FEDERAL
DOLLARS. THE POT. RATHER THE
HOPE IS THAT SET UP THE- WAY I
WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR MAINLY
FEDERAL DOLLARS REYES EDITION
ALL. INFRASTRUCTURE OR CLIMATE
RELATED LEGISLATION THAT MOVES
IN WASHINGTON DC OR PERHAPS
FUNDING FROM ELSEWHERE- TO BE
DEPOSITED IN THIS VEHICLE IT'S
AN ESPECIALLY ATTRACTIVE. PLACE
GIVEN THE GOALS OF THAT
LEGISLATION- AGAIN THIS
CONCORDANT WITH OUR CLIMB
GOALS- AND SO ANY FUNDING THAT
WHERE IS SHE AND CREATED SOME
RESPOND THE- MR AT IN ORDER TO
MEET CERTAIN. GOALS RELATED
GOALS ARE JOB RELATED GOALS I
WAS HELPED FROM THE LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY AS
WELL AS THEIR STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
ADVICE BUT I DO WANT TO RIP
BRACE THAT L. THIS. BILL SETS
UP A FUND FOR MONEY TO BE
RECEIVED. NOT THAT MONEY CAN
BE. CREATED WITHOUT CORRECT I
WATCHED. THANK YOU THIRTY STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- WANT TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
STICKING WITH THIS ISSUE AND
TRY AND GET THE ARCHITECTURE
RIGHT- I WOULD I WOULD SAY I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
CATEGORICALLY AS YOU GUYS START
TO DEVELOP SOME MORE REFINED
PROJECT TYPES. TO INCLUDE US IN
THAT CONVERSATION AS A WE ALL
OF AN EQUITY STAKE IN THIS
ARCHITECTURE BUT THE QUESTION
WAS REALLY ABOUT- THE SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN THORNY THAT THIS
ALSO- ENABLES I KNOW THAT
THERE'S SORT OF A CLIMB IN
INFRASTRUCTURE PEACE BUT- MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS. THAT WERE
ALSO. TRYING TO ENHANCE THE
AUTHORITY TO- DO SOME SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN ASSISTANCE HERE
IS THAT RIGHT. YES SENATOR
STERN THAT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
AYE BANK AT IN ADDITION TO THIS
CLIMATE CATALYST FINE REVOLVING
SIGNED THEY'RE ALSO PROVISIONS
THAT BUILDING ON SOME OF THE
SPENDING THAT TOOK PLACE
EARLIER THIS SPRING- TO A SAYS
SMALL BUSINESSES AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE PART BY
DEPEND ON A CRUISE FOR A NUMBER
OF REASONS. MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO ACCESS THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM OR OTHER
RELATED FEDERAL PROGRAM SO
BASICALLY AT YOUR POINT THE
BUDGET INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR IMPROVING ACCESS TO. ALL
FROM US MEDIATION AND I'LL
CLICK CALLIN MY COLLEAGUE IDEA
LAST YEAR ON THE LINE AS WELL
HE BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO
SOMEBODY. INTER OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. IS THINKING
ABOUT. BUDGET FOR YOUR- ON THE
IF AS THE PIECE OF LAB
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS TRAILER
BILL IS RELATED TO AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S IN THE BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR QUIRK. AM I BEING
TOO EITHER DIRECTLY OR WORK
WITH A THIRD PARTY TO SET UP A
FIRST LOSS PROGRAM THAT WILL
HELP- BE A RECOVERY PRODUCT
WERE SMALL BUSINESSES. AND SO
THE AND THE PEACETHAT IS IN
THIS TRAILER. THANK YOU FOR THE
FEEDBACK- YEAH I KNOW THERE'S
NO FUNDS APPROPRIATED IN THAT
EITHER BUT- THINK THAT'S A
CRITICAL AREA FOCUS GOING
FORWARD AND LOOK FOR TO STAY
ENGAGE IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS
THANK. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCCARTHY. I I'M A LITTLE LOST
HERE BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY HAVE
BEEN DEALT WITH ANY COMIC
CATALYSTS LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD WE HAD AN IDEA FROM THE
JANUARY BUDGET SO I WOULD HOPE
WELL THEY'RE SITTING MARKET
TEXTURE I WOULD I WOULD ALMOST
SINCE THIS THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE LEGISLATIVE PEERING SO
THAT WE KNOW. IF MONEY IS
APPROPRIATED WHAT WHAT IS STILL
JUST YOUR IDEAS OF WHAT ARE
APPROPRIATE CLIMATE CATALYSTS
IDEA IS AND WHAT ARE THE
CRITERIA THAT WE WILL SAID- BUT
I DID AT THE BE A KERN WE-
START APPROPRIATE FUNDS THIS
IDEA. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER.
THREE TO LEYVA THANK YOU MADAM
BUT CHAIR I WOULD JUST PUT IN A
PLUG TO SEND LIKE HEALTH HIS
POINT THAT WHEN WE DO HAVE
FUNDING- THROUGH THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL WE FULLY FUND
THE TCC PROGRAM WHICH HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY HELPFUL UP THE STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELL
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS WILL MOVE ON TO AB
SEVENTY NINE HUMAN SERVICES
OMNIBUS TRAILER BILL. AB
SEVENTY NINE COVERS A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AREAS FOR WAY TOO
HUMAN SERVICES I WILL JUST
TOUCH ON A COUPLE BUT THEN OF
COURSE WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ON ANY OF THAT- FIRST
BASED ON A NUMBER OF
DISCUSSIONS WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE COMMITTEE-
THIS BILL PROPOSES TO EXTEND
OUT WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE TIME
CLOCK FOR CAL. ASSISTANCE YES
SIXTY MONTHS WITH THE MAXIMUM
ALLOWED UNDER FEDERAL LAW I
DON'T MANAGE RESEARCH A CENTER
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS AND THIS
TAKE A- TWENTY. TWO LIKELY TO.
ON WHEN. CAN BE UPDATE TO
ACCOUNT THIS. THIS BILL ALSO
REFLECTS A- CHANGE THAT WAS
FIRST PROPOSED IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET. THE INCREASE THE CHILD
SUPPORT PASSED THROUGH AND CAL
WORKS CURRENTLY IT'S FIFTY
DOLLARS UNDER CURRENT LAW. AND
IS AB RACED OUT TO ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS OR SOMEONE THAT IS
JUST. IT HAS MORE THAN ONE
CHILD. TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
THE CHILD SUPPORT PASSED
THROUGH. IT ALSO INCLUDES SOME
SIMPLIFICATIONS TO COUNTERACT
SAYS THEM. AND THEIR VARIOUS
OTHER PROVISIONS HERE RELATED
TO. US YES IT'S TO THE FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE JUST. AND
SEVERAL OTHER HUMAN SERVICES.
PROVISIONS SO HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANYTHING IN THE
SPELLING ACCESS COLLEAGUES ON
THE LINE. SPECIALIZE IN THESE
PROGRAMS AS WELL. THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS MEMBERS. BACK TO PAN.
THANK YOU MAY CHAIR I JUST WANT
TO- THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE BE
SURE THAT WE DON'T MAKE CUTS TO
THESE VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
AT A PREVIOUS HEARING OF THIS
VERY COMMITTEE. WE DID A
CHALLENGE- THE GOVERNOR AND
TERMS OF SAYING THAT WE SHOULD
BE SUPPORTING PROGRAMS THAT
KEEP. AT RISK PEOPLE OUT OF THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT WOULD PUT
THEM AT GREATER RISK. YEAH
WE'RE FACING A PANDEMIC WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THROUGH
THAT LENS AS WELL. AS SOME
PLEASED TO HEAR ABOUT THE- BE
ABLE TO NOT CUT AYE HSS THE
PROGRAM TO KEEP PEOPLE AGAIN
OUT OF INSTITUTIONS THAT BILL
PROTECT OTHER PROGRAMS FOR THE
AGED BUT ALSO TRYING TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES. AS THEY
ARE. BEING PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED BY THE ECONOMIC ISSUES
RELATED TO CO BID- PEOPLE ON
CAL WORKS- PEOPLE GEN GET THEIR
CAL FRESH. AND OF COURSE OUR
DAD PEOPLE WITH THE
DISABILITIES THE SERVICES THAT
THEY GET AS WELL SO I JUST
WANTED. THAT MAKE THIS COMMENT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT- I DON'T
WANT IT TO GO TO. PASS WITHOUT.
TAKING THE GOVERNOR CAN WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND ACHIEVING
THESE VERY IMPORTANT AIMS THAT
WILL PROTECT PEOPLE. THROUGH
COVE ED IS WE- LOOK THROUGH
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS. CENTER TOGGLE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO I'M
DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE OF THAT
THIRD PARTY AGREEMENT REJECTING
CUTS TO SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAMS- LIKED EMESIS P.
PROGRAM SEA BASS AND- AS WELL
AS I ASSESS ARE ALSO SENIOR
NUTRITION I'M ALSO PLEASED TO
SEE THAT THE FUNDING WAS
PROTECTED- THERE FOR OUR
SENIORS AND A LOT OF OTHER
ISSUES AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE.
JUST CAN STRUM MENTAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S AT THE MOMENT SO I
APPRECIATE THE A TO BE MANAGED
AND- ACROSS THE THREE PARTY
AGREEMENT. AND I. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. CHECK THAT
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR JUST QUICK QUESTION OF
WHAT WAS THE THOUGHT BEHIND
EXPANDING THE SIXTY MONTHS OUT
INTO TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR THE
CAL WORKS WE WOULD HAVE A
BUDGET CYCLE IN BETWEEN AND
THE- YOU KNOW WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE CON MEDIA LOOK LIKE AT
THAT POINT. GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER ONE OFTEN. YES I'LL JUST
SPEAK VERY BRIEFLY AND THEN I
HAVE TYLER WOODS ON THE LINE AS
WELL- OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT- WITH THE PROGRAM AT THE
SIDES THERE ARE A NUMBER AT THE
MINISTRATION AT THANKS FOR
MASON TECHNOLOGIES AND RELATED
ISSUES GIVEN THE SIZE AND
COMPLEXITY OF THIS PROGRAM.
THAT WOULDN'T ALLOW. IT WOULD
TAKE SOME TIME TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES SO THAT THE REFLECTED
FOR ALL RECIPIENTS BUT LET ME
TURN IT OVER TO TYLER. I
SENATOR THAT'S CORRECT AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED THAT THE
COMMITMENT TO MAKING THIS
POLICY CHANGE WOULD NEED TO BE
MADE WELL IN ADVANCE BECAUSE OF
THE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
ISSUES IN THE TIME REQUIRED TO
MAKE THIS POLICY CHANGE. IN
THOSE AUTOMATION SYSTEMS SO
THAT IT'S UP AND RUNNING. DO
YOU HAVE DO YOU HAVE A-
ESTIMATE OF WHAT IT WOULD COST
IF IT WAS IMPLEMENTED TODAY. I
DON'T HAVE A COST ON HAND FOR
WHAT WOULD COSTS TODAY BUT I
THINK THE GENERAL THINKING AND
WHY WE DON'T HAVE THAT COST
ESTIMATE IS THAT- THERE WOULD
BE SIGNIFICANT MANUAL WORK
AROUNDS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND
IT WOULD INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF ERRORS FOR WE TO
TURN. THIS POLICY CHANGE ON
WITHOUT HAVING IT AUTOMATED
FIRST. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT THE QUESTION WITH THE
DOLLAR BECAUSE I THINK WHEN-
WE- REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
BECAUSE IT WAS SIXTY WEEKS
AFTER THE PASSAGE OF. FEDERAL
WELFARE REFORM I THINK WHEN WE
CUT IT IN THE BUDGET TO FORTY
EIGHT I DON'T KNOW THE WE HAD
THE LEAD TIME SO I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION. I WISH IT WERE
SOONER BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THE AUTOMATION CHALLENGES SO
THANK YOU FOR RAISING THE ISSUE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SIX MORE COMMENT I WANTED TO
ALSO THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
BUT OUR TWO HOUSES FOR A NUMBER
OF THE ITEMS IN HERE GIVEN THE-
ENDEMIC INDUCED ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN AND- CAN KNOWING WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT WHO LOST JOBS IT
WAS OUR LOWEST WAGE WORKERS WHO
LOST JOBS. I WAS VERY GLAD TO
SEE THE- WORK TO TRY TO ASSIST
BECAUSE WE KNOW MANY MORE
PEOPLE ARE NEEDING CAL FOR US
FOR EXAMPLE- AND WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE ON CAL WORKS MAY HAVE A
MORE TO MORE DIFFICULT TIME.
TRYING TO- SECURE THE TYPE OF
EMPLOYMENT THAT'S REQUIRED AND
I JUST REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT WE IN THIS BUDGET ARE
DRESSING- PROVIDING
APPROPRIATE- BOTH ASSISTANCE
AND- PROCESS EASE TO- SO MANY
PEOPLE IN A THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA YOU'VE REALLY BEEN
IMPACTED AND THERE'S MANY
ELEMENTS OF THIS PARTICULAR
BILL. THAT WILL REALLY HELP-
OUR FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. OKAY FIFTEEN NON
LET'S MOVE ON TO AB AT THE
HEALTH TRAILER BILL MISTER
WILSON OFTEN. YES AB AT IS SET
ANOTHER BIG DEL- RELATED TO
HEALTH- COVERING NUMBER GIPSON
PROVISIONS IN THE HEALTH AREA
I'LL JUST MENTION A COUPLE OF
KEY POINTS THE FIRST IS RELATED
TO A NUMBER OF THE DRUG PRICE-
PROPOSALS THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAD- RACIALLY INTRODUCED IN
JANUARY- THIS INCLUDES
PROVIDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO. NEGOTIATE TRUCK
CRISIS THAT INCLUDING ON BEHALF
OF NINE MEDI CAL RECIPIENTS AS
WELL AS A NUMBER OF OTHER
PROVISIONS TO HELP BRING DOWN
OR REDUCE THE GROWTH IN THE
COST OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
THERE ARE ALSO SEVERAL
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
OVERWEIGHT STRENGTHENING ADD
THE MEDI CAL RESPONSE TO CODE
NINETEEN AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL LINED UP WITH THE
LATEST THAT WE HAVE HEARD. FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THAT
DIRECTION TO MAXIMIZE THAT
POSSIBLE REIMBURSEMENT RECEIVED
THROUGH THAT FEDERAL MEDICAID
MEDICARE MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
PERCENTAGE OTHER FEDERAL
MATCHES MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE ALL THE DOLLARS THAT WE
CAN. THIS HEALTH CRISIS. THERE%
ARE SEVERAL OTHER PROVISIONS OF
THIS- I WILL MENTION TO KNOW
IT'S JUST WHEN IT COMES TO THE
STRUCTURE OF OUR OVERALL BUDGET
THE FIRST IS REGARD.
PROPOSITION HE SAID WHICH I
KNOW. THE SIX AND THE UPCOMING
TWENTY TWENTY DASH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE SCHOOL YEAR-
BUT THE BUDGET DOES INCLUDE-
SUSPENSIONS UP MOST OF THAT
FUNDING. FOR PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF VALUE
BASED PAYMENTS AND SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS TO PROVIDERS ON JULY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
UNLESS THERE ARE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES IN THE BUDGET- TO
REDUCE YET RIVER THOSE BACK TO
THE WAY THEY ARE RIGHT NOW. AND
THEN THE SECOND NOTE BECAUSE I
KNOW IT'S ALSO BEEN A
DISCUSSION WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. IS REGARDING-
THAT PROPOSED EXPANSION OF THE
GOVERNOR HAD IN JANUARY FOR A
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AT AGE SIXTY FIVE
DEPOSITS FOR MEDI CAL. THIS
BILL SIZES THAT'S NOT INCLUDED
DIRECTLY IN THIS BUDGET- BUT
THAT PROPOSAL WOULD BE
PRIORITIZED IF WE DID HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES OVER THE
MULTI YEAR FORECAST BUDGET
WINDOW. IN ORDER TO FUND THAT
PROGRAMS THAT SO THOSE ARE A
COUPLE OF THE KEY PROVISIONS
I'VE GOT RYAN MILLER MY
COLLEAGUES FLAWS WAS WELL
SEVERAL OTHERS ON THE LINE. AND
RAPIDLY TAKING QUESTIONS THANK.
YOU QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THREE TO PAY FOLLOW BY
SENATOR NIELSEN. I THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH I DO. OF WANT TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR AT
LEAST- FOR ONE YEAR- TRYING
MAINTAIN THE PROPERTY SIX-
STRUCTURE AND FOR- NOT TO.
IMPOSING CUTS ON PEOPLE WITH.
REGARDING ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE- ESPECIALLY DURING A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. WHEN WE
ACTUALLY NEED PEOPLE TO GET
GREATER ACCESS- MAY NOT HAVE
DONE AS FAR AS WE'D LIKE TO BUT
AT. LEAST WE WEREN'T- CUTTING-
OPTIONAL BENEFITS MANY OTHER
SERVICES. I DO HOPE THAT WHILE
THIS IS IN THE BUDGET FOR
PLANNING FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO REVISIT THIS VERY ISSUE I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING YET AND
BUDGET SUB THREE. REGARDING A
PROPERTY SIX BE SURE WE
MAINTAIN THOSE REVISIONS
AROUND. VALUE BASED PAYMENTS
AND SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
FISHER PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
ACCESS. PURPOSES THE BASE
PAYMENTS OF US TO MAKE MEDI CAL
MORE. COST EFFECTIVE. TO
PROVIDE THE RIGHT KIND OF
INCENTIVES I THINK WE'LL BE
SHORT SIGHTED FOR US TO CUT
DAD'S THE FEW. BUT THAT WILL A
TO. NECK YOU AND THE NEXT POLLS.
IN THE MEANTIME I DO APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT WAS DONE DAY AT.
FROM BOTH LET'S LEADERS AND
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZING. WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS. DONE TO TRY TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CONTINUE
HAVE ACCESS TO THROUGH THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM. FOR HEALTH
CARE NOW WITH FOR THE WORKING
OF THE GOVERNOR AND- FOR
SITTING OUT FURTHER REFORMS A
MEDI CAL INCLUDING CAL AIM OF
WHICH I KNOW HOW TO BE DEFERRED
I WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
WAIVERS. AND THEN OF COURSE-
CONTINUING THAT PROPERTY SIX
STRUCTURE BEYOND JUST COMING
BUDGET YEAR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THIRTY NIELSEN. THIRTY
NIELSEN. ONE OF THE PROVISIONS
HERE IS BE REQUESTING. NUMEROUS
THE BEST OF MORE INFORMATION
FROM HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS
AND PROVIDERS THEY HAVE TO
SUBMIT ALL OF THIS EXTRA DATA.
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE FOR THAT
DATA AND AS YOU ARE TO RECEIVE
IT HOW IT'S AN APARTMENT GOING
TO HANDLE. THE DATA HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO EVALUATE IT STORY AND
WHAT PURPOSE IS IT INTENDED TO
BE USED. SO I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE- RYAN MILLER-
THEY MAY- IF YOU COULD CLARIFY-
WHICH THAT PROVISION YOU'RE
REFERRING TO SPECIFICALLY
ALTHOUGH MY COLLEAGUE BRIAN MAY
HAVE A SPECIFIC SENSE WELL A-
IT APPARENTLY IS. REQUIRING OF
THESE PLANS AT ALL TO SUBMIT A
LOT MORE DATA TO THE DEPARTMENT.
ABOUT THE POPULATION WHAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING FOR. I WOULD
IMAGINE THE DEMOGRAPHICS-
HEALTH ISSUES THE THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO BE REPORTING ON
I'M WONDERING WHY WE NEED THAT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IS AT
TO- YOU KNOW TO PURGE THE ROLES
OR SOMETHING OR OR- WHY WERE
YOU NEEDING THAT INFORMATION
AND IF IT IS COMING IN FROM THE
FIELD THIS VAST. ARRAY OF
INFORMATION. HOW WILL YOU
DEPARTMENT BE ABLE TO HANDLE
AND THEY HAVE A PLAN FOR
HANDLING- COLLECTING
DISSEMINATING EVALUATING ALL OF
THIS NEW VAST ROUTE RESERVOIR
OF INFORMATION. YEAH THANK YOU
CENTER RYAN MILLER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO AS
YOU MAY BE AWARE A FEW YEARS
AGO- RECENT BUDGET ALLOCATED
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
GENERAL FUND- TO. BUILD OUT
WHAT'S KNOWN AS A HEALTH CARE
PAYMENTS DATABASE OR AND ALL
YOUR DATABASE- AND SO THIS
BUDGET TRAILER BILL MAKE SOME
CHANGES THAT WILL. ALTER MY CAR
LEON MOST WHO CAN PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL AND SPECIFICALLY ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION. WE ARE ALMOST OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO.
ARE AS MY COLLEAGUE JUST
MENTION THIS BILL FOLLOWS AB
EIGHTEEN KIND- WHICH WAS PASSED
COUPLE YEARS AGO- THE PURPOSE
OF COLLECTING THE DATA IS TO
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF THE
QUALITY AND THE PAYMENTS THAT
ARE OCCURRING IN THE HEALTH
CARE INDUSTRY CURRENTLY. THERE
ARE NUMBER OF CONFIDENTIALITY
CLAUSES TO PROTECT THE-
INFORMATION AND THERE'S ALSO-
CONTROLLED ACCESS FROM THE
PUBLIC- FOR QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS. I CAN IMAGINE HAVE
A HIP A NIGHTMARE. WITH THIS
INFORMATION- AND THAT CAUSES
MUSED SOMEWHAT QUESTION THE
NEED FOR DEMANDING IT. SURE SO
THERE THERE'S CURRENTLY AND I.
T. PROJECT GOING ON THAT'S
GOING THROUGH THE- PROJECT
APPROVED BOTH LIFECYCLE OF TO
BE ABLE TO COLLECT- ALL OF THE
STATE AS YOU MENTIONED IT IS A
VAST AMOUNT OF DATA AND WE ARE
PREPARING TO BE ABLE TO COLLECT
THAT- BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU. THIRTY DORADO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ON I MEANT TO
SAY THIS- EARLIER BUT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
MADAM CHAIR- IN THIS WHOLE
BUDGET PROCESS- THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT THE OUTCOME IS
DIFFERENT TODAY BECAUSE OF THE
CHANGE IN THE APPROACH THAT
WAS. THAT WAS TAKEN THANK YOU
AND ARE PRO TAMAN OUR
LEADERSHIP- FOR TAKING THAT
APPROACH AND SHOWING THAT
THERE'S A DIFFERENT WAY OF
DOING THINGS. BUT I AM OUR
RIGHTS TO EXPRESS MY CONCERN
AND ACTUALLY MY FRUSTRATION
WITH THE INTENT LANGUAGE
PROPOSE FOR EXPANDING MEDICAID
ALL FOR UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS OF
THE PROPOSED CRITERIA TO
IMPLEMENT THE EXPANSION. IS TO
BE VERY DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE
ANYTIME IN THE NEAR FUTURE AND
I'M NOT SURE. EVER. SO WHAT DO
I SAY TO. OLDER CALIFORNIANS
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND OF
THEM BUT WHAT I SAY TO THEM
WHEN THEY ASK ME THAT THEIR
INCOME LEVELS SIXTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS. FOR LESS. WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO GET ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE PREVENTATIVE CARE
PRIMARY CARE. I UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT HAD TO
BE MADE ON THIS BUDGET DUE TO
OUR OUR- OF HANDLING AND THE
WAY WHAT WHAT WE HAD TO DO IS
CALL BUT NINETEEN. THIS
LANGUAGE IS A SECOND WALK BACK.
FROM THE COMMITMENT THAT HAD
BEEN MADE. IN JANUARY. THE
MEDICALLY FRAGILE AND
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY- IN
THE STATE ARE STILL THERE. WE
WERE TAKING A STEP BY STEP AND
THAT TOOK PATIENTS ON
EVERYBODY'S PART- FIRST ZERO
TWO EIGHTEEN IN THE NINETEEN TO
TWENTY SIX AND- AS- I KNOW AS
MUCH AS WE ALL MANY OF US
SESSIONS A WEEK BUT MANY OF US.
REALLY WANTED TO TAKE THE NEXT
STEP SOONER WERE. UNDERSTANDING
OF THIS BUDGET AND THE TO SEE A
TAKEN TO TWENTY TWO OR TWENTY
THREE BUT THIS LANGUAGE HERE IS
VERY CONFUSING- ARM AND I DON'T
I DON'T SEE I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING IN IT THAT GIVES ME
HOPE THAT WILL HAPPEN. THE
PANDEMIC IS NOT SON LATE OF
GOING AWAY. IT'LL BE HERE THIS
YEAR NEXT YEAR OFF AND OTHER
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE
ARE COMING IN THE FLU SEASON
AND- OTHER REASONS. COULD WE
HAVE TRIMMED ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM SIXTY FIVE LINE
ITEMS. I THINK SO. WITH THAT
I'VE HEARD ANY DEPARTMENT OR
BUREAU. I DON'T THINK SO I
REALLY EXPECTED THAT WE WERE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD IN A MUCH
MORE EXPLICIT WAY BUT- I THANK
EVERYBODY WORKED HARD ON THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR
MINING. SENATOR PAN I THANK YOU
AYE MANAGER FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON
NASSER NIELSEN'S- QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS- I KNOW THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON A WHAT SOME
PEOPLE TERM THE ALL PAYERS
CLAIM DATABASE- CO ED BASICALLY
DATA COLLECTION TO ALLOW US TO
HAVE A BETTER HANDLE ON HOW WE
ARE SPEND YOUR HEALTHCARE
DOLLAR NOT ONLY MEDI CAL BUT IN
OTHER WE AS A WELL THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN DONE BY
OTHER STATES. I KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR INITIAL PROPOSED IN
JANUARY IN OFFICE AFFORDABILITY
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF
OUR BUDGET SITUATION AND
COVERED- IT WE'RE NOT DANCING
THIS YEAR BUT- CERTAINLY. WANT
TO. SAY THAT WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT BUT- ALSO
APPRECIATE STERN NIELSEN
RAISING SOME OF THE ISSUES
REGARDING THAT- WE THIS DATA IS
COLLECTED IN A WAY AND STORED
IN A WAY THAT MAINTAINS THE
CONFIDENTIALITY WHICH I'M SURE
WILL BE- BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT I KNOW THE WORKING ON
GOING BASIS FOR MANY YEARS-
THAT WOULD. PROVIDE POTENTIALLY
GREAT BENEFIT AND US BEING ABLE
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN
BETTER MANAGE OUR HEALTHCARE
COSTS. PARTICULARLY INCLUDING
THE STATE AND WE SPENT A LOT OF
MONEY ON HEALTH CARE SO- IT'S
WANTED TO TOUCH ON THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATOR
BAIL. OF THANK YOU MEASURE AYE
AYE I NOTICE THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE OF FURTHER. NEGOTIATION
ON STATES. FEDERAL WAIVER
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT LIMóN
FIFTEEN WAIVER AND- WE'RE
ASKING FOR LIKE A ONE YEAR. ONE
YEAR EXTENSION. I THINK NOW IS
THE TIME TO START TALKING ABOUT.
NEW EXPANDED- IDEAS. THERE ARE
TWO OF WE NEED TO HAVE DUE TO
THE EXPERIENCES WERE ALL GOING
THROUGH WITH THIS VIRUS IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC HEALTH AT
INCLUDED AS A PREVENTIVE
PROGRAMS IN THE WAIVER. ONE
THING SPECIFICALLY. I THINK
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE.
DISCUSSED IN THE WAIVER IS- IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH AREA IS THE
PEER SUPPORT. SERVICES
AGREEMENT I WANT TO FIND OUT
WOULD THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDER DISCUSSING IN THE
WAIVER- MENTAL HEALTH PEER
SUPPORT SERVICES- AS PART OF
THE WAIVER AGREEMENT. I SENATOR
BELLAMY TURN IT OVER TO RIGHT
NOW ARE AS WELL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION SENATOR- I THINK
ANY YEAH WE KNOW THAT THE
TRAILER BILL BEFORE US DOES NOT
I DON'T THINK CONTAIN
PROVISIONS RELATED TO THAT
WAIVER ALTHOUGH YOU ARE CORRECT
WE ARE ARE- SEEKING AN
EXTENSION I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WILL HAVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR OFFICE ON.
AFTER THE HEARING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE WITH REGARD TO
THIS TRAILER BILL LET IS MOVE
ON TO. AB AT ONE QUALITY
ASSURANCE FEE MR THIS ONE OFTEN.
YES SIR THAT AS YOU MENTION
ADAM CHAIR AT THAT KEY ELEMENT
IN EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE EXTENDS
WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE CLOCK FOR
THE QUALITY ASSURANCE SPEAK ON
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES IT
ALSO PROMOTED SAID NUMBER OF
QUALITY MEASURES AND
COMPLIANCE- WITH CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS FOR THESE NURSING
FACILITIES AND THEN FINALLY I
SHOULD MENTION INCLUDES A
COUPLE PROVISIONS RELATED TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
AND RELATED SPENDING. BY
COUNTIES- ONE OF WHICH IS TO
SUSPEND FOR VERSION- THOSE
SIGNS OUR UNSCENTED COUNTY
LEVELS UNTIL JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND NEXT YEAR
SO THOSE ARE PROVISIONS IN A
COUPLE DIFFERENT AREAS AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS. THIRTY
STERN. GO TO SENATOR STERN YEAH
THANK YOU. THAT ONLY GETTING
AHEAD OF OUR SUB CHAIR HERE BUT
I DID HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT.
SPECIFICALLY HOW THE QUALITY IN
A COUNT ABILITY SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT SYSTEM IS GONNA WORK
AND I KNOW WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF ISSUES IN OUR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY SPACE
SPECIALLY THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC- WHERE- THERE'D BEEN
SOME QUESTIONABLE PRACTICES
EMPLOYED. AND SERVICE IN SHORT
CUTS EMPLOYED AT THE AT THE
EXPENSE OF BOTH WORKERS-
WORKING IN THE SNIFFS AS WELL
AS THE CLIENTS- WHO ARE THERE
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO GET A
SENSE OF HOW THIS. IS TRUE WILL
WELL SIR TO IMPACT THE OVERALL
INCENTIVE STRUCTURE WITHIN THE
SNIFF SPACE. YES SENATOR STERN
DEFINITELY MONITORING THIS
ISSUE CLOAKS LANE WHAT BE
TURNED OVER TO RIGHT NOW ARE
TED DISCUSS THAT AS WELL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTIONS UNDER-
RYAN OTHER PARKING FINANCE- AS
YOU MAY KNOW IN JANUARY WE HAD
A PROPOSAL THAT WOULD HAVE
CHANGED NURSING FACILITY
FINANCE AND WE HAD A NUMBER OF
REFORMS RELATED TO QUALITY. I
THINK THAT BECAUSE OF HOW GOOD
NINETEEN AND THE IMPACTS ON YOU
KNOW THE NURSING FACILITIES AND
ALSO WORKERS IN THIS AREA- WE
NOW HAVE A PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
TO EXTEND THE CURRENT QUALITY.
SYSTEM AND- AND RATE SYSTEM- SO
WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY MAKING
CHANGES TO THE TO THE QUALITY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS ARE COSTS. PROGRAM BUT
I HAVE OF MY CALLING JACOB LAMB
HERE WHO MAY BE ABLE TO
PROVIDES MORE DETAIL IF YOU.
OBJECT ONE PART OF FINANCE ARE
WE JUST NOTE THAT THE- TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT YOU ARE
CONSIDERING TODAY CONTAINS
PROVISIONS SAYING THAT. NURSING
FACILITIES MUST COMPLY WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND
CODE MEDICATION PLANS PUT
FORWARD BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC. HEALTH AND WITH THAT WE
ARE HOPING THAT OF. REQUIRING
THEM TO COMPLY WITH THESE OF
MITIGATION PLANS WILL. IS
CENTER LAW. BY THE THEM TO
RECEIVE THE COSTA. I QUESTION
THE NATURE MY QUESTION- WAS
REALLY ABOUT. IT MAY NOT BE A
PARTICULARLY WITHIN THE COST
FRAMEWORK WITH. THE MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS THAT THERE'S
ED ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE TO. E.
BRINGING IN TO POST ACUTE
FACILITIES- COVE A POSITIVE
PATIENTS UNDER THE CURRENT
REIMBURSEMENT FRAMEWORK. IS
THAT IS THAT STILL THE CASE.
BUT YOU GET A DID YOU GET MORE
FUNDING UNDER YOUR MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT IF YOU BRING
SOMEONE IN POST ACUTE CARE.
WITH WITH THAT CONDITION VERSES
WITHOUT. THAT IS NOT MY
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE
PAYMENTS ARE CURRENT ONLY
STRUCTURED- WE DO HAVE A 10%
INCREASE FOR REIMBURSEMENT
RATES TO SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY JUST FOR THE DURATION
OF THE FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. BUT THAT IS A RATE
INCREASE FOR ALL SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES REGARDLESS
OF THE- CONDITIONS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY ARE
SERVING IN THE SPECIAL PLEASE I
AM NOT AWARE OF ANY SPECIFIC
PAYMENT THAT INCREASE. PAYMENTS
FOR PATIENTS WHO ARE
SPECIFICALLY DIAGNOSED WITH
KOBE. OKAY THANK YOU. THIRTY
PAN I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
FIRST OF ALL- APPRECIATE THAT-
I MEAN THIS FUNDING THAT WILL
GAME FOR QUITE PRUDENT FEE IS
TO DRAW DOWN MORE MEDI CAL
MONEY FOR OUR- FACILITIES BUT I
WOULD ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT-
THERE ARE CERTAINLY CHALLENGES-
FOR. OUR THERE'S A FACILITIES
WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT THE
NEED TO TRY TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS
THAT KEEP PEOPLE FROM HAVING TO
BE INSTITUTIONALIZED BUT THE
FOR THE ONES WHO ARE- WE KNOW
THAT ABOUT CALIFORNIA AT LEAST.
RECENTLY AT LEAST 5050% OF OUR
CALVET DEATH SAID HAPPENED
AMONG RESIDENTS OF THESE
FACILITIES. SO THERE IS NEED
FOR MORE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
BE SURE THEY HAVE ADEQUATELY
DETER HAVE INCREASED EXPENSES
AS WELL SO CERTAINLY THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT PART. THIS QUITE
SURE AND SPEED TO TRY TO DRAW
DOWN MORE FUNDS FOR THESE
FACILITIES BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
DO A BETTER JOB IN TERMS OF-
INSPECTIONS AND- BE SURE THAT
WE THE THESE FACILITIES ARE UP
TO SNUFF- IN TERMS OF- THE
SUPPORTS AND ALSO FUNDING FOR
STAFF AND- PP AND SO FORTH SO I
JUST. WANNA MAKE MENTION OF
THAT I KNOW THE COUPLE THE PART
OF HEALTH IS. AS CERTAINLY.
NEED TO DRESS AND W. DID HAVE A
HEARING OF THE- PANDEMIC
PREPAREDNESS COMMITTEE ON THIS
VERY ISSUE BUT CERTAINLY NEED
TO CONTINUE TO FOLLOW UP-
FORTIES UP THROUGH IS NOT ABLE
TO DO AS MUCH OVERSIGHT OVER
THIS ISSUE THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF
BECAUSE OF IT BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION WITH CITY PH ABOUT
THE INSPECTIONS AND- WHAT'S
BEING DONE TO BE SURE THAT THAT
WE KEEP PEOPLE SAFE AND
FACILITIES I ALSO WANT TO
FOLLOW UP BECAUSE OF PORTION OF
THIS ALSO HAS TO DO WITH THE-
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT. FUNDS AS WELL. AND
SO WE ARE GETTING MORE
FLEXIBILITY THE COUNTIES- BUT
I. I HOPE THAT- THERE'S GOING
TO BE WITH THAT ACCOUNTABILITY
AND- NOW EVERYONE IS PROJECTING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
GREATER NEEDS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
AS A RESULT OF COVETED. SO IS A
SEE THAT THERE'S MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND GIVING COUNTIES
AN OPPORTUNITY NOT TO HAVE TO
EXPEND OR RESERVES. THAT THERE
IS AN EXPECTATION IN MY MIND
AND I. FINANCES THOUGHTS AS
WELL THAT WE EXPECT COUNTIES TO
BE USING THESE FUNDS TO PROVIDE
THOSE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR PEOPLE WERE EXPECTING A
GREATER DEMAND FOR THEM-
ACCIDENT SHOULD BE REFLECTED IN
THE LEVEL SERVICE COUNTIES ARE
GONNA BE PROVIDING- WITH THESE
FUNDS ARE. AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT
COLLEAGUES FINA LET'S
TRANSITION TO AB AT TO GENERAL
GOVERNMENT MISTER THIS ONE
OFTEN. EIGHTY EIGHTY TWO REFERS
TO A COUPLE DIFFERENT ISSUES-
RELATED TO STATE GOVERNMENT
I'LL JUST MENTION THREE OF THE
CHANGES THERE IN VERY DIFFERENT
AREAS THE FIRST RELATES TECH
CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT AND
SHIFTING INVESTIGATORS FROM THE
DIVISION OF INVESTIGATIONS THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
WITHIN DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. THE SECOND RELATES TO
BROADBAND WHICH I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A SUBJECT OF DISCUSSION
BOTH FOR THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE LEGISLATURE IT TURNS OUT
THAT AT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THROUGH THE FCC HAS A TWENTY
BILLION DOLLAR OUR FEDERAL
RURAL DIGITAL OPPORTUNITY
SIGNED BY TO INCREASE BROADBAND
ADOPTION ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES AND IT'S DISTRIBUTED
THROUGH COMPETITIVE GRANTS. SO
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS IT
WOULD UPDATE THE PROVISIONS ACT
THAT CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND- AND ABLE TO THE
CITY TO BETTER COMPETE FOR
THESE GRANDSON MAY BE SCRAPPED
FUNDS BY ALLOWING THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION PROVIDE
MATCHING FUNDS FOR THIS FINE.
AND THEN FINALLY A THIRD
PROVISION RELATES TO THE SALES
TAX PROVISIONS FOR USED CARS
THAT WERE AT AN ACT- THAT WERE
UP PASSED BY BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE- EARLIER THIS MONTH
AND EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE- AND
THIS BILL INCLUDES A COUPLE OF
CLEAN UP PROVISIONS FOR WEIGHT.
AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS. CENA WITH-
MOVE ON TO A. B. EIGHTY THREE
HOUSING THE SERVICEMAN OFTEN.
AB AT TREE TOUCHES ON A NUMBER
OF ISSUES NOT RIGHT EXCUSE ME
EXCUSE ME MISTER DALI I MISSED
YOU I APOLOGIZE LET'S GO BACK
TO THE PREVIOUS TRAILER BILL
MISTER DALI THANK YOU MANAGER
SORRY I. I'M WEIGH EVEN THOUGH
YOU WERE WAY THAT I MISSED YOU
MY FAULT SO JUST A QUICK.
COUPLE QUESTIONS ON THE SITE I
WAS OF. WE WORKED ON THE CAST
OF FUNDS A COUPLE YEARS AGO AND
I KNOW THAT TIME YOU'RE TENDING
TO LEVERAGE THE FEDERAL FUNDS.
IS THERE'S TECHNICAL STATE OF
ASSISTANCE FOR APPLYING FOR
BOTH THE FEDERAL AND THE STATE
ARE THEY GONNA BE COMBINED.
UNDER THE PC. SO I BELIEVE- AND
I SHOULD PROBABLY- I NEED TO
CHECK THE DETAILS ON THIS I
BELIEVE THAT WHAT THIS BILL IS
DOING IS IT MAKING IT EASIER-
WHEN WE ARE APPLYING FOR THE
FEDERAL FUNDS. TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE MATCHING FUNDS THROUGH
THE ADVANCED SERVICES FUND BUT
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE ACTUAL
GRANT APPLICATIONS FOR THE
DIFFERENT SOURCES ARE POOL
TOGETHER IT'S MORE THAT HOW THE
FUNDS TO BE STACKED ON. TOP
EACH OTHER FOR A GIVEN
APPLICATION IS MADE EASIER
SERVICE FOR OUR BILLS BUT I'M
HAPPY THAT. IT GETS MORE DETAIL
ON THAT FOR YOUR OFFICE. OKAY
PROJECT THAT THEN I HAVE ONE
OTHER QUESTION ON THE- THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS THE
ENTREPRENEUR MICROGRAMS FOR
IMMIGRANTS- IF SO IF I WAS
IMMINENT HOW TO HOW TO ACCESS
THAT PROGRAM WHAT. STATE
AGENCY- PROVIDES THIS SERVICE
FOR. FOR IMMIGRANTS. SO I THINK
THERE ARE THERE ARE NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS THAT PROVIDE A
IMMIGRANTS SERVICES- I BELIEVE
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
SEED- PROGRAM AND THIS WILL BE
A NEW FOR PROGRAM AND SOURCE OF
FUNDING. HOW THAT APPLICATION
PROCESS I WOULD ACTUALLY WORK-
I ALSO NEED TO GO BACK AND
CHECK ON THAT ALSO- THESE LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS. ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WHO WHAT WHAT. A WHAT'S STATUS
DO YOU HAVE TO HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO APPLY FOR THESE GRANTS AYE
I'M- A CONFUSED ON HOW IF YOU
IF YOU'RE HERE ILLEGAL HOW YOU
WOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR
THESE GRANTS IF THEY'RE WHAT
WHAT AGENCY THAT WOULD BE. GOT
IT LET ME TURN IT OVER TO CHRIS
CUT BECAUSE ON THE LINE AND YOU
CAN SPEAK TO THAT. YES THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO. THE
SEED PROGRAM IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE ADMINISTERED THROUGH
THE LABOR AGENCY- THEY ARE THEY
ARE GOING TO BE UTILIZING THE
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT THEY HAVE.
OUT IN THE IN THE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THE LABOR AGENCIES
THAT THEY HAVE OUT THERE- AND
IT IS PRIMARILY IT'S PRIMARILY
TARGETED FOR THOSE ON DOCKS BUT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS BUT
EVERYONE IN THE COMMUNITY WILL
BE OF THAT ELIGIBLE FOR THESE
FUNDS AND IT'S INTENDED TO.
PROVIDE AS SMALL GRANTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
IN THE COMMUNITY TO ARE. TO
PROVIDE THEM THE RESOURCES AND
THE TRAINING NECESSARY TO
BECOME BUSINESS OWNERS FOR
THEMSELVES RIGHT I UNDERSTAND
SO IN THE FIRST SENATE DISTRICT
IF THERE WAS. UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS WHERE WOULD THEY GO
IN MY DISTRICT TO FIND THIS
SERVICE IS AT WHAT'S A GUY
APPARENTLY THERE'S NOT A STATE
AGENCY THAT ACTUALLY IT'S NOT
LIKE YOU WOULD GO TO THE E. D.
D. OR TO THE- WHERE WOULD YOU
GO WHAT WHAT PHYSICAL PLACE
WOULD ONE OF THESE PEOPLE GO-
IF THEY WANTED TO. TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS TEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S IN THIS BUDGET.
YEAH I CAN GET I THINK I CAN
GET BACK WITH YOUR OFFICE ON
THE SPECIFICS BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S
LOCAL EDUCATION- OFFICES IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT CAN DOWN PROVIDE
THE SERVICES THE PORTS FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS. AND THEY CAN
APPLY THERE FOR THOSE FOR THOSE
AND THOSE GRANT OPPORTUNITIES.
OKAY I WOULD I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT HOPEFULLY
BEFORE TOMORROW- AND ACTUALLY
IN MY DISTRICT I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHERE THIS PLACE IS IN SENATE
DISTRICT ONE PLEASE. WE'LL
FOLLOW UP. APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION AND YOUR CONCERN FOR
MAKING SURE THE UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS YOU DISTRICT HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT RESOURCE THANK
YOU SENATOR DOLLY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE
COLLEAGUES WE WILL MOVE ON. AB
EIGHTY THREE HOUSING. YES
EIGHTY EIGHTY THREE IS- TRAILER
BILL RELATED TO BOTH HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS AND I WILL
MENTION THREE OF THE PROVISIONS
UP FIRST IS RELATED TO NATIONAL
MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT AND MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE MAY REMEMBER
THIS FROM BUT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
OR EVEN LAST YEAR IN THE SUMMER
AND FALL WHEN WE WERE
DISCUSSING THIS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND INITIALLY THE
IDEA HAD BEEN TO PUT THIS MONEY
INTO IT TRUSTS. OW THE
PROPOSAL THAT IS BEFORE YOU IS
TO DEDICATE OUT OF THE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TOTAL ON THAT IS
REQUIRED ASKING THE COURT TO BE
SPENT- CHECKS MILLION. A
HOUSING COUNSELING. AND IT
SHOULD BE CAL A- HOUSING
FINANCE EIGHT NINE IT'S
AGENCIES I'M AND THEN THE
BALANCE THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD GO TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. AND THAT
WOULD BE FOR PROGRAMS LIKE
OBJECTION DEFENSE IN OTHER
RENTER. IT'S SO THAT'S ONE
ELEMENT A SECOND IMPORTANT
ELEMENT OF THIS BILL IS THE-
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS AND NOW THEY JUST.
AREAS OF THE OVERALL BY PACKAGE
THAT HELP COMBAT. WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY A PRIORITY IN THE
TIME THAT CALLED IT IN THE
NEEDS FOR. PHYSICAL DISTANCE
CHANGE- BUT HERE INCLUDES THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED. ACCORDING
TO THE HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION ALSO KNOWN AS HAPPY-
THAT FORMULA A HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD GO TO THE
BIG THIRTEEN. EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD GO TO COUNTIES
AND NINETY BILLION DOLLARS.
HERE I SUGGEST AS WHAT
HAPPENED- YOU SEE AN ALLOCATION
AMONG THOSE THREE DIFFERENT
GROUPS- AND THEN YEAH AND I
SHOULD MENTION THAT FOR ALL
THAT SPENDING AND ALL OVER
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS. THERE IS
AN EMPHASIS- INCLUDING
MISSPELLED ON REGIONAL
COORDINATION. ACTION THEN THE
LAST PART OF THIS BILL THAT I
LIKE TO MENTION IS THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT PROVIDED FOR
PROJECTS FROM TEACH- WHICH AT
THE STATE HAS SECURED HOUSING
UNITS. FOR OVER TEN THOUSAND-
INDIVIDUALS ON AND THE BILL
ALSO INCLUDES RELATED TEMPORARY
SEQUEL EXCEPTION IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN ACQUIRE IT
SECURE REYES ME HOUSING UNITS
AS POSSIBLE WHILE WE'RE DEALING
WITH THIS CRISIS. MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT FINO QUESTIONS. THIRTY
NIELSEN. IF I'M A THIS. GIVES
THE DIRECTOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES SOME AUTHORITY
TO SWAP EXCESS PROPERTIES WHAT
THEY WOULD DEEM STATE ACCESS
ROPERTY WOULD LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
I'VE ALWAYS WARY OF ACCORDING
ANY AGENCY MORE AUTHORITY THIS
COULD BE A MATTER OF- MUTUAL
BENEFIT BUT- THE DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES HAS A LOT OF
POWER AND I'M WORRIED THAT.
THROUGH THIS YEAR A AND IN THE
AREA OF A HOMELESS HOUSING AND
THE LOCATION THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD BE ABLE TO
SUCH A SWAY. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO DO CERTAIN THINGS THAT THEY
DECIDE SHOULD BE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND OVERRIDE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WHAT ARE THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WE WOULD HAVE
HERE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
THESE FLOCK DEALS AT AT THE AT
THE ORDERS OF ONE OF THE STEPS
IN THE PROCEDURES. BY WHICH TO
SWAP IS CONSUMMATED THE THEY
HAVE TO HAVE A GOOD MUTUAL
AGREEMENT TO AND A CONTRACTOR
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE.
CENTER NIELSEN LET ME TURN THAT
OVER TO YOU CHRIS **** WHO CAN
DISCUSS THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION CENTER
NIELSEN SO TYPICALLY WHAT WE'RE
ENVISIONING THIS PROCESS TO
INTEL IS REALLY THIS IS. A
PROCESS THAT WOULD BE ACTUALLY
INITIATED BY THE LOCALS BECAUSE
THE STATE DOESN'T HAVE- ACCESS
TO A LOT OF THE ACCESS STATE
LANDS THAT THE LOCALS HAVE- AND
SO HOW WE'RE VISION IN THIS
WORKING JUST AT A VERY HIGH
LEVEL IS ONE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND- THE A-
CONVERSATION. THE STATE TO
POTENTIALLY- PROPOSED TO SWAP
THESE LAND- THESE PIECES OF
LAND- ASSESSMENTS ON THE
PROPERTIES BOTH BY. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND- BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES-
THEY WILL CONDUCT THEIR CONDUCT
A REVIEW AND DO THEIR DUE
DILIGENCE ON THE PROPOSED
PROPERTIES- AND THEN USING THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER. AT
SIX THANKS FOR THE SCREENING
CRITERIA KIND OF TRY TO MAKE
SOME OF THE PAYMENTS THERE TO
ASSESS THE SIGHTS TO SEE IF
EITHER. STATE LANDS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SWAP WITH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THEN FROM
THERE IT WILL BE A NEGOTIATION
BETWEEN BOTH STATE AND- THE LAW.
GOVERNMENTS TO. YOU KNOW THE
STATUS TE INTEREST. AND THE
TIME FRAMES FOR WHICH WE WILL
BE DOING THAT AND THEN ASSUMING
THAT WE GOT. FURTHER DOWN THE
ROAD FOR THOSE LANCE WALKS TO
TAKE PLACE THEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES WITH AN
ISSUE A NOTICE. TO THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDING A THIRTY
DAY NOTICE AND GIVING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS.
AND TO- WEIGH IN ON THE
POTENTIAL LAND SWAPS AND THEN
FROM THERE- AS THE TRANSACTION
WALKER. THANK YOU THAT'S
HELPFUL AND YOU HAD A GOOD
COMMAND OF THOSE STEPS THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS. SEE
NONE WILL MOVE ON TO A. B.
EIGHTY FOUR CAL STARS CALPERS
SERVICEMEN OFTEN. AB EIGHTY
FOUR INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PROVISIONS RELATED TO
BOTH CALPERS AND CAL STARS AND
SOME OF THEM DATE BACK TO
FUNDING THAT WAS ORIGINALLY
ALLOCATED AS PART OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET OUR- LAST YEAR
AT THE FIRST THAT'LL MENTION IS
THAT AS PART OF THAT BUDGET
AGREEMENT- AT THE STATE HAD
PLANNED TO ALLOCATE AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS AND SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
TO CALPERS THESE WILL BE
PAYMENTS. ABOVE AND BEYOND-
WHAT'S THE ACTUAR AWAY REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTIONS UNDER THIS-
TRAILER BILL THIS WILL NO
LONGER BE MAKING THAT EXTRA
PAYMENT GIVEN THE FISCAL
PRESSURES THAT THE STATE IS
UNDER- AND WE NEED TO MAKE MEET
ITS COMMITMENTS TODAY. IN
ADDITION TO THAT BY KID
ALLOCATED AN EXTRA TWO AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS AND WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS CREDIT BACK A
MINUTE TO HELP OFFSET THE
PAYMENTS OF THE STATE WOULD
OTHERWISE HAVE TO MAKE IN BOTH
THE BUDGET. AND THE YEAR AFTER
BUDGET SO WE CAN NOT IN THE
SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE THING THAT THIS BILL DOES
GIVEN SOME OF THE PRESSURES
THAT HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED IN THE
COMMITTEE TODAY WITH REGARD TO
OUR SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL FUNDING
IS A PROVIDE BASED ON WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING THREE POINT THREE
DAHLE IN BOTH HERS. RELEASED
FIRST DISTRICT AND ALLOWS TO
APPLY I TO PAY MAYES THE NEXT
THREE YEARS DAY BYE BYE IT JUST
ROLE WE MORE MEDIA GIVEN
COMPRESSORS BUT THE SCHOOL THIS
ARE ON AS WELL I AND THIS IS
ALSO A CO WITH THE ONE YOU FREE
IN CAL STIRS AT RATE- THAT THE
STATE WOULD PAY IN TERMS AT
THAT RATE TO THE CAL STIRS
SYSTEM I SHOULD ADD HOWEVER
THAT UNDER PROPOSITION TWO THE
STATE IS CONTINUING TO MAKE
SUPPLEMENTARY PAYMENTS-
CASTERS. AND THEN THE FINAL
POINT AT AT THIS BILL HAS IS IT
ALLOWS- ALLOWANCES FOR THE
PERSONAL WEEK PROGRAMS TO
REFLECT- SAVINGS ARRANGEMENTS I
KNOW WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT
BARGAINING- LATER IN THE
AGENDA- BUT I SHOULD MENTION
THAT THAT. THAT BILL WELL.
THIRTY MORE LAW. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MISTER RESPOND THE
FUND- DARN- ARE PREPAYMENT OF
SIX BILLION- THAT MOVE DIDN'T
TAKE LONG TO GET PULLED BACK
IT'S- VERY UNFORTUNATE HI I'M-
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT I'VE
BEEN READING ABOUT CALPERS- AND
THEIR- CHIEF INVESTMENT OFFICER
AT THE LAST. FEW WEEKS. HE
INTENDS TO. BORROW A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF MONEY TO
INVEST. IN PRIVATE EQUITIES AND
OUR ARM I'M WONDERING IF SIR IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE FOLLOWING
THAT- I JUST WANNA. REMIND YOU
THAT ORANGE COUNTY FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY PROTECTION BECAUSE
IT BORROWED TO INVEST. AND I
I'M JUST WONDERING IF PERHAPS
CALPERS IS. TAKING EXTREMELY
UNNECESSARY HIGH RISKS TO TRY
TO. ACHIEVE A 7% RATE OF RETURN
AND I. I'M JUST CURIOUS OF IF
YOU HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW
THAT- AND WHAT YOU YOU MIGHT BE
THINKING ABOUT THAT- PROPOSAL.
YES SENATOR MORE A LOT SO WE
DON'T WHILE OF COURSE FOLLOWING
AT NEWS IN DIFFERENT
SUGGESTIONS AND PROPOSALS I
FINANCE WE DON'T REALLY- WAY
AND ON THE SPECIFIC INVESTMENT
STRATEGY- THAT CALPERS OR CAL
STIRS. IS MAKING WOULD
CALLOUSED WE SAID ACCESS ON THE
BOARD BUT NOT SO CALPERS I'M SO
I CAN'T REALLY OFFER ANY
COMMENT BEYOND TO SAY THAT WE
CERTAINLY FOLLOW THE NEWS IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE DIFFERENT
PORTS ARE PROPOSING. THEN MAYBE
JUST. TO GIVE A LITTLE FREE
ADVICE- WE TALK ABOUT CALPERS
ON OCCASION HERE AND WE WISH
HIM TO PUT A LOT OF BLAME ON.
BANKING INSTITUTIONS FOR THE
GREAT RECESSION. ARE ALSO KNOWN
AS THE BIG SHORT. BUT AT THAT
TIME CALPERS HAD BORROWED A LOT
OF MONEY TO INVEST IN REAL
ESTATE. AND REAL ESTATE PRICES
DROPPED DRAMATICALLY AND THEY
HAD TO. UNLOAD A LOT OF THESE
ARRANGEMENTS AND RECOGNIZE
SIGNIFICANT LOSSES. SO CALPERS
IN RECENT HISTORY HAS A- HAS AT
LEAST ONE. MASSIVE LOSS IN WE
CAN'T JUST ASSUME THAT
TAXPAYERS ARE GONNA. MAKE UP
THOSE LOSSES BY FORCING THE
STATE TO MAKE HIGHER
CONTRIBUTIONS AND FOR FUTURE
YEARS IF THOSE. GAMBLES IF I
COULD USE THAT TERM- DON'T
DON'T PAY OFF SO I WOULD I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO
KEEP AN EYE ON IT SO THAT. WE
DON'T COME BACK HERE WITH A
WHOLE DIFFERENT SET OF
PROBLEMS. THANK YOU MISTER
VISWANATHA THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS. SENATOR MORALE. YES
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO JUST.
PIGGY BACK ON WHAT SENATOR MORE
LACKEY SAID I AM TOO CONCERNED
ABOUT CALPERS BE IN ON THAT
COMMITTEE AND- THERE'S BEEN
SOME OTHER THINGS TOO- THE
GENTLEMAN WHO I THINKS AHEAD OF
A CALPERS. TRIED SHORTING THE
MARKET LAST YEAR IN ANY POLL
OUT EARLY AND IF HE WOULDN'T
HAVE DONE THAT THEY WERE MADE
ABOUT A 13100% RETURN ON OUR
MONEY SO IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THAT'S AN ORGANIZATION AND
CONTINUES TO MAKE. ONE A STEAK
AFTER THE OTHER. AND LET MY
RETIREMENTS NINE CALPERS THANK
YOU. WELL AS A NEW MEMBER THE
LEGISLATURE DOESN'T HAVE A
RETIREMENT AT ALL I GUESS YOU
YOU YOU'RE GOING TO BETTER THAN
ME. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. ANY
OTHER. ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE
LET'S MOVE ON TO AB EIGHTY
EIGHT PUBLIC SAFETY. THE
ELEMENT OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
BELL OF THAT PROBABLY RECEIVE
THAT THE MOST ATTENTION ARE THE
RESULTED FROM THE MOST
DISCUSSED SOME OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS REGARDING BE
PRISON CLOSURE IS THAT THE-
GOVERNOR PROPOSED- IN THE NAY
REVISION AND WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND SO UNDER THIS
TRAILER BILL- DE AT STATE WOULD
BE OBLIGATED THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD BE OBLIGATED TO IDENTIFY.
FIRST PRISON FOR CLOSURE BY
JANUARY TENTH OF NEXT YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND A SECOND
PRISON FOR CLOSURE BY JANUARY
TENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
THEN THE PROCESS WILL CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD AFTER THAT THIS
IS OF COURSE. TRENDS THE PLAN-
CAN'T TO CLOSE TO STATE OWNED
CHRISTIANS OVER THE MULTI YEAR
FORECAST. SO THAT'S ONE MAJOR
ELEMENT OUT THIS BILL- THIS
BILL ALSO INCLUDES A- WHAT'S
UNDERSTAND THE BOX BUT A
PROVISIONS FOR. POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS PSYCHOLOGIST-
REGARDING WHETHER THEY CAN
INQUIRE ABOUT CRIMINAL HISTORY
OF ANY OF HEIR APPLICANTS
DURING THE APPLICATION PROCESS.
IT ALSO INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
OTHER PROVISIONS INCLUDING
EXPANDING THE ABILITIES FROM A
COURT APPEARANCES AND ALSO WITH
REGARD TO PAROLE WHICH I KNOW
IT'S BEEN. ANOTHER BIG ITEM OF
DISCUSSION WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHING A NEW MAXIMUM TERM
FOR PAROLE FOR MOST OF FACTORS
COMING FROM STATE PRISON. HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. SINCE
MEMBERS. THIRTY NIELSEN LET ME
JUST TELL THEM MISTER VERSION
NOT THE NOT GOING TO BE VERY
ACTIVELY UP PUBLISHING THAT
FROM. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
FIRST CENTER MELENDEZ. THANK
YOU I HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT-
WHAT APPEARS. IS IN THIS BILL
WHICH SHOULD BE A POLICY BILL
NOT IS REGARDING THE BANNING OF
A NEW CLASS OF FIRE ARM. I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT ON THAT
BECAUSE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING I
DON'T KNOW THAT THIS FARM IS
EVEN AVAILABLE. IN CALIFORNIA
AT THIS POINT. YES CENTER
MELENDEZ LET ME TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE- IT'S GOING TO BE
EITHER ERIN EDWARDS OR CLINT
CALLUM US LET ME TURN OVER TO
CLICK CALLUM AND THAT HE MAY
TURN IT OVER CARING TO OFFER
THE DETAILS ON THAT QUESTION
FOR THAT FIREARMS. REGULATIONS
IN THIS BILL. THE CALENDAR
PERMITTED FINANCE YEAH ACTUALLY
ERIN EDWARDS IS THAT THE
APPROPRIATE PERSON DISCUSSES
COMPONENT. HI ERIN AND WORKS
WITH THE PRIVATE A FINANCE-
THANK YOU- SENATOR FOR THAT
QUESTION- SO THE LANGUAGE IS
DESIGNED TO CLOSE WHAT IS
CURRENTLY A LOOPHOLE IN STATE
LAW. THERE ARE CLASSES- FIRE OR
DID YOU NOT FALL. NEATLY INTO
ONE OF THE EXISTING- CATEGORIES
FOR FIREARMS THAT ARE- THAT THE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO REGULATE
UNDERSTAND LAW- WHICH ARE
RIFLES- SHOT ONES- STALLS- THE
THESE ARE A RELATIVELY NEW-
TYPE OF FIREARMS- I CAN'T SPEAK
TO THE. AVAILABILITY CURRENTLY
IN THE STATE BUT- IT IS IN OUR
VIEW A LOOPHOLE THAT NEEDS TO
BE CLOSED- BECAUSE THESE
WEAPONS- ARE SIMILAR TO ASSAULT
WEAPONS- IN CAN POSE A
SIGNIFICANT. THREAT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY AND SO THAT IS WHY WE
LEAVE INCLUDED THIS- LANGUAGE
AND ARNOLD SELLABLE TO CLOSE
THAT THAT WILL CALL SOON AS
POSSIBLE. OKAY WELL I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND- WE HAVE A
DIFFERENCE IN OPINION ON.
IDEOLOGY HERE BUT THIS IS A
POLICY MATTER THIS IS IN A
BUDGET MATTER SO WHY IS IT IN
THIS TRAILER BALLOTS THIS IS.
THIS IS A BRAND NEW POLICY. SO
SURE SO I HAPPEN TO SPEAK TO
THAT AND THE REASON THAT IT'S
IN- TRAILER BILL IS BECAUSE
THERE IS FUNDING IN THIS
BUDGET- FOR THE- DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO DEVELOP AND ENFORCE
THESE REGULATORY OF THIS NEW
RECORD THESE NEW REGULATORY
MEASURES ON THESE FIREARMS AND
SO IT IS THERE IS AN ACCESS TO
THE BUDGET. THIRTY NIELSEN. BY
SENATOR ROCK. MADAM CHAIR I DO
HAVE TO FOLLOW UP ON THIS WHEN
I FOUND OUT ABOUT THIS LAST
NIGHT I WAS VERY OFFENDED. AND
ANGRY. TOO OFTEN NOW. MAJOR
POLICY IS SLIPPED IN TO THE
BUDGET AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE I FIND
YOUR REASONING VERY DEFICIENT.
AND FROM THE STANDPOINT OF THE
ARROGANCE TO SAY WELL THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE JUST WANT TO
DO AND THAT'S A DANGEROUS AND-
IF I DON'T EVEN AGREE WITH THAT.
BUT THE POINT IS CIRCUMVENTING
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. THIS
IS REPREHENSIBLE IN MY SIGNAL
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AT THE HORSESHOE IS THIS IS NOT
THE WAY TO DO BUSINESS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. JUST BECAUSE YOU
CAN GET AWAY WITH THAT MAYBE
AND GET THE VOTES. IT'S A GREAT
DISSERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHO DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THESE GAMES BEING PLAYED
IN THE DARK OF NIGHT. SENATOR
OFF. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
FINANCE I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE
YOU A LECTURE ABOUT POLICY IN
BUDGET BILLS BECAUSE- HAVING
BEEN HERE EIGHT YEARS IT SEEMS
IF WE LIKE POLICY IT'S OKAY AND
IF WE DON'T IT'S NOT BUT WHEN
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES ENGAGE
IN THE- IN POLICY INITIATIVE
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS. IN
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARINGS I DO
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO TREAT
IT LIKE A POLICY COMMITTEE IN A
POLICY DISCUSSION. AND PROVIDE
A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL. ON
THE POLICY ISSUES AND I HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH THAT THE COMING UP A
LITTLE LATER IN THE AGENDA- BUT
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE I'D
LIKE SOMEONE TO EXPLAIN TO ME
EXACTLY WHAT THESE WEAPONS ARE.
AND CALL AND REFERRING TO THEM
AS SIMILAR TO ASSAULT. WEAPONS
FRANKLY DOESN'T CUT IT FOR ME
SO THIS IS A POLICY ISSUE
YOU'RE ASKING US TO VOTE ON IT.
SOMEONE STEP UP AND TELL ME
WHAT EXACTLY THIS IS BECAUSE I
TRIED TO FIGURE IT OUT MYSELF
THE OTHER NIGHT. ANY TAKERS
FINANCE. ALTERNATE OVER BACK
TAILORED EDWARDS. SERVICE
CENTER I THINK WE WILL HAVE
MIGHT HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
IN TERMS OF THE SPECIFIC
DETAILS- THE- AND- THE WAY THE
LINE WHICH I THINK IS WHAT IT
IS TO CRITICALLY- DEFINED
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE
FIREARM- IN SO REALLY GETS DOWN
TO I THINK SOME FAIRLY
TECHNICAL DETAILS ABOUT HOW THE
FIREARMS DESIGNED- AND I THINK
I WOULD NEED TO. GET BACK TO
YOU WITH THE SPECIFIC DETAILS I
DON'T OUT OF TURN TRIPS NOT
HAVING ALL THE VERY SPECIFIC
NUANCES OF WHO SHOULD WE JUST
PUT THIS TRAILER BILL ON THE
SHELF UNTIL YOU CAN EXPLAIN IT.
AT THAT EIGHT THIS ONE OUT AND
WE WILL- WILL DEFINITELY GET
BACK WITH THOSE DETAILS BUT- WE
DO BELIEVE I WON I DO WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT WE DO BELIEVE I
KNOW THERE MAY BE A DIFFERENCE
OF OPINION HERE BUT- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO IMPLEMENTING AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED- THAT. DOJ PROVISIONS
RELATED TO REGULATION OF
FIREARMS THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION AND IT'S A
PRIORITY FOR. MANY MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE SO WE WILL GET
BACK TO YOU ON THE SPECIFIC.
ACTIONS THAT THEY CAN BE HIGHLY
TECHNICAL IN TERMS OF HOW THESE
WEAPONS ARE DEFINED IN FACT
IT'S AUSTIN- THE LOOPHOLES IN
THESE DEFINITIONS- THAT TRIED
THE PROLIFERATION OF THESE
WEAPONS IN THE FIRST. PLACE SO
WE'LL MAKE SURE TO CALL BACK ON
THOSE DETAILS BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THIS IS IMPORTANT NOT ONLY IN
ITS OWN RIGHT BUT IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTING THE BUDGET
PACKAGE. WITH YOU UNDERSTAND MY
POINT DO NOT MISS THIS ONE
OFTEN. YOU'RE ASKING US TO A-
AND PROMISE THAT YOU'RE GONNA
BACK TOMORROW. AFTER THE VOTE
WAS EXPLANATION. I'M OKAY WITH
THAT WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
NUMBERS I AM NOT OKAY WITH IT
WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH POLICY.
AND SOMEONE TO GET THE MESSAGE
DOWNSTAIRS IF YOU'RE GOING TO
INSERT POLICY INTO A BUDGET.
WHETHER IT'S A BUDGET OR
TRAILER BILL YOU OR SOMEONE
BETTER BE ON THE LINE TO
EXPLAIN THE POLICY TO THOSE OF
US WHO LIKE TO READ AND
APPRECIATE KNOWING WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO. WHEN WE VOTE ON IT NO
I'M INCLINED TO VOTE ON THIS
TRAILER BILL BUT I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT I'M VOTING ON WHEN I CAST
MY BALLOT. SO WORD TO THE WISE
I DON'T ALWAYS AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE ON THIS- OTHER ISSUES
BUT I THINK YOU NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION WHEN YOU AND THE
GOVERNOR AND THE ADMINISTRATION
ARE INSERTING POLICY ROTH
POLICY UNTETHERED TO ANY SINGLE
LINE ITEM IN THE BUDGET. IN A
TRAILER BILL. NOW I'LL CLOSE MY
MOUTH AND LET US GO ONE. SENATE
ROTH I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
ASSUME THAT ALL OF US WANT TO
KNOW THE CONTENT OF WHAT WE
VOTE ON- SO WITH THAT- MISTER
THIS ONE OFF AND I WOULD WOULD
HAVE TO INSIST THAT- YOU ARE
THE APPROPRIATE PERSON YOUR
DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW GET BACK TO
US BEFORE WE TAKE THIS ITEM UP
ON THE FLOOR TOMORROW. WILL BE
SURE TO HAVE SENATE BUDGET
STAFF COORDINATE WITH YOU THIS
EVENING TO TALK ABOUT TIMING
SENATOR BAIL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
PRISON CLOSURE AND THEN THE-
ELDERLY PAROLE AND
COMPASSIONATE RELEASE I AM- I'M
VERY CONCERNED THAT- WE HAVE.
THREE IS MY UNDERSTANDING THREE
FACILITIES THAT HAVE A HIGH
PROPORTION OF THE CALL BAD
NINETEEN CASES THERE ARE
CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW IS WHAT THE
CURRENT- COUNT. OF CASES ARE
AND DO WE HAVE A- PROGRAM TO
COMPREHENSIVE WE TEST ALL OUR
FACILITIES- HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN TESTED SO FAR- THE
ISSUE REGARDING ELDERLY AND
PAROLE COMPASSIONATE RELEASE IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE VERY
LOGICAL. TO ALLOW PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN THE HIGH RISK CATEGORY.
ACCORDING TO OUR OUR HEALTH.
THE EXPERTS THAT THEY SHOULD BE
STILL IN THOSE FACILITIES- WELL
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
IMMEDIATELY SURROUNDING THEM TO
HAVE OF THE CALL AD NINETEEN
ILLNESS. CAN I THINK THAT WE
OUGHT TO LOOK AT THOSE
FACILITIES AND A AND- I'M NOT
SURE WHICH ONES ARE THE WORSE
BUT I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
HOUSES CLOSELY MODERATORS- THE
REASON I BRING THIS UP BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK- WE'VE ADDED
COOLEY HAD A RESPONSE. OF THE
LAST WEEK'S SITUATION- IN IN
TERMS OF THE BUDGET. AND I
WOULD EXPECT THAT. IN THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS AND MONTHS WE SHOULD
HAVE MORE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACHES TO DEALING WITH OUR
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONS
FACILITIES. IN TERMS OF MAKING
THEM AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE FOR
LEASE FOR THE ADDRESS- INMATES
AND STAFF. AS WELL AS- OF ALL
THE OTHER STAFF AND INMATES
THAT ARE IN THE FACILITIES.
FACILITIES AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT WE'RE GOING HAVE. UNKNOWN
UNKNOWN AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE
MAY HAVE TO SPEND IN THE
FUTURE. IF WE DON'T GET A REAL
GOOD HANDLE ON THIS SO I'D LIKE
TO HAVE A- CLOSE CLOSER
MONITORING AND REPORTING TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE BUDGET.
COMMITTEE AND THEY'LL POLICY
COMMITTEES ON THIS ISSUE. GIVE
ME A RESPONSE TO SENATOR BILL.
FROM FINANCE YES I'LL SAY VERY
SIMPLY WE APPRECIATE THAT POINT
AT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
TOP OF MIND FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW GIVEN
WHAT WE'RE SEEING MORE BROADLY
IN TERMS AS THE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF CASES AND ESPECIALLY
FOR OUR PRISONS WHERE PEOPLE
ARE OFTEN IN CLOSE QUARTERS
ASSET TESTING IS ALREADY GOING
ON OF COURSE BUT- ALSO WORKING
ON A STRATEGY FOR HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU THIRTY WILL
IN THE FUTURE MY COW. THANK YOU
I JUST NOT TO BELABOR THE POINT
BUT I JUST WANTED TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM MY- COLLEAGUE
FROM RIVERSIDE THAT. AS I
STATED THIS IS A POLICY ISSUE
AND- I GUESS THE RESPONSE OF
SAYING WE'LL GET BACK TO WHICH
WE'VE HEARD SEVERAL TIMES
ALREADY DURING THIS HEARING I
DON'T THINK IS SUFFICIENT SO I
WONDER IF WE COULD GET ANY
ANSWER THIS ENTIRE COMMITTEE
CAN GET AN ANSWER. BEFORE WE
END THIS BUDGET HEARING TONIGHT
WE'LL WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU
WITH. I STATE I WOULD. HAVE
BUDGET STAFF WAS GOING TO
COORDINATE WITH THEM AND SO
BEFORE THE HEARING I'LL BE ABLE
TO LET YOU ALL KNOW WHEN WE'RE
GOING TO GET A RESPONSE FROM
THEM. LET THEM TALK AND FIGURE
IT OUT IF YOU DON'T MIND. I'LL
LET YOU KNOW BEFORE TONIGHT'S
HEARING WHEN YOU CAN EXPECT AN
ANSWER. SENATOR PAN. NO THANK
YOU AND I THANK YOU MADAM
BUDGET CHAIR FOR- INSISTING
THAT WE ACTUALLY GET AN ANSWER-
IN A TIMELY MANNER. YEAH I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND MY
COLLEAGUES FRUSTRATION THAT AT
LEAST IF WE HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT'S IN A- AT A BILL
BEFORE US AND FOR THESE ARE
TRAILER BILL THESE ARE STILL
BILLS. THAT ADMINISTRATION HE
SAID BE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
STAFF IS ABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANYTHING THAT'S
THE CONTENT IN THE BILL. NOT
SAYING BUT WHEN I HAVE THE
ANSWER I'M GOING TO YOU KNOW
GET BACK TO YOU TOMORROW. SO I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT- I
APPRECIATE THAT LEARN COVE IT
IT'S PEOPLE SCATTERED AROUND
AND SO FORTH THAT WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO THAT SOME OF THESE
THINGS AND A- BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE PERHAPS. BUT AGAIN
I WANT THANK YOU MADAM
BUDGETARY FOR INSISTING THAT WE
GET THE ANSWERS TO OUR
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE HAVE TO
CAST VOTES. ON THE RECORD SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
TOMORROW. SORRY TO BEAT THIS
HORSE BUT I JUST DON'T OUT I'LL
COMPELLED TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU ARE MORE THAN WELCOME
AND ASSYRIA- IS SOME MY
COLLEAGUES SAID BECAUSE IT JUST
IT'S NOT PROFESSIONAL BECAUSE I
HAVE HEARD OUR FRIEND UP HERE
SIX OR SEVEN TIMES A MENTION
THAT HE'S GOING TO GET BACK TO
US AND SO I'M NOT SURE WHETHER
HE HAS TIME TO GET BACK TO US
BUT WE PROBABLY SHOULDN'T DO
THESE COMMITTEES UNLESS HE'S
PREPARED. THANK AND SO WHAT I
HAVE STEPPED IN THIS COMMITTEE
CHAIR. AND I'LL SAY IT AGAIN SO
EVERYONE IS CLEAR. THAT BEFORE
WE ADJOURN TONIGHT'S HEARING I
WILL BE ABLE TO TELL THE FULL
COMMITTEE WHEN WE WILL GET AN
ANSWER FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
SENATOR SKINNER. YES THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIR SO I WELCOME MORE
CLARIFYING ANSWER FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO CHALLENGE SOME OF
THE- VITRIOL THAT WAS-
REFERENCED ON THE FLOOR SO FAR
ABOUT- THE CURRENT OUTRAGE THAT
HE- WHO IS REALLY THE ORIGINAL.
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM STE FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AROUND THIS THE
DARK OF NIGHT BY WOODS I WOULD
ONCE WE GET THE- FULL DETAILS I
WOULD SAY THAT WE SHOULD ALSO
CHALLENGE THOSE MANUFACTURERS
OF FIREARMS THAT MANUFACTURE
FIRE ARMS IN A SPECIFIC WAY TO
GET AROUND TO CALIFORNIA'S
LAWS. THAT IN THIS CASE AND I
AGAIN I WILL WELCOME WENDY.
BERMAN FINANCE PROVIDES US BUT
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING OF THIS
THERE'S PARTICULAR GUN
MANUFACTURER WHO HAS
MANUFACTURED A NEW WEAPON AND
THAT WEAPON WAS DESIGNED TO GET
AROUND CALIFORNIA'S ASSAULT
WEAPON LAWS NOW BY VIEW THIS AS
A CONFORMITY TO EXISTING POLICY
NOT SOMETHING NEW IN THE DEAD
OF NIGHT. BUT RATHER WE ARE
TRYING TO KEEP AHEAD OF
MANUFACTURERS WHO ARE TRYING TO
KEEP AHEAD OF US SO AGAIN I
WELCOME THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS EXPLANATION BUT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT IT IS. OUR OUR
OUR REGULATIONS ARE UP TO DATE
SO THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
MANUFACTURERS WHO ARE THAN
TRYING TO GET AROUND EXISTING
STATUTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON THIS TRAILER BILL.
SEEING NONE LET'S PROCEED ON TO
AB NINETY TRANSPORTATION MR
THIS ONE OFTEN. YES THE NEXT
STILL IS AB NINETY FOR
TRANSPORTATION THIS INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT PROFESSIONS
I'LL MENTION TO IT AT THE FIRST
IS FOR STATUTORY RELEASE FOR
TRANSIT AGENCIES. ADDRESSING
PARTICULAR RELATED TO STATUTES
THAT DEPEND ON THEIR
REQUIREMENTS ARE REQUIREMENTS
RELATED TO RIDERSHIP THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THAT AND THAT MAKE MAKING SURE
THAT THESE ARE STATUTES THE
PURPOSE BEHIND THEM MAKING TO
FIND THE WAY IT WORK IN TEN
GIVEN THE OF WE'VE SEEN AND
THEN THE SECOND AT. KNOWN THIS
BILL WHICH KNOW IT'S BEEN A
DISCUSSION WITH MY IS FOR
WEIGHT TO HIGH RAIL AND THE
WOULD DOUBLE. YES OF BUSINESS
AND SOUL DECEMBER FIFTEENTH OF
THIS YEAR AND THERE WOULD BE NO
UP REPORT AND SO NEXT YEAR AND
SO HAVE TO TAKE ON I ALSO HAVE
MARKMAN MY CAR ON THE AS WELL.
MADAM CHAIR. JUST WHEN I GET
BACK ASK AT THE WORST OF THIS
ONE OFTEN YOU WERE GONNA HAVE
ANOTHER STAFFER COMMENT HOTEL I
WAS SAYING GUYS ON THE LINE
HAPPY ARE HAPPY TO TAKE ONE YOU
THE FULL SENATOR DAHLE. HERE.
MR DOLLIES MICHAEL THANK YOU
CHAIR. I RECOGNIZE ME FOR
APPRECIATE THAT I SEE THE A AND
THERE'S A DEADLINE EXTENT FOR
THE HIGH RAIL TWENTY TWO BIZ
PLAN TO THE END OF YEAR I
UNDERSTAND IT THE WARTY IN TEN
TO ENTER INTO A COUPLE VERY
EXPENSIVE CAR. WITH ATTACHED
THIRTY MADE ITS- THIS WOULD
FURTHER COMMIT CALL. THE PRO.
WITH CA THAT OUT OF WITH NO
REAL FUNNY PLAN. WINDOWS
MINUTES. EXPECTED AUTHORITY
ENTER. INTO THESE CRUNCH BE. OR
AFTER THE FINAL. OF THE- PLAN.
WELL THE LEGISLATURE HAVE TIME
TO WEIGH IN BEFORE THESE
CONTRACTS ARE EX. LET ME TURN
IT OVER TO MARC MERO. THE
WORKING TO FINANCE AND UP SO IN
TERMS THE CONTRACTS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE THIRTY IS
COULD RETURN OF YOUR SPEAK A
LITTLE LOUDER PLEASE. YOU HEAR
ME NOW YES THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
SO YEAH THE AUTHORITY WORKING
TOWARDS THE FEDERAL DEADLINE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWO COMPLETE
THE CENTRAL SECTION. IN AS IT
IN A BOOK TO BE. FOR YOU KNOW
FOR A FOR HEARING INTO.
PROVIDED FROM TO THE AND- AND
RIGHT
THAT BEFORE THE FINALIZATION OF
THE BUSINESS PLAN THAT WAS THE
QUESTION SO I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S ANYTHING HERE THAT IS
INTENDED TO STOP THEM FROM
PURSUING THIS CONTRACTS- I
THINK THEY'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
THOUGH TO- TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS BEFORE PROCEEDING.
RIGHT WELL I WOULD I WOULD HAVE
A CONCERN THAT WE WOULD. WE
WOULD HAVE A THIRTY YEAR-MAINTENANCE AGREEMENT BEFORE WE
HAVE THE BUSINESS PLAN
FINALIZED IT IT SEEMS TO BE
BACKWARDS TO MEAN I. I WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO WEIGH IN AFTER WE
SEE THE BUSINESS PLAN ON A
THIRTY YEAR CONTRACT. WE NEED
TO EXTEND THAT DEADLINE TIME SO
THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO SEE
THE BUSINESS PLAN BEFORE WE
AGREE TO IT OF A VERY LATE THE
CONTRACT. BUT MY MIND MAY NEVER
BE COMPLETED. IF I COULD JUST
CHIME INCIDENT TO DOLLY-
MESSAGE I'M GETTING FROM BUDGET
STAFF- THE BUSINESS PLAN DELAY
GIVES US TIME TO REVIEW- AND
COMMENT THE CURRENT TIME LINE
MEANS THE CONTRACT WOULD BE
AWARDED UNTIL JANUARY IN THE
BIDS ARE DUE IN SEPTEMBER.
AGAIN MIKE MY QUESTION IS
THAT'S GREAT BUT I WANT TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY I DON'T WANNA I
WANNA MAKE SURE WE DON'T DO THE
CONTRACT BEFORE YOU THE
BUSINESS PLAN. THAT'S THAT'S MY
CONCERN. AND THE CONTRACT IS
NOT SCHEDULED TO BE COMPLETED
BEFORE THE BUSINESS PLAN WOULD
COME OUT THANK YOU WHAT I
THOUGHT I JUST READ BUT OKAY.
ANY OTHER. THIRTY MORE LOT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MISTER
MONROE MAYBE YOU HELP ME TO
FEEL LIKE AMENDED THE BROKERED
BUT WHY IS SO DE ABOUT
PREPARING A BUSINESS PLAN FOR
SPEED. AND WHY IT NEED TO BE.
TO BE CLEAR IS A LOT. ASK SO
THIS WASN'T SOMETHING THAT WAS-
A PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION- THE LEGISLATURE
ASKED THE APPELLATE MOSTLY COME
FROM THE ASSEMBLY- THEY HAD
WANTED- YOU KNOW THE LAST
BUSINESS PLAN CAME OUT- AND THE
DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN RATHER CAME
OUT. JUST BEFORE THE COVERAGE
CRISIS STAR. IN SO. I THINK
THERE'S- ABOUT. TAKING INTO
CONSIDER ANY ANY COVERT REAL
DELAY IN THE AND I JUST UNDER
BETTER AND SO MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THE ASSEMBLY WANTED TO. HAVE
THE AUTHORITY MORE TO DO
ASSESSED. AN ANALYSIS OF THE
PROJECT- BEFORE- GIVEN GIVEN
NEW INFORMATION THAT IS NOW
COMING IN TERMS OF. HOW TO COPE
WITH A CRISIS MIGHT IF IT. AND
MY SECOND MISTER RELAY TO A
WHOLE THE HIGH WAS THERE ARE
TRANSFERRED AGENCY THAT ARE.
BINDING THAT THERE RIDERSHIP IS
DOWN THAT THERE ARE. ADEQUATE
TO THE 2% THRESH. A REQUIRED TO
THE STATE OUT I AM JUST
WONDERING BECAUSE OF SOME IN OF
A THAT ARE. AT THAT COLD IT IS
NOW THE ONLY THAT RIDERSHIP
DOWN IT'S BEEN HISTORIC
HAPPENING AND TRENDING. AND I'M
WONDERING IF IT'S TIME FOR A
LITTLE INNOVATION AND HOW CAN
THE STATE PARTICIPATE- THERE IS
THE IDEA OF PERSONAL RAPID
TRANSIT AND NOW WITH SELF
DRIVING CARS WE COULD.
LITERALLY ORDER A SELF A
DRIVERLESS CAR TO SHOW UP
ADDRESS AND THEN TAKE USED. BUT
WE COULD MAYBE THAT TO VAN WERE
WE COULD MAYBE GET A LOT MORE
PEOPLE. MOVING OUT TO WITH
SMALL VIA VANCE IT SAID. AND
THEN HAVING TO WAIT FOR A BIG
THAT ARRIVE A- HOUR COULD
CERTAIN. DO DURING RUSH HOUR
AND PROVIDE SOME AND NEW FROM
TRANSIT STATE. SO BOB I'M
CURIOUS IF A WAY KIDDING THAT
KIND OF THING WITH OUR REGIONAL
TO. AUTHORITIES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU. A ANY RESPONSE
FROM FINANCE ON THEM. THE CIVIC.
NO I MEAN I KNOW THAT WE
BROTHERS THIS CAN TO LOOK A
MULTI MORE APART BUT WHAT'S
THIS BILL IS A JUST TRYING TO
WHEN IT COMES TO THE OF THE REV
COME TO THE STATE FOR. LOCAL
TRANCE AGENCY THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE A VERY SKEWED AND-
DISRUPTION IN IN WRITER AND THE
FOR BY REVENUES THAT THAT SEEM
THE JUST OF DURING THIS. DURING
THIS. THANK YOU THIRTY BILL
JUST THE I WONDER IF ME FOR THE-
HAS IT RELIEF PROGRAM IS YOU
KNOW IS NOT A ASKING SOME OF
FOR MY BUT IT HOUSING FOR. MORE
FLEX AND MORE UNDERSTAND ABOUT.
THE TIMES THAT WE IN. TO HELP
ARE TRANSIT SYSTEM AND CAL. YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW WHEN PEOPLE GO
THERE ARE GOING TO GET BACK TO
WORK THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO
GET TO WORK AND THEY GET TO
WORK IF- THEY'RE NOT WEALTHY
AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE JUST
GETTING A NEW JOB OR GETTING
BACK TO WORK THEY'RE GOING TO
NEED TO USE A LOT OF TRANSIT.
SO WE HAVE TO GET THE TRANSIT
SYSTEMS READY. TO PERFORM FOR
THOSE HOPEFUL REVIVAL WE HAVE
IN THE ECONOMY AND- I AM VERY
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THE
STATUTORY RELEASE I THINK THEY
COULD DO IT EVEN MORE OVER THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS. THE HELP. THE
TRANS YEAH. BILLS BECOME STATE.
AND HE PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. OF
IN A MANNER YOU KNOW THE
STUDIES HAVE BEEN DONE ON
TRANSIT SHOW THE DOG. OF ALL
THE THINGS THAT- HELP PEOPLE.
GET OUT OF POVERTY ACCESS TO
JOB. IS THE TOP WAY TO GET OUT
OF POVERTY. AS FOR THE STUDY BY
HARVARD OTHER OTHER OF SOCIAL
SOCIAL SCIENTISTS THE HAVE
STUDIED COMPARE THE DIFFERENT
WE WAYS OF GETTING OUT OF
POVERTY ACCESS TO A JOB. HAVING
A WAY TO GET TO WORK. IS SO
IMPORTANT THAT'S WHAT WE GOTTA
KEEP THE SURVIVAL WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE TO RE INVENT THINGS GO TO
CHANGE THEN I'M ADAM ALSO
POINTING OUT THAT. HIGH SPEED
RAIL HAS IS A REQUIREMENT. TO
PRESENT TO THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES EVERY TWO YEARS-
THEIR BUSINESS PLAN AND THEY
WERE DUE TO PRESENTED IN JUNE
SO THIS IS ACTUALLY JUST FIVE
MONTHS. A FIVE MONTH OF DELAY
OF THE REQUIREMENT THAT WE
REVIEW THIS EVERY TWO MONTHS OR
EVERY TWO YEARS EXCUSE ME. AND
I THINK IS APPROPRIATE GIVEN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES WERE IN- THEY
HAVE A DRAFT PLAN THAT THEY
PUBLISH BEFORE THE- THE VIRUS
SITUATION SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THE PLAN THAT THEY HAVE
DRAFTED WHICH I'M SURE WILL
CHANGE BETWEEN NOW AND DECEMBER
BUT YOU CAN. SEE THERE ARE
DROPPED PLAN IT'S AVAILABLE FOR
THE PUBLIC AT THIS POINT. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO THE DID HE
ANTICIPATE THIS FINAL DELIVERY
OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL BUSINESS
PLAN THE- THAT THAT'S NOW BEEN
EXTENDED TO DECEMBER. DO WE
ANTICIPATE ANY. THIRTY CHANGER
RENEWED EMPHASIS BETWEEN THE
DRAFT IN THE FINAL TO ADDRESS
THE BOOK AND ISSUE IN LOS
ANGELES AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION- I KNOW THERE'S BEEN AN
ONGOING ISSUE IN THIS SPEAKER
IS PROPOSED AN ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGY TO. CONTINUE
PRIORITIZING- COMMUTER INTER
REGIONAL RAIL IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO IS ARE ANY OF
THOSE ISSUES ANTICIPATED TO BE
ADDRESSED IN THIS UPDATED
BUSINESS PLAN. I CAN'T SPEAK TO
WHAT THE- WHAT HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY OF WILL BE LOOKING
AT- I KNOW THAT. WAY AND- BACK
IN IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WHEN
WE STARTED WITH THIS ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS OF THE- OF
THE FUNDING WAS ALREADY
ALLOCATED TO LAW TO THOSE TYPES
OF PROJECTS. AND SO AND MIGHT
MIGHT OUR STANDING AS OF THE
LAST LAST BUSINESS PLAN IS THAT
THE AUTHORITY WILL NEED ALL OF
THE FUNDING THAT IT CURRENTLY
HAS- TO COMPLETE THE SECT. THE
SECTION THAT HAS BEEN A BY THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT- BUT I CAN'T
SPEAK TO WHAT OTHER
ALTERNATIVES SO THEY'LL BE-
CONSIDERING. I GUESS I WOULD
JUST FOR SOME KIND OF FEEDBACK
EITHER DEAL WITH OR- IF. ITSELF
ON HOW WE- THAT OCCUR AT THAT
WE HAVE TRANSFER. CHAIR HERE
AND WE ALL SORTS SUB CHAIR HERE
BUT- FOR ALL OF US AND CAL. I
THINK WE'RE EAGER TO SEE WHAT
THE UPDATE ENTAILS THANKS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS
HAVE FOR. ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE
LET'S TRANS TO A. B. NINE TWO
REESE. WITH BIT SO NOT YES
NINETY TWO IS RESOURCE BAIL AND
ALSO IN DID VERSIONS THIS BILL
MENTION TO IT NOW FIRST WHICH I
KNOW HAS BEEN ACTIVE WITH THE
LARGEST CERTAIN MEMBERS OF THE-
ALLOWING EARLY ASKED A ONE
YOU'RE TO SECURE. THIS IS FROM
THIS WATER CONTROL UNDER SIR
PASTOR FROM ACTED ON THE INVITE
WORK EASTER PLACE SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO MORE ABOUT AND SO AS
IT JUST REQUIRE AND
CLARIFICATIONS REGARDING THE
LATTER BATTERY CLEAN ON SO ARE
THE TWO THAT HAS I KNOW OF A
GENERALIZED. BUT HAPPY TO TAKE
ON ANY OF. THE FACILITATION OF
FUNDING. FOR MAINTENANCE OF
FEDERAL LANDS THAT HAVE HIGH
FIRE RISK IN THEM SO. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S GONNA BE
SOME KIND OF COOPERATIVE
AGREEMENTS WITH US FOR SERVICE
I'M JUST WONDERING. HOW MUCH
THE STATE ANTICIPATES- THE
SUBSIDY. TO THESE FEDERAL
PROJECTS TO BE. YES CENTER
STERN YOU'RE CORRECT THIS IS
FOR- FORCE MANAGEMENT ON
FEDERAL LANDS LET ME ACTUALLY
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
STEVEN BENTSEN AND YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN THE MOST
DETAIL. THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
STEVEN BENSON APARTMENT
FINANCE. I DON'T KNOW OF
THOUGHT MY HAND EXACTLY HOW
MUCH OF FUNDING IS CURRENTLY
GOING INTO THE FEDERAL PORTION
OF PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING
DONE. YOUR GOOD NEIGHBOR
AGREEMENTS THAT EXIST RIGHT
NOW- THE WAY THE AGREEMENTS
WORK OF COURSE IS THAT- THE
STATE IS ABLE TO ENTER INTO
AGREEMENTS WITH THE FOR
SERVICE. SO THAT WE CAN TREAT.
FEDERAL LANDS THAT ARE YOU KNOW
COME ALONG- PROJECTS THAT
INCLUDE STATE FEDERAL. AND EVEN
SOMETIMES PRIVATE LAND. YEAH
AND SO. I AM I COULD WORK WITH
CAL FIRE GET SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAIL IN TERM OF WHAT WE
THINK WE'RE SPENDING IN TERMS
OF TREATING ON FEDERAL LANDS-
THE ISSUE WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
THIS IS INTENDED TO ADDRESS IS
THAT WE CURRENTLY ARE
AUTHORIZED TO SAIL TO SELL THE
TIMBER HARVESTED OFF OF THESE
FEDERAL LANDS BUT WE DON'T HAVE
A FUND IN WHICH DEPOSIT THE
REVENUES THAT WOULD COME FROM
THAT. SO THIS LANGUAGE IS
INTENDED TO SET UP THAT FUNDS
THAT WE CAN START SELLING THE
TIMBER THAT'S HARVESTED
DISPARITIES FORCE MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS AND THEN USE THAT
REVENUE TO GO TOWARDS EITHER
THE PROJECTS FROM WHICH THE
CHAMBER IS HARVESTED OR OTHER
SIMILAR PROJECTS THAT COULD BE
ANYWHERE ACROSS THE STATE WE
DON'T HAVE A GREAT ESTIMATES
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
REVENUE WILL BE GENERATED THAT.
COULD BE ANYWHERE YOU KNOW FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OR SO THAT
WOULD BE ABOUT HALF OF WHAT WE
GET FROM. A DEMONSTRATION STATE
FOR US- NUMBER SALES. JUST IS
IT EXCLUSIVELY DO YOU
ANTICIPATE OR IS THAT THE
TRAILER LANGUAGE HERE DOES IT
EXCLUSIVELY LIMITATION. LIMIT
THOSE REVENUES TO SOLELY GO
BACK TO PROJECTS ON THOSE
FEDERAL LANDS OR OR IS IT
ELIGIBLE FOR CERTAIN OTHER FIRE
MITIGATION FORCE HEALTH
CATEGORIES. IT WILL BE SPECIFIC
TO GOING TO PROJECTS- ON
FEDERAL LAND WITHIN A GOOD
NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY AGREEMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR THIRTY FOR THE QUESTION
THIRTY NIELSEN. THIRTY NIELSEN.
YES JUST THE A MESSAGE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AGAIN A VERY
VERY MAJOR POLICY WE'RE DEALING
WITH HERE. IT AFFECTS HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES THAT SOME
OF US IN CALIFORNIA HERE
LEGISLATURE DO REPRESENT. IT IS
A HUGE HUGE ISSUE. AND IT IS
RECKLESS AND REQUIRES FAR MORE
THAN JUST A FEW CURSORY MINUTES
HERE IN THIS BUDGET COMMITTEE
THIS EVENING. PHIL WE WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DIG A LOT DEEPER.
INTO THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE. AND
IT CAN'T BE JUST BRUSHED OFFICE
ZERO JUST TO. QUICK ITEM IN THE
BUDGET IT'S A MAJOR MAJOR ISSUE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR ON I HAVE A QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO THE FOR A ONE
CERTIFICATION PORTION OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL WHICH WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES BOARD TO ISSUE A
CERTIFICATE OR A STATEMENT.
WHICH IS REQUIRED BY FEDERAL
LAW BUT BEFORE. COMPLETING THE-
CALIFORNIAN BERMAN A QUALITY
ACT- REVIEW- AND I'M I'M
SENSITIVE TO IT BECAUSE. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO FOLLOW CALIFORNIA
LAW AND YET WE'RE GIVING THE
STATE WATER BOARD THE AUTHORITY
TO JUST WAIVE THAT REQUIREMENT
AND ISSUE A CERTIFICATE AND IT
THIS PARTICULAR. POLICY CHANGE
AFFECTS ONE OFTHE IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS IN MY DISTRICT THAT
PROVIDES HYDRO ELECTRIC ENERGY
TO A TO RESIDENTS AND- THIS.
COULD DETRIMENTALLY AFFECTED
THEIR RELICENSING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR. YES
SENATOR CABALLERO AGE IS
ABSOLUTELY A SENSITIVE ISSUE
AND THE WAY THE ADMINISTRATION-
IS THINKING ABOUT WHEN IT WOULD
APPLY IS ONLY UNDER AT THE RE
CERTAIN SPECIFIC CONDITIONS AND
LET ME TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES OR YOUR APPLE ARE.
WHO CAN TALK TO THIS. WHERE DO
I GO OVER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO I'LL JUST UNDER.
EXISTING LAW- THE STATE OF THE
WATER BOARD CANNOT CASES
CERTIFICATION UNTIL THE PROJECT
GO THROUGH THE SEQUEL PROCESS-
THERE'S BEEN SOME RECENT
FEDERAL ACTION. NOTHING
PROVIDED A ONE YEAR TIME PERIOD
FOR ON WHEN THE APPLICATION WAS
SUBMITTED. SO WHEN THE WATER
BOARD WOULD NEED TO MAKE. THE
DETERMINATION- AND TO THE
EXTENT. THE WATER BOARD DOES
NOT MAKE THAT INFORMATION WITH
THAT ONE YEAR PERIOD. THEY MAY
POTENTIALLY- BASICALLY GATEWAY
BUT THEIR AUTHORITY BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO PLACE
CONDITIONS ON THE PROJECT AS
THEY WOULD UNDER UNDER THE LAW
AND SO WITH THIS- TRAILER BILL
DOES IS IT ALLOWS THE WATER
BOARD TO- ISSUE CERTIFICATION
BEFORE. THE IT WAS COMPLETED.
IN ORDER TO REALLY KIND OF
ALLOW THE- AS THE WATER BOARD
TO CONTINUE AYE ENFORCING
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY LAWS. THE
PROJECT WOULD STILL NEED TO
CONTINUE GOING TO A SINGLE
PROCESS. AND THEN AFTER A
SINGLE PROCESS WOULD BE
COMPLETED- THE WATER BOARD
WOULD BE ABLE TO RE OPEN THE
CERTIFICATION AND THEN ADD
ADDITIONAL- CONDITIONS BASED
OFF OF THE- ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY REVIEW. AT IF I COULD
FALL UP MADAM CHAIR OF THE WITH
THEIR IN. THOUGHT GIVEN. TO
CREATING AN EXEMPTION FOR THOSE
ENTITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
FURTHER ALONG DOWN THE LINE.
THAT THIS PROCESS COULD
DETRIMENTALLY AFFECT. MY
UNDERSTOOD I UNDERSTAND THAT IT
BE IN IT YOU KNOW IT IT'S- WHEN
IT'S CONVENIENT WE'D CIRCUMVENT
YOU DOING SYKORA. AND IT IT
BOTHERS ME BUT THEN SO LET'S
GET PAST THAT AND IT WAS ANY
THOUGHT GIVEN. TO TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION. THAT WHEN YOU DO
THIS YOU MAY BE HURTING OTHER
POT LICENSING PROCESSES THAT
ARE FURTHER ALONG DOWN THE LINE
THAT THAT WILL BE IMPACTED. I
GUESS THAT WAS PART OF FINANCE
WHAT I WOULD NOTE IS THAT THE
LANGUAGE IS GENERAL AND APPLIES
TO ALL THE POTENTIAL PROJECT
THAT WOULD FALL WITHIN THE FOR
A ONE WATER QUALITY
CERTIFICATION SO WE DIDN'T MAKE
ANY KIND OF PROJECT THE CIVIC
EXEMPTIONS AND IT DOES PROVIDE
FOR MORE CONSISTENT STATE WHAT.
COACH. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I'LL BE BACK. BECAUSE THIS
ISN'T GOING WAY AND I'M I AM
CONCERNED I'M I'M LOOKING FOR
COOPERATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TO HELP. THIS
IRRIGATION DISTRICT THAT
PROVIDES CLEAN. ENERGY TO IT
IT'S A RESIDENTS. FAIR ENOUGH
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ON
THIS ITEM. GOODBYE I'M LOOKING
AT OF FIVE FIFTY IF I COULD
JUST GIVE A SENSE OF PEOPLE WHO
INTENDED AND HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
ON THE NEXT TRAILER BILL WHICH
IS HIGHER IT IF YOU COULD JUST
GIVE ME A SIGNAL. OTHER MEMBERS
WHO HAVE QUESTIONS THAT YOU
KNOW OF YET. YOU WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS ON IT GOOD I THINK-
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE BEFORE THAT
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT AND NOT WHEN
I WOULD LIE BAD ANY OF THE
MEMBERS WILL HAVE QUESTIONS ON
THE IDC. OKAY SO- BEAUTIFUL WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB
NINETY THREE. EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT COLLEAGUES THIS WILL BE
THE IS THE LAST TRAILER BILL WE
HEAR BEFORE WE TAKE A THIRTY
MINUTE. RECESS FOR DINNER. FOR
THE WE HAVE LET'S SAY I HEAR
FROM YOU FINANCE ON A. B.
NINETY THREE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. ON EIGHTY NINETY THREE
AT THE BUDGET OVERALL AND
PRESERVE SAID THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT EXPANSION OF THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED LAST YEAR
BUT IN ADDITION AS A ROAD
RESULT OF THE THREE PARTY
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
REFLECTED IN THIS STILL WORKS
IT ALSO INCLUDES AN EXPANSION
OF THE EARNED INCOME TRACK TAX
CREDITS- TO FILERS. WHO HAD A
INDIVIDUAL TAX IDENTIFICATION
NUMBERS ARE ALSO KNOWN AS I CAN
FIVE HOURS RATHER THAN A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER AND IT EXPANDS
ELIGIBILITY FOR THOSE SCHOLARS
THAT HAD A CHILD UNDER THE AGE
OF SIX- SO IF A HOUSEHOLDER OF
TYLER HAS A CHILD UNDER THE AGE
OF SIX THEY'LL BE ELIGIBLE BOTH
FOR THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT
WITHIN THE EITC. WHICH IS A ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR. CREDIT AS WELL
AS ANY OTHER PRE EXISTING OR
DIFFERENT TAX CREDIT THAT
OFFSETS WERE EXPECTING-
PROJECTING THAT THE COST OF
THIS WILL BE SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A- YEAR. QUESTIONS OF
MEMBER SENATE ROBB. THIRTY
DORADO ALL SORRY SIDE IN HERE-
YES I- I WANT TO OF THANK ALL
THE EFFORT THAT WENT INTO
MAKING THIS CHANGE AND
INCLUDING I TEND FILERS. I TEN
FILERS WORK THEIR- REGULAR
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN THEY'RE
WORKING VERY VERY IMPORTANT
INDUSTRIES- AND THEY'RE PUTTING
INTO THE INTO THE SYSTEM THERE
AGAIN THEIR TAX FILERS SO I'M
I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT THAT-
RECOGNITION IS BEING GIVEN. TO
THEM SO THAT THEY COULD APPLY-
I WOULD OBVIOUSLY IN THE FUTURE
LOOKED TO SEE THAT THEY GET TO
THE POINT OF BEING TREATED
EQUALLY I AS ALL OTHER ODD TAX
FILERS SO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AGAIN SO I THE SAME QUESTION ON
THIS- PIECE OF LEGISLATION AS I
HAD ON THE PREVIOUS A TEN
MILLION DOLLARS SO IF YOU. ARE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT AND YOU
ARE THE- CAN APPLY FOR THIS
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT IN
SENATE DISTRICT ONE WHERE WOULD
YOU GO. SO FOR THIS AT THIS IS
DONE DIRECTLY THROUGH THE TAX
CODE- SO- AS LONG AS YOU ARE
FILING YOUR TAXES- AND YOU MAKE
SURE TO APPLY WITHIN WHEN
YOU'RE GOING THROUGH TAXES THIS
PROVISION YOU SHOULD BE
RECEIVING THIS CREDIT SO HERE
ACTUALLY THE BARRIER IS IN SO
MUCH GETTING. FOLKS TO GO OUT
THERE AND LOOK FOR THE PROGRAM
THAT THEY MIGHT NOT KNOW ABOUT
AS WAS THE CASE IN IN MIGHT BE
THE CASE IS ON THE OTHER
INSTANCES THAT YOU MENTIONED
INSTEAD IT SOMEONE WHO. MAY OR
NOT MAY NOT MEET THE THRESHOLD
FOR REQUIREMENT TO FILE TAXES
IN CALIFORNIA BUT IF THEY DID-
THEY WOULD ACTUALLY GET THIS
BENEFIT BECAUSE THE CREDIT IS
REFUNDABLE MEANING THAT EVEN IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A TAX LIABILITY
OF THAT SIZE THEY COULD STILL
GET THAT CREDIT THEY FILE THEIR
TAXES BUT- I'M TO SOMEONE
WANTED MORE INFORMATION FOR
THIS THEY COULD GO TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. THE THREE
PARTY AGREEMENT ALSO INCLUDES
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT OUT OF REACH THE BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT WHILE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THIS PROGRAM HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR SEVERAL DECADES
WE'VE ONLY HAD IT FOR FOUR
YEARS AT THE STATE LEVEL LIKE
WE. ONLY TO SIXTEEN. I IT'S
JUST WELL AS OUR TAXES IN A PRO
WILL HELP THE WORD OUT BUT FOR
THIS YOU SIMPLY TO YOUR THREE
YEAR TAX CO WHEN YOU'RE FINE
TAX AND HE'S BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
THAT OF DIRECTLY. SO A FOLLOW
UP. IN TWO THOUSAND. I IN
ASSEMBLY WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE ACTUALLY. READ THE BILL
AND- AND I WAS ONE OF THE FEW
PEOPLE ON MY SIDE ALLEN
ACTUALLY THOUGHT WAS A GREAT
IDEA TO. HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE.
REALLY NOT PAYING A TAX I MEAN
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE BARKING
BUT THERE BELOW THAT. LEVEL OF-
THRESHOLD OF PAIN BUT YOU THE
THEY EARNED INCOME TAX
BASICALLY WAS. THAT
INCENTIVIZING THEM TO WORK. AND
SO WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THIS AND TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN. THE LEGISLATION
WAS PASSED EARLIER. SO THE MAIN
DIFFERENCE IS- WERE ACTUALLY
LAST. ONE EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT-
AND A COUPLE OF WEEKS BEFORE
THAT SO MYCOLOGY CHAMBER ONE IS
ON THE LINE AND HE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO THE SPECIFIC
TIME FRAMES- BUT I BELIEVE THAT
THERE WERE TWO STAGES OF
CHANGES THE FIRST STEP RELATED
TO WHETHER IT'S SELF EMPLOYED
INDIVIDUALS- VERSUS BEING AN
EMPLOYEE OF SOMEBODY ELSE- WERE
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR THE TAX AS
WELL AS THE ORIGINAL. TWENTY
FIFTEEN LEGISLATION THAT YOU
MENTIONED I BELIEVE THAT IT
RESTRICTED TO CERTAIN AGE
GROUPS SO WASN'T ANY FILE ARE
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN SO
THAT WAS ONE SET OF CHANGES THE
SECOND SET OF CHANGES OCCURRED
LAST YEAR IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN ACTED. THE EIGHTY
BANDED AND BE IN. WHILE FROM I
THINK IT'S TOPPED OUT ABOUT
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND EXPAND THAT'S THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS BECAUSE THAT
IS ABOUT. THE YEARLY INCOME IF
YOU IMAGINE SOMEONE WORKING.
FORTY HOURS A WEEK AT ABOUT A
FIFTEEN DOLLAR WAGE- IT WOULD
COME TO ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT KIND OF WORKERS AS A
HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD OR A FILE OR-
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
ASSISTANCE UNDER THE CREDIT.
AND THEN THE OTHER THING THAT
OCCURRED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
LEGISLATION. WAS INCLUDING AN
ADDITIONAL ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR
TAX CREDIT. FOR FAMILIES OR
HOUSEHOLDS WITH A LEAST ONE
CHILD UNDER SIX I'M SO THAT WAS
THE SERIES OF CHANGES A LEADING
UP TO THIS POINT. THE ONLY
CHANGE THAT THIS BUDGET MAKES
OTHER THAN PRESERVING AT THE
SIZE OF A CREDIT WHICH WAS NOT
EASY I KNOW GIVEN THE FISCAL
PRESSURES THAT WE'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH RIGHT NOW. BUT
DESPITE PRESERVES THAT AND THE
ONLY CHANGES EXTENDING IT TO
UNDOCUMENTED EITZEN FILERS WHO
HAVE A CHILD OR SEX. BUT THAT'S
BASICALLY THE WAY IT HAS
EVOLVED OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. THEN I HAVE ONE LAST
FOLLOW UP QUESTION DO YOU KNOW
WHAT THE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE
THAT. DON'T FILE IS THAT OUR
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
PROGRAM. SO DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT WHEN WE TRY TO
JAY CHAMBER ONE TO SEE IF HE
HAS THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION.
THIS IS JERRY CHAMBERLAIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. PALM
AND- I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER.
TO THAT I MIGHT SEEK TO
ACTUALLY SOMEONE DIFFICULT TO.
TO DETERMINE. WHO IS ELIGIBLE
BUT NOT. OF THE DOCTOR FINALLY
NOW CERTAINLY IT IS. IT IS-
THERE ARE. THERE ARE TAXPAYERS
WHO ARE NOT CLEAN THE- FEDERAL
CREDIT AND THE STATE CREDIT YOU
ARE ELIGIBLE BUT I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE A NUMBER. FOR WHO
THAT IS. THANK YOU I KNOW THAT-
MY COLLEAGUE CHERYL BROWN AT
THE TIME. WAS VERY FRUSTRATED
THE FACT THAT PEOPLE THAN FILE
AND THERE WAS AN ABILITY FOR
THEM TO RECEIVE THE RK INCOME
TAX CREDIT BUT- JUST SIMPLY
WEREN'T FILING. AND SO- THAT'S
THAT'S A MISSED OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE FOLKS WERE WORKING- AND
NOT ABLE TO. TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE CREDIT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
A CENTER FAN. THANK YOU JUST
VERY BRIEFLY I THINK THE- THE
ADJUSTMENTS AND THE- BUDGET BUT
PARTICULARLY THE CONTINUING THE
OUT REACH MONEY BECAUSE AS WE
MAKE CHANGES I THINK IS US
SENATE DOLLY MENTION WE NEED
PEOPLE TO KNOW- THAT- THE WHAT.
IS OUT THERE AND ALSO WE NEED
TO SYSTEM WITH- FILING THEIR
TAX RETURNS OFTENTIMES. WELL
WHO MAY NOT BE. AS FAMILIAR
COMFORTABLE AND BE ABLE TO
FIGHT THAT SYSTEM TO APPRECIATE
THAT WE HAVE ALLOCATED I HEARD
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CONTINUED OUT REACH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ON THIS.
TRAILER BILL. SEEING NONE OF
COLLEAGUES WITH THE OUR OF SIX
HAVING ARRIVED WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A BRIEF A DINNER BREAK
RECESS ON IT IS MY EXPECTATION
THAT WHEN WE RETURN AT SIX
THIRTY- WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY BILL ON
AND EXPECT TO HAVE OF FURTHER
CLARIFICATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ADMINISTRATION ON
THAT ISSUE BEFORE WE PROCEED
WITH THE ADDITIONAL BILLS WE
WILL TAKE A DINNER RECESS AND
WE'LL RECONVENE. AT SIX THIRTY
AS I COMMITTED RIGHT BEFORE OUR
DINNER BREAK WE ARE- GOING TO
RETURN TO ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
EIGHT ON PUBLIC SAFETY. I HOPE
EVERYONE WHO IS HERE THAT
WANTED CLARIFICATION. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK. FIRST OF ALL LET
ME CLARIFY THAT. I WAS MADE
AWARE THAT THIS TRAILER BE
ELLIS PEOPLE WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT NOT HAVING ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION. BUT THIS TRAILER
BILL HAS BEEN. ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES WEBSITE
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE BEFORE US
SINCE MAY FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY. WITH THAT IF FINANCE
COULD PROVIDE US WITH THE
EXPLANATION THAT PEOPLE WERE
THINKING. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I WILL SPEAK AT VERY
BRIEFLY- AND THEN I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE AARON
EDWARDS ON THIS ISSUE AND I
KNOW THERE WERE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS- SO WE
WANT TO HELP PROVIDE OUT
WHATEVER INFORMATION IS
NECESSARY- IN THIS HEARING
TODAY- I THINK THE FIRST THING
I'LL START OFF WITH- AT THE TOP
LEVELS THAT THE SALE AND
TRANSFER OF ASSAULT WEAPONS. IS
ALREADY GENERALLY PROHIBITED IN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE REALLY
ONLY SPECIFIED EXCEPTIONS TO
THIS RULE I'M AND THIS POLICY
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES IS
WITH GOOD REASON IT'S TO REDUCE
THE SPREAD OF THESE DEADLY
WEAPONS. PREVENTING GUN
VIOLENCE IS A SERIOUS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE.
AND THAT'S WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDED AS PART
OF ITS BUDGET PACKAGE. AND NOW
WE KNOW THAT THEIR REASONABLE
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION ABOUT.
WHETHER AN ISSUE LIKE THIS
SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET PACKAGE. BUT GIVEN HOW
WE IN THE ADMINISTRATION ARE
LOOKING AT THIS AND GIVEN THE
FACT THAT BUDGETS ARE
STATEMENTS OF VALUES ARE. THE
SAME GOES WE FELT THAT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO INCLUDE THIS
ISSUE. AND GIVEN THE THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY FROM GUN VIOLENCE
THE ADMINISTRATION PLACED AT
THE STATE MUST UPDATE ITS LAWS.
TO ADDRESS LOOPHOLES IN THE
LONGER WAITING TO THE
GOVERNMENT'S SPECIAL WEAPONS. I
WOULD OTHERWISE ALLOW PEOPLE TO
POSSESS WEAPONS THAT HAD ALL
THE MAJOR FEATURES AND
CHARACTERISTICS OF ASSAULT
WEAPONS. BUT SIMPLY DO NOT FALL
UNDER THE PREVIOUSLY SPECIFIED
DEFINITIONS. ENACTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. WE KNOW FROM
EXPERIENCE HOW PEOPLE CAN HAVE
BABIES RESTRICTIONS IN CURRENT
LAW WITH VERY DEADLY RESULTS.
AND SO THIS BILL THIS TRAILER
BILL WOULD EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF AN ASSAULT WEAPON
TWIN CLOTHING EVEN THOSE
WEAPONS THAT DO NOT SET THE
TYPICAL DEFINITION. OF A RIFLE
OR A PISTOL OR SHOCK ON. THAT
WOULD FALL UNDER THE CURRENT
BANNER RESULT WEAPON. THIS
INCLUDES CERTAIN FIREARMS. THAT
DO NOT HAVE A FIXED MAGAZINE
BUT STILL UNDER CURRENT LAW.
MAY NOT BE CLASSIFIED AS
ASSAULT WEAPONS. IT ALSO
INCLUDES CERTAIN FIREARMS THAT
YOU HAD A FIX MAGAZINE BUT NONE
THE LESS DISPLAY OTHER FEATURES
CHARACTERISTIC OF ASSAULT
WEAPONS. INCLUDING A SEMI
AUTOMATIC CENTERFIRE FIREARMS
THAT IS NOT A RIFLE NOT A
PISTOL NOT A SHOT GUN. BUT THAT
HAS A FIX MAGAZINE WITH THE
CAPACITY TO ACCEPT MORE THAN
TEN ROUNDS. SO THIS IS ONE
EXAMPLE BUT WE DO BELIEVE THIS
IS AN URGENT PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUE. LET ME TURN OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE HERE NETWORKS WHO CAN
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAILS.
WELL GOOD EVENING- ERIN EDWARDS
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE SOME FURTHER DETAIL- ON
THIS ISSUE- AND WHY WE THINK
IT'S REALLY A CRITICAL- PUBLIC
SAFETY. ISSUE THAT WE ADDRESS
THIS THIS CALL AND THE ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN. ASSAULT WEAPONS
BANS LOT RIGHT NOW AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE- SO I THINK IT'S
HELPFUL TO UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BIT OF. BACKGROUND ABOUT HOW
THE ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN CURRENT
STATUTE- IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND
WHY THERE IS AN EXISTING LOCAL
THAT WE- FEEL THE NEED TO
CLOSE- SO IN PEOPLE CODE
SECTION THREE ZERO. FIVE ONE
ZERO. ON THE LEGISLATURE HAS. A
SPECIFIED A NUMBER OF. WEAPONS
THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY INCLUDED
UNDER THE ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN
THERE ARE DOZENS OF WEAPONS
SPECIFIED- SOME OF THE MORE
COMMON ONES THAT YOU'RE
PROBABLY FAMILIAR WITH OR LIKE
A OUR FIFTEENS. I A. K. FORTY
SEVENS. UZIS THESE ARE THE
SORTS OF WEAPONS THAT ARE ARE.
VERY SPECIFICALLY- DEFINED AS
ASSAULT WEAPONS IN EXISTING
LAW- HOWEVER THAT THAT ISN'T
SUFFICIENT- TO ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE. NO ASSAULT WEAPONS-
BEING- SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE- WE KNOW THAT OF COURSE
THERE ARE NEW FIREARM SYSTEMS
BEING. DEVELOPED AND PUT ON THE
MARKET- CONSTANTLY- AND SO- IT
RECOGNIZING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO ATTEMPTED TO
DEFINE. CERTAIN ASPECTS OF
ASSAULT WEAPONS OR CERTAIN
FEATURES THAT. ARE ARE PRESENT
IN ASSAULT WEAPONS- WHICH-
WHICH- WHICH ARE ALSO-
PROHIBITED. UNDER THE ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN SO. I THAT'S IN SEX
THREE TRANSACTION THREE EASIER.
FIVE ONE FIVE- THAT IS THIS
SOME EXAMPLES THAT ARE. THERE
ARE NUMBER- BUT- THE KEY IS IN
ORDER TO- FALL UNDER THE
DEFINITION OF ASSAULT WEAPON
UNDER THAT PENAL CODE SECTION.
THE FIRE ON NEEDS TO BE DEFINED
EITHER AS A PISTOL A RIFLE OR
SHOTGUN. AND IT HAS TO HAVE
SOME SOME ADDITIONAL AFTER
YEARS SO FOR EXAMPLE- FOLDING
OR TELESCOPING. STOCKS A
GRENADE LAUNCHER A FLASH
SUPPRESSOR AFFORD PISTOL GRANT-
FROM HOLD STOCKS I WILL READ
YOU THE ENTIRE SECTION BUT BUT
YOU GET THE IDEA- I THINK AND
SO THE PROBLEM IS THAT THERE
ARESOME MANUFACTURERS THAT
HAVE. DELIBERATELY ATTEMPTED TO
UNDERMINE- ARE ASSAULT WEAPONS
BAN BY SPECIFICALLY DESIGNING
WEAPONS THAT DO NOT FALL INTO
THE CATEGORY OF A RIFLE A
PISTOL OR SHOCK ON IN THE US
ARE NOT. AFFECTED BY THE
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN THIS IS
WHAT I CENTER SKINNER SPOKE TO-
EARLIER- IN SO- THERE ARE- AS I
SAID. THE TICKET WHERE
MANUFACTURER HAS PUBLICLY
STATED THAT THE DESIGN A
WEAPON- THAT IS DELIBERATELY
INTENDED TO CIRCUMVENT THE
DEFINITIONS AND SAW WEAPON-
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW AND I
THINK- IF THE FOR YOU SEE WHAT
THIS WEAPON LOOKS LIKE YOU YOU
WOULD PROBABLY AGREE THAT
APPEARS TO BE AN ASSAULT
WEAPON- BY. A REASONABLE
DEFINITION- THE WEAPON IN
PARTICULAR IS CALLED THE
FRANKLIN ARMORY IN TITLE ONE IF
YOU IF YOU FEEL THAT ARE ON
YOUR PHONES I THINK- NOW
PICTURES WERE THOUSAND WORDS IN
TERMS OF- REPRESENTING WHAT
SORT OF WEAPON WE'RE TRYING TO-
GET OUT WITH THIS WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE- THE- THE-
MANUFACTURER AS I SAID HAS HAS
BEEN ATTEMPTING TO SELL THIS
WEAPON- IN CALIFORNIA- AND-
DESPITE THE FACT THAT IT THE-
IT. WOULD FOR UNDER ANY REASON
DEFINITE OF THE SONG WEAPON.
THE WAY THEY HAVE A TIME TO
START THE LAW IS BY DECIDING
THAT WEAPONS. BUT IT'S EXACTLY
SIXTEEN AND- ARE IN CURRENT LAW
PISTOL IT IS DEFINED AS A
WEAPON THAT'S LESS THAN SIXTEEN
INCHES SO IT'S NOT CONSIDERED A
PISTOL. YEAH AND IT'S NOT
CONSIDERED A RIFLE IN PART
BECAUSE IT HAS A BUFFER TO-
INSTEAD OF A SHOULDER RAST THAT
SITS AGAINST HIS SHOULDER ONCE
FIRE- AND SO THEREFORE IT DOES
NOT. WELL IT'S SORT OF A HYBRID
SOME PEOPLE CALL THIS A FULL
ODDS ACROSS BETWEEN A RIFLE AND
PISTOL BUT AGAIN I'M NOT
COVERED BY EXISTING LAW- IN SO-
IN ORDER TO CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE
WE HAVE PRESENT THIS THIS THIS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. WHICH
WAS THE BULLS PROHIBIT THE SALE
OF THAT SPECIFIC WEAPON- AS
WELL AS OTHER WEAPONS WHICH
MANUFACTURES MADE ATTEMPTS
DESIGN BASED ON HISTORY NOW WE
KNOW THAT THIS HAPPENS TO GET
AROUND OUR EXISTING STATUTES-
AND SO THAT IS THE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE THAT YOU SEE IN THE-
SECTION- THREE ZERO FIVE ONE
FIVE THAT WE'RE PROPOSING- I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WE DO WE-
INCLUDE AN EXCEPTION- IN THERE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
PURCHASED- FOR OF ENTERTAIN IN
SOME WAY THESE WEAPONS- BEFORE-
THE IMPLEMENTATION. OF THIS OF
THIS SIZE. OF THIS NEW
DEFINITION IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
A SECOND AMENDMENT CONCERNS
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH WITH
THE WAY THAT THE INITIAL
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN WAS WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN STATE LAW- THE
REASON THERE'S AN URGENCY TO DO
THIS NOW. IS BECAUSE- AT THE
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA GUN
DEALERS ARE NOT SELLING THESE
WEAPONS- FOR THE MOST PART
BECAUSE- I'M PRETTY SURE THAT
NO ONE IS ONLY. ACTUALLY
BECAUSE IT IT DOESN'T FALL INTO.
OF THE US THREE CATEGORIES
RIFLE OR COME IN IN ORDER TO
AVOID. THE DEALERS ARE SIGNED
WEAPONS AND THEY I THE MAIN IF
OF THIS. WEAPON HAS NOW. ASKED
TO THE DEPARTMENT AND- HILL I
CLARIFY IT SYSTEMS TO MAKE IT.
ALL MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THEM
TO BE SO THAT'S IN CALIFORNIA-
AND SO IF THAT HAPPENS- WE
COLD SEE THESE WEAPONS START
TO BE INSTALLED IN LARGE
NUMBERS- IN THEIR IT AGAIN IS A
SENSE OF URGENCY BECAUSE OF
THAT THE NEED. UNDER THE SECOND
AMENDMENT CONSIDERATION TO THE
GRANDFATHER FOLKS IN WHO
ALREADY POSSESS THESE WEAPONS-
THE THERE IS A CONCERN THAT THE
WALK LONGER WE WAIT THE MORE
INDIVIDUALS MAY BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN THESE WEAPONS- BEFORE
THE- THE PROHIBITION GOES AND
LESS- SO I THINK I THINK THAT
KIND OF. SUMMARIZES WHERE WE'RE
COMING FROM IN TERMS OF- WHY WE
THINK THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT-
WE YES WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THESE WEAPONS ARE ON THE STREET
WE THINK THAT THERE ARE A
PUBLIC SAFETY THREAT- IN WE
FEEL THAT THERE IS AN URGENCY.
TO ACT NOW- SO I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE MORE MORE
CLARITY ON WHAT EXACTLY WHERE
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE HERE
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT HAVING
INSTITUTIONAL. DETAILS EARLIER
THANK. YOU MISTER EDWARDS
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IN THANK YOU I'D
FOR THAT EXPLANATION AND WHILE
WE WERE ON BREAK. I DID EXACTLY
WHAT HE- SAID WHICH YOU GOOD.
THIS TYPE ONE WITH WEAPON AND
YOU FIND. THE NOT ONLY THE
MANUFACTURE BUT RIFLE
ASSOCIATION'S AND OTHER GUN
RIGHTS GROUPS BASICALLY PRO
CLAIMING IT AS A- LEGAL ASSAULT
WEAPON UNDER CALIFORNIA'S LOST
SO IN OTHER WORDS THEY ARE
EXPLICIT THAT THEIR PURPOSE WAS
TO CREATE AN ASSAULT WEAPON.
THAT COULD DEFY OUR LAW. BEYOND
IT'S A SHAME THAT WELL MAYBE
NOT ASHAMED BUT RATHER. IT'S
YOU KNOW IT'S VERY HARD TO
WRITE STATUTES SINCE WE IT
WOULD BE IMPROPER TO WRITE ONE
THAT SAID IN ANYTHING EVER
INTENDED TO BE AN ASSAULT
WEAPON WILL BE ILLEGAL PERIOD
OR ANYTHING ANYBODY WANTED TO
HAVE IT IS AN ASSAULT WEAPON
WOULD BE ILLEGAL THAT IS AND
HOW WE CAN RATES. AND WE HAVE
TO DO THESE VERY SPECIFIC
DEFINITIONS AND SUCH WHICH THEN
OF COURSE THESE MANUFACTURERS
JUST RIGGALL IN TRYING TO DEFY
SO. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT-
PROVISION THAT WILL ALLOW OUR-
LOOK STATUTE AS FAR INTENT. TO
BAN ASSAULT WEAPONS TO STAY AS
AN ASSAULT WEAPON BAN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IRAQ THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR YOU KNOW HAVING
PLAYED A ROLE IN PROPPING THIS
CONVERSATION I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO. THE KNOWLEDGE
AND THANK OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR THAT EXCELLENT TO
EXPLANATION SO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO PROVIDE.
THIRTY NIELSEN. WELL I TO WILL
THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE LATE INTO THEY'VE
GIVEN US. AN ANSWER OR RATHER I
WOULD CALL IT A JUSTIFICATION.
I WILL STILL ARGUE. THERE IS A
BREACH OF TRUST TO THE PUBLIC
THE FORCE THIS UPON US AT THE
LAST MINUTE. A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO FEEL VERY IMPASSIONED ON
THIS ISSUE AND WHO MAY NOT
AGREE. WITH SOME OF THESE
CONTENTIONS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
INPUT THEIR LEGISLATION AND
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN. SO IT IS
MAYBE. YOU CAN COME UP WITH
SOME JUSTIFICATIONS. I'M NOT
CONVINCED THAT THERE'S ENOUGH
EVIDENCE OF THE PROBLEM AT THIS
POINT. AND MAKE ANOTHER POINT.
ABOUT AN AREA THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE THE HAS NEGLECTED.
AS HAVE THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
THEY ARE PROHIBITED PERSONS
THIS IS A STATUTE WERE BY ONE
WHO IS A FELON THAT IS USED A
WEAPON IN THE COMMISSION OF
THEIR COMMITMENT CRIME AND THEY
HAVE COMPLETED THEIR SENTENCE.
COMPLETED THEIR WHOLE SENTENCE.
THEY'RE BACK IN THE COMMUNITY
NOT SUPPOSED TO HAVE A WEAPON.
WE WERE UP TO TWENTY THOUSAND.
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS NOW THAT
DOESN'T MEAN. TWENTY THOUSAND
GUNS. BECAUSE VERY FEW WOULD
ONLY HAVE ONE. BUT FOR YEARS
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DID
NOTHING ABOUT IT. AND THEN WE
KIND OF FUSSED WITH THEM A
LITTLE BIT. GAVE THEM A LOT OF
MONEY. AT LEAST OVER TWO YEARS
TOWARD THE ALMOST THE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THEN I
NEVER GOT CLEANED UP I MEAN THE
REDUCTION WAS SOMEWHAT GOT DOWN
I THINK AS LOW AS TEN THOUSAND.
BUT THEY WEREN'T AGGRESSIVELY
PURSUING IT WE HAVE ALL KIND OF
PREVARICATION. NOW I'M GONNA
DROP IT AT THAT POINT EXCEPT TO
SAY. HERE YOU HAVE ABSOLUTE
KNOWN INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE USE
WEAPONS. AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CONFISCATE BUT NOW PREEMPTIVELY.
BECAUSE OF THESE SUSPICIONS.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE ON THIS
PARTICULAR WHAT THE- AND IN A
MANNER ON WAGE THE LARGER A
PUBLIC WAS ABSOLUTELY SHOT OUT
THOUGHT. THAT PART I DO NOT
THINK THAN YOURS TO THE
REPUTATION OF THIS INSTITUTION.
NOR DOES IT EQUATE WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND LASTLY LET ME SAY
DO YOU THINK THE GANGS AND THE
CRIMINALS WILL NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO THESE WEAPONS. THEY WILL. I
ASK NO NO VOTE ON THIS
REMINDING. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
THINK. YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
SECURING THIS RESPONSE TO THIS
IN REAL TIME IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FOR. PROVIDING THE
EXPLANATION I DO HAVE A
QUESTION ON THIS BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I THINK
WE MADE A REFERENCE TO WIN. HOW
LONG THIS IS BEEN IMPRINT COULD
THEY REPEAT THAT. I THINK I DID
SIR AT THE TOP OF A LONELY RE
OPENED IT HAS BEEN- HOSTED ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WEBSITE SINCE MAY FIFTEENTH.
THE DAY AFTER- MAY REVISE WAS
RELEASED MAY NINETEENTH SO I
APPRECIATE THAT SO IT'S NOT
FIRST APPEARING LAST NIGHT OR
THIS AFTERNOON. AS HAS BEEN
SAID SUGGESTED BY SOME. I'D
ALSO JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
THIS IS APPROPRIATELY WITHIN A
PUBLIC SAFETY. PROVISION ONE
THING THAT WE CAN'T PROVE WE
DON'T HAVE DATA. IS WHOSE CHILD
WILL BE PROTECTED FROM FIX
SCHOOL SHOOTING BECAUSE THIS
WEAPON THAT IS DESIGNED TO DEFY
CALIFORNIA ALONG. WE PROVIDE A
MECHANISM TO ENFORCE THE
PROHIBITION OF THIS WE WILL
NEVER KNOW. WHAT WE DO KNOW IS
IF THESE ARE ALLOWED TO BE SOLD
INTENTIONALLY TO DEFY
CALIFORNIA ALONG THEY WILL BE
BOUGHT. AND THEY WILL FALL INTO
THE HANDS OF BOTH LAW ABIDING
IN NON ALONG A BITING RESIDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA. IN THE FAMILY
WHOSE CHILD GRADUATES FROM HIGH
SCHOOL WHO'S NOT STOPPED. BY AN
ASSAULT WEAPON IN THEIR SCHOOL
WE'LL NEVER KNOW THAT OUR
ACTION TODAY MAY HAVE SAVED
THAT LIFE SO I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR REQUESTS FOR CLARIFICATION
SENATOR MORE LOCK THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I HAVE A FEW
HOBBIES. A WHEN I HAVE TIME FOR
THEM BUT TWO OF MY HOBBIES THAT
I DO NOT HAVE. THE ARE READING
BUDGET BILLS EARLY I CANNOT
WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE A CHANCE TO.
SEE WHAT'S REALLY REAL AND WHAT
WE REALLY VOTE ON SO I DON'T
GRAB. BUDGET BILLS ON MAY
FIFTEENTH THE SECOND IS I'D I
DID NOT. REQUIRE MY FATHER IN
LAW'S A HOBBY OF BEING A
GUNSMITH. SO I'M NOT A- EXPERT
ON FIREARMS- SO TONIGHT YOU
KNOW JUST READING THE BILL- I
WENT TO MY IPHONE TO DO A
LITTLE RESEARCH GOOGLE. ED A
YOU KNOW I KEY AND P. I. F. L.
E. S. WHICH IS IN THE REPORT-
PARAGRAPH NINE ON PAGE. TWO OF
THREE FROM THE STAFF REPORT. I
DON'T GET ANY FIREARMS. SO I
DON'T KNOW MAYBE IT'S A IT'S A
TERM THAT WAS USED JUST TO. THE
CREATIVE BY BY THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE BUT IT IT DIDN'T COME
UP FOR ME SO. I APPRECIATE THE
EXPLANATION AS WELL AND- I'M
SURPRISED YOU'RE SPENDING SO
MUCH TIME. ON THE HOBBY- FOR
BECAUSE THIS IS THIS ITEM I
DON'T MEAN TO LAUGH BUT- BLOOD
DISORDER EXPLAIN FOR MY
PERSPECTIVE WHY I JUST DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT. THIS THIS WAS SO I
APPRECIATE THE EDUCATION PATH
MATT I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
APPRECIATE- THE- OVERWHELMING
AMOUNT OF DOCUMENTS AND TRADE
THE BILL'S A WHAT COMES OUT I
GET ALL THAT. THE POINT OF
MAKING THE COMMENT. IS TO
SUGGEST THAT YOU DIDN'T HAVE.
HAVE THE LANGUAGE VERSES YOU
DIDN'T CHOOSE TO READ A TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS. THAT'S THE
ONLY REASON WHY I WANTED TO
MAKE CLEAR. THAT IT IT'S BEEN
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC FROM
MAY FIFTEENTH. THAT'S THE ONLY
REASON WE MADE THE DISTINCTION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS ARE.
SENATOR MELENDEZ. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD THE
INFORMATION WE NEED TO MAKE A
DECISION ON THIS BILL I KNOW
YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO DO THAT AND
I CERTAINLY DO APPRECIATE THAT-
AND I WISH THAT- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD PROVIDED
THIS INFORMATION AHEAD OF TIME.
BUT THE REALITY IS THIS IS
STILL A POLICY BILL. THIS IS
NOT A TRAILER BILL THIS IS THIS
IS THE LEGISLATURE IMPLEMENTING
POLICY YOUR BUDGET TRAILER BILL
AND THERE IS A WAY IF THE
ADMINISTRATION OR THE MAJORITY
OF THIS BODY DOES NOT WANT THIS
TYPE OF FIREARM TO BE- SOLD IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE
IS A WAY TO DO THAT AND THAT IS
BY. DEFINING IT IN STATUTE AS
AN ASSAULT WEAPON WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NOT DONE THERE
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DO
THAT BUT WE'VE NOT YET DONE
THAT SO- I GO. I JUST I GO BACK
TO MY EARLIER STATEMENT WHICH
IS THAT THIS IS A POLICY BILL
AND HAS NO BUSINESS THIS TYPE
OF LEGISLATION HAS NO BUSINESS
BEING IN A BUDGET TRAILER BILL
BUT THANK YOU FOR- FORWARD FOR
ALLOWING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS IT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE THANK
YOU MINISTRATION GONNA MOVE ON
TO AB NINETY FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION MR THIS ONE OFTEN.
YES AB NINETY FOUR IS THE
HIGHER EDUCATION OVERALL BILL
THERE EXCERPTED BUILDER NUMBER
PROVISIONS I'LL JUST MENTION
THREE AT THAT THE FIRST RELATES
TO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE COVER K. TWELVE
BUCKS FOR IN THIS CLARIFIES THE
STUDENT CENTER CENTER FINDING
PARKING LTS AS WELL AS THE
DEFERRALS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHICH WE ALSO HAVE IN
ADDITION TO THE CASE FILES
DEFERRALS IN THE BUDGET. THE
SECOND PART OF THIS BILL THAT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT RELATES TO
CALIBRATE AND MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP AND EVEN THOUGH THE
BUDGET WAS UNDER A LOT OF
PRESSURE FISCALLY GIVEN THE
PANDEMIC- THAT THREE PARTY
AGREEMENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE REACHED A
PRESERVE ELIGIBILITY AND
SUNDAYS FOR CAL GRANTS AND
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP SO.
THIS BILL PROVIDES HIM THE
DETAILS FOR WHAT IT'S THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
PROGRAMS ANOTHER ITEM OF NOTE
THAT RELATES TO TEACHER
TRAINING DAY EIGHTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM I'D
DISCUSS THE TRIGGER FUNDING
BEORE AND BASICALLY THIS
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IS NOT DIRECTLY
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET. BUT IF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES
PROVIDE AT LEAST FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT EIGHTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TEACHER
TRAINING WILL BE RESTORED- BUT
THERE MANY OTHER PROVISIONS I
ALSO HAVE CHRIS FERGUSON ON THE
LINE. WE ARE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THE QUESTION FOR
MEMBERS. SENATOR Y. CASKEY AN
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN ON THE UC'S
SAN FRANCISCO. PARNASSUS
HEIGHTS A PLAN I'M WONDERING
WHAT IS THE URGENCY THAT THIS
BILL THAT WE GIVE THIS.
PARTICULAR YOU SEE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT- THE AB. NINE HUNDRED
TREATMENT OR OF VALUE- OPTION
OF HAVING A TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
DAYS TO HAVE THEIR EYES DIR GO
THROUGH THE PROPER. AT A COURT
PROCESS IN MEN HAVE BEEN DOING
ALLOW THE UC REGENTS TO ENTER
INTO THE GROUP AND AGREEMENT
FOR CONSTRUCTION AND LISTED SAY
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT AND IT
IT HAS ITS EFFECT UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY SIX CITIES I DON'T.
UNDERSTAND AT SIX YEARS FROM
NOW WHY WOULD WE WHAT'S THE
NEED TO HAVE THISIN THIS IN
THIS HIGHER EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL. SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KEY
ON THIS ISSUE ACTUALLY- I AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ON THIS THE
ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY I
DIDN'T HAVE A STRONG POSITION
ON THE SPECIFIC ITEM AND IT WAS
NOT PART OF OUR NAY REVISIONS.
IT WAS SIMPLY INCLUDED IT AS
PART OF THAT NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE SO WAS OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
WERE REALLY PUSHING THOSE
PROFESSIONS. IN ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT SEE NONE
WILL MOVE ON TO. AB ONE HUNDRED
GENERAL GOVERNMENT TO MISTER
THIS ONE OFTEN. THIS IS THE
SECOND GENERAL GOVERNMENT DALE
AND ONLY TWO MAJOR ITEMS OF
NOTE- FIRST IS THE TRANSFER OF
THE SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION
TO ADD THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES- AND THEN
THE SECOND IS RELATED TO THE
USE OF PREVIOUSLY APPROPRIATED
FUNDING FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTIONS THIS NOVEMBER I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS ON
EITHER OF THOSE. QUESTIONS THE
FINANCE. QUESTION. THANK YOU
SEEN NONE WILL MOVE ON TO AB
ONE OH TO CAL SAVER. FINANCE.
SORRY WAS NEEDED TO NEXT STILL
RELATES TO CAL SAVERS- AND
INCLUDES TIãU- CHANGES- BUT
GENERALLY TECHNICAL WITH SOME
SUBSTANTIVE IMPACT THE FIRST-
REGARDS THE ENFORCE MANY CAL
SAVERS PROVISIONS AND THIS
MOVES AT THOSE ENFORCEMENT
FUNCTIONS ARE KEY
RESPONSIBILITIES FROM THE AND I
MEAN WITH THE E. D. I. TO THE
CAL SAVERS BOARD ALSO WORKING
WITH THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD-
AND THEN THE SECOND MAJOR ITEM
OF NOTE SERVICE THEY ALWAYS
CLARIFYING THE OPT IN OPT OUT-
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO THE CAL
STATE FIRST PROGRAM. THE THANK
YOU QUESTIONS THIRTY MORE LOT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST WANT
TO MAKE A COMMENT- CAL SAVERS-
IS NOT A CORE FUNCTION OF
GOVERNMENT AND I SEE IT IS A
STYLE DRIFT FROM WHAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING AND PERHAPS NOW THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT HARD CHOICES A
CAL SERVERS SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED AS A BUDGET
REDUCTION MEASURE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SO I'M JUST WORRIED ABOUT
THE EASY PART OF THIS I KNOW
THAT- MY OFFICE AND I'M
ASSUMING MANY OFFICES HAVE BEEN
OVERWHELMED WITH- FOLKS TRYING
TO GET THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT TO SO
IT IS THIS ANTICIPATION THAT
WILL HOPEFULLY STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS SO THAT THE NEARLY
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT
OF WORK OR ABLE TO GET THERE
YOU AYE A- BENEFITS. SO SENATOR
THOSE AREN'T- ADDRESSING THE
SPECIFIC DETAIL BUT I THINK-
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE WELL
KNOWN ISSUES THAT YOU DO DE UM
HAS HAD- IN TERMS OF GETTING
THOSE BENEFITS OUT AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. AND I THINK OUR
WORK CERTAINLY VERY AWARE OF
THAT SCALING UP AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE ARE THE MINISTRATION
AS- ALREADY NOTED THAT THE
PERFORMANCE TO THIS POINT. IS
NOT ACCEPTABLE AND WE NEED TO
GET BETTER SO WE TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT ARE WORKING ON
THAT AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
A COLLEAGUE SEEN NONE WILL MOVE
ON TO AB ONE OH THREE.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. FINANCE
YES ON EIGHTY ONE OF THREE- IT
TO SPECIFIC CHANGES- IN THIS
TALE- FIRST- RELATES TO
TRIGGERING ON CERTAIN BENEFITS
RELATED TO A. B. THAT
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE ACCETTURO
LEGISLATION ON AND THEN THE
SECOND- WHEN IT COMES TO YOU
ARE YOU AYE PROGRAM SPECIFIC TO
KOBE ON MAKING SURE THAT THESE
PAYMENTS ARE NOT CHARGED
AGAINST THE EMPLOYERS RESERVE A
CAL ASSISTANCE THAT YOU
SOMEWHAT TECHNICAL SOUNDING BUT
IMPORTANT CHANGES- AND I ALSO
OF COURSE CLICK ON THE WIND IF
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT EITHER. THE.
SENATOR DOLLY. THE VENTURE THE
FOUND A BILL LIKE A SUPPORT
TODAY THIS IS GREAT. I DID HAVE
A QUESTION ON THE ON THE- SO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
HELPING PARTICIPATE IN- THE SIX
HUNDRED PER WEEK I BELIEVE IN.
IS FOUR FIFTY FOUR. THE STATE-
IF I'VE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
EMPLOYERS TO ONE OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES TO COME BACK TO WORK
BUT THEY'RE- MAKING MORE MONEY
ON UNEMPLOYMENT WITH THE DUAL-
BENEFITS. IF YOU'VE OFFERED
YOUR JOB BACK AND THEY DON'T
ACCEPT IT AND THEIR REPORTED
THEN DO THEY LOSE THOSE
BENEFITS. YEAH CHRIS COOK WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALL. I
CAN'T SAY FOR SURE WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WOULD LOSE THEIR
BENEFITS BUT DEFINITELY IF
SOMEONE IS OFFERED THEIR JOB
BACK THEN THEY SHOULD BE
REPORTING BACK TO WORK AND
THEN- BY THEM BEING ELIGIBLE
FOR THAT JOB THEY SHOULD NOT
THEY SHOULD NO LONGER BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS BUT IT WOULD HAVE TO
BE SOME- I THINK IT A LOT OF IT
IS CONTINGENT UPON THE AGREE
ABOUT. HOW THEY WERE RELEASED
WITH THEIR- WITH THEIR EMPLOYER
IF THEY WERE LATE LATE OFTEN
THEY RECEIVED A SEVERANCE
PACKAGE- THEN DEFINITELY YOU
KNOW THERE'S NO CERTAINTY THAT
THEY THEY SHOULD BE REPORTING
BACK TO WORK BUT IF THERE WAS
SOME AGREEMENT TO BE IF IT WAS
A- AND- A MOMENTARILY LOOK LIKE
A ENTER I'M WAY OFF WHERE THEY
STILL RETAIN THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR THEIR JOB AND THEN THEY
SHOULD BE REPORTING BACK TO
THEIR EMPLOYER AT THAT POINT IN
TIME. IT WOULD IT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TO HAVE SOME
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S.
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS THROUGH
THE- I ALWAYS CALL THE BAIL OUT
OR THE IS. IT IS QUITE HIGH AND
IF YOU COUPLE THAT WITH THE
STATE- THIS LIKE A THOUSAND
DOLLARS A WEEK. AND I KNOW
THAT- MANY EMPLOYERS TO. OR
TRYING TO GET BACK TO WORK
THERE PLEASE DON'T WANT TO COME
BACK TO WORK BECAUSE THE ACTION
MAKING MORE MONEY WHEN THEY'RE
NOT EMPLOYED. THEN WHEN THEY
WOULD BE EMPLOYED SO THAT'S
BECAUSE SOME OF THE- CONFLICT-
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO
REOPEN THEIR BUSINESSES. MISTER
THIS ONE I FOUND- IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT AS OF LAST
WEEK. THE STATE IS ALREADY
PAID. THIRTY BILLION AND
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. THERE
WAS ACCORDING TO A NEW SOURCE
FROM KNX AM IS AT. CORRECT.
COULD YOU HEAR SENATOR MORLOCK
ARE THE AND I WAS HAVING HARD
TIMES HE DID EXACTLY WE COULD
HEAR AND THAT WE NEED TO CHECK
THE EXACT FIGURE BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY IN THAT BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND THERE'S
NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT BOB
WE'RE TALKING BILLIONS I THINK
SEC YEAH THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S
WHAT I SAID BILLION SO YEAH
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION WE
BORROWED. FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PAY- UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS I'M JUST CURIOUS. IS
THAT THE CASE AGAIN. YES SO WE
ARE- WE HAVE BEEN AUTHORIZED TO
DRAW DOWN HONEST FEDERAL SIGNS
FOR BORROWING FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PAYMENTS JUST AS WE
WERE DURING THE GREAT RECESSION
I SHOULD ADD THAT FEDERAL
LEGISLATION. THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR I DOES NOT
REQUIRE INTERESTS TO BE PAID ON
THAT BORROWING AT LEAST NOT
UNTIL NEXT YEAR AND THE
GOVERNOR HAS PETITIONS- OUR
PARTNERS IN CONGRESS TO EXTEND
THAT DEADLINE POSSIBLE. AND DO
WE KNOW HOW MUCH WE BORROWED
TODAY. LET ME TURN OVER TO
CHRIS KIRKER WE MAY NOT HAVE
THAT INFORMATION RIGHT AT HAND
TO. LET ME TALK WITH CHRIS.
YEAH CHRIS CHRIS COOK WITH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE CENTER MORE
LIKE THAT. TO BE EXACT I
BELIEVE EARLIER THIS WEEK WE
HAD ISSUED SINCE MARCH I WANT
TO SAY IT WAS AROUND THIRTY SIX
BILLION IN BENEFITS. THROUGH
THE U. I. PROGRAM AND AS FOR
MARLENE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE HAVE BECOME FAR AWAY
AND I WANT TO SAY IT'S
APPROXIMATELY. AROUND. TWO TO
THREE BILLION DOLLARS HER. BUT
THAT NUMBER FLUCTUATES DAILY
BASED ON INCOMING RECEIPTS OF-
OF- YOU AYE PAYMENTS FROM
EMPLOYERS AND THEN HOW MUCH
WE'RE PAYING OUT SO IT
FLUCTUATES. SO THEN A DO WE
HAVE A PAYMENT PLAN WILL. WOOD
IT TOOK THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
QUITE A LONG TIME- WITH THE
GREAT RECESSION TO PAY OFF- THE
FEDERAL LOAN WE HAD LIKE A TEN
BILLION DOLLAR BALANCE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. AND SINCE
BUSINESSES WERE FORCED TO PAY A
HIGHER FUTA TAX EVERY DECEMBER
TO PAY IT DOWN TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT I'M I'M WONDERING IS
THAT GOING TO OCCUR AGAIN. SO
WHAT I'LL SAY TO THAT IS THAT
WE CAN'T KNOW FOR SURE WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE
BUT- AS YOU KNOW SENATOR MORE
LOCK WE'RE SEEING HISTORICALLY.
HIGH LEVELS OF UNEMPLOYMENT WE
ARE ALREADY WELL ABOVE THE HE
GOT EMPLOYMENT THAT WE SAW IN
THE GREAT RECESSION AND OF
COURSE THAT'S THE SISTERS
STATISTIC THAT IS DIRECTLY
DRIVING- THESE REQUESTS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND THEN
HE- SOME FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S.
GENERALLY THE WAY THE SYSTEM
WORKS RIGHT NOW IS THAT AS YOU
NOTED. BUSINESS IS A PAIN TO
THE UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM- WOULD
HAVE TO PAY. FOR THE PRINCIPLE
OF THE LOAN OVER TIME AS WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE GREAT
RECESSION. AND THE GENERAL
FUND- IS OFTEN ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE INTEREST RATES ALTHOUGH AS
NECESSARY- THAT EXAM SO WE FOR
THE REST OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
HOWEVER WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE FOR WEEKS
ACROSS ALL AREAS AND SPOKE FOR
BUSINESSES AND FOR THE STATE
BUDGET THIS IS CERTAINLY ONE OF
THEM THAT. WE HOPE THAT THEY
ARE INTERESTED AND- WILL
HAPPENS BE ONE OF THOSE OFF
BALANCE SHEET. LOU LOANS THAT
SOMEHOW FALLS INTO THE PURVIEW
OF. SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AYE
AYE SIR MEMBER GETTING HERE AND
HAVING A CALL. IN DECEMBER FROM
A BUSINESS OWNER. WHO WAS JUST
BESIDE HERSELF BECAUSE SHE JUST
GOT HER FORM NINE FORTY FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT TAX. RETURN FROM
HER PAYROLL SERVICE WHO. I DO
AND FORMER DECEMBER JANUARY
THAT- THE STATE STILL OWED
MONEY TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SO SHE HAD TO PAY A HIGHER RATE
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN SHE SAID MY
GOODNESS I GOTTA PAY. FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND I WASN'T
PREPARED TO NOW I CAN'T PAY MY
CHRISTMAS BONUSES AND I HANDLE
THE BUSINESS OWNER OF A DEAR
LADY ON THE PHONE CRYING ACT.
SO WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
COMMUNICATE TO OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY THAT THEY MAY BE
SUBJECT TO A MUCH HIGHER. FUTA
TAX WHEN- THAT ROLLS AROUND IN
DECEMBER JANUARY OF THIS YEAR
WHEN THEY'RE READY. YOU KNOW OP
BUCKLING AT THE KNEES IF
THEY'RE STILL IN BUSINESS. SO
GENERALLY IT HAPPENS ON A
SPECIFIED TIME LINE ON THAT IT
DOESN'T RAPIDLY RISE-
IMMEDIATELY RATHER IT SCALES UP
OVER TIME SO THERE IS SOME
PREDICTABILITY. BUT LET ME TURN
IT OVER TO CHRIS WHO CAN TALK A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL. THANK YOU
YEAH- MY COLLEAGUE IS CORRECT
THE FOOD ATTACKS ACTUALLY
DOESN'T TAKE A FACT ONLY WHEN
THERE IS- TWO YEARS THAT THE
STATE HAD DIED THE STATE'S YOU
WHY. BALANCE IS INSOLVENT AND
SO FOR EXAMPLE- AT THE POINT IN
WHICH THE- THEY WERE IN SOLVE
IT NOW THE AFFECT OF THAT-
THEIR TAX MORE INCREASE FOR TWO
MORE YEARS SO REALISTICALLY
WE'RE LOOKING AT. MAYBE FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
UNTIL- IS WHEN THE ACTUAL TAX
WILL INCREASE FOR THOSE
EMPLOYERS SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR AND THAT WILL ALL BE
BASED ON YOU KNOW HOW MUCH THE
STATE IS BORROWING AN-
ABSOLUTELY WILL BE.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS CATENA RICE
THAT WILL BE BORROWED THE MORE-
BUT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
EMPLOYERS WILL BE KNOWN- WILL
KNOW ABOUT THIS INCREASE- I
WOULD ALSO ADD AS WELL IS THAT
THIS TRAILER BILL IS PROVIDING
SOME LIMITED SUPPORT. FOR THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES IN THAT DAY-
THEIR EXPERIENCE RATING IS NOT
GOING TO BE AFFECTED AND SO AS
A CONDITION OF RECEIPT OF SOME
OF THESE FEDERAL FUNDS- THAT.
ONE OF THE CONDITIONS WISE IS
THE STATE I SHOULD BE HOLDING
THOSE- SMALL BUSINESSES
HARMLESS WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR
EXPERIENCE RATING AND SO WHAT
THAT MEANS IS BASICALLY- THEIR
EXPERIENCE RATING OR HOW MUCH
THEY PAY INTO THE U. I. FUND.
IS IN PART BASED UPON HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN LAID OFF
AT THEIR BUSINESS. AND BECAUSE
OF WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH
COLLUDED AND- HOW HOW THAT WAS
BEYOND THEIR CONTROL
ESSENTIALLY WHERE EXEMPTING
THEM FROM THOSE FROM
EXPERIENCING THOSE- AT THE
IMPACTS OF THEIR. EXPERIENCE
RATING DUE TO THE LAYOFFS.
MISTER COOK THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME KNOW ABOUT TWO YEARS
THAT CAN BE REAL HELPFUL IN
DEALING WITH CONSTITUENTS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE- THE DETAILS
ON THE RATES FOR ISSUE I. JUST
ONE LAST QUICK QUESTION OF THE
THIRTY SIX BILLION HOW MUCH OF
THAT WAS STATE FUNDS. I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT AMOUNT I KNOW
THE LORD SHARE I BELIEVE IT WAS
ESTIMATED AROUND THIRTY ONE
MILLION WAS IN PARK. TO BE
LARGELY PAID BY THE FAT SO. THE
BOOK OF THE DOLLARS THAT HAVE
GONE OUT THE DOOR IT HAS BEEN
DUE TO THE FEDERAL FUNDS. SO WE
PAID OUT THIRTY SIX BILLION THE
FEDS PAID THIRTY ONE MILLION SO
THAT THERE THAT STILL YOU MEAN
THIRTY ONE BILLION. OKAY GREAT
GREAT OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE MANAGER YOU'RE VERY WELCOME
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. THIRD
THIRD ARE ALSO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I KNOW THAT THIS. THIS IS
ABOUT OF THE ACTUAL BENEFITS
THEMSELVES BUT I CAN'T HELP
BUT- BRING UP THE ISSUE OF HOW.
WHAT IS STILL LACKEY IN IT AT
THE E. D. D. AS FAR AS GETTING
THESE DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR AND
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES. THERE IS
NOTHING THAT- TAKES UP MORE
TIME FOR OUR STAFF. THEN HE DID
A CALLS ABOUT AN EMAILS ABOUT
EDT. EVERY WEEK HUNDREDS
SEVERAL HUNDRED ALMOST DAILY UP
CLOSE TO A HUNDRED CALLS AND
EMAILS WE HAD A TOWN HALL-
THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATED IT BUT WE HAD
SIXTEEN HUNDRED WOULD SAID THEY
HAD AN ISSUE- THEY NEEDED HELP-
WE WERE TOLD THAT HUNDREDS WERE
MORE WE'RE GOING TO BE. HIRED
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS STILL
ON EVERY LEVEL OF COMMUNICATION
THERE'S ENORMOUS ANGER AND MY
STAFF HAS TO TAKE OUR STUFF OR
YOU KNOW OUR STATE GOVERNMENT
STAFF THEY HAVE TO TAKE THE
BRUNT OF ENORMOUS ANGER
ENORMOUS FRUSTRATION AND YOU
KNOW IT TO DO THAT EVERY SINGLE
DAY WHEN YOUR- YOU HAVE. NO
POWER TO AFFECT- HOW TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM HOW TO DEAL WITH
THE PROBLEM IS- IS REALLY
UNACCEPTABLE. AND I REALLY IT
YEAR IT'S BEYOND WHAT WE WERE
GOING TO HIRE HUNDREDS MORE WE
STILL CAN GET IN THE STILL
CAN'T MAKE CONTACT THEY STILL
CAN'T- GET THEIR CASES ADDRESS
AND THEY CAN GET A CALL BACK
SO. WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THAT MONEY
IS THERE BUT AND I'M SURE I
KNOW BILLIONS ARE GETTING OUT.
BUT ENORMOUS ENORMOUS ANGER AND
FRUSTRATION THAT OUR STAFF OF
THE DISTRICT STAFF IS HAVING TO
DEAL WITH EVERY DAY. INCIDENT
DRAWS A LIMITED DATA DID-
HAVING HOSTED A TOWN HALL ALSO
WHERE THE EDT STAFF WHEN WE
PUSH BACK IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE WHAT'S THE RECOURSE IF
THEY HAVEN'T HEARD BACK IN
MONTHS AND THEIR ANSWER WAS
WILL CALL YOUR SENATORS OFFICE.
SO EDT STAFFERS CITY PEOPLE ARE
TELLING THE PUBLIC WILL CALL
YOUR LEGISLATOR- SO DID ON THAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. ANY
RESPONSE TO WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM FIND IT SENATOR DOLLY. IS
REAL QUICK I'D LIKE TO JUST ADD%
BECAUSE I KNOW THE EVERY SINGLE
OFFICES HAD. REALLY THOUSANDS
OF CALLS AND ONE OF THE ISSUES
WE FOUND IN OUR THIS MAYBE WILL
HELP SOME OF THE OTHER OFFICES.
WHEN THE FRIDGE ONLYFILED.
THEY WENT ONLINE IN THE FILE
AND THERE WAS NO ABILITY FOR
THEM TO SAY THIS WAS COVE IT.
RELATED SO THEY PUT IN THAT
THING THE CHECK THE BOX THAT
SAYS. I'M UNEMPLOYED AND THEY
DIDN'T KNOW THEY DIDN'T NOTICE.
IF YOU'RE NOT LOOKING FOR WORK
YOU'RE DENIED ANY THEY GOT.
PUSHED INTO A PILE. BECAUSE
THEY REALLY EREN'T LOOKING FOR
WORK THEY KNEW THAT AS SOON AS
CO BUT- WAS WAS OVER OR- THE
TIME RAN OUT WE WOULD GO BACK
TO WORK. SO THEY REALLY WERE
LOOKING FORWARD TO IT PUT ALL
THOSE PEOPLE IN A CATEGORY AND
THEY WAITED. A LOT OF THEM. TWO
OR THREE WEEKS A MONTH AND
DIDN'T GET A RESPONSE AND STORY
CONTACT THEIR OFFICES AND- WE
REALIZED THAT THEY NEEDED TO RE
APPLY BECAUSE- THEY WERE. THEY
THEIR KIDS SYSTEM DID NOT ALLOW
THEM. THERE WASN'T A SPOT FOR
THEM TO SAY HEY THIS IS C BUT
IF THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN A-
BOXES SAID CODE RELATED. WITH A
KNOWN RIGHT THEN THAT THEY JUST
NEED TO GET RIGHT ON THE ROLE
WE GET A PUMP THE MONEY OUT SO
I JUST WANT TO. SHARE THAT WITH
YOU BECAUSE I KNOW THAT MY
STAFF FIGURED THAT OUT AFTER.
SOME TIME OF DEALING WITH MANY-MANY MANY CASES IN A LOT OF.
VERY FRUSTRATED CONSTITUENTS SO
JUST WANNA SHARE THAT
INFORMATION. WE DISCOVERED THAT
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
TO TELL ANYONE ELSE. BUT WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION LIKE TO
RESPOND AT ALL OR- SHALL I KEEP
IT MOVING. I'LL JUST SAY THAT
WE UNDERSTAND- THE AND
FRUSTRATION OUT THERE AND WHILE
IT CALIFORNIA'S NOT UNIQUE APP
THAT IS NO JUSTIFICATION SO
EVERYONE HERE IS WORKING AS
FAST AS WE CAN- TO FIX THESE
ISSUES. WE APPRECIATE BACK OF
PEOPLE ARE FRIGHTENED AND
DESPERATE. MOVE ON TO AB ONE-
FINE THE SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEM.
YEAH I'M A ONE EIGHTY ONE OH
FIVE THIS MAKES SOME CHANGES-
REGARDING BE TAX TREATMENT FOR-
SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS SO OFTEN
YOU KNOW SOMEWHERE WHEN TO SORT
FARMS THAT THEY'RE CALLED- AND
THESE- ENERGY SYSTEMS THAT ARE
NOT TIED TO A RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES SO FOR THOSE SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEMS IT WOULD MAKE A
COUPLE CHANGES NUMBER ONE
CLASSIFYING IT AS PERSONAL
PROPERTY AND NUMBER TWO- IF
THESE AS SOLAR ENERGY FARMS OUR
SYSTEMS ARE CONSTRUCTED. AND OR
INSTALLED PRIOR TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE- AND THERE IS NO
TAXATION ON THAT PROPERTY- A
CLASS FOR THAT PERSONAL
PROPERTY EXCEPT THERE'S A
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP ON AND
THEN- MOST IMPORTANT THAT THIS
WOULD ONLY GOING TO A FACT IF
THESE SCHOOL COMMITTEES FIRST
AT AT AND A BALLOT MEASURE THIS
FALL IS ENACTED- OTHERWISE THIS
WOULD BE REPEALED. AS OFFICIALS
THERE NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU
QUESTIONS. THROUGH A LOT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- THERE IS A
REAL PROPERTY TAX AND THERE IS
PERSONAL PROPERTY TAX AND MR
THIS ONE UP ON YOU'RE AYING
THAT IF SOMEONE PUTS A SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEM ON THEIR
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY THAT WILL
NOT BE ADDED TO THEIR- ASSESSED
VALUE THEIR BASIS FOR REAL
PROPERTY TAXES. BUT THEY WILL
HAVE TO REPORTED AS PERSONAL
PROPERTY ON FORM FIVE SEVEN ONE
L. IS THAT WHAT I HEARD SO LET
ME SAY AND THEN I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO CHANGE CHAMBER WHEN YOU
CAN ELABORATE DICTATE SICKLY IF
IT IS NOT HARD AT A HOME OR
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY THAT IS
NOT PART OF THE REAL PROPERTY
TAX- AND AJ- WILL SPEAK TO THE
SPECIFICS THAT YOU MENTIONED
REGARDING THE TAXATION OF
PERSONAL. PROPERTY THANK YOU ST
CHAMBER ARM FINANCE. ALSO
CENTERED MORE LIKE- AS YOU AS
YOU SAID THAT THIS WOULD BE. ON
THIS PROPERTY WOULD BE
RECLASSIFIED AS PERSONAL
PROPERTY BUT IT WOULD BE AS
PERSONAL PROPERTY IN THE STILL
BE EXEMPT FROM THE PROPERTY
TAX. AS LONG AS IT'S
CONSTRUCTED PRIOR TO JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND UNTIL IT
IS- IT IT CHANGES OWNERSHIP. SO
THE ENTERED. IT'LL BE SHOWN AS
PERSONAL PROPERTY BODY WILL BE
EXEMPT FROM. PERSONAL PROPERTY
TAX TO THE BE MAYBE A SPECIAL
LINE FOR IT ON THE FORM PART
SEVEN ONE NOW. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MEASURE
VERY WELCOME ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. SENATOR OUT SO.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN THE- WHO GETS
THE BENEFIT IS THIS A THESE
BUSINESSES THAT GET THE BENEFIT
IS IT. UP ON INDIVIDUALTHAT
GETS THE- EXEMPTION FROM PAYING
TAXES WHO ACTUALLY GETS THE
BENEFIT OF THE EXEMPTION OF THE
TAXES. SO SENATOR AWESOME TO
SUPPLY SPECIFICALLY TO THE
SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS ARE WHEN
THEY'RE NOT TIED TO A
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY SO THE
OWNER OR ANYONE WITH AN
INTEREST IN THAT PROPERTY THEY
WILL BE THE ONES WILL BE
AFFECTED BY THE BILL. THE
QUESTIONS. JUST TO THE OFFENDER
MARLA MISTER MANAGER JUST. THIS
WOULD ONLY BE OF. EFFECTIVE IF
THE BALLOT MEASURE FOR SPLIT
ROLE IS APPROVED IN NOVEMBER.
THAT'S CORRECT YES THANK YOU
HARPER THIS IS ALL BRAND NEW TO
ME SO WHO SHOULD I SHOULD I
SHOULD CLARIFY IT IS A TRAILER
BILL- SO TRAILER BILLS TO GO
INTO EFFECT. IF THIS WHAT ROLE
MEASURE IS NOT- IS NOT ENACTED
IN NOVEMBER THEN THE
PROVISIONAL BE REPEALED AS OF
THE FIRST YEAR NEXT YEAR AND
I'M SURE THIS WAS UP ON THE WEB
ON MAY FIFTEENTH AND I DIDN'T
READ THIS FUNNY THERE'S AT THE
CASE MANAGER. WITH ME NOT SURE
OF ABOUT I'M NOT SURE ABOUT
THIS ONE SO THIS IS THIS IS A
DIFFERENT MEASURE FROM BE DONE
VIOLENCE PREVENTION MEASURES
THAT WE WERE TO SETTLE YOUR
MIND AT EASE. YEAH I DID DID
YOU COULD JUST COME ABOUT LATER.
AND NOW LEGISLATIVE. SELECT TWO
HOURS AGO MAYBE. TO SALIVA BY
MOST THIS TIME IS THAT. I'LL BE
BACK TO YOU ON THAT. THE DALAI
A YOU HAVE MORE QUESTIONS NO I
JUST. IT JUST KIND OF YOU KNOW
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I GET IT
THE PUBLIC KNOWS THAT SOME OF
THESE THINGS CAN I COME AS A
SURPRISE SO. THANK YOU MANAGER
AND IN THE PUBLIC SHOULD BE
CONFIDENT KNOWING THAT THANKS
TO THEIR VOTE THAT NOTHING
COULD BE VOTED ON WITHIN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS OF BEING IN
PRINT. SO SENATOR DOLLY. THE
MANAGER THIS IS A- IT'S REALLY
CONCERNING TO ME- THINK SENATOR
ALSO BROUGHT UP A GREAT POINT.
SO FIRST OF ALL I'M SURE MOST
YOU KNOW ON THIS FLOOR THAT.
WE'VE BEEN DOING WE'VE BEEN
GIVING TAX FREE SOUL OR- FOR
HOMES A IN THE COUNTIES WITH
THAT WOULD WE WOULD BENEFIT
FROM THOSE TAXES SO IT'S NOT A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WITH ALL
FORMS OF RENEWABLES SO SOLAR
GET TO AN EXEMPTION. SO YOU'RE
COUNTY DOESN'T RECEIVE THE TAX
THAT YOU FIND. A LOT OF THINGS
WITHIN YOUR COUNTY YOUR YOUR
PUBLIC SAFETY- ROADS AND ALL
THE THINGS THAT COUNTIES
PROVIDE THIS WOULD BE A TAX
EITHER SO I AM I'M MY QUESTION
TO THE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
IS WHY IS THIS BILL IN HERE AND
WHAT. I MEAN I KNOW WE'RE GONNA
IT WE HAVE A SPLIT ROLE COMING-UP. BUT DID A WORD OF WARNING A
BUDGET. DEFICIT AND WE TALK
ABOUT REVENUES THIS IS ONE
PLACE WHERE I BELIEVE AS A
REPUBLICAN. WE SHOULD LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD AND MAKE THEM PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S PUT IN.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE A WIN PERSON
OR YOUR- OR YOUR OTHER TYPES OF
RENEWABLES THEY DON'T ENJOY
THIS SAME. A BENEFIT AND SO
IT'S REALLY NOT LEVEL AND IT'S
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS IN
THE RENEWABLES SOMETHING I'VE
BEEN FRUSTRATED WITH FOR A LONG
TIME IF IT'S ABOUT SAVING THE
ENVIRONMENT THEY SHOULD PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE THE- IN MY
OPINION THE SOLAR LOBBY IS JUST
OWN CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IT'S
OBVIOUS WHEN YOU SEE- SOME OF
THE ABSURDITIES THAT COME OUT
OF THIS PLACE. WITH THE
INCENTIVES THAT THEY GET OVER
OTHER TYPES OF RENEWABLE SO I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHY THIS IS
IN THIS BUDGET IT IS A LAST
MINUTE DEAL- NO DOUBT ABOUT IT-
IN IN IN ITS RETROACTIVE ONLY
IF. ABOUT INITIATIVE GETS
PASSED SO THIS IS REALLY
CONCERNING IN THE PROCESS OF
HOW WE LEGISLATURE HERE AND I
WILL TELL YOU THE LOCALS ARE
LOSING OUT ON THIS AND THE AND
THE AND EVERYBODY ELSE IS IN
THE RENEWABLE BUSINESS. THANK
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
BUT STILL LIKE AN ANSWER FROM
DHAHRAN THEM ONLINE ASK WHY
THIS IS IN THE AIR AND WHAT'S
DRIVING THIS FINANCE. A YES
CENTER GOLLY I'LL MAKE A COUPLE
OF BRIEF POINTS- I THINK FIRST
OF ALL- IS THE FACT AS HE
MENTIONS THAT THAT THIS
WOULDN'T GO INTO A FACT UNLESS
THERE'S SCHOOLS AND RELEASED
FIRST INITIATIVE. IS ENACTED BY
THE VOTERS IN NOVEMBER AND
WHILE I SHOULD EMPHASIZE THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS NOT TAKEN AT
SPECIFIC POSITION ON THAT
BALLOT MEASURE AS OF YET- TO
ADDRESS YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
FISCAL PRESSURES AND IF THAT
MEASURE ERE TO BE ENACTED- AND
THIS PROVISION WORDS TO TAKE A
FACT OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS ON THERE WOULD BE A NET.
POSITIVE EFFECT ON LOCAL
REVENUES AT FOR SCHOOLS ANOTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO YOUR POINT
ABOUT NAY SO I'M TAKING REVENUE
AWAY IN A BUDGET DEFICIT I'M
WHILE THERE MIGHT THERE WOULD
BE A REVENUE DECLINE FOR THIS
SPECIFIC PROVISIONS IT WOULD BE
IN THE CONTEXT OF A BROADER
STACKS OF REVENUE INCREASES AND
I THINK THE BROADER POINT- I
WILL MAKE IS. AS YOU MENTIONED
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PROVISIONS THAT RELATED TO
ENERGY- THAT THE MIST VERSION
OF LEGISLATURE OFTEN DISCUSSED
TOGETHER- BUT SOLAR AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY MORE BROADLY-
IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PART AT.
MEETING STATES CLIMATE GOALS
ARE AND WE KNOW THAT AS YOU
TODAY AS THE YEARS GO BY THOSE
GOALS BECOME INCREASINGLY
URGENT- SO THAT'S ANOTHER
REASON WHY CAN RESULT IT WAS
IMPORTANT. TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS. TO ALL TAKE THAT AS-
THEIR GOOD AT GETTING LOBBY IN.
AND THEIR HEDGING THEIR BETS
EVEN IF THE PROPER. SPUR ROLE
PASS. THIS IS A- THIS IS JUST.
I CAN'T BELIEVE. WE'RE DOING
THIS IN A TIME WHERE WE NEED
REVENUES AND WE NEED TO LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD SO I
APPRECIATE- THE LONG ANSWER TO
A SHORT QUESTION. THAT THEY'RE
JUST AHEAD OF THE GAME ON
GETTING THEIR POSITION. SO THAT
THEY STILL CONTINUE TO GET A
BREAK. OVERALL IF THERE'S A
SPLIT ROLE. SENATOR MORLOCK
ANOTHER CLARIFICATION FROM
MISTER VISWANATHA AND CENTER
DOLLAR BRINGS UP A GREAT POINT
WE ARE NOW GIVING A TAX BREAK
BUT IT COMES AT THE COST OF
COUNTY. GOVERNMENT ARE ARE WE
THEN GOING TO REIMBURSE THE
COUNTY FOR THE LOST REVENUE I
MEAN IT IT'S SO EASY FOR US TO
CUT DEALS WITH IT DOESN'T
AFFECT SACRAMENTO BUT IT IF IT
AFFECTS SOMEONE ELSE I I'M NOT
SO SURE THAT'S- THAT'S THAT'S
EVEN ETHICAL BUT- I I'M JUST
CURIOUS IT. WHAT HAPPENS TO
HOUSES THAT EXISTS OUT OF THE
COUNTY MAKE UP THE LOST REVENUE
FINANCE YES I WANT TO MAKE A
COUPLE POINTS FIRST- AND I MAY
NOT HAVE CLARIFIED THIS BEFORE
BUT THIS IS A RE ENACTMENT OF
CURRENT LAW SO THESE PROVISIONS
AND THE PURPOSES BEHIND THEM
ARE ALREADY A CURRENT LAW AND
SO- IF HE INITIATIVES AND ACTED
THIS WOULD SIMPLY REFLECT AT.
NEW A SNAP THAT ALREADY AND
THEN THE SECOND POINT THIS BILL
DOES NOT CERTAINLY DOES NOT
CONTEMPLATE A BACK SALES BUT I
THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE
BROADER CONTEXT OF SCHOOLS IN
THE FIRST FOUR TO PASS-
ESTIMATED REVENUE RANGES
ANYWHERE STATE TEN OR TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS SO- THE ANY
REVENUE GAINS FROM THE LIST
WOULD MORE THAN OFFSET BY MANY
MULTIPLES HI ANY EXCHANGE. AS A
RESULT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU SIR ANY
OTHER QUESTION. THREE NONE
CLIPS PROCEED TO AB ONE
NINETEEN- INVOLVING STATE
EMPLOYMENT IN THE STATE
BARGAINING UNITS AND THERE ARE
SEVERAL LISTED THERE IN THE
AGENDA. FINANCE YES ON THE
ESTATE BARGAINING BILL AS YOU
MENTION MADAM CHAIR- THIS-
MAKES CHANGES ALLOWING FOR THE
RATIFICATION OF AMMO USED IN
ATTENDANCE FOR SEVERAL
BARGAINING UNITS I'LL JUST LIST
THEM BARGAINING UNIT ONE THREE
FOUR SIX NINE ELEVEN.
301-718-2020 ONE ON AND IN
PARTICULAR THE PROVISIONS OF
THE TRAILER BILL. LABEL RIGHT
TO SIXTY. AS LONG AS THERE ARE
SAVINGS IN THESE AGREEMENT- IN
THESE AGREEMENTS THAT REFLECT-
WHAT IS THE SAVINGS ASSUMES AS
PART OF THE BUDGET AT THAT IS
BEING CONSIDERED AN ENACTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY. SO I KNOW THERE MAY BE
A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS RELATED
TO THE SPECIFICS OF THESE
HEARINGS I'M SORRY LEASE
AGREEMENTS- SO I'M GOING TO.
ALSO HAVE MERRY HALTER MADE MY
COLLEAGUE A DEAL LAST AND WILL
BOTH BE ON THE LINE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT. THE
SPECIFIC AGREEMENTS OR THE
SAVINGS THAT WERE REFLECTED IN
THE BUDGET ACT. QUESTIONS
MEMBERS THIRTY PAN. I THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH ACTUALLY MY
QUESTION ISN'T ABOUT ANY ONE
THE SPECIFIC AGREEMENTS AND
APPRECIATE- THAT YOU THE AGENT
A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS
WITH THOSE BARGAINING UNITS. I
IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY IS
PROVISION IN THIS TRAILER BILL
THAT BASICALLY HAS THE
LEGISLATURE SIGN OFF ON
ADDITIONAL AGREEMENTS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN REACHED YET PRIOR TO
THE- END OF THE YEAR ARE. CAN
YOU CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT IS-
PROVISION FOR US TO APPROVE
AGREEMENTS HAVE NOT YET BEEN
INTO GHOST COME. WHEN WHICH
NEGOTIATIONS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED. SENATOR PENN DEAD SO
IT YES AS YOU KNOW THAT FISCAL
YEAR BEGINS ON JULY FIRST FOR
NEXT YEAR SO A LOT OF AT LEAST
FOR THESE AGREEMENTS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SAVINGS ARE
REFLECTED. FOR ANY CHANGES THAT
MIGHT OTHERWISE GO INTO EFFECT
ON JULY ONE. AND ENSURE THAT WE
GET THE SAVINGS FOR THAT WHOLE
YEAR WHEN IT COMES TO THE EXACT
MECHANISM LET ME TURN IT OVER
TO. AND SPEAKS THAT. ALL RIGHT
APARTMENT FINANCE GUYS SO AND
WITH THAT IS INCLUDED IN THIS
TRAILER ABOUT VERY FACING IS
I'M CIRCUS. I THIS IS ALL AS
AROUND PROCESS FOR AGREEMENT
AND THAT ARE STILL TO BE SHE-
SO IT'S GOING TO AS AND WAS
MAKING ONLINE A LONG
STREAMLINED PROCESS
SPECIFICALLY I'M THEY MUST
CONTRIBUTE TO THE CONTROL
SECTION REFINANCING AND BUDGET
FOR IN TIME IN THE BUDGET-
JUNIOR LANGUAGE AND THIS
PROCESS IS ONLY IN PLACE
THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH SO NEXT
USAIN. ROXBURY ON JULY ONE NEXT
OF NEXT WEDNESDAY I'M WILL
REVERT BACK TO THE NORMAL
RATIFICATION. I JUST LIKE HER I
AM RIGHT RIGHT INTO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE ON.
OKAY WELL I WOULD JUST NINETY
EIGHT THEN. SHE THE END SO I AM
GUESS SOME OF TO OF PUBLIC AND-
IN RETURN COMMITTEE. FOR THE
STATE SENATE. AND IN THE PAST I
IN USED ACTUALLY HEARD. BY THE
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO FULLY THAT THE
MO USE AND THEN WE SIR SHIFTED
TO A PROCESS BY WHICH- WE PUT
THEM TO USE THROUGH THE BUDGET
NOW BILLY THAT ALLOWED THE-
NUMBER YOU TO ACTUALLY TAKE A
FAX WITH THE NEW BUDGET YEAR
INSTEAD OF WAITING TILL.
JANUARY FIRST BUT DID SORT OF
SHORT CIRCUITED OF THE
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW. AND NOW IN
THIS CASE WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE HELP FREE APPROVING
AGREEMENTS THAT HAVEN'T EVEN
BEEN SETTLED ON NOW I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND AND YOU HAVE SAID IN
YOUR TESTIMONY- THESE ARE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES. BUT I DID
WANT TO ASK ABOUT IT AND SAY
THAT I CERTAINLY HOPE AND I
KNOW REALIZE THAT THE PROVISION
IT'S IN THIS PARTICULAR TRAILER
BILL IS VERY TIME LIMITED- THAT
THIS DOES NOT BECOME A HABIT.
THIS IS NOT A PRECEDENCE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE EXPECTED- IN
FACT A RIGHTS I STILL THINK
EMMA YOU SHOULD HAVE A GREATER
VETTING THAN THEY DAY IN RECENT.
OFFICE HAVE BEEN IN PLACE DEBTS
I THINK THAT IS A ROLE THE
PURSE COMMITTEE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO SHOULD ACTUALLY A PLAY- BUT-
CERTAINLY I DO NOT THINK IT'S A-
GOOD IDEA FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO BE PRE APPROVING- HELLO USE-
YOU KNOW EXCEPT IN EXTREMELY
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES SO.
YOU HAVE SAID THIS IS EXTREMELY
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCE WILL
CERTAINLY WE CAN LOOK AROUND
AND SAY YES IT PROBABLY IS THIS
IS A ONE IN A HUNDRED YEAR
PANDEMIC- BUT CERTAINLY I HOPE
THIS IS NOT THE TYPE OF
PROPOSAL WE EXPECT TO SEE FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION. ANYTIME IN
THE NEXT HUNDRED YEARS AFTER
THIS THANK YOU. SENATE MORE LAP
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF EVERY
TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT. FOR
NEGOTIATING FOR PARTICIPATING-
IT IS IT IS NICE TO SEE THAT
THE EMPLOYEES ARE TAKING A 10%
CUT IN PAY. DURING THIS MOST
DIFFICULT TIME BUT- THIS
AGREEMENT ALSO SAYS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO SUSPEND. THE
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS FOR
OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
WHICH IS 4% SO. THEY'RE TAKING
A TRADE OFF IN THE REALLY
ACTUALLY JUST TAKING A 6% PAY
CUT SO. BAD TO ADVERTISE THAT
WERE. ASKING HIM TO MAKE A 10%
CUT IS ACTUALLY AN EXAGGERATION.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO RECOMMEND TO
MISTER THIS ONE OF FUND. THAT
YOU CONSIDER MOVING FORWARD NOT
TO CONTINUE WITH HOLDING 4%
FROM THE EMPLOYEES OF THE
STATE. THAT THE STATE ITSELF
PLEASE. AT 4% INTO THE- HAVE
TRUST AND THEREFORE YOU HAVE
SOME ROOM TO GIVE RAISES
WITHOUT GIVING A REYES
NECESSARILY- BUT- YOU ALSO
DON'T HAVE TO INCUR MORE IF I
COULD TAX FOR OTHER EMPLOYEES
ARE IMPACTED. BUT YOU THEN AS A
STATE WE AS A STATE WILL BE
PAYING THAT. ANNUAL
CONTRIBUTION TO PAY DOWN THE-
HOPE HAVE TRUST BALANCE OF SOME
EIGHTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
WHICH IS ON OUR BALANCE SHEET.
AND THEN YOU RE NEGOTIATE THE
ENTIRE RETIREE MEDICAL PLAN.
YOU INTEGRATED WITH MEDICARE
YOU. HAVE MORE REALISTIC. A
COLA PERCENTAGES YOU- WHO HAVE
SOME EARLY RETIREMENT
DISINCENTIVES WE DID THIS. IN
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE AND WE
REDUCED OUR UNFUNDED LIABILITY
BY 71% WITH JUST A FEW MINOR
BARGAINING UNITS AGREED TO. AND
YOU WOULD REMOVE FROM THE
BALLOT SHEET OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YOU'D REMOVE SIXTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES. AND THAT WOULD GET
US OUT OF THE BOTTOM OF THE
RACE WITH THE ILLINOIS IN NEW
JERSEY SO HERE'S A REAL
OPPORTUNITY. TO MAKE A CHANGE
TO A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM THAT
KEEPS GROWING. BECAUSE IF YOU
DO NOT. WITHHOLD THE- CAB
CONTRIBUTION THIS YEAR TO
SUSPEND THAT YOU'RE ADDING
ANOTHER ONE POINT TWO BILLION
TO OUR LIABILITIES. AND WE'RE
ALREADY ADDING ANOTHER THREE
BILLION BECAUSE WE'VE TAKEN
BACK ARE PREPAYMENT OF CALPERS
SO. WE'RE REALLY ADDING. SOME
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL BURDENS
TO THE NEXT YEAR TWO THREE
FOUR- FOR THOSE THAT FOLLOW AND
WE REALLY HAVE TO HOPE FOR SOME
KIND OF ECONOMIC EXPANSION. AND
I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN BE TO
RECORD. BUT WE'VE GOT TO START
PLANNING AHEAD SO I. I OFFER
THAT TO YOU MISTER RESPOND UPON
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
FIX SOMETHING THAT SYSTEMIC
WITH BROKEN. AND IF YOU NEED
ANY HELP PROMOTE WE GET AN
ORANGE COUNTY I'M HAPPY TO HELP
YOU OUT THANK YOU MISS. MR BUT
IT'S ONE OF ON IT THANK YOU
MANAGER. YOU'RE VERY WELCOME
THE OTHER MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CITY
NONE. COLLEAGUES LEADS A GO TO
OF THE GOLDEN ROD THE
ADDITIONAL BILL THAT WAS ADDED
AS AN ADDENDUM TO THE AGENDA
SENATE BILL. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. MR THIS ONE OFTEN. THE
LAST- BILL ON THE AGENDA AT AGE
AND AS YOU SAID- MADAM CHAIR
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE AND I SHOULD MENTION THAT
THAT THIS IS- WHILE NOT
TYPICALLY- TRAILER BILL UNDER
THE DEFINITION OF PROPOSITION
TWENTY FIVE- IT IS- WE BELIEVE
AN IMPORTANT PART OF IT BUDGET
PACKAGE AND SO I'LL JUST SPEAK
BRIEFLY TO THE KEY ELEMENTS ARE
CHRIS COOK IS ON THE LINE- FOR
ANY DETAILS AS WELL AND WE'RE
ACT ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT-
THE- KEY PROVISIONS OF THE
STALE GREW OUT OF BOTH THE
TWENTY NIGHTS. IN BUDGET AX
EXPANSION OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FROM
SIX WEEKS STATE WEEKS AS WELL
AS THAT TASK FORCE WAS FORMED
THAT CAME UP WITH ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE KEY A
MEASURE OR THE THRUST OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS THE FACT
THAT EVEN WHEN KATE AND WE
WAIVE IS AVAILABLE WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT WORKER PROTECTIONS
MANY EMPLOYEES DON'T FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT ENABLES TWELVE
WEEKS OF JOB PROTECTED LEAVE
FOR ALL WORKERS ARE CARD MOST
OF THEIR EMPLOYERS SIZE.
EXPANDS THE TYPES OF FAMILIAL
RELATIONSHIPS CONVERTS THAT
MORE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND IT ALSO
ALLOWS- EVEN IF YOU PERRANCE AT
THE SAME EMPLOYER THEY DON'T
HAVE TO SPLIT THE TWELVE WEEKS
AMONG EACH THAT MAD THEY WOULD
EACH GET ACCESS TO THE FULL.
TWELVE YEAH THAT'S- SO WE THIS
IS PART OF THE OVER. MOOD THAT
WE WHICH IS NOT FOR JOB WHICH I.
FROM TO ACTUALLY TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE LEAD THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS PROVIDED.
QUESTION FOR MEMBERS TO THE TO
ROTH FOLLOWED BY SENATOR MILK
IT ARRIVES. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR FIRST TO. COUPLE
STATEMENTS OR COMMENTS AND
THEN- SOME QUESTIONS YOU KNOW.
WHEN WE SET THE EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS POLICY FOR EMPLOYERS
AND EMPLOYEES WE GENERALLY
ESTABLISH COVERAGE THRESHOLDS
TO ENSURE THAT THE- EMPLOYER
AND THE EMPLOYER'S BUSINESS CAN
SUSTAIN THE POLICY IN IN THE
CASE OF LEAVE POLICIES THAT THE-
EMPLOYERS OPERATION OR THE
ENTERPRISE IS ABLE TO HANDLE
THE LOSS OF AN EMPLOYEE EASE
SERVICES AS WE PROVIDE. A IN
THIS CASE WELL DESERVED LEAVE
BENEFITS. AND IN IN SETTING
THESE EMPLOYEE COVERAGE
THRESHOLD FOR LEAVE ENTITLEMENT
WE ALSO LOOK AT THE ANTICIPATED
FREQUENCY OF THE LEAVE THAT'S
GOING TO BE PROVIDED. AND SO-
FOR THOSE REASONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS I KNOW FINANCE
KNOWS. WE'VE HAD A PREGNANCY
DISABILITY LEAVE PROGRAM THAT
FOR FORTY YEARS SINCE AROUND.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT SEVENTY NINE HAS
SET A COVERAGE THRESHOLD. OF
FIVE EMPLOYEES FIVE FULL TIME
OR FULL TIME EQUIVALENT.
PREGNANCY EVENTS OCCURRING WITH
SOME FREQUENCY IN THE WORKPLACE
BUT NOT QUITE AS FREQUENT AS AN
EMPLOYEES OWN ILLNESS OF THE
ILLNESS OF EMPLOYEES FAMILY.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON BACK IN
ABOUT NINETEEN NINETY THREE
WHEN WE- SET UP THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHTS ACT TO PROVIDE
LEAVE TO AN EMPLOYEE ON ACCOUNT
OF THE EMPLOYEES OWN SERIOUS
HEALTH CONDITION OR THE SERIOUS
HEALTH CONDITION OF EMPLOYEES.
OF PARENT SPOUSE OR CHILD. WE
SET UP AN EMPLOYEE THRESHOLD SO
THAT'S FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
WE'VE HAD THAT WE SET UP A
COVERAGE FULLY COVERED
THRESHOLD OF FIFTY EMPLOYEES.
LEAST UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHEN FOR THE BONDING
PIECE BONDING WITH A NEWLY
ADOPTED OR NEWLY BORN CHILD
THAT THRESHOLD WAS REDUCED. TO
TWENTY EMPLOYEES. SO IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING NOW THAT WE HAVE
TAKEN THOSE POLICIES AT A BRAT
BEEN AROUND FROM TAUGHT FOR
TWENTY SEVEN OR FORTY YEARS
WITH COVERAGE THRESHOLDS THAT
HAVE BEEN WELL ESTABLISHED AN
EMPLOYER THE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY
ANY EMPLOYEE COMMUNITY
UNDERSTANDS WE'RE TAKING ALL OF
THOSE THRESHOLDS DOWN TO ONE
EMPLOYEE IS THAT CORRECT. MR
HIS WHEN OFTEN. YES THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD LIKE TAKE
THAT ANY EMPLOYEE- IN THE
STATE- GIVEN THAT THE PURPOSE
OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE TO PROVIDE
TIME FOR BONDING- OR RELATED
PURPOSES FOR FAMILY WE- BELIEVE
THAT ANYBODY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT. LIST IS
CLEAR ONE THING UP YOU KEEP
USING THE TERM PAID FAMILY
LEAVE AND WE'LL GET TO THE TASK
FORCE REPORT IN A MINUTE. BUT
PAID FAMILY LEAVE IS AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT SUBJECT SET
FORTH IN THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CODE OF CALIFORNIANS
SECTION THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
SEC. IT'S A IT'S A WAGE
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM IT'S
ADMINISTERED BY THE EDT SIMILAR
TO STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
AND IT HAS PROVIDED THE SIX
WEEKS AND WILL PROVIDE THE
EIGHT WEEKS THAT YOU. MENTIONED
EARLIER BUT THAT'S TERRACE
MANAL CORRECT TALKING I
APOLOGIZE SENATOR I MEANT JOB
REJECTED WEEDS OUT I APOLOGIZE.
FOR THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION. SO GOING TO MAKE
AND YOU ANSWERED IT SO GIVEN
THAT EXPLANATION THE THRESHOLDS
ARE GOING DOWN TO ONE EMPLOYEE.
SO AS AN EMPLOYER FOR HAVE ONE
EMPLOYEE AND SHE HAPPENS TO BE
A FEMALE. AND SHE IS BECOMES
PREGNANT. AND IT'S A PROBLEM
PREGNANCY THEN THAT EMPLOYEE
WOULD BE ENTITLED TO UP TO FOUR
MONTHS SIXTEEN WEEKS OF
PROTECTED PREGNANCY DISABILITY
LEAVE CORRECT. LET ME TURN IT
OVER TO CHRIS CUT CHECK
CONFIRMED THAT EXACT SITUATION
THEY DESCRIBED. YES SENATE ROTH
THE YOU'RE CORRECT IT IF THERE
IS A THE INDIVIDUAL WOULD ALSO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR A DISABILITY
LEAVE IF THERE WAS- ISSUES WITH
THE PREGNANCY AS WELL. BUT FOUR
MONTHS OF NOT PAY BUT FOUR
MONTHS OF JOB PROTECTED
PREGNANCY DISABILITY LEAVE
CORRECT CORRECT. AND THEN AT
THE COMPLETION OF THE PREGNANCY
DISABILITY LEAVE WHEN THE
EMPLOYEE MY ONE EMPLOYEE IS
ABLE TO RETURN TO WORK THE
EMPLOYEE IF THE EMPLOYEE SO
CHOOSES. UNDER THE
MODIFICATIONS TO THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHTS THAT COULD BE
ALSO BE ENTITLED TO. TWELVE
THREE MONTHS OR TWELVE WEEKS OF.
BINDING LEAVE CORRECT. CLEARLY
YES YOU MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR
WHAT. FOR TWELVE WEEKS THREE
MONTHS OF BONDING LEAVE WITH
THE NEWLY BORN CHILD CORRECT.
WELL SAVE YOU TIME THE ANSWER
IS YES. SO DURING THIS TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD OF TIME MY ONE
EMPLOYEE WOULD BE OFF WORK FOR.
SEVEN MONTHS CORRECT. AND
DURING THIS LEAVE BOTH THE
PREGNANCY DISABILITY LEAVE AND
THE- BONDING LEAVE THE EMPLOYEE
WOULD BE ENTITLED TO TAKE AND I
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO PAY. FOR
MY ONE EMPLOYEE. ANY AND ALL
ACCRUED VACATION AND SICK LEAVE
CORRECT. A CRACKED. AND THE
EMPLOYEE WOULD BE ENTITLED TO
RECEIVE THAT I WOULD BE
OBLIGATED TO PROVIDE TO THE
EXTENT THAT I. HAD A GROUP
HEALTH POLICY IN PLACE FOR
MYSELF AND MY EMPLOYEE I WOULD
BE OBLIGATED TO CONTINUE. THE
PREMIUMS AND CONTINUE THE GROUP
HEALTH COVERAGE FOR THAT
EMPLOYEE RIGHT. THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY. MEL MY RESEARCH REFLECTS
THAT IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
ONE POINT SIX MILLION EMPLOYERS.
TEN ABOUT ONE POINT ONE MILLION
OF THOSE EMPLOYERS HAVE FIVE OR
FEWER. EMPLOYEES. SO I GUESS MY
NEXT QUESTION IS WHY WHAT WAS
WHAT WAS THE RATIONALE. TO TAKE
THESE WELL ESTABLISHED COVERAGE
TRACHSEL'S THAT WERE SET
OBVIOUSLY FOR A REASON AT THE
TIME THAT THE VERY STATUTES
WERE ENACTED AND DRAW ALL OF
THOSE DOWN TO ONE EMPLOYEE.
YEAH. WE BELIEVE ARM. WE
BELIEVE PROVIDING THESE THE
COVERAGE IS ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE
THE PROTECTION IS AVAILABLE FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS- AND THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
PAYING INTO IT SHOULD BE
ENTITLED TO THESE PROTECTIONS
WELL I'M SURE THAT'S THE CASE
BUT I MEAN WAS THERE SOME
OBJECTIVE ANALYSIS THAT WENT
INTO THIS DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. SOME SERIES OF
DECISION POINTS THAT YOU
CONSIDERED AN- DEALT WITH AN
USED TO MAKE THE DETERMINATION
THAT YOU MADE OBVIOUSLY WE'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE BENEFITS TO
EVERYONE. RIGHT BUT I WILL SAY
SENATOR ROBB THAT AT THIS HAS
BEEN- DISCUSSION THAT- THE
GOVERNOR AND THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS BEEN HAVING- OVER ANY
MONTHS INCLUDING BOTH IN THE
TASK FORCE AS WELL AS
CONVERSATION SO I KNOW THERE
MAY BE A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
ON THE OUTCOME- BUT IT WAS NOT
A ROSS STORE CARE WAS DECISION
WELL THIS GOES TO MY EARLIER
COMMENTS I MEAN YOU WHEN. YOU
TAKE A POLICY ISSUE THAT IS
UNTETHERED TO A LINE ITEM IN
THE BUDGET. AND YOU BRING IT
INTO A BUDGET COMMITTEE YOU
MUST NOT TO BE TOO DISAPPOINTED
IF WE DEAL WITH THIS AS A
POLICY ISSUE AND ASK YOU POLICY
BASED QUESTIONS SO LET ME
FOLLOW WITH ANOTHER ONE. IN
COMING UP WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
DID THE ADMINISTRATION THE
ADMINISTRATION. DO A STUDY OR
ANALYSIS ON THE IMPACT OF THIS
RATHER SIGNIFICANT POLICY
CHANGE. SINCE IT'S GOING TO HIT
ONE POINT SIX MILLION EMPLOYERS
TO ONE EXTENT OR ANOTHER. DID
THE ADMINISTRATION DO A STUDY
OR ANALYSIS OF THE IMPACT OF
THIS POLICY CHANGE ON EMPLOYERS
AND IN PARTICULAR SMALL
EMPLOYERS. THE TASK FORCE
CERTAINLY CONSIDERED AT ALL OF
THOSE CONSIDERATIONS- I'D HAVE
TO CHECK WITH THEM UNLESS CHRIS
KNOWS THAT BUT WE HAVE TO CHECK
WHETHER THEY DID THAT SPECIFIC
ANALYSIS YOU'RE REFERRING TO
BUT CERTAINLY THAT WAS PART OF
THE EVALUATION WILL BE IS THIS
THE TASK FORCE THE TASK FORCE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PAID LEAVE.
TASK FORCE THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT YES ALTHOUGH THAT'S JUST
ONE VEHICLE- THIS IS DAN- UNDER
DELIBERATION AND- YOU KNOW WE
HAD THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED
IN JANUARY- THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT A LOT OF THOUGHT HAS GONE
INTO. WILLOWS ILLUSTRATES
ANOTHER PROBLEM I ASK FOR ANY
REPORTS THAT FORM THE BASIS FOR
THIS POLICY DETERMINATION AND
WHAT I WAS PROVIDED. WAS A I
WAS PROVIDED WITH ESSENTIALLY.
AFIVE PAGE TYPED REPORT NOT
SIGNED. AND I WAS TOLD THIS WAS
THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS USED TO
COME UP WITH THE POLICY CHANGE.
AND IT'S ENTITLED PAID FAMILY
LEAVE IN AGE YOU HAVE ALREADY
NOTED IN RESPONSE TO MY
QUESTION PAID FAMILY LEAVE IS
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CODE
NOT THE GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTIONS THAT WE'RE AMENDING
HERE SO. IS THERE ANOTHER
REPORT THAT I WAS NOT PROVIDED
WITH IN RESPONSE TO MY REQUEST.
I'LL DEFER TO CHRIS ON THAT-
IT'S WE KNOW OF ANY OTHER. YEAH
SO CENTER OUT THE DOCUMENT THAT
YOU HAVE I OR A SCENE YOU HAVE
IT WAS A SUMMARY OF THE WORK
THAT WAS PUT FORWARD BY THE
TASK FORCE. WHICH WHICH
REPRESENTED- MANY STAKEHOLDERS
MEMBERS I STAFF FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FINANCING
DEPARTMENTS- AND CONSIDERATION
DID GO INTO THE IMPACTS ON
SMALL BUSINESSES. AND AS A
MATTER OF FACT A SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY AND OTHER SMALL
BUSINESS- GROUPS WERE- ACTIVE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE TASK THAT
THE MONTHLY TASK FORCE MEETING.
WELL I'M GLAD YOU MENTIONED
THAT I'M LOOKING AT THE- I WAS
LOOKING AT THE SIGNATORIES OF
ALL THEY'RE NOT SIGNATURES BUT
THERE'S SIGNATURE BLOCKS. AND
OF COURSE THE LEAD ONE IS THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL AND MY
QUESTION WAS WHETHER THERE WAS
SMALL BUSINESS PARTICIPATION IN
THIS GROUP FRANKLY I'LL BE
HONEST WITH YOU. AND I LOOKED
AT THE BAY AREA COUNCIL AND I'M
LOOKING AT THE MEMBERSHIP. THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE FOR EXAMPLE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS. GENENTECH
UNION BANK. LIVE I GUESS THEY
HAVE EMPLOYEES NOW COMCAST. AT
AND T. PGA. I'M WELLS FARGO AND
ON AND ON AND THEN YOU GO BACK
AND YOU LIST THEM YOU LOOK AT
THE MEMBER COMPANIES I HAVE
I'VE HAD A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
IDENTIFYING ANY OF THE
COMPANIES IN THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL THAT I WOULD CONSIDER
SMALL EMPLOYERS SOMEONE WITH
FIVE EMPLOYEES OR TEN EMPLOYEES
OR EVEN FIFTEEN AND THEN I
LOOKED AT THE- OTHER.
PARTICIPANTS IN THIS TEST WORSE
OF COURSE THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION OUR FRIENDS OVER
THERE AND- ON AND ON AND I GET
DOWN TO THIS THING CALLED THE
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY. AND I
DID A LITTLE HOMEWORK AND WHAT
I FOUND WAS IT'S A FIVE OH ONE
C. THREE BUT- DO YOU KNOW HOW
MANY. EMPLOYER MEMBERS. THE
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY HAS.
FINANCE WE DO NOT WAIT I HAVE
WILL IN FACT IN THE YOU KNOW TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN CONSIDER
NEWSPAPERS AUTHORITATIVE
SOURCES ANYMORE THE NEWSPAPER
REPORTS INDICATE SORT OF
REFLECTED THERE ARE NO EMPLOYER
MEMBERS OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY IT IS IN FACT A FIVE
OH ONE SEE THREE. OF FUNDED BY
FOUNDATIONS AND SO I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THIS TASK FORCE
REPORT HAD. VERY LITTLE IF ANY.
SMALL BUSINESS REPRESENTATION
SO IN ADDITION TO IT FOCUSING
ON THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE WHICH
IS NOT THE SORT OF. SECTIONS
THAT WERE AMENDING. I DON'T
BELIEVE IN IT DOESN'T REFLECT
THAT IT HAD ANY SMALL BUSINESS
REPRESENTATION PROVIDING INPUT
AS TO THESE RATHER SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES. WAS THERE ANY OTHER
STUDY THAT WAS DONE. DID THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE ANY OTHER
CONTACT WITH CALIFORNIA'S SMALL
BUSINESS CONTENTION TO
DETERMINE HOW THESE CHANGES
WOULD IMPACT THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY. YES I'M I BELIEVE
THERE WAS A REPORT OR A STUDY
DONE BY STANFORD- ON ON THIS
IMPACT DO YOU THINK SINCE
YOU'RE ASKING US TO CHANGE
POLICY DO YOU THINK. THAT
HAVING THAT STUDY TO REVIEW IN
ADVANCE AND DISCUSS WITH YOU
WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL
AND 4 DEGREES OF INCREASE. I
THINK IF THE WE THEY WERE THERE
ARE POOR WE CAN PROVIDE THE
REPORT IF THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING AGAIN I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT DURING THE TIME OF THE
TASK FORCE THERE WERE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM- THE LEAD
STAFF THAT WERE ALSO IN
ATTENDANCE- AND- THEY WERE-
THEY HAD ACCESS TO THE SAME
INFORMATION THAT WAS PROVIDED
TO THE TASK FORCE WILL
UNFORTUNATELY THEY OF WHOEVER
THEY ARE WHEREVER THEY ARE IN
THIS BUILDING THEY DON'T TALK
TO ME. SO IS IT YOUR POSITION
THAT SMALL BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS THIS CHANGE.
I CAN'T SPEAK ON BEHALF OF ALL
SMALL BUSINESS BUT THE ONES
THAT WERE PARTICIPATING IN THE
TASK FORCE YES. WHAT THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES WHICH
CLAIMS I'M NOT A MEMBER. CLAIMS
TO REPRESENT FIFTEEN THOUSAND.
SMALL BUSINESS. OPERATORS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HAS
FILED A LETTER OF OPPOSITION
DID YOU CONSULT WITH THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS. I CAN'T
CONFIRM OR DENY IF WE IF WE DID.
SENATOR ROBB WE'VE GOT SEVERAL
OF THE MEMBERS THAT HAVE
QUESTIONS COULD YOU JUST ABOUT
INTERNET MORE YOU'LL BE ASKING
I HAVE SEVERAL MORE MANAGER
THAT I DIDN'T ASK TO PUT THIS
POLICY BILL IN A BUDGET
COMMITTEE SENATOR ROBB. I AM
AWARE OF THAT SIR AND I'M
SIMPLY ASKINGYOU HOW MANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
BECAUSE WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS AND I HAVE AND IF THERE
ARE QUESTIONS THAT FINANCED
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE CAN
ACTUALLY ANSWER MADAM CHAIR
WHAT DO WE DO IF THEY DON'T PUT
SOMEBODY AT THE MIKE WHO CAN
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THE CENTER
WALL GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
QUESTION THE NUMBER TO MOVE ON
WITH THE OTHER MEMBERS FATAL
HEAD. SO IN LOOKING AT YOUR
REPORT- MISSED HIS WHEN OFTEN.
ONE OF THE THINGS IT SAYS AS
PART OF THE RECORD
RECOMMENDATION IF YOU ARE GOING
TO MAKE THESE CHANGES. IS TO
CREATE A PILOT GRANT PROGRAM TO
HELP SMALL EMPLOYERS WITH
INCREASED LABOR. AND OTHER
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH LEAVE
TIME. WAS A GRANT PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED. IN FACT IT SAYS
THE TIMING OF EXPANDED JOB
PROTECTION AND SMALL BUSINESS
MITIGATION MUST BE CONGRUENT.
I'M SORRY COULD YOU REPEAT THAT
QUESTION. RE TASK FORCE REPORTS
WHICH YOU ALL ARE RELYING ON TO
SUPPORT THESE CHANGES SAYS. IN
ORDER TO MAKE THE CHANGES THAT
YOU SHOULD CREATE A PILOT GRANT
PROGRAM TO HELP SMALL EMPLOYERS
WITH INCREASED LABOR AND OTHER
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH LEAVE
TIME. IT FURTHER STATES THE
TIMING OF EXPANDED JOB
PROTECTION AND SMALL BUSINESS
MITIGATION MUST BE CONGRUENT.
WAS A PILOT GRANT PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED. NO NO PILOT
PROGRAM. SENATOR ROBB I
WOULDN'T KNOW THAT THERE IS ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
CURRENTLY SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS
PURPOSE I DID NOTE THAT SO IF
THERE'S A MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET PROVIDED IT'S PASSED
AND SIGNED THAT'S LESS THAN ONE
DOLLAR PER EMPLOYER NOT ONE
DOLLAR PER EMPLOYEE DO YOU FIND
THAT. SMALL BUSINESS GRANT
PROGRAM TO BE SUFFICIENT TO
COVER THE MITIGATION AND OTHER
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CHANGES THAT YOU PROPOSE. NOW
BUT WE VIEW THE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS AS A PILOT PROGRAM AND
IT WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR
ALL IT WOULD BE JUST TO-
PROVIDE SOME RELIEF IN ADDITION
TO THE OTHER SERVICES THAT ARE
ALSO PROVIDED THROUGH THE STATE
I WOULD KNOW THAT THE- THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL HAS A
LOT OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THAT CAN HELP BUSINESSES. BY
WAY OF PROVIDING. TRAINING AND
OTHER TYPES OF-SERVICE LIKE-
SHORT TERM SERVICES FIRM HOLE
AND SMALL EMPLOYERS. THE
HARDSHIPS WITH- OF VACANCIES OR
POTENTIALLY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ONLY. DID THE ADMINISTRATION
MAKE ANY ATTEMPT TO ASSESS AND
QUANTIFY THE COST TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS INDUSTRY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE THE QUANTITY OF
FUNDING TO BE PROVIDED IN THE
BUDGET TO. MITIGATE THESE COSTS.
NO THE ONE MILLION DOLLARS WAS
WAS WAS NOT MEANT TO COVER ALL
OF THEM IT WAS MERELY JUST A
PILOT PROGRAM- TO PROVIDE SOME
IMMEDIATE RELIEF WITHIN WHY
DIDN'T WE DO A SIMPLE PILOT
PROGRAM WITH RESPECT TO SOME OF
THESE CHANGES INSTEAD OF HAVING
THE CHANGES APPLY STATEWIDE TO
ALL EMPLOYERS. AGAIN I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT I THINK WE VIEW
THAT PROTECTING THOUGH THE JOB
FOR ALL THE WORKERS REGARDLESS
OF THE SIZE IS CRITICAL FOR
THOSE EMPLOYEES WHO ARE ALL WHO
ARE ALSO PAYING IN. TO THESE
ARE FOR THE EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
ALSO PAIN AND FOR THESE. LEADS
OR TRY TO MOVE THIS LONG BEFORE
I GET THE HOOK BUT- YOU KNOW
IT'S BEEN MY EXPERIENCE
REPRESENTING BUSINESS. AND
OTHERS FOR. QUITE SOME TIME
GIVEN MY AGE. THAT MOST
BUSINESS VERTICALLY SMALL
BUSINESS TYPICALLY HAVE A KEY
EMPLOYEE OR MAYBE TO THAT ARE.
SIMPLY ESSENTIAL TO KEEPING THE
BUSINESS RUNNING IN THE TRAINS
RUNNING ON TIME WOULD YOU AGREE
WITH THAT. I THINK IT'S ALSO
AND- THAT IS OFTEN THE CASE
SENATOR ROSS BUT AT THE
ADMINISTRATION NOTABLE WAYS
THAT JOB PROJECTED LEAVES- IS
ALSO IMPORTANT FOR ALL WORKERS
SO WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
TRADE OFF. WITH THE LET ME ASK
A QUESTION SO FOR TWENTY.
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS SINCE THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY TWENTY SEVEN
OR TWENTY EIGHT SINCE TE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS ACT
WAS FIRST ADOPTED. THE ACTORS
HAD A PROVISION IN IT THE- SAYS
THAT IF AN EMPLOYEE IS A
SALARIED EMPLOYEE ONE OF THE
HIGHEST PAID IN OTHER WORDS THE
KEY EMPLOYEE. THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE
ACT DESCRIBES IT. BUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AS CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE THE EMPLOYER FACES
SUBSTANTIAL AND GRIEVOUS
ECONOMIC INJURY TO THE
OPERATIONS THAT IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES THE EMPLOYER CAN
ASK THE EMPLOYEE WHO IS ON
FAMILY LEAVE TO RETURN TO WORK.
TO HELP SAVE THE EMPLOYER.
YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT CORRECT.
CORRECT OKAY THEN HAVING BEEN
AWARE OF THAT WHY IN THIS
PARTICULAR SET OF AMENDMENTS
DID YOU DID THE ADMINISTRATION
ELECT TO DELETE THAT PROVISION.
WHAT WAS THE DECISION MAKING
CALCULUS THEIR- THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT
JOB PROTECTED WE'VE REALLY DOES
NEED TO BE AVAILABLE TO ALL
WORKERS AND AFTER THE STUDY
THAT WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
TRADE OFFS BUT IT REALLY DOES
NEED TO BE AVAILABLE WHETHER
YOU'RE A HIGH SALARIED EMPLOYEE
WHETHER YOU'RE ON LOW SALARIED
EMPLOYEE. WHETHER YOU WORK AT
IT TAKES FOR WHETHER YOU WORK
AT A SMALL FIRM AND THAT'S
REALLY WHAT IS DRIVING THIS
BILL AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THINGS- MIGHT HAVE BEEN
DIFFERENT FOR. AT TWENTY OR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS- BUT WHEN
DEEP MISTRUST LOOKS AT THERE'S-
A LOT OF THE VALUATION BUT IT'S
ALSO A VALUES ISSUE THAT I EVEN
AN EMPLOYEE IN THAT POSITION
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO JOB
PROTECTED WILL YOU
MISUNDERSTAND YOU MISUNDERSTAND
THE PROVISION THE EMPLOYEE HAS
A FOR HAS ACCESS TO THE LEAVE
AND IS ENTITLED TO TAKE THE
LEAVE. BUT THE EMPLOYER IF THE
EMPLOYER IS ABLE TO ESTABLISH
SUBSTANTIAL GRIEVOUS ECONOMIC
INJURY. THE EMPLOYER HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CALL THE
EMPLOYEE BACK THE EMPLOYEE HAS
A DECISION AT THAT POINT TO
OTHERS STAY ON LEAVE OR COME
BACK AND THEN AT THE
APPROPRIATE POINT WHERE THE
EMPLOYEE RISK REQUEST RETURN TO
WORK. SOMEONE OTHER THAN THE
EMPLOYER GETS TO DECIDE IF THE
EMPLOYERS ACTION IN IN FILLING
THE POSITION OF THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED WAS JUSTIFIED OR NOT
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECT.
YES ALTHOUGH I DO BELIEVE THAT
WHAT YOU DESCRIBED IS A WEAKER
FORM OF JOB PROTECTED LEAVE
THAN WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING DID YOU DO ANY STUDY
OF THE WORKPLACE IN CALIFORNIA
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THAT
PARTICULAR PROVISION WAS
CAUSING ANY. PARTICULAR SET OF
PROBLEMS AND IN TERMS OF HOW
OFTEN IT WAS USED AND- HOW
OFTEN THE SUBSTANTIAL GRIEVOUS
ECONOMIC INJURY PROVISION WAS
TRIGGERED. I'D HAVE TO DEFER TO
CRASH ON WHETHER AT ANYTHING ON
THAT SPECIFIC PROVISION. I'M
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANYTHING
SPECIFIC THAT PROVISION. WILL
LET ME MOVE ON. FOR ABOUT THE
SAME PERIOD OF TIME THERE WAS
ANOTHER PROVISION IN THE
CALIFORNIA RIGHT FAMILY RIGHTS
ACT WITH THE PROTECTED LEAVE
FOR SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITION OR
LEAVE ON ACCOUNT OF THE SERVICE
HEALTH CONDITION FAMILY MEMBERS.
BUT SAID IN PARTICULAR WITH
RESPECT TO BONDING LEAVE THAT
IF TWO EMPLOYEES WERE PARENTS
AND THEY WORK FOR THE SAME
EMPLOYER. THEY COULD TAKE THE
LEAVE BUT THE LEAVE WAS LIMITED
TO THE PERIOD OF TIME FOR ONE
EMPLOYEE WHICH IS TWELVE WEEKS
AS OPPOSED TO. A TOTAL OF
TWENTY FOUR. YOU ELECTED TO
REMOVE THAT PROVISION FROM
THESE AMENDMENTS WHAT WAS THE
CALCULUS BEHIND THAT DECISION.
THE ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T FEEL
THAT- I SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
WORK AT THE SAME COMPANY AS
THEIR SIGNIFICANT OTHER. DID
YOU AGAIN DID YOU DO ANY STUDY
OF THE- LAWYER. BASS CAL TO.
DETERMINE OR NOT THAT PROVISION
AS IT WAS ORIGINALLY DRAFTED
WAS CAUSING ANY PARTICULAR
LEVEL OF DIFFICULTY EITHER FOR.
THE EMPLOYEES INVOLVED OR THE
EMPLOYERS INVOLVED. I'M NOT
AWARE OF THAT. WELL THEN LET ME.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE THAT
I THINK SORT OF ILLUSTRATES THE
PROBLEM. I AM THE OWNER OF A
COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY COMPANY
FAIRLY SOPHISTICATED STUFF. I
HAVE A FULL BOOK OF CLIENTS BY
HER BY HER TO. THE EMPLOYEES
BOTH HIGHLY HIGHLY SKILLED
HIGHLY COMPENSATED COMPUTER
TECHNOLOGY SPECIALISTS ALL
THREE OF US SPEND EVERY WORK
DAY FIVE OR SIX DAYS. A WEEK IN
THE FEEL THAT OUR CLIENTS
OPERATIONS THEIR OFFICES DOING
SOFTWARE JUDGMENTS
SOPHISTICATED COMPUTER WORK-
ETCETERA. WELL ONE OF THE
EMPLOYEES OF IS A FEMALE SHE
GETS PREGNANT SHE'S OUT FOR
FOUR MONTHS SHE'LL LECTURE
BINDING LEAVE FOURTH THREE
MONTHS. AGO AND IS OUT SHE
COMES BACK FOR A WEEK MY MAY
EMPLOYEE HIS SIS. BECOME VERY
ILL WELL MYELOMA. HI HE NEEDS
THREE MY UNDER THE FAIR RIGHT
SECTOR AMENDED TO CARE FOR HER
BOTH. ALL PERFECTLY LEGITIMATE
LEASE NO QUESTION THERE. SO I
NOW HAVE FIVE NOW HAVE TEN
MONTHS OF A TWELVE MONTH WORK
HERE. WITH ONE THIRD OF MY WORK
FORCE ONE LEAVE. OUT ITS
COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY IS HIGHLY
SKILLED MAYBE IN THE COVERT
NINETEEN ENVIRONMENT I WON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM BUT I HAVE A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME SECURING
TEMPORARY EMPLOYEES TO FILL
THAT JOB BECAUSE I CAN'T BE
THERE TRAINING THEM I HAVE A
FULL BOOK OF CLIENTS MYSELF THE
SERVICE. I CAN'T GO TO A
REGULAR EMPLOYMENT AGENCY TO
HIRE A REGULAR EMPLOYEE BECAUSE
NO ONE'S GOING TO COME TO WORK
FOR. NINETY DAYS. AND I CAN'T
CONTRACT FOR THAT WORK WITH
ANOTHER COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY
COMPANY BECAUSE OF THE BUSINESS
TO BUSINESS ISSUE WITH AB FIVE.
SO MAYBE THOSE SITUATIONS ARE
SOLVABLE BUT LET'S ASSUME THERE
THEY ARE WHAT DO I DO MR HIS
WHEN ASSN. SO WHAT I CAN SAY
ABOUT THAT- THIS SITUATION THAT
YOU DESCRIBED IS THAT I
UNDERSTAND IN THE
ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS THAT
THAT WOULD RAISE OBSTACLES- FOR
THAT EMPLOYER- BUT REDUCING AN
EMPLOYEE'S JOB PROTECTED WE
WOULD ALSO A BRIDGE ABOUT A
YEAR. THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES. SO THERE IS A TRADE
OFFS I RIGHT WE BELIEVE THE- IN
THIS CASE PROVIDING THAT JOHN
PROJECT WE EVEN AND THAT THE
WORKER HAS THAT PROTECTION. IS
THE RIGHT MOVE EVEN NASH AND
THE HIGH SITUATION. THAT YOU
DID JUST. IT COULD LEAD TO SOME
OF THE OPS FOR THE PEOPLE AND-
WELL. IT'S AVE THAT THEIR WHOLE
BY OF P. ON THE FOR FLOOR. WHO
HAVE NEVER EVER BEEN EMPLOYER.
IN THE PRIVATE. IN THE STATE.
AND THAT'S TO SAY THING ANY
OTHER COMMON TO MAKE BEFORE I
IT BACK MY CHIU. IS YELLOW WE
MAY AND IT SO OF US TO OFFER
SINCE. TO THE GOV AND THE
INVENTOR ON THIS MAY. AND WE
WERE TOLD A SENSE. THAT IT WAS
A TAKE IT OR LEAVE IT
PROPOSITION. NOW I WANT YOU TO
THINK ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THIRTY NIELSEN.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TO BE HOUSE THAT. BECAUSE
EVERYBODY SOUTH OF WHERE I COME
FROM. I TAKE THIS THIS PIECE OF
THAT FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO SAY.
THAT I AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE THAT. THIS BILL
IS. SHOULD IS A POLICY BILL
QUITE FRANKLY IT NEEDED TO BE
VETTED OUT. IN A POLICY
COMMITTEE. AND WE'VE HEARD
SEVERAL TIMES TODAY OVER THE
DISCUSSION THAT. THAT THIS WAS
DONE BY THE THREE PARTY
AGREEMENT. QUITE FRANKLY THAT'S
TO ME. ONE OF THE BIG PROBLEMS
WE HAVE WITH THIS LEGISLATURE'S
THAT THIS BUDGET HAS BEEN PUT
TOGETHER BY THREE PARTIES. THE
GOVERNOR AND THE IN THE
LEGISLATOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE PRO TâM AND THE
SPEAKER. AND I REPRESENT A
MILLION PEOPLE ALONG WITH ALL
OF YOU. AND THIS HIT THIS IS
PERSONAL. I AM THAT IN PLAYER.
I HAVE ONE FULL TIME EMPLOYEE
USED UP FOR BUT I'M DOWN TO ONE.
YEAH I HAVE A COUPLE OF PART
TIME EMPLOYEES THERE ARE MY
SONS. WHO ARE MAKING MONEY
DURING THE SUMMER SO THEY CAN
ATTEND SCHOOL. I DON'T HAVE AN
HR DEPARTMENT THE H. R.
DEPARTMENT IS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
MAKING DOLLY. AND IT'S CRAZY TO
KNOW THE LAWS THAT ARE PASSED
IN THIS LEGISLATURE THAT I HAVE
TO COMPLY WITH. WITH OUR SMALL
LITTLE BUSINESS OUR FAMILY FARM
IN OUR TRUCKING BUSINESS. WE
HAVE TO HIRE AND A PERSON TO DO
OUR PAYROLL FOR THAT ONE PERSON
IN AND THE PART TIME HELP THAT
WE HAVE SO WE CAN COMPLY. AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT DOING
SOMETHING OUT OF COMPLIANCE TO
WHERE WE WOULD EITHER HARM OUR
EMPLOYEES OR BE SUED BY
SOMEBODY WHO. THANKS FOR BAD
PEOPLE BECAUSE WE SUPPLY A JOB
IN A PRODUCT THE CALIFORNIANS
NEED. THIS BILL. A LET ME JUST
TELL YOU I HAVE A TRUCK DRIVER.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS UNDER SOME
OF THE OTHER LEGISLATION WAS
PASSED YEAR. THEY HAVE A
SPECIAL LICENSE THEY'RE
ENROLLED IN A DRUG PROGRAM.
THEY ARE DEAD MONITORED BY
HOURS OF SERVICE. THERE ARE
THERE ARE MANY MANY LAWS THE A
TRUCK DRIVER AS AN EMPLOYEE HAS
TO ABIDE BY. AND WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF THOSE IN CALIFORNIA
QUITE FRANKLY CROSS THE NATION.
SO FOR ME TO LOSE THAT EMPLOYEE.
WOOD SHOP MY BUSINESS DOWN AND
I WANT TO SHARE YOU KNOW THE
GOOD SENATOR OUT TO QUESTION
WHAT DO YOU DO YOU GO OUT OF
BUSINESS OR YOU LEAVE THE STATE.
THERE ARE A ONE POINT WHERE.
ARE MY STATISTICS SO ONE POINT
ONE MILLION. BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE FEWER FIVE EMPLOYEES. AND
WE ARE WE DON'T HAVE A LOBBY I
IN THE LOBBY FOR THOSE PEOPLE
BECAUSE I AM ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE SO I RAN FOR THIS JOB
WAS TO. SHARE THE STRUGGLES
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA FACE AND- FOR THE
LIFE OF ME. WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT
HOW WE NEED TO. MAY HAVE A
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE AND WE
NEED TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
WORKERS. MY WORKERS MAKE MORE
THAN MINIMUM WAGE. MY TRUCK
DRIVER MAKES TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. WHICH IS
EQUIVALENT TO ABOUT THIRTY
THREE DOLLARS AN HOUR TO THE
BUSINESS. MY POINT IS THAT THIS
BILL SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE
THROUGH A COMMITTEE. SEVERAL
THESE BILLS ARE THESE POLICY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE THROUGH
POLICIES COMMITTEE. AND THEY'RE
GONNA BE A TIME SUNDAY WHEN
THESE BUSINESSES AS I SPOKE
UNDER THE ORIGINAL BUDGET. IT'S
A RESPECT. YOU CANNOT HAVE A
GOVERNMENT. AGENCY OF ANY SORT
OR GOVERNMENT WORKER OF ANY
KIND OR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM OR
ANYTHING INTEL A PRIVATE
BUSINESS PAYS A TAX OR THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR THEM. PAY
A TAX FIRST. AND PUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE OUR
PRIORITIES WRONG HERE OUR
PRIORITY SHOULD BE WE NEED A
BALANCE WE A BALANCE OF YES
GOOD EMPLOYEES AND THERE ARE
BACK THERE ARE BAD ACTORS.
ABSOLUTELY PEOPLE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OTHER PEOPLE. BUT
THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE NOT
BAD PEOPLE THEY HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH MY EMPLOYEES.
I WANT THEM TO SUCCEED I WANT
THEM TO BE PART OF OUR FAMILY.
IT IS HARD TO FIND GOOD PEOPLE
TO WORK. THE CARE AND I'M
COMPETING WITH GOVERNMENT JOBS
THAT PAY GREAT AND HAVE GREAT
RETIREMENTS THAT I CAN'T BE
WITH AND ALSO COMPETING WITH
BUSINESSES THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF
THE STATE. SO I TO SAY TO YOU
THIS BILL NEEDED TO BE PUT INTO
A POLICY STATEMENT. I COMMEND.
MY COLLEAGUE FOR ASKING SOME
VERY TOUGH QUESTIONS THEY CAN'T
ANSWER BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T GET
IT OUT BECAUSE THEY NEVER HAD
AN EMPLOYEE. AND I FEEL SORRY
FOR THE- THE FOLKS THAT WORK
FOR DEPARTMENT FIGHTING TO HAVE
TO DEFEND THE GOVERNOR'S
MISGUIDED POLICY RIGHT HERE I
FEEL I FEEL SORRY FOR YOU
BECAUSE YOU CAN ADD TO THE
QUESTIONS. BECAUSE THERE
MISGUIDED AND THIS IS JUST A
SHAM PUT UP IN THE LAST FEW.
BUT THIS PROCESS. SO I'M NOT
ASKING YOU TO ANSWER THE I
DON'T WANT YOU TO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH. STUFF THAT YOU CAN
ANSWER. THE PROBLEM HERE IS. IS
THAT WE NEED TO. WORK WITH
BUSINESSES TO HELP THEM KEEP
EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS BE ABLE
TO STAY IN BUSINESS. SO WE CAN
HAVE A THRIVING ECONOMY SO WE
CAN GIVE THE SERVICES TO THOSE
WHO NEED IT THE MOST. THANK YOU
MADAM. I'VE SAID. CHAIR PUTTING
UP WITH ME AND SEE ME BACK HERE
AND I KNOW BEEN A LONG DAY.
WHICH BEEN VERY PATIENT I
APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR LABEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I FEEL LIKE
I HAVE TO STAND UP I THINK
BETTER ON MY FEET. SOME
INTERESTING THINGS THAT WE'VE
HEARD. I ALWAYS ENJOY HEARING
MEN DEBATE WOMEN HAVING BABIES
AND TO MY SENATOR- FROM
RIVERSIDE I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE MAY NOT
HAVE ANY EXPERIENCE WITH SMALL
BUSINESS BUT YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
EXPERIENCE WITH CHILDBIRTH. AND
I APPRECIATE THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS BUT I ALSO THINK THAT
THE THINGS THAT WE VOTE ON THIS
FLOOR OUR STATEMENT OF OUR
VALUES AND RIGHT NOW IN SOCIETY
WE VALUE MONEY WE VALUE STATUS
WE VALUE STUFF. WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF WE VALUE PEOPLE IF WE
VALUED HEALTH AND WE VALUE
COMMUNITY AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE IN THE EXAMPLES OF IN
USE WE TALK ABOUT A WOMAN A
WOMAN WHO HAS A DIFFICULT
PREGNANCY. I WAS ONE OF THOSE
WOMEN WERE MY HUSBAND I'D IS.
DORA FOR. AND IT HAPPENED. THE.
TOMORROW I DON'T RECOGNIZE
POINT OF OR I'M GONNA ASSN
LEYVA HER TESTED AND THEN I'M
GOING TO GO TO MORE BERKELEY
THANK YOU SO LABOR YOU CAN CAN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
PAUL SO MORAL FILLED I'M ATTACK
SOME I'M JUST OUT THINGS WERE
SAID I'M NOT A ANYONE BUT I WAS
ONE OF THOSE WOMEN WHO DID HAVE
A DIFFICULT PREGNANCY WHEN MY
HUSBAND I DECIDED TO HAVE A
BABY I WAS THE ONLY ONE IN THE
RELATIONSHIP WHO COULD HAVE THE
BABY SO I'M THE ONE WHO GOT
PREGNANT. AND I END UP BEING
PREGNANT WITH TWINS WHICH WAS
AN AMAZING BLESSING BUT IT ALSO
MEANT THAT I HAD SOME CALL IT
DIDN'T HAVE TO BE BUT I DID
HAVE COMPLICATIONS I HAD TO GO
OFF WORK EARLY I WORK FOR A BIG
EMPLOYER SO WASN'T A PROBLEM
BUT WHAT WE DO FOR OUR WOMEN
WHO WANT TO WORK FOR A SMALL
EMPLOYER SHE WE JUST TELL THEM
HEY WHATEVER YOU DO DON'T GO TO
WORK FOR SMALL EMPLOYER BECAUSE
WHEN YOU WANT TO HAVE A BABY
YOU'RE JUST GONNA HAVE TO QUIT.
I THINK WE CAN FIND A WAY I
THINK THERE'S ALWAYS AN EASY
WAY TO SAY NO BUT CAN WE FIND A
WAY TO SAY YES WE ALSO OWN A
SMALL BUSINESS WE'VE OWNED A
SMALL BUSINESS FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
RIVERSIDE AND I HAD THIS
CONVERSATION AT THE AIRPORT ON
MONDAY AND I SAID MY HUSBAND
HAD AN ISSUE WITH HIS BY ONE OF
HIS ARTISTS AND HE HAD A GALL
BLADDER PROBLEM HE HAD TO TAKE
SOME TIME OFF WHO'S GONNA BE
OUT OF WORK FOR A COUPLE OF
MONTHS. MY HUSBAND TO FIND TEMP
TO WORK AS HIS SO DID THAT SO
WE CAN DO THESE THINGS AND I'VE
SEEN SMALL BUSINESSES DO MORE
FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES THE BIG
BUSINESSES SO IT'S NOT A MATTER
OF HOW TO IT'S A MATTER WILL
TOO AND I ALSO HEARD THAT THIS
IS MISGUIDED AND A SHAM BUT I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS BEEN WORKING
ON. THIS BEFORE I EVER CAME TO
THE SENATE. A FAMILY EXCUSE ME.
PROTECTED HAS WITH THAT THE
WIND CAUCUS BEEN WORKING ON
FOR. AND I THAT THIS JUST ABOUT
PREGNANCY LEAVE BOB BID YOUR OR
YOUR CHILD OR YOUR MOTHER OR
YOUR FATHER WAS ILL AND YOU
WANT TO TAKE CARE OF THEM WE'RE
NOT ASKING YOUR EMPLOYER TO PAY
YOU TO DO THAT WE'RE JUST
SAYING HEY I'D LIKE TO TAKE
CARE OF THE PERSON I LOVE. CAN
YOU HOLD MY JOB FOR TWELVE
WEEKS OR RICHARD CASE IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT WITH SOMEONE
SORRY THE CENTER FROM RIVERSIDE
A LITTLE DIFFERENT FOR SOMEONE
WHO'S ON PRESIDENT HAS A
DIFFICULT LEAVE BUT WHAT WE
VALUE LET'S VALUE PEOPLE ITS
VALUE HUMANS WE CAN DO THIS WE
CAN FIGURE IT OUT WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES LET'S VALUE EACH
OTHER LET'S VALUE WOMEN LET'S
VALUE OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
LET'S MAKE THIS WORK WE CAN DO
THIS IT'S NOT A LACK OF HOW TO
IT'S A LACK OF WILL TO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
SENATOR MORE LAW. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SENATOR ROSS WHICH
REALLY ABOUT MENTIONING I MAKE
WE GET FOR HIS TO WITH REGARD
TO EMPLOY DEVELOPMENT THE
ISSUES AND- DURING THIS WALK
DOWN I WORK EVERY DAY I WENT TO
THE OFFICER DAY AND TOP IS CALL.
FOR ME WHERE THE BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO WERE EXPLAINED TO ME.
HOW THEIR CASH WAS RUNNING OUT.
HI THERE GOES YOUR BUSINESS HOW
THEY'RE GONNA LOSE OUR HOME AND
THEN TELL ME THERE'S YEARS WHEN
THEY DO. AND EVERY SOME CALLS
WHERE I WANTED JUST. CARRILLO
INTO A BALL AND CRY AND ANOTHER.
THE SLIDE DOWN AS BEEN PRETTY
TOUGH AND SO NOW HAVE THE-
PARTICULAR BILL AND I HAVE A
LETTER. WITH BUSINESSES ARE. AN
ASSOCIATE THAT ARE. TO THIS
BILL. THAT IS A MILE LONG.
WE'RE IN A RECESSION. AND WE'RE
ASKING BUSINESSES. TO DO
SOMETHING THAT IS IMPORTANT BUT-
RIGHT NOW FOR ME IT IT APPEARS
AS IF MADAM CHAIR WERE TONE
DEAF. IT APPEARS THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS JUST. NOT PRE
SHADING WHAT'S HAPPENING TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. MANAGER I WOULD I
WOULD REQUEST WE DEFER THIS
PARTICULAR BILL UNTIL
STABILIZATION IN THIS ECONOMY
HAS BEEN ACHIEVED. AND THIS
LOOK AT IT WHEN THINGS ARE A
LITTLE BETTER. BUT RIGHT NOW I
THINK IT'S IS THE WRONG MESSAGE
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU.
GAINES QUESTION YOU LIKE TO
BOTH A MINUTE TO MOVE ON
REGISTER. THANK VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR NOT FOR SENATOR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I WON'T I WILL
REPEAT IN. THAT'S CENTER BUT I
JUST TO SAY THAT THIS THIS
PARTICULAR. I GOT MORE CALL
FROM. THE SMALL BUSINESSES IN
MY DAY. THE IT'S ALMOST LIKE
THE EDT CALLS. REALLY THE I
WHAT I WANNA SAY IS I THAT I
HAVE. DISAGREEMENT WITH THE
ADMIN. ON THE NEED FOR
PROTECTED FAMILY LEAVE AND I
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND. THE
VALUE- AND THE NEED AND THE
NECESSITY FOR. ALL OF US TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT DESPERATELY NEED
IF. EITHER TO TAKE CARE OF
OURSELVES- OR OTHER PEOPLE THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
PARTICULAR. BILL IS THAT IT HAS
NO FLEXIBILITY FOR THE EMPLOYER
THE EMPLOYER CAN'T NEGOTIATE
THE EMPLOYER- IS HAS THE
POSSIBILITY OF FACING- A- AT AT
CAUSE OF ACTION THROUGH A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION. ON THE
LEAVE DOESN'T MATCH UP WITH THE
FEDERAL LEAVE THAT AS WAS
ARTICULATED BY MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND
SO- PART OF THE CHALLENGE IS
THAT BECAUSE- THERE WAS NO
NEGOTIATION AND- IT WAS
ATTEMPTED- AND REJECTED IT'S
THE SAME LANGUAGE WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT FOR THE PAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS. THE PAST MONTH I
GUESS- IT REALLY AREN'T BECAUSE
VERY VERY VERY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE THE GIVES ABSOLUTELY NO
FLEXIBILITY TO SMALL BUSINESSES
SO- I WON'T BE SUPPORTING AT
THE AT THIS TIME BUT I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR. THAT I SUPPORT.
I SUPPORT. THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILIES IT'S JUST YOU'VE GOT
TO GIVE SOME FLEXIBILITY THE
SMALL BUSINESSES ONE POINT ONE
MILLION WHO HAVE UNDER FIVE
EMPLOYEES. SENATOR PAN THANK
YOU A MADAM CHAIR NO THIS IS A-
CHALLENGING ISSUE AND I THINK
CERTAINLY FROM THE DEBATE. AND
CERTAINLY I AND VERY
SYMPATHETIC. TO THE GOVERNOR'S
POSITION- AND CERTAINLY IN MY
PROFESSION I SEE- THE
CHALLENGES FAMILIES FACE- AND
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF BONDING I DO HAVE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR-
DEPARTMENT FINANCES THAT'S
ALRIGHT ABSOLUTELY. SO I GUESS
MY FIRST QUESTION IS THAT- WHEN
YOU'VE HEARD SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AND I CAN YOU KNOW
FROM SOME THE PREVIOUS PEOPLE
WHO TESTIFIED AND I WILL ALSO
MENTION THAT- NO I FAMILY WE ON
THE SMALL BUSINESS BUSINESS OF
UNDER FIVE PEOPLE. IN WHICH
EACH EMPLOYEE ACTUALLY HAS A
UNIQUE FUNCTION FACT SOME OF
THE EMPLOYEES ACTUALLY HAVE
LICENSES. SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE
ONE EMPLOYEE DO ANOTHER
EMPLOYEES JOB. THE LAW WOULDN'T
PERMIT IT. ANYWAY SO WHEN YOU
LOSE AN EMPLOYEE WE CAN'T JUST
SIMPLY SHIFT SOMEONE AROUND-
BUT I GUESS THE QUESTION I HAVE
FOR FINANCE FIRST OF ALL IT IS
THAT. KNOWING THAT. WE HAVE
SEEMS TO BE SOME ISSUES THAT
ARE UNRESOLVED OR UNEXAMINED.
IS AND I REALIZE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE FINANCE NOT THE GOVERNOR
HIMSELF HERE. IS THERE- SOME
WILLINGNESS ON THE PART OF. THE
GOVERNOR THE MINISTRATION TO
TRY TO RESOLVE SOME OF THESE
ISSUES. THAT WOULD STRONGLY
AFFECTS SMALL BUSINESSES. IN A
WAY THAT COULD STILL TRY TO
FIND A WAY TO AFFORD. EMPLOYEES
LEAVE WITHOUT ESSENTIALLY-
POTENTIALLY RUINING THE
BUSINESS ITSELF. A SENATOR PAN
THIS IS THE LATEST ONE OFF AND
ON YOUR QUESTION THAT I WANT TO
CLARIFY IN OUR GENERAL
ORIENTATION POSITION ON THIS
THERE ARE CERTAINLY
DISAGREEMENTS- BETWEEN- THE
MINISTRATION NOW AND SOME OF
THAT SENATORS OUT WHICH WHICH
HAVE BEEN VOICED BUT I WOULDN'T
AGREE WITH YOUR
CHARACTERIZATION THAT- THESE
POLICIES HAVE BEEN UNEXAMINED I
KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT I DID SEE
THE POLICY IS AN EXAMINATION
SOME OF THE BACKGROUND OKAY
WELL THAT'S IT THAT'S IT THAT'S
RIGHT SERA. ASSN QUESTION THAT
APPEARED LIKE THERE HAS NOT
BEEN RESEARCHER VETTING DONE OF
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WOULD
CERTAINLY AFFECT CONSIDERATION
POLICY UNLESS YOU. WISH TO
PROVIDE THOSE ANSWERS NOW. SO
THIS IS BEEN A YEAR LONG EFFORT
AT IT NOW OF THESE IS. I KNOW
SOMETHING. WERE AROUND VERY
SPECIFIC ONCE ANALYSES WE HAVE
FINANCE I DON'T HAVE DOES RIGHT
IN FRONT OF US SOME OF THEM IS.
MAY HAVE BEEN DONE IN ANOTHER
FOR MAYBE NOT IN THESE FORM OF
THE- STATE BUT I DO TO CLEAR.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE ISN'T
A PERSON OUT THERE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION JUST AUTUMN ONE.
AND STUCK IN A BILL BECAUSE IT
BEEN THE OPPOSITE OF THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF. THAT GOES INTO
THIS I THE FUNDING DISAGREEMENT
HERE IS THAT ACTUALLY A AND
IT'S KIND OF LATE SO I THINK
I'M JUST. YOU JUST SAY IS THE-
OR TO MINISTRATION AND REALLY
YOU'RE NOT TO GO HIMSELF. OPEN
HAVING FOR. COM TO TRY TO
MITIGATE OF THE ISSUE. THAT
WERE. BY WORK AND- ABOUT THE-
SO WE'RE WE'RE ABSOLUTELY OPEN
SAID CONTAINING THE
CONVERSATIONS ON THESE ISSUES
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW
IN THE MIDST OF A PANDEMIC THAT
IS EXPOSING FAULT LINES FOR
WORKERS. ALL ACROSS THE ECONOMY
HAS AND HAS DEMONSTRATE INDEED
THE IMPORTANCE OF WEAK AND
WE'VE EVEN SEEN. SO RESIGNED
ANY YES OR NO. SO YEAH I GUESS
YES. OKAY YES WE'RE OPEN FOR
THEIR COURAGE AND SEE HERE. BUT
WE WHAT WE DO BUT THAT THOSE
ARE NONE OF COURSE YOU BELIEVE
IN THE BILL WELL ASSUME THEY
SINCE WE BILL FOR IF YOU
BELIEVE IN THE BILL ON NOT A-
OF. WILL TAKE THE YES ALRIGHT
SINCE YOU SEE YES THIS QUESTION
I HAVE IS JUST THE BECAUSE.
FIRED LEGAL OBLIGATIONS. SO WE
HAVE TO DO RESEARCH ON THAT
SPECIFIC SCENARIO I KNOW YOU
DESCRIBED IF THE BUSINESS YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT WITH SO YOU SEE
YOU DON'T KNOW WITH A
BUSINESSES UNABLE TO SUSTAIN
ITS OPERATIONS. RIGHT NAY EVEN
FILE FORMALLY FOR BANKRUPTCY OR
DECIDE JUST CHOOSE THE CLOTHES
RIGHT THE **** SAYS YOU KNOW
WHAT THIS IS NOT SUSTAINABLE.
I'M GONNA BASICALLY CLOSED DOWN
ACTION OFF SELL OUT THE ASSETS
CLOSE DOWN. YOU KNOW BEFORE
THAT LEAVE TIME IS UP. DO YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RESULTS
WHAT WITH THEIR OBLIGATION
WOULD BE TO THE EMPLOYEE WHO
TECHNICALLY IS FIRST OF JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE BUT THERE'S NO
JOB AT THE END OF THIS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO BUSINESS YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT. THE WHAT THE LEGAL
OBLIGATION IS FOR THAT
BUSINESS. LET ME CLARIFY CENTER
PAN AT LEAST THERE IS NO
BUSINESS TO RETURN TO I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE BUSINESS OWNER
HAS AN OBLIGATION TO KEEP THE
BUSINESS OKAY AND- WHEN THEY
WERE OTHERWISE GOING TO- DOCTOR
OTHER REASONS JUST A HIGHER
THAT EMPLOYEE BUT- IF YOU'RE
ASKING ABOUT SPECIFIC WHETHER
IT'S SEVERANCE. WHETHER OKAY
CONGRESSIONAL IT'S ALL THESE
COULD BE TIED- UNDER THE
BANKRUPTCY CODE UNDER PRE
EXISTING CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENTS
THAT ARE GOVERNED BY STATE LAW
FOR THE EMPLOYERS I DON'T WANT
TO SPEAK TO THAT. OKAY I
PROPHETICAL SCENARIO AND SO I
HVE ALL THE FACTS. OKAY SO I
MEAN I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE ALSO NEED PEOPLE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND- IN TERMS OF
THEIR PLANNING BUT- YOU KNOW. I
GUESS THE- SO FRANKLY I WOULD
SAY IS THAT FIRST OF ALL. I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT- IDEALLY WE
SHOULD HAVE NOT ONLY JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE WE SHOULD
ACTUALLY HAVE PAID LEAVE. FOR
EVERYONE. BUT I ALSO WOULD SAY
IS THAT- BECAUSE WE TALKED
ABOUT OUR VALUES AND- OUR
BUDGET IS AN EXPRESSION OF OUR
VALUES. IS THAT WE SHOULD BE
BUDGETING FOR ENOUGH MONEY NOT
JUST A MILLION DOLLARS. TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES WHEN THEY HAVE
AN EMPLOYEE WHO NEEDS TO
BEYOND. TWELVE WEEKS SEVEN
MONTHS OF LEAVE. SO THAT THAT
SMALL BUSINESS IS STILL AROUND.
AT THE END OF THAT LEAVE
BECAUSE OF THE BUSINESSES IN
AROUND NOT ONLY HAS THE-
EMPLOYEE WHO WENT ON LEAVE LOST
THEIR JOB EVERYONE ELSE WHO'S
BEEN IN THAT BUSINESS IS ALSO
LOST THEIR JOB AS WELL. SO YOU
KNOW I. YOU KNOW LARGER
BUSINESSES CAN PERHAPS YOU KNOW
SIX FIGURE OUT HOW TO EXCHANGE
PEOPLE HAVE SOMEONE COVER FOR
SOMEONE- THEY CAN SPREAD THE
COSTS AROUND A LITTLE MORE. IN
YES PROPORTIONALLY THE HAVE YOU
KNOW CERTAIN NUMBER PEOPLE ON
LEAVE BUT THEY CAN BALANCE IT
OUT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
VERY SMALL BUSINESS LISTING
UNDER FIVE. WHEN YOU LOSE A KEY
EMPLOYEE AND I THINK THAT'S
PART OF PERHAPS I DON'T KNOW
THE ENTIRE LEGAL HISTORY OF
THAT PROVISION IN THE LAW. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT YOU HAVE A KEY
EMPLOYEE AND OF THAT PERSON'S
GONE. YOU MAY OR MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO FIND SOMEONE WHO CAN
TEMPT FOR THAT IT DEPENDS- THAT
PERSON WHO YOU'RE HIRING IS
ATTEMPTED IS NOT GOING TO BE
COMMITTED TO YOUR BUSINESS
BECAUSE- ONLY ATTEMPT. IN FACT
THE WILL IF SO THEY CAN FIND A
PERMANENT JOB THEY'RE GOING OFF
TO WORK THAT PERMANENT JOB. AND
THEN YOU'RE NOW TRYING TO FIND
ANOTHER PERSON TO COVER
WHATEVER REMAINING PORTION IS
LAUGHED BUT IT WITH THE
CRITICAL PART OF THE JOB THEN
ESSENTIALLY YOUR BUSINESS MAY
GO BELLY UP BECAUSE THERE'S-
WITHOUT FORGET. IT'S NOT JUST
YOUR COSTS THAT YOU HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IT'S THE MATTER
REVENUE YOU BRING AND SO IF
YOUR BUSINESS ISN'T ABLE TO
FUNCTION YOU NOT BRING IN ANY
MONEY. TO PAY FOR ANY COSTS NOT
JUST THE COST OF THE PERSONS ON
LEAVE THE COST OF PAYING ANYONE
ELSE THE RENT UTILITIES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE. I THINK THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE PERHAPS HEARING
FROM SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS CLEAN
HELLO IT'S MONEY IN MY YEAH SO
YOU HAVE TO MAKE ALL THE BOOKS
BALANCE. SO SINCE YOU SAID YES
TO THE QUESTION ABOUT- PENDING
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS- I
UNDERSTAND THAT- THAT- YOU
KNOW. THAT THIS IS CERTAINLY
PRIORITY FOR THE GOVERNOR- I
ACTUALLY. AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR THAT WE SHOULD FIND A
WAY TO GIVE EVERYONE LEAVE BUT
WHAT I THINK WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO IT IN A WAY SO
THAT THIS IS A REAL PROMISE.
BECAUSE I HAVE WOULD HATE FOR
BUSINESSES TO BE CLOSING FROM
UNDERNEATH PEOPLE. WHO WHO ARE
IN THE MIDDLE TO LEAVE THAT'S
THE WORST THING THAT WAY TO
LOSE YOUR JOB- AND- AND ALSO
HAVE OTHER PEOPLE LOSE THEIR
JOBS OF THOSE AS WELL. AND SO-
I WILL BE WILLING TO VOTE TO
GET THIS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE-
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT
FURTHER DISCUSSION- BUT I DO
HOPE. THAT WELL I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE GOVERNOR'S HAD
CONVERSATION WITH OUR
LEADERSHIP AND- LEADERSHIP AND
ASSEMBLY. THAT WE CAN HAVE A
FURTHER CONVERSATION ABOUT
REALLY WERE VALUES ARE AND WHAT
WE SHOULD COMMIT IN TERMS OF
OUR RESOURCES TO BEING SURE
THAT. WE CAN ACTUALLY GIVE THE
GET THE LEAVE THE PEOPLE IN A
WAY. THAT IS SUSTAINABLE AND
THAT WE DON'T SIMPLY SAY WELL
WE'LL PUT A RULE AND WE'LL PUT
IT ON THE BACKS OF ALL THE
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE THE RESOURCES. TO
MAKE IT ALL WORK OUT. BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S A DIFFERENT KIND
OF COST AND THAT WOULD POINT
OUT YES IT'S- COVE IT IS A TIME
WHEN WE NEED PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE LEAVE. IT'S ALSO A TIME
WHEN BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING
AND THEY DON'T THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOING. YOU KNOW PPP LOANS AND-
DISASTER LOANS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE ALSO
REVENUE SHORT AND- SO. LET'S
TRY TO FIGURE OUT A SOLUTION
THAT WE CAN GET TO A POLICY
GOAL TOGETHER. IN A WAY THAT.
CAN GET US TO YOU KNOW WHAT.
IT'S IT GETS REFLECTIVE OUR
VALUES SO- WITH THAT. LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AND WITH%
MY COLLEAGUES AS WELL IN TRYING
TO ACHIEVE. I THINK I SHARED
GOALS OF TRYING TO BE SURE
PEOPLE CAN GET BELIEVES THAT-
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE AND THAT
WE CREATED A DIFFERENT WAY OF
LOOKING AT OUR WORKPLACE IN A
WAY THAT'S TRULY SUSTAINABLE.
AND ALLOWS PEOPLE TO CONTINUE
TO AFTER JOBS THANK YOU. SENATE
BILL. I DO A LITTLE RESEARCH ON
THIS ON MY OWN. AIR AND. THIS
IS A PROBLEM FOR THE WHOLE
COUNTRY. WERE SO FAR BEHIND
OTHER COUNTRIES ON THIS ISSUE.
IT'S ALMOST IS PRETTY MUCH OF
BURSTING. I THINK THAT THE
ECONOMIC. CONDITIONS THAT
EXISTS IN AND- FAMILIES THAT
HAVE PAID LEAVE. IS MUCH
SUPERIOR TO WHAT WE HAVE TODAY
WERE. SIMPLY A CHOICE HAS TO BE
MADE BETWEEN YOUR- LOVE ONE AND
KEEPING YOUR JOB AND I THINK
THAT'S A PROBLEM I UNDERSTAND
THE ISSUES WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESS. BUT I HAVE A QUESTION
HELLO THIS CAL CALIFORNIA
UNITED STATES. COMPARED TO
OTHER COUNTRIES. THE RESEARCH
I'VE SEEN SHOWS THAT WERE WAY
FAR BEHIND IS THAT IS THAT TRUE
IS THAT A TRUE STATEMENT.
COMPARED TO OTHER COUNTRIES. IN
TERMS OF THE RESEARCH THAT HAS
BEEN DONE ON THIS. THAT'S A
QUESTION FOR. OR BUDGET THE
FINANCE DEPARTMENT PEOPLE YES
SENATOR VAL- IT DEPENDS WHAT
YOU'RE COMPARISON SET IS BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT FOR EXAMPLE- MANY
OF THE COUNTRIES AND NORTHERN
EUROPE THAT THE UNITED STATES
IS SOMETIMES COMPARED TO WHEN
IT COMES TO THE SOCIAL BENEFITS
PROVIDED BY THE GOVERNMENT IT
IS THE K. A. SAT IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE UNITED STATES WE DO NOT
PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL OF
BENEFITS IN AREAS LIKE THESE.
THERE IS THERE A LIST OF THOSE
YOU CAN COMPARE OUR OF. US TWO
OF THE OTHER COUNTRIES. I DON'T
HAVE THAT WITH ME BUT- YES YOU
CAN CERTAINLY FIND WEST OF. THE
BILL ALSO WHO ARE ROBUST WE'VE
PROTECTIONS IN THERE AND THEN
IN TERMS OF THE OTHER COUNTRIES
SINCE THEY HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE
ON THIS AND WE DO. HOW DO HOW
DO THEY HOW DO THEY- DEAL WITH
SOME OF THESE COMPLEXITIES WITH
THE- SMALL BUSINESS THEY HAVE
THEY HAVE CERTAIN THINGS THEY
CAN DO. WITH THE SMALL BUSINESS
HOW DO THEY- THERE WAS SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES- OR HOW ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS IN THOSE COUNTRIES. IN
SOME OF THESE. ANECDOTAL CASES
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP TODAY
ON THE FLOOR THE SENATE. WELL
SO WHAT WE HAVE TO LOOK INTO IT
DATE WITH THEY WILL CERTAINLY
VARY BY COUNTRY I THINK THAT-
THE ONE THING I CAN SAY IS THAT
IN A LOT OF THESE COUNTRIES
WHERE- THESE PROTECTIONS ARE IN
PLACE I DIDN'T IN PLACE FOR
MANY YEARS. SO SOCIETIES HAVE
ADJUSTED- TO RECOGNIZING THE
VALUE THESE PROTECTIONS WHILE
ALSO KNOWING THAT THEY COME
WITH SOME TRADE OFFS BUT THAT
THE SOCIETY HAS ADJUSTED AS THE
LAW HAS GONE INTO EFFECT AND-
WE HAVE BEARING STATES AND THEY
HAVE VERY LAWS ON THIS CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT IS THE AREA OF
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT- WE
SHOULD HAVE SOME KIND OF
NATIONAL. GENERAL LAW ON THIS
SUBJECT. SHOULD THE GOVERNOR
HAD AYE AYE AS FAR AS I KNOW
HAS NOT WAITING ON ASK FEDERAL-
LAW IN PARTICULAR- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF- JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE AS WELL AS EXPANDED PAID
FAMILY WEEDS SO WE'VE MADE THAT
CLEAR IN THE STATE- I SHOULDN'T
GO BEYOND WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
SAID FOR THE STATE BUT HE IS A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THOSE
OPPOSITION YEAH I THINK PERHAPS
WE ARE A- CONSIDER WHEN WE CAN
MAYBE WE CAN NOW BUT- SOME KIND
OF. RESOLUTION OR STATEMENT
FROM THE- FROM THE SENATE-
PERHAPS OVER THE WORK WITH THE-
OUR WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS SPECIALLY. TO
URGE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
DO SOMETHING ON THAT I HEAR I
HEAR THE COMPLAINTS I EAR THE
PROBLEMS. BERMAN URGED URGE
THAT- WE SUPPORT THIS AT THIS
TIME. I THINK THAT- WERE WAY
BEHIND. WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IT IN THE SENATE. OVER
THE YEARS AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN
HERE THAT'S FOURTEEN YEARS. AND
IT BE NICE FOR ME PERSONALLY TO
BE ABLE TO VOTE ON THIS MY LAST
YEAR IN THE SENATE. SO I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THAT STATEMENT
IT'S. IS CHáVEZ A LONG TIME
COMING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS WOULD THAT
WOULD LIKE TO POLLS AND
QUESTIONS TO FINANCE WILL WE
HAVE THEM HERE ON THIS BILL.
FINANCING THE CLOSING REMARKS
YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE. JUST THAT
WE- APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
AND- WHILE WE DO BELIEVE THIS
IS THE RIGHT APPROACH ON THIS
BILL CERTAINLY CHRIS AND I ARE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
SHARE EVERYTHING WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES OF. YOUR. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LIKE TO
THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IN LA OWES OFFICE FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY I'D LIKE TO
INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTED TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER. 1-844-291-6364 WHEN
PROMPTED. PLEASE USE THIS
ACCESS CODE SIX SIX FIVE. SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I'M INSTITUTING TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY. I
APPRECIATE THE LATENESS OF THE
HOUR BUT SEVERAL MEMBERS HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERN WANTING TO
MAKE SURE THE PUBLIC HAS HAD
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO EXPRESS
THEIR- OPINION SO I'M SURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
BE HERE AND EAGERLY LISTENED TO
THEIR PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS I
INTEND TO DO. ACCORDINGLY EACH
PERSON PROVIDING COMMENT WILL
ONLY BE PER MINUTE A TOTAL OF
UNDER ONE MINUTE. I MAY HAVE TO
SHORTEN THIS TIME LIMIT BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF CALLERS THAT
WE HAVE. LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. IS IT
ON IT IS NOW OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTIAN K. LEE ON
BEHALF OF SEVERAL CLIENTS
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. THAT YOU
JUST HEARD OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH- THE
PROCESS HERE AND WOULD PREFER
TO GO THROUGH THE NORMAL A
POLICY HEARING PROCESS YOU HAVE
SUFFICIENT TIME BETWEEN NOW AND
AUGUST THE THIRTY FIRST. ON THE
POLICY GOING DOWN TO ONE
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEE- I WOULD
NOTE THAT JUST A WEEK AND A
HALF AGO THIS LEGISLATURE- TOOK
STRIDES TO PROTECT SMALL AND
EVEN MEDIUM SIZE BUSINESSES
FROM THE REVENUE RAISING-
TRAILER BILL. AND HERE YOU'RE
GOING TO IMPOSE SIGNIFICANT
COSTS ON BOTH SMALL AND MID
SIZE EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE AND
JUST LAST YEAR AND SENATE BILL
ONE THIRTY FIVE IT LACKS
SUFFICIENT VOTES TO CLEAR THE
SENATE FLOOR. AND THAT HAD A
FIVE EMPLOYEES THRESHOLD. THE
FEAR OF LITIGATION IS VERY REAL
THIS BILL AMENDS SEA FRONT IN
THE GOVERNMENT CODE. SUBJECT TO
A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION NOT
ONLY CAN YOU OBTAIN. ECONOMIC
DAMAGES INJUNCTIVE RELIEF.
ATTORNEYS FEES BUT EVEN
PUNITIVE DAMAGES. WE HAVE QUITE
A NUMBER OF LEADS ALREADY
PROVIDED AS SEVERAL MEMBERS
HAVE ENUMERATED AND THERE'S
GREAT COMPLEXITY FOR THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY TO COMPLY
WITH ALL OF THESE AND AS A
PICTURE OF THAT I WOULD ASK YOU
TO LOOK AT PAGE FOUR OF YOUR
ANALYSIS ON THIS BILL AND THE
CHART THAT OUTLINES THOSE
DIFFERENT COMPLICATED LEASE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT SO ARE THERE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN
THE GALLERY SEE AND NONE
SERGEANTS OF ANY WITNESSES A
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THERE DON'T
APPEAR TO BE. WITH THAT. THANK
YOU AND WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY.
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
WHO ARE ON Q. TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. A YES AND LAYS IN
GERMAN ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME THEY HEAR A TONE
INDICATING PLACING QUEUE WILL
BE PROVIDED NUMBER THEN YOU
WILL BE ANNOUNCED BY THAT
NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN COULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND CHAIR AT THIS TIME
SEEN WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
FORTY IN Q. WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT FORTY
IN Q. THE REALITY IS THAT
PEOPLE TESTIFIED THAT NUMBER
WILL INCREASE. AGAIN I'M GOING
TO ASK EVERYONE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC OR HERE TO TESTIFY TO
KEEP YOUR TESTIMONY UNDER ONE
MINUTE. YEAH IF YOU GET CLOSE
TO APPROACH TO ONE MINUTE I
WILL- TELL YOU YOUR TIME IS UP
AND THE MODERATOR WILL. MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT PERSON SO THANK YOU
MODERATOR IF YOU'D OPEN THE
LINES OF ANNOUNCED EACH CALLER
INDIVIDUALLY AND WE CAN BEGIN
HEARING FROM THE PUBLIC.
MODERATOR WE'RE READY TO BEGIN
HEARING FROM THE PUBLIC PLEASE.
ABSOLUTELY JUST A MOMENT HERE.
AND WE'LL START WITH NUMBER TWO
OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD NUMBER
TWO OH EIGHT. PUBLIC MANY OF
OUR DISTRICT EMPLOYEES ARE
LICENSE. AND IT IS AN EXAMPLE
IS- JUST REPLACING THEM WITH
THAT THEY'RE OUT BUT DISTRICTS
ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED COVER NINETEEN
AND THIS BILL WILL FURTHER
COMPOUND THOSE FINANCIAL
STRUGGLES. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SECOND EVENING CAN LESS
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW AND I
JUST WANTED TO REALLY UNDERGRAD
AT THE LEGISLATURE HER
PROTECTING CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
FOR OUR CHILDREN. A WITH FOR
WORKING WITH US RESTORE FUNDING
AND EXPEDITE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE FAMILY- CAN RESPOND WITH
THEM FOR YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE
AND THEY'RE KICKED CARE GIVER.
AND I'M PUTTING HAVE BRIEFLY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YEARS. THANKS FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP BY
SUPPORTING. THE NEEDS OF HOW
MUCH YOU'RE GOOD AT 8%
SATISFIED WITHIN THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION PROVIDED FOR
AROUND HALF. AND WE'RE SUPPORT
ABOUT PROTECTION AB AGING OUT
OF FOSTER CARE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DIDN'T END UP
HOMELESS YOU KNOW THIS MONTH
AND I. SPECIAL GRATITUDE
BREEDERS WORKING TOGETHER AND
ALL OF YOUR STAFF. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
NIGHT HOTEL THREE NINETY.
YOU'VE GOT. GOOD EVENING THIS
IS THE RECEIPT FROM THAT VOICE
WE SUPPORT JUDGMENT A HARDSHIP
EXEMPTION DONCASTER PEARLS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND THANK YOU FOR YOU
AND YOUR STAFF ATTENTION THAT
THIS ISSUE. HOWEVER WE DO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE CHARTER
SCHOOL OR ANY OTHER QUALITY
SCHOOL GROWTH ENROLLMENT
MORATORIUM THOUSANDS OF PARENTS
AND A TOWN CHARTERS IN OTHER
SCHOOLS TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS
OPEN SHAPING TEACHING STUDENTS
OF ACTIVELY ESPECIALLY NOW
DURING THE CAN DOWN ACT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT BE
CUTTING OUT SUCCESSFUL OPTIONS
FOR CHILDREN FAMILIES THE
NUMBER ONE EXAMPLE THE STATE.
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION USES IN
ADDRESSING PANDEMIC IS USED AS
A CHARTER SCHOOL IN UNDER THIS
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THIS IS AB
SEVEN SEVEN THAT THE SCHOOL
THAT SCHOOL WOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO GROW MAKES NO SENSE
HOLD HARMLESS OR GROWTH. IS A
FALSE DICHOTOMY ESPECIALLY WITH
TEN BILLION DOLLARS INTO FOR
ALL YOU CAN HAVE BOTH WITHOUT
GROWTH MORE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
CHARTER WILL BE DRIVING UP THE
PRESSURE FOR DEFERRAL HARDSHIP
EXEMPTIONS WE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO FIX THIS ISSUE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE THE SCHOOL. CAN PLAN
APPROPRIATELY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NICK WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL
NUMBER FOUR OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MEMBERS-
CHEN KERBER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE CLOSED AT THE
EIGHTEEN. ME ONE THREE EIGHT
THREE- AS I DON'T LOOKING TODAY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TALK ABOUT THE UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES WERE IN THE RECORD HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT AND THE BUDGET
DEFICIT. IT IS UNCLEAR WHY
WOULDN'T POSE A TWELVE NEED
WEEK MANDATE AT THE BEACH ARE
SMALL EMPLOYERS WHO ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING AS A RESULT OF THIS
PANDEMIC. IT WILL BE HUGE
POLICY CHANGE THAT WILL SIMPLY
OVERWHELMED THE SMALL EMPLOYERS
AND PUT THEM OUT OF BUSINESS
INCREASING THE ALREADY RECORD
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT. IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE CLOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT NEXT BINGO
THE NUMBER SEVEN OH TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL THAT
THE EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
ABOUT HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSIT AGENCY THAT LIKE TO
SHOW OUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETY WHICH INCLUDED. A DASH
TOWARD RELIEF MEASURES THAT
RECOGNIZE THE TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
AND STARBUCKS REVENUE IS DOWN
IT TRANSIT AGENCIES STATEWIDE
BY MORE THAN EIGHTY. THESE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT MEASURES
WOULD PROTECT TRANSIT FUNDING
ENSURE THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES
ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
WHITEPLAINS READ THE SERVICE.
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE AS WE REFLECT ON
IMPROVEMENTS AND EFFICIENCY
MEASURES. THE BILL BACK BETTER
FROM THE CRIED. BUT WE WANT TO
THANK YOU YOUR- AND YOUR BELL
MEMBERS IN BOTH THE HOUSE AND
THE GOVERNOR FOR RECOGNIZING
THE NEED TO INCLUDE THE
STATUTORY RELIEF MEASURES. IN
THE FINAL BUDGET ACTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO A NUMBER SEVEN FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MADAM
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN TO DRIVE A
REPRESENTING NFIB WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE- WE THINK THIS IS A
TERRIBLE POLICY FOR SMALL
BUSINESS. AS THEY ATTEMPT TO
GET BACK ON TRACK AFTER THE-
KOBE CRISIS IN THE SHUT DOWN
THAT OUR STATE. HAS SEEN WE
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS- OF
OUR SENATOR RON AND OTHERS THAT
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO ASK WE ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO A NUMBER SEVEN FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS KATIE WATTERS LEFT AND WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA WORKING FAMILY
COALITION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AT THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE TRAILER
BILL BECAUSE ALL WORKERS SHOULD
HAVE JOB WHICH I COULD LEAD
ACTUALLY DURING A PANDEMIC. WE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THAT JUGGLING
SMALL BUSINESSES NIGHT BUT WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER IT PEOPLE WHO
ARE WORKING IN EVERY BUSINESS
REAL PEOPLE WHO ARE HUMAN
BEINGS AND LOOK AT THAT AND LET
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE ALL
CURRENTLY AT RISK FOR
CONTRACTING FOR THE NINETEEN.
MANY WORKERS ARE STATE AND
POSSIBLE CHOICE WHEN THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS THANK YOU MUST
DECIDE BETWEEN BREAKING THEIR
JOB TO CARE FOR THEIR FAMILY
LIFTING THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS I
CONTINUE TO WORK BETTER. THE
CHOICE THAT NO ONE SHOULD EVER.
THANK YOU. THANK NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO A EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU THANK YOU MY
NAME IS MARTY MOTOROLA HAMLEY
MEMBER OLDER SISTER WITH
DEVELOPMENT OWN PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS REVISED BUDGET AND ALSO
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES-
TRAILER BILLS OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION AND THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP IN BOTH HOUSES
INCLUDING YOU. SENATOR MITCHELL.
AND IN OTHERS IN THE SENATE
WHAT A PROFOUND DIFFERENCE YOU
HAVE ALL MADE FOR US ESPECIALLY
IN REJECTING THE- MASSIVE. HE
BASS REGIONAL CENTER AFTER FIVE
SAID MEDI CAL TROUT CARE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES EDUCATION AND
MORE. BLUEPRINT THERE'S NEED TO
OUR LIVES WE APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR FOR DOING THE RIGHT
THING ANY. ACTIONS
ADMINISTRATION HAS BROKEN THE
PREVIOUS MONTH IN RESPONDING TO
COPE WITH THAT SAVE LIVES IN
CLOSING THE BUDGET RESPECT ALL
OF US AS PARTNERS IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. RATHER THAN
VICTIMS IT BUYS THIS TIME SO WE
CAN CONTINUE TO RESPOND AND
BIKE THIS MAN DOWN THERE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND- WISHING OVERCOME THIS LATE
TAKE CARE. ALL AND WE HAVE
HOURS TO GO TRUST ME THANK YOU.
LET ME JUST SAY TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC WE ALL
APPRECIATE. YOU ACKNOWLEDGE IN
OUR WORK AND JUST WANT TO. KEEP
YOUR TESTIMONY TO YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THE BILLS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO CALL INDIVIDUAL
NAMES WE ALL KNOW THAT WE
APPRECIATE IT- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL
NUMBER SIX THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
NICOLE ME BERMAN I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF THREE FOR
OVER TEN YEARS NOW AND STILL
GOING STRONG I URGE YOU TO MAKE
THEM AND EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
INCLUDING REMOVING ALL
BURBRIDGE THAT IS AIMED AGAINST
ALLOWING EIGHTY EIGHT ON THE
FOLLOWERS DIDN'T. REMOVE THE
CAP ON THE GROWTH FUNDING I
THINK EVERYONE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO US SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM OUT OF JERRY MEMBERS JOHN
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE UP
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME- JUST THAT BECAUSE OF THE
PREVIOUS COMMENTS ON OPPOSING
THE EIGHTY A CAP ON GROWTH WE
BELIEVE IT INEQUITABLE TO ALLOW
REQUIRE SCHOOL TO TAKE ON NEW
STUDENTS WITHOUT ANY FUNDING IT
TOUCHES SO WE ARE HOPING THAT
YOU WILL- RECONSIDER AND- WORK
WITH THE THROUGH THE- THROUGH
THE COMING MONTHS TO TRY AND
FIX. THAT ISSUE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO IT A
NUMBER FIVE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
AND ALL I AM A HOME SCHOOL
MOTHER OF THREE CHILDREN AND I
AM FROM CALL THEM- I'M ASKING
THAT YOU WOULD CREATE A MAN AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GROWTH I MEAN. AS TAX
PAYERS DEFINING IT SHOULD
FOLLOW THE STUDENT TO THE
SCHOOL THEY ARE ENROLLED IN. AT
THE MOMENT IS NOT AN OPTION FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND MANY HAVE
ALREADY ENROLLED HUNDRED
STUDENTS. SCHOOL YEAR.
CELEBRITY CLASS THAN THEIR
UNFORTUNATELY IF IT CONTINUES
NOT GOING TO RECEIVE THE
FUNDING. NEEDED IN ORDER TO
FULFILL THAT. AFFECT YOU PLEASE
AMEND. EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN TERM
OF THE CATHOLIC SCHOOL GIRL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO
THE NUMBER EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THOMAS
TAURUS YEAR AND THE CHAIRMAN
FOR THE POOR WORKING IN
DENTICLE UNION. WE ARE SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY EIGHT
WITH CONCERNS CORD REGINA
SUPPORT SECTION TWENTY ONE OF
AB EIGHTY EIGHT. DATA TO THE
CLOSURE OF TO THE STATE PRISONS
WITHIN THE NEXT TWO YEARS
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
THAT CAN TWENTY ONE OF THE BILL
AB EIGHT EIGHT ONLY REQUIRED
EDT ARE YOU NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH PRESENTS A
PLAN A PLAN TO CLOSE WITH THE
NEXT TWO YEARS. WE BELIEVE THE
LANGUAGE IS DIFFICULT INSOFAR
AS THEY DID NOT ESTABLISH A
PROCESS ALLOWS STAKEHOLDER OR
WHITE INPUT IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS. AND THE
DECISIONS ARE NOT TIED TO ANY
THE WHITE PLAN THE MANAGER
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE WE BELIEVE
A CLOSE DECISION MAKING PROCESS
THAT THEY THOUGHT APPROACH AND
WILL NOT LEAD TO OPTIMAL-RESULTS. I'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF
LEGISLATORS AND MEETINGS AND ON
THE BOARD OF EACH OF THE HOUSES
THAT THE STATE NEEDS A PLAN TO
MANAGE BRITAIN'S ALLEY ALL ALSO
PLEDGES A REPORT TO HERE
INDICATING STATE. THAT HAS NO
PLAN AND THE LEGISLATOR
REQUIRED EDTA YOU ARE AVAILABLE
PLAN MANAGING THE STATE PRISON
EVER STRUCTURE WE AGREE THE
PLAN IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE
LEGISLATOR OVERSIGHT AND-
FISCALLY PRUDENT AND SOUND
DECISION MAKING. WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A PRODUCT THAT THE STABBING
EITHER BY SECTION TWENTY ONE
OFF THE BILL I KNOW THERE ARE
NO OTHER MEANS FORMAL OR
INFORMAL. THIRD THAT IN ONE
MINUTE. HE'S AVERAGE AB WELL
LET. AND PLAN SIR THAT'S ONE
MINUTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY MODERATOR
WOULDN'T PLEASE ONE. NEXT YEAR
THE NUMBER EIGHT OH ONE PLEASE
GO. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS BONTA TYLER READY
BUT THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
ALL KEEP IT BRIEF SO WHERE ARE
CHRISTIAN AT BOB BEYOND
REALIGNMENT BACK ON THE BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR I'M WHICH WILL
SUPPORT TOWN CRITICAL COUNTY
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS. AS I'M
EIGHTY WINE WHICH INCLUDES THE-
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
BACKED THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A NUMBER NINE
OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS JUSTIN GARRETT THAT
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THAT COUNTY THERE IN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
INCLUSION OF ONE BILLION IN
FUNDING FOR THE BUDGET IN THE
BUDGET ACT. AFTER STATING THAT
THERE IS A BIG COUNTY RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE WE WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THE LEADERSHIP AN AGREEMENT
TO PRIORITIZE. PRESERVATION OF
THE STATE IN THAT THE ONE
BILLION THAT IS BEING PROVIDED
A REAL ON THE BACK WILL HELP
PREVENT THE MOST SEVERE CUTS TO
THESE PROGRAMS ARE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AGAIN I WE
APPRECIATE YOUR RECOGNITION NOW
THAT THE SERVICE OF THEIR
FACING DEVASTATING CUTS. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO A NUMBER
NINE OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RONALD COLMAN FOR HELP
ACCESS CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PLEADING GREAT FOR THE BUDGET
JUNIOR AB AT AVOID MOST BECAUSE
PROPOSED IN GOVERNOR'S SINCE
MAY REVISED THANK YOU YOU KNOW
THAT IS STILL HAVILY RELIES ON
HAS YET TO BE SEEN FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID WORKERS
LEGISLATORS AND THE GOVERNOR TO
CONTINUE TO SPEAK ADDITIONAL
REVENUE ALTERNATIVES TO ENSURE
WE CAN AVOID ANY FUTURE CUT THE
HEALTHCARE. BUT ALSO FULLY FUND
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES IN THE
FUTURE CUTS TO MEDICARE
PROVIDERS BUT PROPERTY SECTOR
BUT OFF THE BUDGET THIS YEAR
BUT SCHEDULED FOR NEXT YEAR
STARTING JULY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THIS WILL IMPACT ACCESS
ADDITIONALLY MORE OF A MAJOR
DISAPPOINTMENT FOR US IS THE
NOTION MADE MINISTRATION
INDEFINITE DELAY TO EXPAND THE
MEDIC OUT TO UNDOCUMENTED THING
IS WHEN THIS POPULATIONS BASED.
AND UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS
DESERVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THE CHRONIC CONDITIONS MANAGE
DAY BEFORE KOBE NINETEEN IMPACT
THEIR LIVES MAKING THEM MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO COMPLICATIONS
AND OR DEATH. I'M QUITE FRANKLY
WE STILL NEED TO TURN OUR
ATTENTION BACK TO ONE MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO LEAVE OUT HOWEVER
WE ARE PLEASED THAT THAT WE DID
NOT ABOUT THE CUT THAT YOU NOT
COVERAGE YOU CAN NOW WITH THE
SENIORS FALL OFF THE
PRESERVING. THAT CALENDAR AND
IT'S FOR P. THANK YOU KNOW
THAT'S ONE MINUTE. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO A NUMBER.
TWO THREE PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THE PUBLIC AT A MEMBER
OF THE EQUITY COALITION WITH
THE COURT MUCH OF THE EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL INCLUDING NO CUTS
OUT THE FF YEAH CATION OF TWO
POINT NINE BILLION FOR LEARNING
LOSS MITIGATION ACCORDING TO
THE EQUITY FORMULA OR COALITION
RECOMMENDED. AND A FORTY FIVE
NINE FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOL WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE EL CAP
LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT REQUIRED IN
DEVELOPING THE LEARNING
CONTINUITY AND ATTENDED PLAN
HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE DISHES
THE CARD FROM AFFORDABLE
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
STUDENTS OF COLOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS. I NOT INCLUDING A
FRIEND REQUIREMENTS FOR REAL
TIME INSTRUCTION THE BILL OPENS
THE DOOR FOR INSTRUCTIONAL
MINUTES THE FILTER ASSIGNMENTS
OR PRERECORDED LECTURE WE
RECOMMEND REQUIRING AT LEAST
THREE HOURS A DAY OF LIFE FACE
TO FACE INSTRUCTION BEATING
CLASSROOMS THEIR DISTANCE
LEARNING OR HYBRID MODEL.
PLEASE YEARLY DISPLAY LATE
REGIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS RECEIVE
THE HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION
THEY'RE ENTITLED AND LASTLY WE
ASK YOU TO CLOSE THE OUT THE
ABOUT LOOPHOLE BY ADDING TO THE
BUDGET LANGUAGE IN EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WEBER TO ENSURE
THE SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
DOLLARS INVESTED IN THE HIGH
NEED STUDENTS THE GENERATE FROM
THANK YOU HAVE. ONE MINUTE.
NEXT WITNESS. NECK TO A NUMBER
NINE. TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
NEED AND THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO WORKING WITH
CONCERNS MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
BECAUSE YOU CON AND I'M
HONESTLY YEAR RESIDENT ANIMAL
THOUGHT. AND I CAN TRULY SAY
THAT I SPEAK FOR EVERY PARENT
OF A CHILD LEARN TO COMMUNITY
MONTESSORI CHARTER CHOOL- WE
WILL LIKE TO SEE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE PROVISIONS
UNVEILED AB SEVENTY SEVEN THAT
WOULD EFFECTIVELY CAP GROWTH IN
CHARTER SCHOOL ATTENDANCE IN
FUNDING. I DIDN'T MEAN THAT OUR
SCHOOL WITH THE FUNDING FOR
OVER A HUNDRED KIDS UNDER THE
ONLY ONE TO THIRTY BASED
LEARNING CENTER IN OUR AREA AND
IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE TO MATCH
THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION IF
THIS GOLDEN ADEQUATE OR CAT
PROPER FUNDING. I DID A VERY
UNIQUE AND DIVERSE COMMUNITY
AND YOU WOULD HER HUNDREDS OF
FAMILIES THAT THIS PROVISION-
WOULD PASS. AND SEND THAT THE
BEING A THING- I'LL ANOTHER
ISSUE THE WATER LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT. FOR A COMPREHENSIVE
THE FAMILY. YEAH THANK YOU.
NEXT WHAT ONE MINUTE NEXT WE GO
TO NUMBER NINE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MICHELLE GIVEN THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE THE CITY THAT
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEGE BORN
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR IT
BE UP TO ONE BILLION IN FINDING
WHAT REALIGNED PROGRAMS I WHICH
WILL SUPPORT VITAL PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICES. I ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THAT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION IN KERRY
FUNDING PROVIDED THE COUNTY AND
TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION FOR
REJECTING CUT THE OTHER VITAL
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE BLACK AND THE
HEALTH PROGRAM AND THE CHILD
HEALTH THE DISABILITY PROGRAM
AND FUNDING AT AND INDIGESTION
MAKING THE FUNDING FOR AT HE
HIV AND AIDS THE BE ON GOING. I
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR DIFFERING
THE BEEPING TAX LOOK FURTHER
THAT LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
ENGAGEMENT ON THOSE ITEMS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT YEAR
NUMBER NINE FIFTY TWO. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FLETCHER MEMBERS
BENJAMIN CHAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PET AT THINK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE ECHO
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WORSEN PRE
EXISTING HEALTH IS VERY
AFFECTING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUTER COLOR FORCING HIS
WORKERS TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE
CHOICE BETWEEN PROVIDING FOR
THEIR FAMILY OR MINIMIZING THE
FAMILIES. OF INFECTION EIGHTY
FAMILY LEAD DURING THESE TIMES
OF AMERICANS YOU CAN IMPORT
YOUR EQUITY PALM BEACH THE
WORKER CAN HIGH- HAS THEIR OWN
HEALTH AND HEALTH OF THE
FAMILY. IF YOU'RE GOING TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WE MUST ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO DRIVE ECONOMY ARE
HEALTHY BY DIRECTING YOU TO
START. ALSO WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR DISAPPOINTMENT IN
THE GOVERNMENT'S DECISION TO
NOT INCLUDE MEDICAL EXPENSE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IN YOUR IN THE
BUDGET I THINK CANNOT WAIT FOR
NEEDY CARE ESPECIALLY DURING
THE ATTACK. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT A
NUMBER NINE NINE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M ROBBIE GONZALEZ
NOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BREASTFEEDING COALITION AND WE
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE TO ALL WORKERS HAVE JOB
AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS A SMALL
BUSINESS. WE HAVE HAD OUR OWN
EXPERIENCE WITH HAVING- SOMEONE
TAKE BELIEVE MYSELF FOR SURGERY
DUE TO CANCER. AND I'M THE ONLY
PART TIME EMPLOYEES WE HAVE A
COUPLE CONTRACTORS BUT WE DID
SURVIVE THAT PERIOD AND IT
MEANT A LOT TO ME BECAUSE MY
EMPLOYER VALUES ME AND I VALUE
THEM. AND I AGAIN JUST WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE. NEXT TO A
NUMBER EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
LOOKING. UNDER ON BEHALF OF
PEOPLE LIKE THAT THE KIDS THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK
CALLING IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE IT
WILL ENSURE THAT WORKERS WHO
ARE PAYING INTO THE STATE PAID
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM ARE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY TAKE THAT
LEAVE. WITHOUT ANY PAY REQUIRED
OF THEIR EMPLOYERS IN ORDER TO
CARE FOR A SERIOUSLY ILL FAMILY
MEMBER THEIR OWN ILLNESS OR UP
ON THE NEW TILE OVER 40% OF
WORKERS TO PAY INTO THE SYSTEM
CAN ACTUALLY ACCESS THE
BENEFITS. BECAUSE THEY COULD BE
FIRED FOR TAKING THAT UNPAID
TIME OFF TO CARE FOR THEIR OWN
ILLNESS SO THAT A FAMILY MEMBER
THAT REASON YOU STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THIS BILL THE BILL
THAT EQUITY GAP. THANK YOU NAY
WITNESS. THANKS TO A NUMBER
NINE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS BACKING
THEM YES I LIVE IN SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY FOUR AND I'M
WITH CALIFORNIA WORKING FAMILY
COLLECTION I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AT THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE TRAILER
BILL ALL WORKERS SHOULD HAVE
JOB PROJECTED PAID NEEDS THAT'S
QUITE HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR
HARD ORKING PEOPLE LIKE MY
SISTER. YOU HAVE THE PROTECTION
WORKING PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WERE QUITE INTO AND YEAH I AM
NOT ABLE USE THE PROGRAMS THEY
PAY YOU WITHOUT. RISKING THEIR
JOB THANK YOU. THE QUICKNESS.
NEXT YEAR THE NUMBER NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
SENATE. BERNIE WITH LEGAL AID
AT WORK THE UNIT AND WE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA'S LOW WAGE WORKING
FAMILIES IN STRONG SUPPORT
ABOUT THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THE BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS PROVIDE PAID LEAVE
RATHER INSURED EMPLOYED CAN ACT
THE STATE INSURANCE AND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE ENTIRELY AND FULLY
FUNDED PROGRAM FOR THE WITH THE
PROGRAM WE NOTED THAT THIS BILL
AMENDS THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RIGHT BACK AND NOT THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM IS
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
TWO THINGS GO HAND IN HAND.
PAID FAMILY BENEFITS ARE
MEANINGLESS AND HE MADE BY YOUR
FOR TAKING AT LOW WAGE WORKERS
LIKE MY CLIENT SIMPLY. CANNOT
AFFORD TO RISK THEIR JOBS IN MY-
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WHETHER YOU
HAVE ONE BECAUSE- OR A HUNDRED
YOU SHOULDN'T BE FIRED FOR
HAVING A CHILD. FOR GETTING
CANCER ARE CARING FOR YOUR
PARENTHOOD BODY. COVERING ALL
EMPLOYEES OF NOT A NOVEL IDEA.
FIVE OTHER STATES INCLUDING NEW
YORK RHODE ISLAND MASSACHUSETTS
CONNECTICUT AND OR AGAIN. ALL
ENACTED EIGHT FAMILY PLOT. THAT
PROVIDE JOB PROTECTION FOR ALL
WORKERS REGARDLESS OF EMPLOYERS
THAT. AND THE BRIEFLY DISCUSS
WHERE WOEFULLY BEHIND THE REST
OF THE WORLD. UNITED STATES
ONLY IS THE ONLY COUNTRY AMONG
FORTY ONE NATIONS OF THE NOT
MANDATE ANY PAID LEAVE FOR YOU
CAN'T. ALSO A PAID LEAVE
REQUIRED ANY OTHER. IN ABOUT
TWO MONTHS. WE CAN AND MUST BE
BETTER TO MAKE SURE THE HEALTH
ECONOMIC SECURITY AND WELL
BEING OF ALL OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
THOSE REASONS. WE ARE TRANSPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE ONE MINUTE. NEXT
TO A NUMBER NINE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVENING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ALLOCATE CAPRI ON
BEHALF OF FIRST AND CALIFORNIA
IN TERMS OF THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BECAUSE NO PARENT SHOULD
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THE WELL
BEING OF THEIR NEW CHILD AND
FAMILY FINANCIAL SECURITY AND
HEALTH. RESEARCH MAKE THAT
CLEAR THE FIRST MONTH IN YEARS
ARECRUCIAL I THINK THAT WOULD
FREQUENT NURTURING PARENT CHILD
INTERACTION BEING THE KEY TO
TRONG B. BRAIN DEVELOPMENT AND
THE FIRST THREE NOT. TOO MANY
WORKERS HOWEVER OFTEN ATTORNEY
PAID FAMILY LEAVE AMOUNTS ARE
PAYING INTO A BENEFIT THERE TOO
AFRAID TO ACCESS FOR FEAR OF
LOSING THEIR JOBS ARE BEING
ABOUT- WORKING PARENTS MUST
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FIND THE
FIRST TEAM I THINK EACH CHILD
WHITE. AND ASIAN TO ENSURE
THEIR CHILD DRIVE WHICH IS
ACTUALLY IMPORTANT. DURING
STRESSFUL AND UNCERTAIN TIME.
CAN ABOUT YEAH PROPELLED JUST A-
TO THE PROPER OF OUR FUTURE
CHEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITNESS. NEXT TO THE NUMBER ONE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO NUMBER
ONE NINE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'LL MOVE TO
NUMBER NINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS KELLY JAKE UP AND ON
BOTH EDUCATORS AND PARENTS IN A
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL I
WOULD SPEAK OUT OF MY STRONG
OPPOSITION TO CAP ON SCHOOL
GROWTH FUNDING EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN. THE HOLD HARMLESS
LANGUAGE BEING USED AS A
MISNOMER AS IT ONLY HARM WITH
THE TOOLS WITH DECLINING
ENROLLMENT IT'S ACTUALLY QUITE
HARMFUL TO GROWING SCHOOL WHICH
IS ARE. WE ALREADY IN BOLD NEW
STUDENTS FOR NEXT SCHOOL YEAR
AND THE CAP WILL NOT ALLOW IT
TO PROVIDE ADEQUATELY FOR THE
STUDENTS. THE MONEY SHOULD
FOLLOW THE- NOT AMENDING THE-
ONLY FAIR TO TAKE AWAY MY RIGHT
TO THE PARENT TO THE SCHOOL THE
EXACTLY NAVIGATING EDUCATION IN
THE CURRENT CLIMATE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS ONE
MINUTE. NEXT TO A NUMBER NINE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ATTY REAGAN AND I AM A
TEACHER AT HIGH TECH ELEMENTARY
EXPLORE IN SAN DIEGO I OPPOSE
THE EIGHTY A CAP ON GROWING
PUBLIC SCHOOL EACH OF OUR
STUDENTS DESERVE THE HIGH
QUALITY AND FULLY FUNDED PUBLIC
EDUCATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO
A NUMBER NINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS REBECCA
MORE THAN AT A AND I HAD TO
COME AND CHECK FOR ALSO YOU CAN
EITHER AND I'M ASKING THAT YOU
AMEND AB SEVENTY SEVEN TO
REMOVE THE CAP ON SCHOOLWORK
FUNDING SCHOOLS THAT NEED TO
EXPANSION I HAVE TO STRUGGLE
WITH FINDING ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR EACH STUDENT. IF ONE THIRD
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE
BANNING THE FUNDING CAPRICORN
SCHOOLS UNACCEPTABLE I ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
EITHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO A NUMBER
NINE NINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE SHIRE AND
I'M REPRESENTING HIGH TECH
ELEMENTARY AND DIFFERENT BAND
YET THOUGH AND I HAVE CLOSE TO
EIGHTY A CAP ON GROWING PUBLIC
SCHOOL. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO A NUMBER TEN NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ERIN AND HOME SCHOOLING PARENTS
AS- TWO NINE THE CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER STUDENTS AND ONE
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL IT'S AN
ACKERMAN ACCOUNTING I BELIEVE
THAT. WE NEED TO REVISE OR PAIN
NOW TO AB SEVEN SEVEN BECAUSE
THE SCHOOL ATTENDANCE FUNDING
SHOULD FOLLOW THE STUDENT TO
WHATEVER'S COOL THEY CAN AND
SHOULD NOT BE BASED. ON LAST
YEAR'S STUDENT NUMBERS BUT ON
THE CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. I
WOULD ASK THE WITNESSES IF
YOU'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
BEFORE YOU TO MAKE UP POINTS
THAT YOU CAN FEEL FREE TO SAY
YOUR NAME THE BILL YOUR
OPPOSING AND JUST SAY DITTO
WE'VE HEARD LOTS OF PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE- ISSUES AROUND A.
B. SEVEN SEVEN SO. DON'T FEEL
COMPELLED TO REPEAT THEM NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT TO A
NUMBER TEN TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
MICHAEL ACOSTA JOHN WITH
KENTUCKY HOW HARD THEY CAN'T
STAND POINT MEMBERSGENDER
JUSTICE LA. WE ARE JUST
LEGISLATOR TO NOT TO YOUR BACK
ON THE HEALTH CARE OF
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE AND
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
INCLUDE HOUSE ALL SENIORS
SENATOR LEYVA MENTIONED EARLIER
THE FUTURE ISSUES ARE MATTER
WELL. EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU
HAS BEEN A GREAT CONSTITUENTS
AND WE ARE IMMIGRANT CALIFORNIA
WHY IS IT THAT WE'RE WILLING TO
CONSISTENT AND IDOLIZES
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU KNOW THAT
WE ARE ON THE FRONTLINE
EVERYDAY STAINING CALIFORNIA
STATION FROM THE FROM MY FARM
AND WAREHOUSES TO GO SHE STARTS
TO THE LANDSCAPE. CALIFORNIA
MADE A SUBSTANTIAL LIFE HI MOST
I'M LOOKING AT THE CORRECT LAKE
HOUSE UNDER A PANDEMIC
IMMIGRANTS WE ASK THAT YOU CARE
FOR SENIORS FIRST ENERGY TO
INCLUDE HEALTH FOR ALL THE
YEARS THAT MAKE IT FEASIBLE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
FIGHT. FOR THE LIFE OF OUR
FAMILIES. BEYOND FRUSTRATING AT
HEARTBREAKING CONSISTENTLY LOW.
AT A LOSS FEELING HOPELESS
BECAUSE THE WORST. EFFICIENTLY
MATTER AS WELL. AND WE ARE YOU
THAT YOU CAN. TO FOR THE RIGHT
ONE MINUTE THANK YOU. MUCH ONE
MAY. NO WITNESS PLEASE. THE
NEXT WILL GO TO NUMBER TEN
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS SHANNON HOW THIS FROM
THE DIRECTOR THEY WERE OUT
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS STATEWIDE WE STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. LEAVE
THE QUIRK KILLER HERE ELSE
WORK. BECAUSE THERE IS NO
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM WITHOUT
PAID FAMILY LEAVE. AND WITHOUT
JOB PROTECTION HE LEAVE IT'S
MEANINGLESS. MILLION
CALIFORNIANS P. INTO PROGRAM
THEY CANNOT THEY CANNOT USE. I
MEAN FOR THEIR BEING ROBBED OF
THE PROGRAMS THEY ARE
LEGITIMATELY PAYING. AS
MENTIONED FIVE OTHER STATE ALL
HAVE FAMILY LEAVE WITH
UNIVERSAL DROPPED ACTION
REGARDLESS OF THE PLAYER SIDE.
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
CATCH UP. CHARLIE URGES YOUR
WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE. NEXT TO A
NUMBER TEN THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE HI I AM A HIGH
SCHOOL PRINCIPAL CALLING FROM
OAKLAND I'M CALLING TO ASK THAT
YOU AMEND AB SEVENTY SEVEN TO
REMOVE THE CAP ON CORPORATE
FUNDING WE'VE ALREADY COMMITTED
TO TAKING ON A NEW CLASS OF
NINETY METERS. AND HIRE
TEACHERS FOR THE FALL AB
SEVENTY SEVEN IS NOT AMENDED WE
WILL BE SEEN ZERO FUNDING FROM
THE STATE TO SERVE THE STUDENTS
AND PAY OUR TEACHERS. OUR
STUDENTS COME FROM THE CODE
THAT HAS BEEN HARD HIT BY
CORONAVIRUS THAT ARE COUNTY
DURING THE SHELTER IN PLACE OUR
SCHOOL HAS BEEN A KEY LIFELINE
THAT OUR FAMILIES DEPEND ON FOR
CONSISTENT DAILY INSTRUCTION
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND MORE
IF YOU DO NOT REMOVE THE EIGHTY
A COP YOUR ACTIONS WILL HAVE A
REAL HUMAN IMPACT ON OAKLAND
STUDENTS. OR FURTHER FROM
PRIVILEGED PLEASE A MAN AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE. THE
CAP ON SCHOOL GROWTH FUNDING.
THE NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO A
NUMBER TEN FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS PAIGE
PANIC AND REPRESENTING HIGH
TECH ELEMENTARY EXPLORING SAN
DIEGO ONE OF THE MANY CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA AND I ASK
THAT YOU A MAN EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP ON
SCHOOL GROUNDS FUNDING TO
ENSURE THAT EACH OF OUR
STUDENTS RECEIVE THE QUALITY
EDUCATION AND ALL THE STAFF
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THEY
DESERVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO NUMBER
TEN FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHRIS RESPONSE WHICH ARE THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS SURELY DISAPPOINTED OF
THE FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT WALK
BACK ON THE COMMUNITY AND THE
GOVERNOR HAS MADE EXCLUDES
IMMIGRANT FAMILY THE BILL'S
RECOGNIZE YOUR MONEY DURING THE
ACADEMIC THE BUDGET I YOU'LL
VOTE ON TONIGHT FOR THE DRUGS
AND BACKING A FAMILY DEEP
POVERTY AND THESE ARE
FREDERATOR SYSTEM COUNTY. HERE
ONCE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL MEANT
THAT EVERYONE IS PROTECTED IN
THE CALLED THE CALIFORNIA BUILT
A HOUSE THE IMMIGRANTS- I BILL
AND I CALIFORNIA'S BEEN ABLE TO
CALL THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD WITH BUDGET FROM
THE WRONG SIGNAL CENTER
COMMUNITY WITH A CALIFORNIA
MORE LONGER HAVE THE BODY THE
ONE TIME. WE DEMAND OF THE
BUDGET INCLUDE IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES THIS YEAR NEXT YEAR
AND EVERY DOCTOR THAT WE ASK.
YOU NOT TO LEAVE YOU
CALIFORNIANS BEHIND. THANK YOU
WHEN IT WITNESS. NEXT TO NUMBER
NINE SO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND READ WITH THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION ALSO
HERE FOR NATIONAL SHOOTING
SPORTS FOUNDATION KIND UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTY EIGHT SECTION TWENTY
THREE TO FORTY THREE WE
POLITICS MANSION OF THE TOILET
AND CONTROL ACT THAT POLICY
DECISION SHOULD BE DEALT WITH.
IN A POLICY COMMITTEE RATHER
THAN A THAN A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL IS ACT IS SUBJECT ONGOING
LITIGATION AND THIS-
RESTRICTION ONLY SERVES TO BUY
ME FURTHER TECHNOLOGY. AND THE
BUDGET IN AN APPROPRIATE PLACE
THE WITH THIS POLICY DECISION
FURTHER IF WE OPPOSE THE
EXPEDITING OF THE PRECURSOR
PRECURSOR PARTS RESTRICTION
THAT CONTAINED IN THE BUDGET
MOVING UP T TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
A DOJ IS FAILING TO ADEQUATELY
PROCESS BACKGROUND CHECKS AS IT
IS IN A LOT OF THE AMMUNITION
BACKGROUND CHECKS HAS CREATED
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS FROM
ACCESS THE AMMUNITION AND THE
PRECURSOR PARTS RELY ON THAT
AIM SYSTEM. TO FUNCTION IT
PREMATURE AND WE ASK THAT BE
REMOVED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE NEXT WITNESS. NEXT YEAR AND
NINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS WENDY MONTEZ AND I'M
A PARENT OF SIX CHILDREN AND I
AM IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN THE FUNDING SHOULD
FOLLOW THE STUDENT. AND THERE
SHOULD BE NO CAP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO
A NUMBER TEN FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU GO HEAD ONE MINUTE.
YEAH HI MY NAME IS ACTUALLY
READ BUT I AM THE MOTHER OF A
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD AND I'M
CALLING IN OPPOSITION AT
EIGHTY. SEVEN THE BILL
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST STUDENTS
WHO NEED TO ENROLL AND NON.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO COVER
NINETEEN PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE LEGALLY REQUIRED TO
STUDENTS WHO WISH TO AND ALL
BUT WOULD NOW BE REQUIRED TO
EDUCATE THAT STUDENT WITH ZERO
FUNDING. FROM THESTATE MEANING
THAT THE FUNDING FROM THEIR
EXISTING KINECT WILL NEED TO
BE. REDISTRIBUTED TO COVER THE
NEEDS. ORDER ARE YOU OPERATING
ON WHAT SENDING THAT OUR PUBLIC
DISTRICT SCHOOL. PLEASE DO NOT.
PASSED THE BILL. IT'S GOING TO
AFFECT FMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
THAT CHILDREN THE TYPICALLY
DISABLED THAT. DID NOT MEAN TO
HELP FURTHER THEIR EDUCATION.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON EIGHTY SEVEN
ELEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE. NEXT TO A
NUMBER SEVEN NINE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THE CALL
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
CALLING ON OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE I WANT TO
THANK THOSE SENATORS WHO RAISED
CONCERNS ON THE FLOOR THIS
EVENING ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
SMALL BUSINESSES AND THE NEED
FOR GREATER CONSIDERATION OF
THOSE AND PASS. AND I ALSO LIKE
TO REMIND THE BODY THAT TWO
THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING IT'S TWENTY FIVE
OR LESS EMPLOYEES. THESE ARE
WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES THAT ARE OFTEN TIME
GENERATIONAL AND THEY'RE ALSO
JOB CREATORS WHO SUCCESSES
INTEGRAL TO THE REVITALIZATION
OF THE STATE'S REGIONAL
ECONOMY. GIVEN THE NATURE OF
OUR OPERATIONS AND THE
CONSTRAINTS ON OUR PRODUCTION
SCHEDULES THIS PROPOSAL IS AND
MANAGEABLE AND COSTLY IN TERMS
OF LOS PRODUCTION CAT CAPACITY
AND THE INABILITY TO BACK STILL
ABSENCES DUE TO THE NEED FOR
SKILLED LABOR. WE ASK THAT YOU
DON'T KNOW ON SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE.
NEXT TO A NUMBER TEN THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE GOOD
EVENING FORGET ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA IN THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION DURING OUR HISTORY
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHICH IS
THE SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION. AND
COSTLY CIVIL LIABILITY AT A
TIME WHEN PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS ESPECIALLY SMALL
EMPLOYERS CANNOT AFFORD IT WE
ENCOURAGE YOUR OPPOSITION AT
THE TIME THANK YOU. NEXT ORDER
NUMBER NINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE HOTCHNER AND A MOTHER
OF THREE AND THAT WOULD CREATE
THE MEN EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN TO
REMOVE THE CAP ON SMALL GROWTH
FUNDING I'M SORRY SCHOOL COULD
FUNDING WE SHOULD NOT CUT
VARIOUS OPTIONS FOR LEARNING
SPECIAL DURING COPE WITH.
UNANSWERED AND DURING THE
CENTER IN TOWN I ALSO OPPOSE SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AS IT IS
WRITTEN MOM BUT PLEASE FIND A
BETTER WAY TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIAN AND SMALL
BUSINESSES I THINK YOU CAN DO
THAT. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK I ALSO CALLED
THE GOT. THE GUN BILL THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER ONE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS TWENTY ACT PLAN I AM
A MOM OF THREE CHILDREN FROM
ORANGE COUNTY PLEASE AMEND AB
SEVENTY SEVEN COULD REMOVE THE
CAP ON SCHOOL BUT I NEED TO
ALLOW ANY OTHER STUDENTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
MODERATOR. NEXT TO A NUMBER
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THEN WILL MOVED IN
NUMBER TEN SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING NIGHTER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HELP FACILITIES
WHICH REPRESENTS OVER NINE
HUNDRED. CALIFORNIA I NEED TO
CREATION WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHTY
ONE BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE IT
REPRESENTS AN APPROPRIATE
BALANCE BETWEEN PROVIDING
GREATER SUPPORT TO WORKING
FACILITIES IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. WHILE SHARING ITS
ABILITY TO COMPLYING WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE CODE BUT
NINETEEN REQUIREMENTS
MAINTAINING STRICT MINIMUM
STAFFING AND WAGE REQUIREMENT.
AND PROVIDING QUALITY AND STATE
CHARACTERS NO PATIENT. WITH
THIS FOUND THE PRODUCE THANK
HEALTH PRECIPITATION HELP THE
THIRTIES MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO
SUPPORT. YOU ASIAN OF THEIR
CALL SURE THE PAYMENTS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN AB EIGHTY ONE. AND
ARE NECESSARY TO HELP FUND THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM FOR NURSING
HOME PATIENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT TO A NUMBER TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANASTASIA DOWN
I AM FROM SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA I NEED A HOME SCHOOL
MOTHER. ARE YOU A HOME BASED
CHARTER AND I OPPOSE AB SEVENTY
SEVEN REMOVAL OF BODY. FROM
GROWING ENROLLMENT THE FUND
SHOULD FOLLOW THE STUDENT AND
IT DISCRIMINATORY NOT TO HAVE
THE FUNDS FOLLOW THE STUDENT-
ITSELF THAT ILLEGAL AND
VIOLATE. PART THE STATE
CONSTITUTION I AM NOT SURE WHAT
YOU GUYS ARE TRYING TO DO BUT
THIS ISN'T OKAY THANK YOU. THE
NEXT WILL BE GOING TO NUMBER-
TEN SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ARE WE GOING TO NUMBER
TEN SIXTY TO TEN SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
MEMBERS THIS IS ROY CRIBBAGE
BEGIN ON THE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION WE STAND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB AT A-
DISCUSSION EARLIER REGARDING
THIS CLOSING A LOOPHOLE IN THE
CURRENT LAW I WON'T EVEN GO
THERE. I COLLEAGUES EARLIER
TOUCHED ON OTHER POINTS OF THE
SHORTENING OF TIMELINE OF THE
PRECURSORS ARE STILL ONLY
PASSED LAST YEAR. I'D LIKE TO
ADD WHAT WE HAVEN'T TALKED
ABOUT YET IS THIS BILL ALSO
PROHIBITS THE JOINT
REGISTRATION OF ASSAULT
WEAPONS. THAT IS NOT A RIFLE
PISTOL OR SHOCK AND THIS
REQUIREMENT ALONE IS HUGE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUING DEPRIVE
SPOUSES OF THE RIGHT TO SEARCH
FARMS. AS COMMON PROPERTY THIS
BILL ULTIMATELY JUST HIGH-
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYING DOLLARS
AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS LITIGATIONS- AB AT IS
JUST YET NOT A BACK DOOR-
ATTEMPT TO GREATLY RESTRICT THE
SECOND AMEND RIGHTS OF ARE LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS. WHILE DOING
NOTHING TO PUNISH CRIMINALS
KNOWINGLY USE FARMS COULD BUY
ONE CRIMES. WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR OPPOSITION AND VOTE NO ON
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS AN HOUR ONE MINUTE. NOW
ONE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS TERRA PART I
AM A MOTHER IF YOU FROM LIKE
ALL LEARN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
I'M ASKING YOU PLEASE AMEND
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN TO REMOVE
THE CAP ON WILL GROWTH FUNDING.
MY TAX DOLLARS SHOULD FOLLOW MY
KIDS GO TO SCHOOL THE FUND
SHOULD FOLLOW THE STUDENT.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WILL GO TO
NUMBER FOUR SEVENTY ONE OF FOUR
SEVENTY ONE YOU LINES OPEN.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS JEFF RICE
WITH THE A PLUS PERSONALIZED
LEARNING NETWORK ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS SERVING MORE
THAN SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND K.
TWELVE STUDENTS. REGARDING AB
SEVENTY SEVEN WE TO OPPOSE THE
DRASTIC CHANGE IN STATE FUNDING
POLICY THAT IS GUARANTEED FOR
DECADES THAT L. CFF FUNDING
FOLLOWS THE STUDENT SEVERAL
SENATORS DURING THIS HEARING OF
ALREADY EXPRESSED THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT NEW POLICIES
BEING INSERTED. INTO BUDGET
TRAILER BILL THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS IS A MAJOR. SCHOOLS
THAT ARE IN A POSITION TO GROW
AND BETTER SERVE THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS DURING OR IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS IS HARMFUL NEW
POLICY THE DENIAL OF FUNDING OF
NEW STUDENT ENROLLMENT IS A
POLICY SHIFT. THAT REACHES THAT
LONG STANDING PER STUDENT
SELFIE FF FUNDING POLICY AND
PROMISED TO ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
IN IN ITS ESSENCE PUNISHES
QUALITY PUBLIC SCHOOL SUCCESS.
SUCH A MAJOR POLICY SHIFT IN
STATE AB A FUNDING SHOULD NOT
BE EMBEDDED IN AN ELEVENTH HOUR
BUDGET TRAILER BILL WHEN SO
MANY PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE
ALREADY FULLY COMMITTED TO
SIGNIFICANT NEW STUDENT
ENROLLMENT FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU STRIKE GOLD TAPPING
INTO FUNDING POLICY LANGUAGE.
IN THIS TRAILER BILL REQUIRED
THAT LANGUAGE BE INCLUDED THAT
GUARANTEES ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
BE FULLY FUNDED FOR EVERY NEW
STUDENT ENROLLED AFTER FEBRUARY
TWENTY NINE TWENTY TWENTY IN
ADDITION TO CONTINUING STUDENTS
THAT'S ONE MINUTE LONGER ONE
MINUTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY THAT'S ONE
MINUTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
LIKE TO REMIND ALL OF THE BY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON THE
PHONE IF- A PREVIOUS WITNESS
HAS GONE INTO GREAT DETAIL ON
THAT IT'S A SIMILAR ISSUE THAT
YOU LIKE TO REYES FEEL FREE TO
JUST AGREE WITH THE PREVIOUS
CALLER GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
THE BILL YOU'RE CALLING TO.
SUGGEST AMENDMENTS ARE POLLS
NEXT. CALLER MODERATOR ONE
MINUTE PLEASE NECK SO THE LAW
TEN TO ONE THOUSAND FOUR. TEN
FOR. I AGREE. MY NAME IS CAN
TWELVE I'M SORRY CAR I'M
CALLING IN WHO STRAW INTO ABA
TO AB EIGHT THE CONCERN OVER
PATENTS BANTAL BUDGET TRAILER
BILL CONCERNS ARE A LACK OF
WATER JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE
LACK OF STUDY SHOWING HOW EASY
IT WILL PICK LEGAL NON TITLE
ONE OTHER FIREARMS AND THE
POTENTIAL OVERREACH THE RATE OF
LEGAL FARM OWNERS SECONDLY
LAWSUIT WITH MUCH OF EARLIER IN
THE EVENING I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
COST NOT GOVERNOR'S BILL PASSED
PEOPLE IN THE BUDGET CONSIDER
THE FUTURE COSTS OF A PUBLIC.
FIGHT IN COURT. THE BAND THAT
PASSED IN THE MATTER SO WHAT
EVERY TIME THE- IF YOU. HELLO
AT THE VOTE NO ON. EIGHTY
EIGHTY. THANK YOU NICK WITNESS.
THE ACCIDENT TEN FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CAMERA
AND THEY REPRESENT AN
ASSOCIATION OF THOUSANDS OF
SPECIAL NEEDS PARENT. POSE THE
TRAILER TO AB SEVENTY SEVEN AS
DISCRIMINATORY BECAUSE MANY OF
THE SPECIALLY INDEPENDENT
CHARTER SCHOOL HAVE DONE AN
EXEMPLARY JOB OF HELPING
SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS RELATIVE
TO THE REGULAR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THE OTHER THING IS
THAT THERE IS A SECTION IN
THERE ONE ONE NINE REGARDING
DYSLEXIA AND THE DYSLEXIA
LANGUAGE IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE
THE DYSLEXIA PROBLEM THE TRONG
COMPLICATED THAT THEY SHOULD
NOT IT SHOULD GO THROUGH
REGULAR COMMITTEES WHEN YOU CAN
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION. LASTLY WE
OPPOSE SHIFTING THE FUNDING FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION THERE'S
ALREADY ENOUGH FIGHT WITH
ATTORNEYS AND PARENTS AND WE
DON'T NEED TO BE SHIFTING
ANYMORE WE NEED TO MAKE A REAL
REFORMS IN HOW WE SPEND OUR
MONEY THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A LINE TEN
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS KAREN AND BRING TIME OF
PARENTS FROM WAY TO PARK. ALL
REGARDING AB SEVENTY SEVEN
APPRECIATE PROTECTING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS FROM SEPARATE FUNDING
DEFICITS BUT PLEASE LEAVE IT IS
A FLOOR NOT A CAP SO THAT
SCHOOLS ARE EXPANDING TO SAFELY
SUPPORT ALL STUDENTS CAN
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU BUT NEXT
WILL GO TO. SCHOOL NEXT A
NUMBER TEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DESIREE
MARCH. TWO ELEMENTARY AGE
CHILDREN ESCONDIDO ONE OF WHICH
IS A SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD
ENROLLMENT CHARTER SCHOOL HEY
ECHO EARLIER OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN SEVEN THAT WOULD LIMIT
GROWTH IN SCHOOLS OF EDUCATION
MODEL WELL SUITED TO STIR
STUDENTS THROUGH THE ENDEMIC
PRACTICAL NEED TO BE FUNDED
BASED ON CURRENT ENROLLMENT. I
ALSO WANT TO STATEMENT BEFORE
VERGE BANNING JOB PROJECTED
PAID FAMILY LEAVE. NEXT TO A
NUMBER NINE OH TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME THE ORDER TO
MY MOTHER FOR SOMEONE WE AND I-
OPPOSE AB SEVEN SEVEN I ALSO
OPPOSE AB EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT WORD A NUMBER
EIGHT TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVEN TEN MEMBERS
TELLING THE HUNTER ON BEHALF
THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION THE LARGE SCALE
SOLAR ASSOCIATION. YES FOR
NOBLE ET PURE NOBLE FUND FOR
SOLAR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE OH FIVE. MEASURES SIMPLY
MAINTAINS THE EXISTING A LOT
AND TREATMENT OF- SOLAR FOR TAX
PURPOSES. THAT WILL ALLOW
EXISTING CONTRACT. SERVING
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS TO
CONTINUE ECONOMICALLY AND
ALLOWS FOR CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE INVESTMENT
CERTAINTY FOR SOLAR GOING
FORWARD. IT IS SIMPLY A MEASURE
THAT CLEANED UP AND IT IS
IMPORTANT I DRAFTING ERROR AND
LOCAL INITIATIVES. AND WE ARE
TO SUPPORT. THE NEXT TO GO TO
NUMBER NINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SHERRY
JOHNSON I AM AT A THREE AND
LAKE ELSINORE RIVERSIDE AND I
AM AT SEVENTY SEVEN- THE
FUNDING NEEDS TO FOLLOW THE
STUDENT. AND THANK YOU. NEXT TO
A NUMBER NINE EIGHT NINE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
IF. HELLO MY NAME IS JOYCE
SPRINKLE FROM ONTARIO
CALIFORNIA I'M RENDON
REPRESENTING MANY OTHER MOMS IN
FAMILIES OF CAUSING AB SEVENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU ALL HER HEARING
IN I HAVE THREE CHILDREN
INCREASED HER SCHOOL INTERVIEW
TO A CLOSE AB SEVENTY SEVEN AT
THAT DISCRIMINATES AGAINST THE
FAMILY RIGHT TO CHOOSE. THE
PLACE OF EDUCATION BEST FOR
THEIR FAMILY'S NEEDS AND HEARD
THE EDUCATION OF THE STUDENTS
CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN CHARTER
SCHOOL. FUNDING SHOULD FOLLOW
THE STUDENT. A NUMBER BEEN AS
WELL ENCOURAGE ALL THE PUBLIC
REPRESENTATIVES OCCURS IN
DEBATE I KNOW THE YOU'RE A
MINORITY BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
SPEAKING UP I HEARD SOME PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT VALUES CHOICES. IS
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU'RE
NOT A HEREBY USUALLY SWIM TAKE
SOME LESSONS PROPERTY. AND GIVE
IT TO ANOTHER CITIZEN TO GET
THEIR VOTE I KNOW SOME OF YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT VALUES BUT
UNTIL YOU ACTUALLY PERSONALLY
PAY FOR IT WITH YOUR NOT
DEALING. SO YOU'RE HURTING
BUSINESSES YOU'RE LIMITING
THEIR RIGHTS AND THEN YOU'RE
YOU'RE SELLING THEIR RESOURCES
TO OTHER PEOPLE FOR FOLKS.
THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT RIGHT.
THERE'S A RECKONING COMING AS
WHEN SHE KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING
TO WORKING AS HARD AS WE CAN TO
GET ANYBODY WHO IS BASICALLY
UNDERMINING THE RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIANS. TORRENT OF OFFICE
AND IF YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE US
WHO HAVE BEEN SITTING ON THIS
PHONE. FOR SIX AND A HALF HOURS
THINK ABOUT THAT. AVERAGE
PEOPLE. THERE'S AN- CRY YOU'RE
GOING TO. IF YOU TO STRIP US OF
OUR LIBERTIES ONE LAST THING.
YOU WORK FOR US AND WE HAD
BOUND YOU THANKS. SO MUCH AND
THAT IS YOUR OWN ONE MINUTE.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT TO A
NUMBER NINE SEVEN THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
STRONG SUPPORTER SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE ALL THE
MAIN POINT OF ALREADY BEEN MADE
BY OTHER WITNESSES WE JUST
REALLY WANTED TO. EMPHASIZE THE
FACT THAT WHAT'S REALLY AT
ISSUE HERE IS WHETHER OR NOT
YOU CAN BE FIRED FOR TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE
FOR BONDING WITH THE CHILD FOR
GETTING SICK YOURSELF. SPENDING
SOME TIME WITH A SICK PARENT
BEFORE THEY DIE RIGHT NOW IF
YOU WORK FOR SMALL EMPLOYERS IF
YOU CURRENTLY LEGAL FOR YOU TO
LOSE YOUR JOB FOR GAUGING IN
THOSE THERE'S A LOT OF REALLY
HELPFUL REALLY INSPIRING TALK
ABOUT MORE ABOUT WHO WE ARE AND
WHAT OUR VALUES ARE. WE
STRONGLY HOPE THAT THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT KIND OF ACTIVITY
GETTING FIRED FOR BEING WITH
YOUR FAMILY IT'S NOT THE KIND
OF THING THAT WE SUPPORT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE GOT A GREAT
CHANCE TO CHANGE THAT HERE WITH
THE SPELL WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS NEXT WILL GO TO
NUMBER. ONE THOUSAND FIVE TEN
OH FIVE PLEASE YOU HAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS AL CONTRARIO SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU SAID SOMETHING
EARLIER AND IT WAS THAT WE NEED
TO LEARN FROM LAST WEEK THE
MALL AFTER A FASHION AND THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T
CUT PROGRAMS ARE RESIDENTS RELY
ON. I WORRY HOW EIGHTY SEVENTY
SEVEN AND CAP ON EIGHTY EIGHT
FUNDING WILL AFFECT THE LONG
TERM SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAMS MY
FAMILY WILL LIVE ON. IN A KIND
OF CAN GET NETWORK KIDS ARE
ALREADY BEING SUBJECTED TO SOME
MEETINGS COMPLETELY OUT OF
THEIR CONTROL WE NEED TO MAKE
IT A PRIORITY TO PROTECT AND
PRESERVE THE OPPORTUNITY YOU
CAN ACTUALLY. DURING SUCH A
ROLE IN THE WORLD TIME FOR OUR
KIDS I ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER THE NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN TO ENSURE THE
PRESERVATION OF THE PROGRAMS
ARE DAMAGED. THANK YOU THANK.
YOU NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE.
NEXT TO A NUMBER NINE THIRTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS NIKKI
TURNER AND I'M CALLING FROM SO
CATHOLIC SCHOOL I ECHO THE
SENTIMENT ALREADY EXPRESSED AN
ACT THAT YOU WOULD NAY AND
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN AND REMOVED
THE EIGHTY A CAP ON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS NEXT WITH A
NUMBER OF THREE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS BONNIE AND I'M WITH FORTUNE
COOL AND EDUCATION AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I ALSO
OPPOSE A CAP ON GOING PUBLIC
SCHOOL OF AN AB SEVENTY BACK
AND- THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO A NUMBER OF ONE
THOUSAND NINE TEN OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DIRECTORS TO FIND THE BONES SO
I'M CALLING FROM FOURTEEN
SCHOOL IN PACOIMA COUNTY. AND
AYE OPPOSED THE EIGHTY EIGHT
CAP ON GOING PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. OUR NEXT TO A NUMBER
TEN SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEY THIS IS ERIN RAIN
BURKE I'M A CHARTER SCHOOL
EDUCATOR FROM NUMBER COUNTY AND
I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN SEVEN AND A HALF ON
EIGHTY EIGHT WILL GROWTH
FUNDING FOR ALL POLL. THIS IS A
DISSERVICE AREN'T DIDN'T
FAMILIES AN EDUCATOR THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE CANNOT PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE QUALITY AND
SUSTAINABLE EDUCATION FOR
INCOMING STUDENTS ABOUT THEIR
FUNDING TO DO SO. FUNDING TO
FOLLOW THAT IT MADE A POLICY
THAT SUPPORT ALL CALLS AND GIVE
THEM WHAT THEY NEED DURING THE
CHALLENGING TIME WITHOUT
SHORTCHANGING ONE TOOL FOR
ANOTHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO NUMBER
TWO TWO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY TOOK AND I
AND EIGHT CHARTER SCHOOL MOM OF
A NON QUESTION BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND- I ASK AS
MANY BEFORE ME THAT. AB SEVENTY
SEVEN BE AMENDED TO ALLOW HER
GROW AND CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
PUBLIC SCHOOL ALL OF THEM WERE
ALL THE SCHOOL DOWN ON THE
TABLE THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING A
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND IT CRIMINALS
FOR THE FUNDS NOT TO FOLLOW THE
CHILDREN YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
MITIGATING LEARNING MARKS. AND
THE CO THAT NINETEEN HAS
CREATED SO MUCH LEARNING LOCKED
ESPECIALLY WITH THE BRICK AND
MORTARS THAT HAVE TRIED TO DO A
MODIFIED DISTANCE LEARNING THAT
HAS GREATLY COMPROMISED THE
FUTURE. OF OUR STUDENTS THAT WE
ARE PUTTING MORE EMPHASIS ON
LAOS PROTECTION AND WE ARE IN
THE EDUCATION OF OUR STUDENTS
AND WE ARE SERVING THE UNION
RATHER THAN THE CHILDREN. YOU
SHOULD FOLLOW THE CHILDREN.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
MINUTE PLEASE NECK RELY NINE
NINE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS THOUSAND JAMES I'M
AN EDUCATOR AND KAREN HAD A
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I ALSO A
CLOSE AT SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
RECONSIDER WHAT THE FED SO MANY
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEGAN AT THE END AND
ROLLING STUDENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO
A NUMBER SEVEN ONE THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI TERRY BRENNAN WITH
CAL- S. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA.
YOU'RE CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE HOW BY I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT- IT DOESN'T CREATE A SOLAR
TAX CREDIT. LIKE OLD TAX CREDIT.
THANK YOU PUBLIC TAX CREDIT.
NEARLY ALL THE EVERY HARMLESS
SURE SCHOOL THE COMMITTEE AT-
OUR SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES FOR
AFRICA BURKE. REMEMBER THIS
PLACE ON THE BALLOT BY DID LEAD.
I CALIFORNIA ACT. WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS CREDIT
STAYS INTACT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK. NEXT WHAT NYNEX
ORDER NUMBER NUMBER EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANYTHING AND I'M CALLING FROM
CAPE SO HELPFUL BUT BOTH THE
NIGHT BECAUSE THE AB A CAP ON
GROWING PUBLIC SCHOOL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THE
NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER FOUR FOUR
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TOUGH
FOR THREE LINE IS OPEN. THE
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. OTHER WILL
GO TO NUMBER FOUR ONE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR ONE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. I WILL GO TO TEN
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE AND I
AM A SCHOOL COUNSELOR AT A NON
THANK FACE CHARTER SCHOOL I
OPPOSE THE ADA CAP CHARTER
SCHOOL GROUP AB SEVENTY SEVEN I
FEEL LIKE IT HURT ALL STUDENTS
AND- OUR SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE
EQUITABLE EDUCATION BUT ALSO
CAMPAñA. SERVICES TO ALL
STUDENTS. AVIATION FOLLOW EACH.
PLEASE A MAN AB SEVEN TO REMOVE
EIGHTY EIGHT CHARTERS GROW AND
ALLOW EIGHTY EIGHT TO FOLLOW.
THANK YOU. THE QUICKNESS. OUR
NEXT 310-007-1007 PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
FRANK TOWN AND I MET WITH A
THING HIGH TECH COMMON TRAIT
CURRENT BAN DIEGO I'M ALSO
CALLING TO A- EM AND EIGHTY
SEVEN TO THE LATE THE EIGHTY A
CAP ON GRANT PARTICLES. ONE OF
OUR CHILDREN TO THAT AN
EDUCATION TO BE FUNDED. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO A NUMBER NINE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS JAMIE HE
COULD SEE I'M CALLING FROM OUR-
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL AND
LOCAL DISTRICT FIVE OF LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY A CAP ON GROWING
PUBLIC SCHOOL ECHOING THE
REASONS THAT PASSED WITNESSES
HAVE ARE DEFEATED. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. OUR NEXT TO A
NUMBER SIX HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A
CHARACTER FROM KERN COUNTY AND
I'M WITH PARENTS FOR PARENTS
CHOI I'M A NON CLASS YOU'RE
BATES CHARTER SCHOOL MOM AT
THREE OF ALMOST NINE YEARS
PLEASE AMEND AB SEVEN SEVEN
DURING THE OF THE CAP OF
CHARTER SCHOOL GROWTH. ARTICLE
GROWTH FUNDING THE MONEY SHOULD
FOLLOW THE STUDENT AND MANY
HAVE CHOSEN THE SAME PATH. THE
REASON IS DUE TO CO THAT NOW
MORE THAN EVER IT IS NOT THE
TIME TO CYCLE CHARTER SCHOOL
GROW THANK YOU FOR YOUR- NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A NUMBER NINE
NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING EVERYONE BRED
PETERSON CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL I URGE YOU TO AMEND
AB SEVENTY SEVEN AND REMOVED
THE CAP. OUR SYSTEM OPENED-
THREE SCHOOL THE LAST TWO YEARS
IN THE COMPACT THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FAMILY IN AN EQUAL
PARTS IMMORAL AND ILLEGAL AND
ALSO- OF WHATEVER THE RIGHT
WING GUN PEOPLE ONE. THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA GO AGAIN SUGGEST TO
THE PUBLIC ON INTO THE MEMBERS
HERE WE HAVE OVER TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE ON THE PHONE. AND IT'S
MY GOAL TO WITHIN THE TIME THAT
WE'RE ALLOWED TO CONTINUE BEING
THE BUILDING TO HEAR FROM AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE SO I'M
GOING TO ASK THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. TO RESPECT THE PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN WAITING ON THE
PHONE LIKE YOU HAVE FOR SIX
HOURS BY SIMPLY STATING YOUR
NAME THE BILL AND YOUR
POSITION. IF WE DO THAT YOU CAN
GET IT DONE WITHIN TEN SECONDS.
BOB THERE'S ANY QUESTION I'M
SITTING HERE WITH MY PHONE TIME
AND EVERYONE SO I'VE LOOKED AT
THE AVERAGE TESTIMONY. AND SO
IN HONOR OF THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO ALSO ARE
WAITING ON THE PHONE AND ASK
THAT YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME. IF
IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD IF IT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE
IT THEN FEEL FREE TO USE UP TO
YOUR MINUTE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THE NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER NINE FIVE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND GOOD
EVENING THIS EXAMPLE HOW THE
HELL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE SOME VERY SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT AB SEVENTY
SEVEN. THIS WOULD- PUT HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE SERVICES
AT RISK BY CREATING A NEW
ACCESS HE WRAPPED. CALCULATION
IN THE WOULD BE DONE BRATCHER-
ACTIVELY AND OUTSIDE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
WE TAKE SERVICE ON BRIDGE WITH
THAT LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE DIALOGUE. NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO VOTE NUMBER TEN EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TEN
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS ALLEY AT THEIR
TOWN I AM AT A CHARTER SCHOOL
PARENT AND TEACHER AND I OPPOSE
AB SEVENTY SEVEN AS IT STANDS.
HI THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM OUR COTTON OF AN
EDUCATOR AND A PARENT SAN DIEGO
I ASK YOU PLEASE AMEND AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GROUNDS FUNDING. NEXT
WILL DO NUMBER NINE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS COLLEEN MERRITT.
MOTHER OF THREE WHO HAVE A
LEARNING DISABILITY I'M CALLING
REGARDING ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
SEVEN I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT
AMENDMENT BEING MADE- I'M
PLEASED THAT OUR CHILDREN FIRST
AND ENSURE THAT THE GOAL TO TEN
FIFTY EIGHTY EIGHT FUNDING TO
ENSURE EACH CAL NEEDS ARE MET.
I ALSO OPPOSED THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WELL I WHAT WOMAN AND
FAMILY- WE NEED TO FIND A
BETTER SOLUTION THAT DOES NOT
PUT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES IN
JEOPARDY THANKS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT LEVINE
NUMBER NINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING. YOUR
TESTIMONY PLEASE. WE CAN NOW BE.
GREAT I'M READING OF THE CALL
WHEN YOU I AM FROM THE GOOD
SIDE CARRY AND I'M IN
OPPOSITION EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT-
I SUPPORT GUN AND I DO NOT
SUPPORT ANY INFRINGEMENT UPON
MY CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO. AB SEVENTY
SEVEN. I'M GONNA GET A
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST- CHILDREN
GO CHARTER SCHOOL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PUBLICLY THEY GONNA
NEXT WITNESS. HELLO CAROLINE
THREE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS NANCY MARTINEZ I'M CALLING
FROM FAMILY DINO COUNTY AND I
WAS ALSO CALLING TO STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB SEVENTY SEVEN- I
ALSO OPPOSE AB EIGHTY EIGHT AB
ONE ZERO FIVE IN AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU FOR
TAKING Y CALL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. AXOLOTL LINE EIGHT
NINETY FOUR LINE EIGHT NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS JACQUELINE BLOCKER FROM
CLOVIS FRESNO COUNTY I CALL IN
OPPOSITION- THAT THE CAP ON
HOLD PENDING. AB. SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. MAX SILICON LINE TEN
TWENTY ONE. AGAIN TEN TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS VANESSA MARIA AND I'M
REPRESENTING HI FRANK
ELEMENTARY CHLORINE SAN DIEGO
AND I AM AND I OPPOSE ADA
KAPLAN GOING PUBLIC SCHOOL- AND
I WOULD ALSO ASK THAT THE AND
THEN AB SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE
THE CAP ON GROWING. ON GROWING
I'M SO SORRY ON. THE CAP ON
PULLED THE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO
A LINE TEN SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
AND FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I'M
CALLING TO ECHO THE CONCERNS
WITH AB SEVENTY SEVEN AND THE
GROWTH DIFFICULT BROKE FUNDING.
THANK THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THE NEXT TO A NUMBER NINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS PAUL KIEFFER I
WITH THE CIVIC CENTER INSTITUTE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I OPPOSE THE
ADA CAP AND ON GROWING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO A NUMBER
TEN THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME'S- HE'LL
TAMPA CONFERENCE RAN AND
MOUNTAIN CHARTER IN SUMMER YOU
KNOW COUNTY. AND I OPPOSE AB
SEVENTY SEVEN AND I ALSO OPPOSE
SB EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO THE
NUMBER NINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME IS KELLY
ARNOLD AND THE TEACHER AT A NON
CLASSROOM BASS CHARTER SCHOOL.
I WOULD LIKE. I DON'T OPPOSE I
UNDERSTAND THE EIGHTY A
HARMLESS BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
GET THE LANGUAGE AND THE CAP-
OFF OF THE LANGUAGE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE. NEXT TO A
NUMBER THREE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M A NON CLASSROOM
BASED EDUCATOR AND RATHER FOR
IN YUBA COUNTY AND I JUST WANT
TO ADD MY VOICE TO THOSE WHO
HAVE ASKED FOR AMENDMENT TO AB
SEVENTY SEVEN SPECIFICALLY THAT
THE EIGHTY A CAP ON BILL GROSS.
BE AMENDED AND REMOVED THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WITH A
LINE TEN EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GREG A GRANDPARENT
EDUCATOR CARLSBAD ECHOING
LITERALLY EVERYBODY ELSE WHEN I
SAY OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN
COMPLETE CHANGE LANGUAGE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT YEAR THE
NUMBER NINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME IS JASON
POMPON CALLED GAVE THE
COMMUNITY CHARTER. ONLY A LIFE
COACH THE EIGHTY EIGHT CAP.
EIGHTY MORE GROWING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT- NUMBER TEN TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MEMBERS I'M CALLING FROM SUMMER
NINETY NO COUNTY AYE OPPOSED AB
SEVENTY SEVEN EIGHTY A CAP. BUT
YOUR PLAN UP TO SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN AND I WILL NOT STAND
FOR LEGISLATORS ALLOWING UNITS
AND DISTRICT SCHOOL CURRICULA
MONEY. FROM CALIFORNIA SHOULD
SCHOOL CHILDREN. STATE
LEGISLATORS TO REVISE THE
BUDGET TO REFLECT THE VALUE.
EDDIE WE MUST PLACE AND EDUCATE
CALL CONNECTED. HARDER SCHOOLS
INCLUDING NON CLASSROOM BATES
WHO RECEIVED A CREDIBLE FUNDING
CONSERVATIVE STUDENTS IN THEIR
SCHOOL THANK YOU MMHM NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A NUMBER TEN
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
A LOT OF HEAT IN ANOTHER THREE
IN A FINE I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
ORDER HEARING A LOT OF
OPPOSITION AB SEVENTY SEVEN BUT
I SINCERELY HOPE THAT THAT
MEANS THAT THE CAP ON COOL
GROWTH FUNDING WILL BE REMOVED.
DURING THIS DIFFICULT TIME CODE
NINETY MY FAMILY THE ALREADY
SUFFERING WE SHOULD BE
SUPPORTING PARENTS AND THEIR
CHILDREN IN ANY WAY THAT WE
POSSIBLY CAN FAMILIES A
FAITHFUL ATTENDING THE CHILDREN
BACK TO BEGIN WITH THE SCHOOLS.
YOU TO VERY THREE THERE'S SUCH
A SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITION THE
FAMILY FEEL SUPPORTED THAT
THEIR CHILDREN WILL WILL
RECEIVE AN EXAM THREE EDUCATION
THREE THAT CHARTER SCHOOL
PLEASE I URGE YOU TO LISTEN TO
THE VOICES THAT EVERY SINGLE
PERSON ON THE COLD. FRONT
ALTHOUGH YOU TO PLEASE REMOVE.
THE CAP ON SCHOOL GROUNDS THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING. NEXT TO IT.
NEXT TO A NUMBER THREE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
EVENING- MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVE
BUTLER AND I'M- REPRESENTING
THE UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY
NETWORK A COALITION OF. LOCAL
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE IN THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA
INCLUDING THE CROAK CHAMBER.
AND WE'RE CLOSING- SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. DURING THIS.
EDIBLE TIME OF ECONOMIC
CONTRACTION IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO ENCOURAGE
EMPLOYERS PARTICULARLY SMALL
BUSINESS. OWNERS AND OPERATORS
TO ADD TO THEIR WORK FORCE NOT
CREATE MORE BARRIERS IN FRONT
OF THEM SO WE URGE YOUR-
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE AND- APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF SENATOR ROBB THANK
YOU VERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THE NEXT
THEIR NUMBER TEN SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS OMAR NYC BRIGHT I'M A
HOMESCHOOL MOM OF BY. AN APTLY
THAT MEN EIGHT I'M CALLING TO
AMEND AB SEVENTY SEVEN TO
REMOVE THE CAP CALLED ROPE
BINDING. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT SO THE NUMBER SEVEN THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
THE ANDREA REAGAN I'M CALLING
THE QUEUE OPPOSED AB SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT AND
F. B. ONE THREE EIGHT THREE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO IT A NUMBER TEN NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATIE
HARD AMOUNT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
ON A DATE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND PRIORITIZE
EDUCATION IN THE BUDGET. BPA
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT HOWEVER WE ARE
SEEKING SOME CLARIFICATION
RELATED TO DISTANCE LEARNING IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE BECAUSE OF THE
FLEXIBILITY TO OFFER DISTANCE
LEARNING OR A HYBRID MODEL WHEN
RE OPENING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. LECTURE NUMBER
TEN NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BERNIE THE MARKING AND
REPRESENTING SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY WHICH WORK DIRECTLY
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES THERE ARE
EDUCATION ADVOCACY AND RESEARCH
WORK I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT AT
THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WE
WERE ONE AT THAT THREE THAT THE
SERVING ORGANIZATIONS WHO WERE
PART OF THE PAISLEY TASK FORCE
AND SINCE THE RELEASE OF THE
FELT. REAL CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED ABOUT EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM THAT WILL PLACE
ADDITIONAL BURDENS ON
BUSINESSES BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE CONCERNS WHILE JENNY WHEN
HAPPENED SOMEWHAT OVERSTATED
AND THE RESEARCH AND THE DATA
IS CONCLUSIVE THAT THE OVERALL
BENEFITS FAR OUTWEIGH ANY
POTENTIAL CAUGHT. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF SMALL BUSINESSES DO
SUPPORT PUBLICLY ADMINISTERED
PAID LEAVE PROGRAMS I WANT TO
REFERENCE THE ECONOMIC STUDY
STUDY THAT WE CO COMMISSION
WITH OTHER ORGANIZATIONS WHICH
CHAU PETER BACK OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS PAID FAMILY LEAVE
RESULT IN A REDUCTION IN LABOR
COSTS FOR SMALL FIRMS. AND DOES
NOT APPEAR TO HAVE ANY INCREASE
IN. FARM EXIT RATE. THE BEAT
RECOMMENDED WERE A HUNDRED PER
TRIP BIKING. THE FAMILY BE IS
GOOD FOR IN. AND A GOOD SMALL
BUSINESSES WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. MAKE SURE THE
NUMBER TEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
PERSECUTE US ON BEHALF OF THE
ATTACK ACCESS INSURANCE OF
THIRTY RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB
THIRTY EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO
A NUMBER NINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS MARK BIGGER HIçN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CITIZENS
OF THE WORLD BUT D'ANGELO AT
THE NETWORK OF CHARTER SCHOOL
LOCATED SENATE THE SENATE
DISTRICT. THIRTY TWENTY SEVEN
TO TWENTY FOUR. BEGIN AT THAT
AB SEVENTY SEVEN BE AMENDED TO
REMOVE. FROM GRANGE PUBLIC ALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A NUMBER TEN
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER TEN SIX ONE LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THERE TO NUMBER TWO SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO SIX
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. HELP. THE
NEXT WITNESS. HELLO YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. YES WE CAN. OKAY YOU
JUST HAVE TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
I'M TALKING SO I WOULD I DON'T
WANNA LOSE MY MINUTE. I AGAIN
MY NAME IS AMY ELDER COMMITTEE
CALIFORNIA I THINK ON BEHALF OF
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SEVENTY
SEVEN I'M FROM THE CAMERA THAT
CAN YOU FOUNDATION. CARE AND
APPEARANCE NEGATIVELY IMPACT
THE TYPICALLY CHARTER SCHOOLS
AS WE RECEIVED LESS FUNDING
THAN REGULAR PUBLIC SCHOOLS FOR
EDUCATION IF THE BLATANT THEFT
OF OUR TAXPAYER MONEY. WE WERE
SET UP PRIOR COULD HOLD IT
SHOULD PROVIDE FULL TIME HOME
PART TIME. AND FULL TIME PLAY
THEY'VE LEARNING WHEN COVER
CLOSURES OCCURRED HE DID NOT
GET A BEAT HE KEPT ON GOING
PROVIDING THE SAME RIGOR AND
EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS. EVEN IN
THE TIME A CODED IN THIS NEW
WORLD THE TYPICALLY WILL NEED A
PROFESSIONAL. FOR QUITE THE
COURT RESOURCES SERVICES STAFF
TO OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. I AM FOR YOU TO STOP
THE HARMFUL LANGUAGE IN AB
SEVENTY SEVEN LOOK ALLOW THE
FUNDING BECAUSE IT IS A
TRAVESTY AND WILL BE DEDICATING
ALL COOL BUT- AGAIN TO TRY. YOU
ARE A NATIONALLY IN A GROWTH
PATTERN OUR COMMUNITY THIS IS
CONTRARY ONLY BECAUSE JUSTICE.
FREE AND APPROPRIATE EDUCATION
ALL STUDENTS AND WHILE YOU'RE
PUNISH FISCAL AND THEIR
FAMILIES FOR SEEKING A SAFER
AND BETTER. FOR THEIR CHILDREN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
EFFORT INTO WRITING MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING FOR CRITICAL. LIKE OURS
HAVE A GOOD EVENING. NEXT WHAT.
NEXT FOR THE NUMBER THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO TEN
THIRTY EIGHT TEN THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS FLORA DONNER AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF SANTA BARBARA
CHARTER SCHOOL WE ARE ASKING
YOU TO AMEND AB SEVENTY SEVEN
TO REMOVE THE EIGHTY A CAP. ON
SCHOOL GROWTH FUNDING THANK YOU.
I'M FINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT TO A
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AMAAN
BROTHER CREAMY I'M CALLING FROM
BRIGHT FOR SCHOOLS WE HAVE NINE
SCHOOL STREET LOS ANGELES I
SUPPORT A HOLD HARMLESS POLICY
BUT AYE OPPOSED TO EIGHTY A CAP
ON GROWING PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
TEN EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE THAT THE DâN
MECHANISMS OF CALIFORNIA I URGE
A NO OR AND WE ARE BOTH ON
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT. OR AT THE
END AT THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. I WITHIN THE MOVIE IN
LITTLE BE THE **** WITH PROP
THIRTY THREE. IT HAD TO BE
HEAVILY MODIFIED BY THE SENATE.
WE NEED THAT SENATE AND
pASSEMBLY WRITING A LOT OF INPUT
FROM THE GOVERNOR AND NOT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND. PLEASE DON'T
ABDICATE RESPONSIBILITY I AGAIN
URGE THE NO WAR AND BEYOND
VOTE. ON EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT
AND AT THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU NEXT TO A
NUMBER EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS RICHARD DR RICHARD SAVAGE
AND I'M CALLING FROM CALIFORNIA
CONNECTIONS ACADEMY AYE OPPOSED
AB SEVENTY SEVEN AND THE EIGHTY
A CAP ON GROWING PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
APPRECIATE YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THE NEXT NUMBER WILL GO TO
ELEVEN TWELVE ELEVEN TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS AMERICAN DOLLARS
REPRESENTING HIGH TECH
ELEMENTARY LEARN CAN DIEGO I DO
ASK THAT YOU AMEND AB SEVENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. A NEXT TO A NEW ELEVEN
THIRTEEN ELEVEN THIRTEEN YOUR
LINES OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JOY
BALL AND I AM A NON CLASSROOM
BASED. A CHARTER SCHOOL TEACHER
AND MOTHER JONES AFTER COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SEVENTY
SEVEN AS IT IS WRITTEN BY THE
MANY REASONS ALREADY MENTIONED
THERE FOR ME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT TO A NUMBER TEN
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE YOU HAD.
YEAH TEN SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVED TO NUMBER
TEN THIRTY TEN THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS LAUREL WARD I'M THE MOTHER
OF THREE I LIVE IN SILVERADO IN
CALIFORNIA PLEASE AMEND AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GROWTH FUNDING WE
NEED OPTIONS WE NEED
EDUCATIONAL ALTERNATIVES THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT THE NUMBER NINE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THAT ISN'T TO SAY FROM A
PRIVATE CITIZEN CONSENT. JUST A
COUPLE OF MONTHS LUCIEN TO A.
B. C. SEVEN FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY OUTLINED I ALSO POSE
A BE A EIGHT. I'M VERY CLOSE
ROOM WE DEFINE THE LANGUAGE
BUDGET BILL DIGIT A COMPLY WITH
THE USE MORE ALLOWING ACTUALLY
ON THE SPOT. AND NOTHING THAT
SO THAT NEEDS TO BE DISCUSSED
AND DEBATED THROUGH BUDGET BILL
AND I TO SECTIONS MAY BE A ABA
TELLING YOU PICKED A TOPICS AND
KNOWS HAVE BEEN DONE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT
TO NUMBER OF OO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M CHRIS TO READ AS
SLANG CUT FOR FOUND THEIR AND
TECH EL A- I HAVE THAT YOU AND
THEN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN CURING
THE EIGHTY TAP ON WILL GROWTH.
THANKS FOR YOUR WORK THANK YOU
IN A WITNESS. NEXT TO A NUMBER
TWO SIR ONE PLEASE GO. HI MY
NAME IS AMONG AND I'M A LITTLE
COOL PRINCIPAL IN. CAL I I'LL
URGE YOU TO A SEVEN SEVEN AND
WHEN THEY EIGHTY CAP WE ARE
GROWING THAT IS OUR BIT THE
NEXT YEAR THE WAY EIGHT BE AT
LEAST A THAT CURRENTLY READ ANY
WE WOULD HALF A BUT THEY TWENTY
ONE BIRTHDAY WHICH REALLY AT
THE TOP. ALL RIGHT JUST TO IT
IN THAT ALL FUNDING STRUCTURE I
ALSO WANT TO OUT THE TIME OF
THE WE HAVE BEEN COMMITTED TO
FAMILY MARCH AND HOW OF THE
THOUGH IS THAT APPROPRIATE. A
LONG TERM PANNING THANKS VERY
NO WITNESS. NEXT TO AN A
NINETY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING AND MARK WIDE FROM CAN
AND MEN MEANT BABY SEVEN A LOT
OF THE POLICY I WOULD ALSO THAT
USE THAT YEARS IT REALLY ON
WALL. AND BAM WE HAVE TO LEAVE
THE STATE AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS I
DON'T HOME SCHOOL. AND COURAGE
REVISIONS ACT EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY TWENTY. YEAR. TIME NEXT
WOULDN'T PLEASE. NO TO IT AND
LET THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FIRST THING
LATE MINING HEART. CALLING
EIGHTY. SEVEN SEVEN I FEEL LIKE
THIS REPORT LIMIT THAT YOU
FREEDOM FOR LOW INCOME. BY
URGING TO AN IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT A NUMBER
FOR TWO PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO
NAME IS JEFF ROGERS. A SUPER
FOR AND SCHOOLS SERVE SEVERAL
TROUBLE WALKING INTO COME ON
SCHOOL THIS. AND I TO OPPOSE A
CAP GOING. SCHOOLS PROPOSED TO
MAYBE START SEVEN PASSAGE OF
THE WOULD BE. TO OUR FAMILY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A NAY THREE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS KELLY THAT HE
READ OUT REPRESENTING HIGH TECH
HIGH NORTH COUNTY WITH SPC HIGH
TECH HIGH STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY A CAP ON GROWING PUBLIC
SCHOOL POINT EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO COULD ADVANCE. TO
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. A NATIONAL NUMBER
EIGHT FIFTY THREE BECAUSE YOU
HAD. HI MY NAME IS I THINK THE
NUMBER BEGINNING HIGH TECH
ELEMENTARY INTO THE- ACT. AB
ONE. AT ONLY GOOD FOR. YOU
THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS. THE
NEXT TO A NUMBER ELEVEN TWENTY
NINE PLEASE NOTE THAT. HI MY
NAME IS CAPITA HOMES AND THE
TEACHER AT A NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER AS WELL THE HOME
SCHOOL PARENTS AND I AM AN
AUTHOR IN OPPOSITION AB SEVENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT SALUTE TEN SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GIVE THAT. MY NAME IS
CLAIRE DEACON AND THE FIRST
THREE TEACHER AT A CHARTER
SCHOOL IN SAN DIEGO I HAVE HAD
TO LEAD ACTIVE SHOOTER GRILL
WITH SIX AND SEVEN YEAR OLD AND
I MEAN TRONG FAVOR AT
CALIFORNIA'S BAN ON ASSAULT
WEAPONS. EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO AMEND
AB SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE
EIGHTY A CAP FOR SCHOOLS THAT
ARE OPENING ADDITIONAL GRADE
LEVEL THANK YOU. FOR SURE THAT
NEXT WITNESS. OUR NEXT TO A NEW
ELEVEN FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS JESSICA MULLIN ADAM I AM A
PROUD MEMBER OF THE KIT SO CAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ADVOCATE- I'M
CALLING TO OPPOSE THE EIGHTY
EIGHT CAT IN AB SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THE NEXT
THIRTY NINE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING YEAH
GAME I AM AN EDUCATOR AND A
PARENT AND I'M OPPOSED TO AB
SEVENTY SEVEN SECTION SIXTEEN
EIGHT. EIGHT AND LIKE HALF THE
PLACES ON THE GROWTH OF GOLD
THANK YOU MADAM THANK YOU
THURMOND AND THE COMMITTEE I
APPRECIATE THAT NEXT WITNESS
NEXT TO A TO NUMBER ELEVEN
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MELISSA FRIEND TEN I'M
A PUBLIC EDUCATOR AND MOTHER OF
THREE IN SAN DIEGO I WOULD LIKE
TO STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
PROVISION IN EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
THAT LIMIT FUNDING GROWING
SCHOOLS IN ORDER TO TRULY A
HOLD HARMLESS ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS INCLUDING GROWING
SCHOOL. PLEASE CONSIDER
ALLOWING A LEAD THE CHOICE TO
USE EITHER TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY OR 202-020-2180
EIGHT FOR FUNDING CALCULATIONS
AND AMEND AB SEVENTY SEVEN
ACCORDINGLY THANK YOU. HI NEXT
TO A NUMBER EIGHT TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS CHRISTY
BOMBER I AM A MOTHER- THAT HOME
SCHOOL FOR FOURTEEN YEARS AND
I'M ALSO A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION- AB
SEVENTY SEVEN. EIGHTY EIGHTY
EIGHT AND AT THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT TO A TO ELEVEN THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS DAVID JONES AND AS A
MILITARY FAMILY WE RELY ON THE
FUNDING PROVIDED CHARTER
SCHOOLS FOR A THREE SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN IN ORDER PROVIDED
EDUCATION WE THE PARENTS ARE
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE FOR. A
TAXPAYERS ARE TAX YOU SHOULD
FOLLOW THE STUDENT AND WE WOULD
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE PROVIDE AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GROWTH FUNDING TO
ENSURE THE FREEDOM OF EDUCATION
IS APPLICABLE TO ALL AND THE
FUNDING DOES NOT GO TO TEACHERS
IN THEIR UNION OF WHICH
POLITICIANS THE THING TO PAY
FOR. WE ARE ALSO STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTY EIGHT AT THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IS THE GROSS OVER
REACH AND CREATING ALL GUN
POLICIES OR THEIR RIGHT AND
IT'S AN EXCUSE TO PUNISH
TAXPAYING CITIZEN BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE ONLY ONES THAT FALL
LAWS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE IT ON
THE RECORD THAT THE MADAM CHAIR
ONLY REMIND TWO BOYS THEY CALL
IT DID- AFTER AB SEVENTY SEVEN
OPPOSITION IS MENTIONED AS THAT
IS BEING- AS IT IS CAN BE
PERCEIVED AT THE TYPICALLY
TARGETING OR DEGRADING CHARTER
SCHOOL FAMILIES ARE THOSE IN
OPPOSITION THIS IS. FOR TIMES
AN APPROXIMATE HOUR AND A HALF
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ON THIS WAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
RESTING YOU'RE. CONSTANTLY
YOU'LL MAKE THE RIGHT CHOICES.
NEXT TO IT NINE NEXT. NEXT WE
GO TO TEN EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
THE REST HUMMER AND I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BUT MOM
NONPROFIT PRESS IT AWAY- CURE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR AT THE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WE HAVE A
STAFF OF FIVE AND ONE STAFFERS
RECENTLY SECOND NEEDED TIME.
OFF TO CARE FOR HERSELF I WAS
PROUD THAT WE WERE ABLE TO GIVE
HER THE TIME SHE NEEDED. IF WE
CAN DO IT AT THE MALL NONPROFIT
AND SURVIVE JUST FINE SO CAN
OTHER SMALL BUSINESSES ALL
WORKERS DID THEIR JOB PROTECTED
PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BEFORE GO ON TO THE NEXT
WITNESS I WANT TO RESPOND TO
THE PAST WITNESS- PERHAPS
YOU'VE NEVER BEEN IN PERSON TO
A BUDGET HEARING AND SEEING THE
OPERATE IF WE WERE HERE IN
PERSON. I'D BE ABLE TO ASK THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
WHO WERE. A POLLS ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT TO REALLY TRY TO
MANAGE THE TIME- I MADE THE
COMMENT SPECIFICALLY TO THOSE
WERE CALLING IN TO AB SEVENTY
SEVEN BECAUSE THAT'S THE LINE
SURE THE PEOPLE. AND WE'RE
HEARING REPETITIVE TESTIMONY.
AGAIN WE'VE GOT ABOUT. A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY PEOPLE TO
GO. AND MY GOAL IS TO ALLOW AS
MANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE THEIR PERSPECTIVE. AND
WE HAVE TO SHUT DOWN IN THIS
BUILDING BY MIDNIGHT. AND SO
THE LONGER YOU TALKING REPEAT
WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID. THE
FEWER PEOPLE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WILL BE ABLE TO HEAR
FROM. THAT'S WHY I DID IT THAT
WAY SO AGAIN. IF YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON SOMETHING THAT
SOMEONE HAS ALREADY TESTIFIED
ABOUT BEING AB SEVENTY SEVEN OR
ANYTHING ELSE. PLEASE KEEP IT
BRIEF TO ALLOW OTHER MEMBERS TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO SHARE
THEIR PERSPECTIVE. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE GOING TO
ELEVEN SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE JONES MATTER FOR
FROM GRANDPARENTS PLEASE A MAN
AB SEVENTY SEVEN I URGE THE
GOVERNOR AND STATE LEGISLATURE
REVISE THE BUDGET TO REMOVE THE
CAP ON SCHOOL GROUNDS FINDING
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WILL GO TO
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANDREA
DAVIS I'M A MOTHER OF THREE IN
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY I'M
ASKING TO PLEASE AMEND AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GROWTH FUNDING AND
THEN I AM ALSO. IN OPPOSITION.
TO EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO ELEVEN NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I AM
CALLING ABOUT A RECENTLY. THE
COLOR OF THE NINE NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS EUGENE OCCURRED AND THE
NINTH GRADE TEACHER SERVING
SOME OF THE MOST HARD HIT
FAMILIES OF HOLDEN AND ALSO TO
PROVIDE YOU. AND ASKING YOU
AMEND EIGHTY SEVENTY SEVEN TO
REMOVE THE CAP ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS. I CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
OAKLAND AND HAS NOT ONLY
MANAGED TO CREATE. INNOVATIVE
DISTANCE LEARNING TEACHING. BUT
ALSO THEN ABLE TO CARE FOR KIDS
THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND
ANOTHER SCHOOL. NOT A HOLD
HARMLESS BILL FOR THOSE KIDS
THAT ARE NOT THINK THAT'S WILL
TRADITIONAL EDUCATION. YOU GOT
TO WORK AND TEACHERS LIKE ME ON
THE FRONT LINES SERVING OUR
KIDS DAY AFTER DAY. BY THE
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO EDUCATE OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO NINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. POPCORN BUT THEN
THEY'LL I'M AN EDUCATOR
ACTUALLY NEED TO CORRECT THE
LANGUAGE IN AB SEVENTY SEVEN
TERM IN THE CAP ON WILL GROW BY
NOON THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WILL GO TO EIGHT
OH SIX PLEASE AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS KIMBERLY CHAPTER CITY OF
SANDY AND THE TAX PAYER AND
CANDLES EACH CHILD I WOULD LIKE
TO THE COLLISION. SEVENTY SEVEN
WHICH IS A BLATANT. AGAINST HER
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND AGAINST THE
EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS NEXT
TO A TWO EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE THOUSAND PRESTER
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR PART
WITH CHARTER SCHOOLS NO MY
COUNTY I'M ALSO THE PARENTS OF
THREE CHILDREN WE ARE GROWING
SCHOOL ENTRY SECOND YEAR OF
OPERATION. WE'VE ALREADY
CRINKLE UP WITH ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS DUE TO
THE EARLY RECORDING OF P. TWO.
AND WE REALLY WE REALLY OUT
THANK YOU A MAN AB SEVENTY
SEVEN WE WOULD LOSE ROUGHLY 60%
OF OUR BUDGET FOR NEXT YEAR WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO RECEIVE FUNDS.
FOR INCREASED ENROLLMENT THERE
WAS NO INDICATION THIS COMPANY
THAN UNDER CONSIDERATION AND
WE'VE ALREADY ACCEPTED STUDENT.
TEACHER SUPPORT STUFF
CONTRACTORS FOR RENT AND MADE
OTHER COMMITMENTS FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR. I
NOTICED AB SEVENTY SEVEN MAKES
AN EXCEPTION FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS WE'RE WHO ARE IN THEIR
FIRST YEAR OF OPERATIONS FOR
THE HEALTHY SCHOOL WILL.
CONTINUE TO GROW FOR MANY YEARS.
NOT JUST DURING THE FIRST.
STILL PUT AN ALMOST
INSURMOUNTABLE OFF THE PUTTING
GROWING CHAR SCHOOLS THE
NINETEEN THE RIGHT EQUITABLE
FOR THE PUBLIC PROGRAM THAT
BEST SUPPORTS HER EDUCATIONAL
GOALS PLEASE KEEP THE FUNDS
FOLLOWING STUDENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
NEXT WILL GO TO ELEVEN NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THERE A SALLY ON.
INCREASE THEM AND EIGHTY
SEVENTY SECOND TERM OF EIGHTY A
CAP ON MONDAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. A NECK TO A TO ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS SHERRY HERNANDEZ
EDUCATOR FROM YUBA CITY I ALSO
ECHO ALL OF THE VOICES THAT YOU
HEARD TONIGHT IN OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS FOR SHAPE THAT
NEXT WITNESS. MAX OVER TO
TWELVE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
EDDIE BARGAINS NINE THE
CONCERNED TO THE FUND FROM LA
COUNTY I AM ATTY MY BOYS TO
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTY EIGHT
STRONGLY YOUR SUPPORT AGAINST
BE EIGHTY EIGHT. AS IT IS. THIS
BILL THAT WEAPON IS ANOTHER
OPTION FOR HOME DEFENSE. I'M
NOT ALREADY DWINDLING SMALL
ROSTER OF AVAILABILITY FROM U.
K. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WILL BE GOING TO
NUMBER TWELVE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
EVERYONE BURKE ALL OF THE FACT
THAT. BUT YOU BOTH FOR YEAH I
WANT TO RECORD WHAT. IT RECALL
OF THE BIG DATA ARE I OFFER ONE
RIGHT. IF THANK YOU BUT IT US
BOAT ALL NOT COULD BE. I GOT.
ALL WE OKAY WELL WHAT THE
MARKET THAT BY THE WAY. BOB ALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR. NEXT
TO GO TO TWELVE TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SANDY
SHOULD BE AROUND FROM A MOTHER
BUT AGE CHILD IN THE SOME
VALLEY A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
AND A MEMBER OF A GROUP THAT
ENCOMPASSES MORE THAN A HUNDRED
FAMILIES. AND ONE NINE CALLING
AS AN INDIVIDUAL TODAY I KNOW
FOR A FACT THAT I AM ECHOING
THE SENTIMENT OF THE MAJORITY
OF THOSE FAMILIES WHEN I SAY
PLEASE AND THEN AB SEVENTY
SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP ON COOL
GIRL FUNDING. PLEASE ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO RECEIVE FUNDING FOR
EVERY SINGLE CHILD THEY AND
ROLL THANK YOU MA'AM THERE ARE
SO MANY REASONS I COULD SAY BUT
I WANT TO GIVE OTHERS A CHANCE.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CAMILLE BENNETT I
MEAN ALAMEDA COUNTY RESIDENT
FOR TWENTY EIGHT YEARS. AND
PARENT OF FIVE CHILDREN TOPPLED
AT BROKEN WATER PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS FOR THE
PAST FOURTEEN YEARS. I URGE YOU
TO CLEAN UP HOLD EQUAL
PROTECTION UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND STOP
INCRIMINATION AGAIN CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND STUDENT BAKER BY
INCLUDING AB SEVENTY SEVEN. I'M
ALSO A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND
IT'S OBVIOUS AFTER HEARING
QUESTIONING TONIGHT THAT THE
DUE DILIGENCE. ON THE AFFECTED
SMALL BUILD BUSINESSES HAS NOT
BEEN DONE CONCERNING SB THIRTY
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AND-
OPPOSE THAT AND EIGHTY EIGHTY
EIGHT AS WELL. THE NEXT WILL GO
TO TWELVE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT WHEN THIS GEM
SANDERS- TO THE STREET WITH A
GOOD EDUCATION IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AB SEVENTY SEVEN IN ITS
ATTEMPT BUT CAP ON SCHOOL
FUNDING IS YET ANOTHER EVER
TAMPER PARENTS FROM SEEKING THE
SCHOOL OPTIONS THE BEST SERVE
THEIR CHILDREN. IN THE SCHOOL
TO KEEP THE FUNDING PER STUDENT
THEY SHOULD GET BETTER EFFORTS
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS AND THE HIKERS WILL
NOT SEEK OTHER OPTIONS SUCH
INCREASING NUMBERS EVERY YEAR.
THANK THE REGARDLESS OF THE
SERVICE. OPERATED SENDS THE
MESSAGE THEY ARE NOT
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE STUDENT
EXPERIENCE AT THEIR SCHOOLS
THAT'S HARDLY IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILDREN. KEEP
THE FUNDS FROM THE SCHOOL WHICH
THE TRAVEL THE WORLD
DISCRIMINATORY IMMORAL. AND
HAPPY. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WILL GO TO ELEVEN
OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELEVEN
OH NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
WILL GO TO TWELVE FIFTY THREE
TWELVE FIFTY THREE GO HEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MARLENE CHANDLER-
FROM NEWPORT BEACH CALIFORNIA
AND THE MOTHER OF THREE AND AYE
OPPOSED ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
SEVEN- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE
GO TO EIGHT OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
KERRY HELLO THE ACT I AM A
PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATOR IN OUR
GREAT STATE AND BECAUSE OF THIS
AND DEDICATING MY CAREER TO.
EDUCATING STUDENTS I ECHO
EVERYONE ELSE IN OPPOSING AB
SEVENTY SEVEN. IN ORDER FOR
STUDENTS TO BE FAIRLY AND
PROPERLY EDUCATED THEIR PUBLIC
SCHOOL FIND NEED TO FOLLOW THEM
TO THEIR PUBLIC SCHOOL OF
CHOICE GREAT THANK YOU AND
GOODNIGHT MMHM NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO GO TO TWELVE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DECISION ON
HOW WE HEALTHCARE CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS THE WORKING COMMITTEE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S FOR
MANY OF THE TARGETED SOLUTIONS
AND EIGHTY EIGHTY WE ARE
OPPOSED TO MEASURES THAT GO
WELL BEYOND ADDRESSING THE
DISRUPTIONS CAUSED BY KOBE. OF
PARTICULAR CONCERN TO RESTORE
ORDER PROPOSAL IN THE EIGHTY
EIGHTY WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE RATE ACTIONS THE
REPLY RETROACTIVELY TO JULY
TWENTY NINETEEN SOME SEVEN
MONTHS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC OUR
RECORD OR SOME PARTICULAR
INEFFICIENT POORLY TARGETED
MECHANISMS FOR GENERATING
SAVINGS TO AWARD LOW PERFORMING
NCOS THE EXPENSE OF HIGH
PERFORMING AND SHE HAS
DEMONSTRATED THE ABILITY TO
CONTAIN COSTS- NADER WHICH CORD
OR YOUR LONG TERM RATE CUT
WOULD RECOGNIZE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT UTILIZATION WILL
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
SECOND HALF OF TWENTY TWENTY.
LEADING THE MEDICAL PROGRAM
UNDER FUNDED TO ABSORB THE COST
FINALLY WILL MANY BUDGET CUTS
WILL BE AVOIDED IF FEDERAL
SYSTEMS MATERIALIZES THERE'S
SUCH TRIGGER EXISTS TO AVOID
RATE ACTIONS THREE THAT THE
STATE REVENUES CONTINUE TO
OUTPACE PROJECTIONS AND THEY
DID BY FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN MANY. THESE CUTS
WOULD REMAIN. AS THE SPECIFICS
YOU READ ACT YOU'RE ABOUT TO
THE STATE'S REVENUE PICTURE
BECOMES CLEARER. BUT ASKED
LEGISLATE IN THE EVENT. TO
CONTINUE TO EXPORT. THAT ARE
THOUGHT TO DESIGNED TAILORED TO
COME. THE PANDEMIC THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE
GO TO TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWELVE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
NEXT TO GO. TO TWELVE SEVENTY.
NAME IS SHANE A CRIB AND I AM A
TEACHER HIGH TECH ELEMENT
ENGINE DIEGO. I AM THE MANY
OTHERS WHO ARE THE EIGHTY CAP
FOR SCHOOL UNDER A SEVENTY. OUR
SCHOOL SHOULD BE FUNDED FOR THE
TO WE ARE. I ALSO SUPPORT THE
ASSAULT BAN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO
NINE SO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS JUDY A DEER FROM
RIVER COUNTY I AM A CHARTER
SCHOOL TEACHER I THAT YOU AMEND
A SEVENTY. TO REMOVE ALL ON
SCHOOL GROWTH FUNDING. SCHOOL
NINETY NINE FOLLOWED THAT DUE
TO THANK YOU MEN WHO NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO READY TO SO
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME'S GREG EXTREME.K FROM
BARBARA COUNTY THANKS OPPOSE
THE FUNDING CAP PROVISION OF AB
FOR SEVEN. THIS CAP WOULD BE.
TO HOURS. AND MANY THANK YOU
THANK YOU WITNESS. THE NINE AND
AT THE THIRTEEN NINETY THREE
WANTED TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION
TO THE COMMITTEE REGARDING
INVESTMENT IN SOCIAL SERVICES
SAFETY THAT ARE THE MOST
CRITICAL AND DESPERATELY NEEDED
TIME IN PARTICULAR WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT. THE STATE GENERAL
FUND BOX FILLED FOR REALIGNMENT
LOSSES RESTORATION OF FUNDING
FOR FIRST TO OPT FOR CPR AND LA
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAM FINALLY
WANTED TO URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONTINUE TO LOOK. TO NEW
FUNDING STREAM TO MAKE SURE
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T ONLY SURVIVE
BUT THRIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO
FORTY FIVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE
WAS. LEVEL FIVE REALIGNED OPEN
YES WE HEAR YOU CAN HEAR ME
YEAH YES I JENNIFER TO CARLO
AND I SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE I AM ALSO
REQUESTING A COMMAND AB SEVENTY
SEVEN REMOVE THE CAP FOR SCHOOL
GROWTH FUNDING AND FOR THE
FUNDING TO FOLLOW THE CHILDREN
I HOME SCHOOL MY FIVE KIDS. TO
MAKE APPROPRIATE ACCOMMODATIONS
FOR LEARNING AND INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES BEING TO ADVANCE
INAPPROPRIATE QUESTION BY THE
BULLYING AND BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
CHOOL SYSTEM CAN'T OR WON'T
MAKE HIS ACCOMMODATION. I HAVE
TO GO INTO MORE YEAR AFTER YEAR.
BECAUSE I FEEL BEING HOME
SCHOOLED AT THE BEST FOR MY
CHILDREN. I UNDERSTAND
LISTENING TO THE PEOPLE YOUR
PRESENT FOR ONE MINUTE EACH.
IT'S TIME CONSUMING. BUT I
RECOMMEND THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY DID- AT THE VICE BY THE
CHAIR YOUR VOICE OPINION
DESERVE TO BE HER. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. AND WE'RE GLAD
TO AS THE SENATE TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS
TO BE ABLE TO PHONE IN AND I
HAVE TO TRAVEL TO SACRAMENTO TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS SO
YOU'RE WELCOME. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NEXT TO A TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I MY
NAME IS LAUREN TREMBLAY FROM
PINE MOUNTAIN CLUB AND KERN
COUNTY I AM A MOTHER OF JUNE
THE CHARTER SCHOOL SYSTEM AND
I'D LIKE YOU OPPOSE THE CAP
WRITTEN IN AB SEVENTY SEVEN I'D
LIKE TO ALSO OPPOSE EIGHTY
EIGHTY EIGHT. AND A COAT AT B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE
GO TO TWELVE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THERESA
ALDER ST I AM FROM SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY I'M A TEACHER OF RECORD
FOR IT NINE CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER IN A MOM AT TWO AND A
TRADITIONAL CHARTER SCHOOL.
PLEASE A MAN AB SEVENTY SEVEN
TO REMOVE THE CAP ON WILL
GROWTH FINDING THE PLAN TO
SHOULD FOLLOW THE STUDENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. LEX
WITH A TWELVE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS LONG
WHEN AND I'M A CPA MEMBER OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER WORKING ORANGE COUNTY
OLDEST AND LARGEST TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND ASK FOR YOU
TO PLEASE AMEND AB SEVENTY
SEVEN TO REFLECT. FUNDING THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO A- LEVIN SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
CASSANDRA BRIDGE CALLING FROM
MONTEREY COUNTY I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY OPPOSITION TO THE
CAP ON AB SEVENTY SEVEN AND MY
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
TO IT A TWELVE NINETY PLEASE GO
pTHE DATA CENTER. I'M A MOTHER
OF FIVE POINT DAY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THE DEMAND AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GROUNDS FUNDING. AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR WORK.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE
GO TO TWELVE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS ROB MAY BE AYE
AND THE APPLE PIE TECH SOLUTION
THAT BOTH THE EDUCATOR IN PARIS
AND ECHO WITH SO MANY BEFORE ME
ABSOLUTELY CLEARLY STATED AND
ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER MANY AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE
CAP. WILL BE. BUT I MANAGER
WILL BE DEBT. FOR MANY PEOPLE
TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
SERVICES DURING A TIME WHEN
STUDENTS. AND FAMILIES WHO NEED
IT THE MOST. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO IT A TWELVE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS THERESA BORN I'M A
MOTHER OF THREE INCLUDING TO
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILDREN ONE OF
WHICH YOU CAN NO LONGER TRYING
TO SITE BASED SCHOOL DURING CUT
WOULD NINETEEN. BEING BECAUSE
BONE MARROW TRANSPLANT.
AVIATION HALL OTHER STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY DURING A TIME WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO ENSURE THE
BEST OPTION FOR THEIR CHILD FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY REASONS
ADDITIONALLY SOME STUDENTS
INCLUDING. HAVE BEEN OR WILL BE
DISPLACED AND HOMELESS DUE TO
CARVE IT SOUNDING SHOULD FOLLOW
THE STUDENTS PLEASE AMEND AB
SEVEN FIVE AND- I ALSO. EIGHTY
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THE NEXT LUGER DO
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DEBORAH
FELLOW COME ON A SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER CHARTER
SCHOOL IN LONG BEACH AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO ECHO IN
COMIC BUT AB SEVENTY SEVEN TO
REMOVE THE CAP ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS FUNDING. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO TWELVE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GUIDE. HERE
MY NAME IS JENNIFER THOMAS
MOTHER OF TWO FROM ORANGE AYE
OPPOSED AB SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
A MAN THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO TEN
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AB
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MEDINA
BY HOUSING OUT WITH WILL KEEP
FLURRY REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY
WOMEN. WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THE COLOR
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CAN CERTAINLY
EXPOSED THE UNCONSCIONABLE GAP
IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE LOSTA LOT
OF THEM WORKERS TAKE LEAVE
WHILE OTHERS WERE DOING THEIR
JOB. A MATTER OF LAW ALL
INCLUDED PAINTED PAID FAMILY
LEAVE BENEFITS AND REGARDLESS
OF THEIR EMPLOYERS BY SHOULD BE
ENTITLED TO JOB PROTECTION WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. FOR SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO YOU TO FOR. HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BRENDA 4% AND I AM BOTH THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER AND
PARENT OF FOUR CHILDREN AND NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOL
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. RIGHT TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE CAP ON
GROWTH FIRST SCHOOL AND EIGHTY
SEVENTY SEVEN THAT WIL NOT
ALLOW THE SCHOOL PROFESSOR
CORRECTIONAL DURING DIFFICULT
PINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A TWO THIRTEEN
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HAVE YOU
HAD A CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MATT REGAN CALLING FROM THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL- AND THE BUSINESS
OF ASSOCIATION WE TO THE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COST OF
EXPANDING FAMILY PARTICULARLY
AT THIS TIME ALSO WAS A MEMBER
OF DEFINITIONS FAMILY PASSPORTS
I HAD. FIRST HAND- INFORMATION
KNOWLEDGE PARTNERS- PACKAGE WAS
PUT TOGETHER AS PART OF OUR
CONCERN WE COMMISSIONED A STUDY
TO ANALYZE FOURTEEN YEARS OF
PAID FAMILY LEAVE APPLICATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA. I'M NOT DATA
SHOWS THAT ONLY 7% OF FIRMS OF
25% ON PLOY EACH OR FEWER EVER
HAPPEN POY E. ACCESS PAID
FAMILY LEAVE ON ALL THOSE FORMS
THEY- THAT THAT DID HAPPEN
COMPLETE ACCESS PAID FAMILY
LEAVE. THEY EXPERIENCE THE 14%
HER. EMPLOYEE COST REDUCTION.
ARE YOU POTENTIAL SO THE DATA
THAT FAMILY IS GOOD FOR HIM.
AND GOOD FOR. ALIKE WE SERVE
THIRTY EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NATIONAL GUARD TO THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS AMBER TôI AND I'M THE
MOTHER OF FOUR FROM TESTING AND
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO PLEASE
CONSIDER AMENDING AB SEVENTY
SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP WORK
SCHOOL GROWTH FUNDING THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO NINE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY GOOD
EVENING THIS OF LOVE THAT- WITH
INLAND COALITION FOR MARGARET
JUSTICE ALSO KNOWN AS I SEE AJ
AND I WANTED FRONT- MY
FRUSTRATION OVER THE GOVERNOR
NOT WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE HEALTH
FOR ALL SENIORS WE NEED. THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON HEALTH FOR ALL
SPECIALLY SINCE THE STATE STILL
HAS A MILLION- IMMIGRANT PEOPLE
WHO ARE UNINSURED. OUR
COMMUNITY CAN NO LONGER BE AN
AFTERTHOUGHT ESPECIALLY SINCE
THEY MAKE THIS STATE MOVE ON
ALL FRONTS AS MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES HAVE SHARED. EARLIER
TONIGHT- WE ALL WANT THE
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATORS TO.
CONTINUE LOOKING FOR OF ANY
COLLEGE SOLUTION TO ENSURE WE
CAN FULLY- FUND PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT IMMIGRANT COKE.
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR NEED
TO THRIVE THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO ELEVEN FORTY FIVE
FORTY NINE. ELEVEN FORTY NINE
YOUR MIND OPEN. GOOD EVENING
AND THANK YOU MY NAME
INSTRUCTORS KARABAKH AND I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOUNDER
AND PARENT OF THREE FOUR BRICK
AND MORTAR CHARTER SCHOOL PICK
MORE CREEK COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL. IN HUNTINGTON BEACH
ORANGE COUNTY- I UNDERSTOOD
WHERE IN OUR FIRST YEAR WE JUST
FINISHED OUR FIRST YEAR AND I
UNDERSTAND WELL THAT IN THE
SPIRIT OF THE HOLD HARMLESS
LANGUAGE. IT ALSO. HER CAN HELP
COOL BUT DISTRICTS AS WELL.
CLASSROOM AND NON COST TO BE.
ESPECIALLY SMALLER YOURS YOUR
SCHOOL. I THINK THERE'S SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
WERE CONSIDERED IN THE LANGUAGE
OF THE BILL- WE STARTED WITH
FIFTY THREE STUDENT. ENDED WITH
EIGHTY AT THE TECHNICAL AND NOW
WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE CENTS BUDGET FOR NEXT
YEAR. WE'RE OUT ANOTHER CREED
WHICH WILL MAKE THAT DIFFICULT
WHAT ABOUT THE COULD. BELIEVE
THAT THE CURRENT STUDENTS. I
WHAT DO WE TELL THESE HOW CAN
YOU FOR. NEARLY TWICE. THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WITH ONLY OF
THE CRIME. YOU TOO AB A WAS.
COUNTED EARLIER THANK I TOOK
OUT THAT WE ARE ALLOWED TO THE
PARAMETERS FOR IN A LEGALLY
BINDING CHARTER OF OUR AND
LONELY PROJECTION AUTHORIZED
HERE AND OUT ANOTHER GREAT AS
WELL EXCEPT THE STUDENTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU ZERO NINE A HIGH
LANGUAGE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WE GO TO
TWELVE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS VERA I WORK FOR A
GRAND MOUNTAIN CHARTER SCHOOL A
NON PRESERVATION PUBLIC SCHOOL
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I
STRONGLY ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
AMEND A. B. SEVEN SEVEN TO
REMOVE THE EIGHTY EIGHTY CAP ON
SCHOOL GROUNDS FUNDING. THANK
YOU. NEXT YEAR THE TWELVE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS WEARING THE END I AM A
TEACHER IN INDIGO AND LIKE-
EIGHTY SEVEN THE SEVEN TO BE
AMENDED THIS WEEK AT DIFFERENT
MEANS TO ESTIMATE FUNDING FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SCHOOL YEAR ALSO ANY PAPER AT
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR DID YOU HEAD. WHEN
I NOTICED MY NAME MADE ME
NOTHING APPEAL I AM A PARENT
FROM CAPITAL CAPITAL OF THE
SCHOOLS AND I CAUGHT UP TO
OPPOSE THE EIGHTY EIGHT CAP AND
AB SEVENTY SEVEN. ELEVEN LA
COUNTY RESIDENT AYE OPPOSED AB
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO A TEN
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY MARTIN AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CORPSMAN
LEARNING CENTER HERE IN LOS
ANGELES SPECIFICALLY IN SANTA
CLARITA. AND I ATE A ARGUED TO
OPPOSE AB SEVENTY SEVEN AND THE
CAP ON EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU THE
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE ARE
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OR HEY MAYBE NEXT ONIONS
CARROTS AYE OPPOSED AB SEVENTY
SEVEN CREE TO MOVE THE CAB AND
ALLOW THE PLAN IF I LOOK AT IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. REX WITNESS.
NEXT WE GO TO THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS JOHN AT HAND
DIRECTOR FOR VALLEY VIEW
CHARTER CRAP BY BECAUSE AB
SEVENTY SEVEN AS IT IS WRITTEN
DEPRIVED FAMILIES AND STUDENTS
OF EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES THEY
DESERVE AND PUNISHES SCHOOLS.
THAT HAVE PROVEN STUDENT
OUTCOMES BY FAILING TO ALLOCATE
EDUCATIONAL FUNDS BASED ON
ACCURATE. STUDENT ENROLLMENT.
THANK YOU. NEXT YEAR THE
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO PLEASE GIVE.
HELLO CHAIR WOMEN IN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THAT ARE
RIGHT NOW I KNEW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ONLINE TRIP BUT OUR
COMMUNITY AND I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS MY FRUSTRATION OVER THE
GOVERNOR NOT WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE HELP FOR
ALL. SENIOR AND HIS RELUCTANCE
TO MOVE IT FORWARD GIVEN THE
URGENT NEED FOR ACTED TO HELP
CARRY IN OUR COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC WHERE INDIVIDUALS OVER
THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE ARE AT
HIGH RSK AND MORE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO COMPLICATIONS. AND OR GAS
AND KOBE NINETEEN I THINK THOSE
OF YOU WHO HAVE CONTINUED TO
SUPPORT THIS ISSUE I URGE YOU
TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON HEALTH
FOR ALL. THE SUPPORT EIGHTY
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AFTER ALL
EMPLOYEES- BECAUSE ACTUALLY THE
TIME THAT WE NEED TO OFFER YOU
CAN POORLY- BENEFIT AND I ALSO
SUPPORT GREATER RESTRICTIONS ON
THE THOUGHT WEAPON BUT I'VE
BEEN HEARING ABOUT ON THE CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK. YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL
THIRTY FIFTY FOUR PLEASE AHEAD.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR LINES OPEN.
OF. NEXT WITH A THIRTEEN FIFTY
TWO THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINES OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
SHARON DâN AS THE MILITARY
HOMESCHOOLING FAMILY ASSIGNED
TO EDWARDS AIR FORCE BASE IN
DISTRICT TWENTY THREE I'M
CALLING CAN AND EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN THROUGH THE CAP ON SCHOOL
GROWTH FUNDING PLEASE HELP
SUPPORT MILITARY FAMILIES IN
YOUR STATE BY BANNING NO ON. AB
SEVEN SEVEN I ALSO OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO EIGHT OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. PEDRO FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS MICHELLE ANDERSON AND I'M
REPRESENTING A THOUSAND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WITH COLOR
SHIP PROPUBLICA COOL. WE'RE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE ADA
FUNDING CAP IN AB SEVENTY SEVEN
AS IT'S WRITTEN AS IT WILL HURT
STUDENTS AND NEWLY HIRED
EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE STATE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO
A TWELVE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
DAVID GILLINGHAM REPRESENTING
HIGH TECH BUT WE ARE CONTINUE
GO. I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THE HIGH TECH HIGH AND-
DUE TO A MAN AB SEVENTY SEVEN
SIR BOTH THE APA CAP FOR GROWTH
SCHOOL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS HERE AT THE HOPMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION I GUESS FIRST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE THE BUDGET- WE'RE
NOT CUTTING IN THE LCS THAT
FUNDING FOR INCREASING THE BASE
RATE FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION. AND
ALSO FOR ENSURING THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL RECEIVE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING INTERVIEW
AFTER HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THAT. WE WORK TOGETHER TO
CLARIFY LANGUAGE WITHIN THE
DEAF DISTANCE LEARNING PORTION.
OF THE TRAILER BILL SB- AB
SEVENTY SEVEN KEYS MEANS- WHEN
SHE'S AT SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN
APPROPRIATELY OFFER HYBRID AND
DISTANCE LEARNING PROGRAMS- FOR
ALL OF THEIR FOR ALL THE
NECESSARY STUDENTS. IN ORDER TO
MEET THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY.
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE DO HAVE
SOME CLARIFICATION AT THIS
RATHER CONFUSING AND CAN BE
INTERPRETED IN A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WE TO THIRTEEN NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS KRISTIN
THEM BACK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TEND TO THE SICK
VIOLIN SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE FOR
ALL THE REASONS OTHER THAN
PREVIOUSLY STATED BUT ALSO ON
THE HIGHLY THAT ECONOMIC
REPORTS LIKE AIDS CAN YOU LEAVE
HELLO BUT HE CREATED AN ACTUAL
CAPTAIN FAMILY OF COULD BE
USEFUL LIKELY HAD. A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OCCURRING AT BOTH A
PROTECTIVE FACTOR AS WELL THE
LATEST PUSH THE BIBLE. YOU I
UPON PEOPLE ONLINE WE URGE YOU
ALL IF THE PART THE PART AND
BELL. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. JUST A MOMENT. AXOLOTL
LINE THIRTEEN FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NEXT TO A LOT
TIMELINE. ELEVEN NINETEEN
ELEVEN NINETEEN YEAR MINUS OPEN.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU YES I'M
SORRY MEDIAN IN MY NAME IS BETH
AND I'M NOT AND I AM FROM AND I
AM CALLING BECAUSE I REALLY
OPPOSE AB SEVEN SEVEN WE NEED
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR FAMILIES
FOR CHILDREN THAT NEED SUPPORT
IN THIS MOMENT. AND THERE'S
THAT PLEASE CONSIDER AND THEN.
THERE IS BILL. WE NEED HELP AND
SINGLE IN STATE NOT. FOR
LOOKING ME OF KING AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I HAVE NO WITNESS.
NAY TO GO DO TEND NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND SIXTY NINE LINES
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YES WE CAN HELLO YES WE CAN- MY
NAME IS KATIE AUDIO- I AM FROM
IRVINE CALIFORNIA I'M A MOTHER
OF FOUR AND A BRICK AND MORTAR
CHARTER SCHOOL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR MADERA BOX ACTUALLY
SPOKE EARLIER THE WITNESS- OUR
SCHOOL HAS BEEN VERY SMALL THE
FIRST YEAR BUT IT IS GROWN
INCREDIBLY ANDI'VE SEEN
TREMENDOUS GROWTH FOR MY
CHILDREN I'M TERRIFIED IF THIS
IS AB SEVENTY SEVEN DOES NOT
GET AMENDED. THAT OUR SCHOOL
HAPPY SHUT IT TOWARD NEXT FALL
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THE
EIGHTY EIGHT FUNDING CAP WILL
NOT MAKE UP TO THE AMOUNT THAT
WE WILL NEED TO MEET THE EXTRA
GROW QUITE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
ON ME EIGHTY EIGHT FUNDING CAP
FOR GROWTH AND CHARTER IN
PUBLIC SCHOOL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS NEXT TO- DO
ELEVEN SIXTEEN ELEVEN SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M SHERRY
LEWIS UMBILICAL MOM OF ONE
CALLING ONCE COUNTY. AND I.
PLEASED WITH THE EIGHTY EIGHT
ON CORPORATE FUNDING IN EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL
EIGHT THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M GOOD EVENING LARA
NAY ALL DIRECTOR OF ALL OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN PASADENA IN
THE SPIRIT OF EQUITY EVEN THEN
AB SEVENTY SEVEN AND REMOVE THE
ADA CáC ON GROWING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
THIRTY THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JASON AND I OPPOSED EIGHTY
EIGHTY EIGHT ABA MOM BY THE
VERY STRUGGLE NAVIGATE- BY
THINKING FIRING COACH AND IS
STILL ONLY FURTHER COMPLICATE
THE MATTER I WOULD POINT YOU
COULDN'T SIMPLY THROW UP THEIR
HANDS THESE OF THE LEGISLATORS
AND HIGHLY. FOR THIS REASON AS
PRINCE WILL POSE OR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WE SIMPLY SELECT
NONCOMPLIANT MORE RIGHTEOUS
PATH. LASTLY TO A THE WITNESS
WHETHER TO. IT GERRY GARNER
WITH ACT HURDLE THE- YOU'RE
MORE LIKELY TO BE STRUCK BY
LIGHTNING. THREE OVER. BEFORE
EVERYTHING BEHIND THE SCHOOL.
YEAH WE KNOW BETTER FINANCIAL
ABOUT BAD WEATHER. THANK YOU
AND HAVE A GOOD EVENING. IF THE
NEXT TO GO DO THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CHRISTY BATMAN I HOME
SCHOOL THREE STUDENT STARTED
FOUR YEARS AGO IT'S BEEN
AMAZING EXPERIENCE TO GIVE ME
THE OPTION TO EDUCATE MY KIDS
THE WAY WANT AYE OPPOSED AB
SEVENTY SEVEN. AND I ASK THAT
THE FUNDS FOLLOW THE STUDENT AS
WE ARE INVESTING OUR TAX
DOLLARS TO- IT TO EDUCATE OUR
CHILDREN THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE ARE THE
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES HELLO PLEASE
SORRY ABOUT THAT MY NAME IS
ABOUT MEDIA I LIVE IN ETCETERA
ROB A DISTRICT IN RIVERSIDE IN
THERE BUT IN MEDICALLY
PARTNERSHIP ECLIPSE OVERLY
IMMIGRANT DIGNITY AND PART OF
THE HEALTH LAW COALITION AND
WE'RE ASKING THE BUDGET THE BUT
HERE IN THE BUDGET HEARING TO
PLEASE CLOSE HEALTH FOR ALL
ELDERS WE HAVE COUNTY SIX
NUMBER DO YOU KNOW RIVERSIDE
IMPERIAL COUNTY THEY DON'T HAVE
A STRONG COUNTY SAFETY NET. WE
NEED HELP FOR ALL OUR COMMUNITY
IS NOT JUST FOR SOME ARE BUDGET
REFLECTS OUR VALUES- WE ARE I
BELIEVE THOSE ARE WHAT HE DOES
TOOK CARE OF US AND IT'S OUR
TURN TO TAKE CARE OF THEM
PLEASE INCLUDE HEALTH FOR OUR
ELDERS AND MAKE SURE YOU PUSH
THE GOVERNOR- TOO BECAUSE I'S
VERY FRUSTRATING THAT WE'VE
BEEN PUSHING AND THAT THIS HAS
NOT BEEN INCLUDED THE GOVERNOR
PROMISED ENGINE GENERATE BUDGET
AND YOU NEED TO FOLLOW THROUGH
WITH HIS PROMISES AND MORE THAN
EVER. EVEN WHAT CO IN NINETEEN
WE NEED HELP FOR OUR ELDERS
THANK YOU THANK. YOU BYE BYE
UHHUH THE NEXT WITNESS. LET
YEAR THIRTEEN. EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
TONY MACAULAY AND I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN FOR IBM IN NON
CLASSROOM BASED EDUCATION
THROUGH ON THE LANCASTER
CHARTER SCHOOL WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE EIGHTY SEVENTY SEVEN CAP
ON CHARTER SCHOOL FUNDING GROW.
AS IT IS JUST ANOTHER ATTACK ON
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL. AND OF
OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS WRONG YOUR ACTUAL
DURING THE RIGHT TO THE REACH
THEIR POTENTIAL THE MONEY
SHOULD FOLLOW THE CHILD
THANKFULLY THE MANDATE BE SEVEN
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO A THIRTEEN SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
JENNY CASSIDY AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORKING VALLEY
COALITION AND I'M- CALLING IN
IN SUPPORT OF AT THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WE NEED A STRONG
OKAY LEAVE LAW THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYBODY NO ONE SHOULD GET
FIRED FOR BONDING WITH THE NEW
CHILD OR CARING FOR A FAMILY
MEMBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL OF
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CINDY JO
THREE CONTESTANTS ALL MY KIDS
ARE AT SCHOOL AGE. MY HOPE AB
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE REMOVE THE
CAP ON SCHOOL GROW FUNDING TO
OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT CO TWO THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ELAINE BUTLER AND I
LIVE IN MISSION VIEJO I'M
CALLING TO ASK YOU TO AMEND AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GROUNDS I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE MADAM CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE ON THE PHONE
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO DRIVE UP
YOUR PANDEMIC TO MEET YOU IN
PERSON. STATE MY OPINION THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL GO TO-
THIRTEEN OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS DANIEL ANOTHER
TRAIN I AM A CHARTER SCHOOL
TEACHER FOR LIKE THE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND ALSO COMPOSED
TEACHER FOR MY TWO KIDS FROM TO
GO CALIFORNIA. THE MAN EIGHTY
TWO SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
REMOVED THE CAP ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS FUNDING I ALSO HOLD
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE
GO TO FOURTEEN TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOURTEEN TWENTY YEAR
LINES OPEN. HI GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS IT GOT A LITTLE ALSO
AND THEN AND NOW SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTY I SUPPORT
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THE PAID FAMILY TRAILER
BILL- NO WORKER SHOULD HAVE
DROPPED THAT. OF THAT. NO ONE
SHOULD HAVE DUBBED THAT. EVERY
WORKER SHOULD HAVE DROPPED AT
THE PAIN IN A SPECIALLY TRAINED
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THE NEXT TO GO TO
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DENISE MET
THEM IN CONCERT COUNTY I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY SEVEN
THREATEN WITH CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BURDEN IT WILL PLACE ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
REACHES FOR FEDERAL LAW. AND
CERTAIN LEGAL CHALLENGES- I'M
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THAT EIGHTY
EIGHTY EIGHT I DON'T BELIEVE
ALONG SENATE BUDGET BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A FOURTEEN
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS JENNIFER GEORGIAN
AND A HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER OF
FIVE CALLING FROM WESTMINSTER
SOMEONE ALCOHOL PLACES THAT ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SEVENTY
SEVEN AND URGE YOU TO STOP
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST CHARTER
SCHOOL PLEASE AMEND AB SEVENTY
SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP ON.
SCHOOL GROUNDS SPENDING. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT TO A
FOURTEEN THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND FOR STAYING UP
LATE TO HEAR OUR VOICE SAYS. MY
NAME IS GINNY BROWN AND I TAX
PAYING RESIDENT OF ORANGE
COUNTY AND THE MOTHER OF THE
SCHOOL AGE CHILD WHO STRONGLY
OPPOSES AB SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK
ON KERLEY DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
STUDENTS SHOULD HEALTH
BACKGROUND OR UNIQUE FAMILY
SITUATION REQUIRES A NON
CLASSROOM BASED APPROACH
BECAUSE THE CURVE IN NINETEEN.
MY FAMILY AND I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO PLEASE REVISED AND OR WE
CHAT THE EASY SEVENTY SEVEN
HOLD HARMLESS TRAILER ADDS THAT
IN FACT THE BARELY HARMS OUR
CHARTERS. IN THERE FOR OUR
CHILDREN HE IS THE MAN EIGHTY
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GROUNDS FUNDING THANK.
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
FOR YOUR ATTENTION. THANK YOU
VERY WITH THE OUR BI OH SIX
HAVING ARRIVED I'M GOING TO ASK
THE FOLLOWING THE REMAINDER OF
THE WITNESSES TO SIMPLY SAY
YOUR NAME AND WHERE YOU'RE FROM
AND THE POSITION ON THE BILL.
MOM IF WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO HEAR FROM THE REST OF YOU
SUGGEST YOUR NAME IN THE
POSITION. NEXT WITNESS
NEXTBOOK. NEXT ORDER TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS JULIA PARISH AND
FROM THE LATE AT WORK AND
NONPROFIT ADVOCATES ON BEHALF
OF LOW WAGE WORKERS AND WHEN I
BY THANKS ON SUPPORT FOR
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
INDEED THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER
STATES THAT OFFER DROP
PROTECTION REGARDLESS OF THE
PLAYER. HOW BRINGING UP. THANK
YOU NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
PLEASE NEXT WITNESS. NEXUS
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME AND LARA DERAIL
AND- DIRECTOR OF I NEED
EXPLORATION AND- I AM IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE
GO TO FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BRIAN THOMAS IN PLASTER COUNTY
I WOULD LIKE TO STATE MY
EXTREME DISAPPOINTMENT OF HOW
MANY OF THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
TAKE NO CONSIDERATION OF PUBLIC
COMMENT AND DISREGARD FOR THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIANS WHO YOU
WORK FOR. I'M DISAPPOINTED AS A
PRECIOUS MEETING LIVE AND HOW
MANY OF YOU ARE WALKING AROUND
AND TALKING TO EACH OTHER
DURING PUBLIC COMMENT INSTEAD
OF LISTENING TO AND CONSIDERING
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
IT'S UNETHICAL AND IMMORAL. I
OPPOSE LAST MINUTE UNETHICAL
ADDITION OF THE TRAILER. TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN AND I ALSO
CLOSE A. B. THANK YOU I'M GOING
TO ASK OUR FUTURE WITH THIS IS
IF YOU COULD JUST GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND THE POSITION ON THE
BILL SO I CAN TRY TO HEAR FROM
AS MANY OF YOU AS POSSIBLE.
NEXUS TWELVE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS WILLIAM
HANCOCK FROM OUR- BECAUSE
PROSPECT IN A COUNTY AYE
OPPOSED EIGHTY A CAP ON GROWING
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT YEAR TO
FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO. COULD YOU
AT. OKAY HI MY NAME IS COURTNEY
ERIN- I AM THE MOTHER OF THE
SCHOOL AGE CHILD FROM BURBANK
AND THEN I AM OPPOSED TO AB
SEVEN SEVEN THE WAY THAT IT'S
WRITTEN- I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
JOIN WITH THE CAP ON SCHOOL
GROWTH FUNDING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A FOURTEEN
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ALLEY THE DAM I AM A
PUBLIC SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR I'M
FINE TO OPPOSE AB SEVENTY SEVEN
AND ALSO OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL DO NUMBER
NINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS AUDREY
WRITTEN A MOTHER OF THREE IN
CORONA HE'S A MAN AB SEVENTY
SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP ON
SCHOOL GROWTH FUNDING I URGE
YOU TO LISTEN TO ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE ON THE ON THE CALL.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW TO FOLLOW
THE STUDENT THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO FOURTEEN
SEVENTY YOUR LINES OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DANA CARILLO ANOTHER AS
A SCHOOL AGE CHILD NUMBER YOU
KNOW COUNTY IN ONTARIO
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN LEARNED
AB SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE
CAP ON THE GROWTH FUNDING THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WITH A FOURTEEN SIXTY
GLAZER AT. HI MY NAME IS
CANDACE ROUTINE IN SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY AND I AM CALLING TO
OPPOSE AB SEVENTY SEVEN AND THE
TRADING PLEASE AND TO REMOVE
THE CAP ON CALDERON GROWTH AND
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AHA NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
YEAR THE FOURTEEN FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
JOE HENDRIX DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AB SEVENTY
SEVEN BECAUSE IT CLEARLY HARMS
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES BUT
ALSO OPPOSE A. B. EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A FORK IN
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE A- HI GOOD
EVENING AND I KNEW THAT- CUTE
LEADER AT POLITICALLY BOTH
CENTER WE SERVE THE INLAND
EMPIRE WHICH- BALLY I DID FIND
A ELEVATE THE HEALTHCARE
EXPANSION FOR ARE UNDOCUMENTED
FIVE MINUTES AND I WOULD. WELL
LGBT DID NOT NOW MORE THAN EVER
IN THE STATE OF CRISIS ARE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY IS
SUFFERING TREMENDOUSLY WITHOUT
THE HEALTH COVERAGE I'M ASKING
FOR YOUR NAME THE ORGANIZATION
AND THE BILL YOU'RE SUPPORTING.
OR OPPOSING PLEASE THAT SET.
OKAY NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. I
WILL GO TO FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE
PLEASE YEAH. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES BEGINNERS. MY NAME IS
ANNA TOM AN EDUCATOR
REPRESENTING HIGH TECH
ELEMENTARY WORK AND I THOUGHT
YOUR MEN AB SEVENTY SEVEN TO
REMOVE THE CAP ON SCHOOL BROKE
SPENDING THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. COMPLEX WITH A
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LISA GORE
AND I'M AN EDUCATOR WITH HIGH
TECH ELEMENTARY OR EXPLORE IN
SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I
PROBABLY DID- TO AMEND AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GROWTH FUNDING THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE A
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME
GIVEN ME THAT I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER OF TWO
FROM ANY CAN BE TAUGHT IN
ORANGE COUNTY. I AM CALLING TO
REQUEST THE REE THE MAN EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN DURING THE- CALL
GRANDSTANDING. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. LEX WITH A FOURTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WE GOT. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS ON HATE
DEFINITELY MONTH AT ALL AND THE
PARENT OF A CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN LOS ANGELES. AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GROUNDS. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO THE
FOURTEEN NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MANY MCCARTY BOSTOCK AN
IMAGE EACH YEAR AND MOTHER OF
TWO SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY PLEASE AMEND
AB SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE
CAP ON SCHOOL GROUNDS FUNDING
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO A DO A NUMBER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PLEASE I HAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS HEAD FONG KERR
TO I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE AB A
SEVEN SEVEN ASKING TO AMENDED
TO. ALLOW ONE TO FOLLOW THE
STUDENT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WE ARE TO FOURTEEN NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS COURTNEY SERRANO
HOMESCHOOLING MOTHER FORM YOU
COUNTY PLEASE A MAN AB SEVENTY
SEVEN TURN WITH THE CAP ON
SCHOOL GROUNDS FUNDING THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WE GO TO TWELVE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE FAIR AND I AM A
CHARTER SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR
AND I'M CALLING YOU UP AB
SEVENTY SEVEN FOR ALL THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
TO IT A FIFTEEN ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIFTEEN ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOING TO THE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO FIFTEEN OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DAN I'M A
GAY TRANSGENDER FATHER OF THREE
O'CLOCK TO THE TALLINN I'D LIKE
TO OPPOSE AB EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO FOURTEEN
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOCAL
GLENDALE I AM THE LOW INCOME TO
GET GOOD. WELL I AM TROPICAL
AND I AM AT SEVEN PM. TO REMOVE
THE CAP ON SCHOOL GROUNDS
FUNDING THANK YOU NEXT WHAT.
NEXT OVER A FORTY NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KAREN EAGLE TO CHILDREN CENTER
VALLEY MY SON I IT IS THE YOU
PROPER SUPPORT PLEASE DON'T
TAKE MONEY FROM THE CHILDREN
DID AB SEVENTY SO CAPPER VISION
THANK YOU NEXT WHAT. NEXT A
FIFTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
WE CAN AREA IN I AM JACQUI DEAR
I MADE HER SCHOOL I'M NOT AND I
WHOSE AB SEVENTY SEVEN THE
FUNDING SHOULD FOLLOW THE
STUDENT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WE HAVE A FOURTEEN TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS KRISTEN WATANUKI PARENT
OF TWO ELEMENTARY STUDENTS AT
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED THE FULL TIME
CLASSROOM TRADITIONAL AND
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I DID-
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN CAP REVISION
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR LETTING
OUR VOICE TO BE HEARD THANK
NINE. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WE'LL THIRTEEN OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTEEN OUT
YOUR LINES OPEN HI MY NAME IS
HEIDI GOT YEAH I AM AN
ADMINISTRATOR FOR EXCEL ACADEMY
CHARTER SCHOOL IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
SEVENTY SEVEN FOR ALL THE
REASONS STATED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD EVENING LANCASTER WHAT
GRANT AND THAT DIRECTORS THE
JOKER CALLED AND I'M CALLING
OPPOSITION AT EIGHTY SEVENTY
AND THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE. HELLO YES
MIX WITH GOOD. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE SOMEONE ONLINE. YES I WILL
GO TO THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ANYWAY AND
I AM THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR AT
XCEL COUNTY CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I OPPOSE AB SEVENTY SEVEN FOR
ALL REASONS BUT THE BEFORE
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. OUR
NEXT TO A. TO FIFTEEN TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY HOW
YOU THINK YOU FOR TAKING OUR
CALL THIS IS BONNIE KELLER IM
A MOTHER OF FOUR FROM STAMINA
DINO AND I ALSO OPPOSE AB
SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL DO FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CERVANTES PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL DO
FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENNY
MOLLEN AT AND I'M A MOTHER IN
HIGH CALIFORNIA. OUR CHILDREN
DESERVE MORE AND DESERVE AN
EDUCATION THAT INDIVIDUAL NEEDS
PLEASE A MAN AB TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP ON
SCHOOL TRUST FUNDING THANK YOU
FOR TAKING OUR PUBLIC COMMENT
UHHUH THANK YOU THE NAME AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
PLEASE NEXT WITNESS. THE NEXT
CO TO ONE THOUSAND PLEASE YOU
HAD. MY EIGHT GRAHAM ACLU
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY MAYBE THREE AND
ALLIED MIKE ON THE- ORDER THAT
CAME BEFORE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT TO DO FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAIN MARKET
THERE I GO AGAIN. REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER WE
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TO REFLECT THE
CONCERNS IDENTIFIED IN TODAY'S
GLOBAL FLORA ALERT YEP YEP THAT
WOULD BE COALITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE
GO TO FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE PLEASE
YEAH. MY NAME IS PRETTY SICK
GREEN LINE I'M A PARENT OF A
CHILD A COMMUNITY MANDATORY IN
CARLSBAD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE AMEND. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE ARE
THIRTEEN OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BRIAN
BAILEY AS BOTH A CHARTER SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR AND PARENTS OF
TWO STUDENTS WITH THE RIVER
SPRINGS CHARTER SCHOOL IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I URGE YOU
TO OPPOSE AB SEVENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
FIFTEEN THIRTY NINE PLEASE ADD.
A FIFTEEN THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINES OPEN. MORE THAN. I WILL
GO TO FIFTEEN FORTY ONE A.
HELLO MY NAME IS VALERIE CAMPUS
AND OUR PARENTS OF CHIU
CHILDREN HER WITH GRANT AMOUNT
CHARTER SCHOOL IN TIME AGAIN-
COUNTY AYE OPPOSED AB SEVENTY
SEVEN AS WELL AS AB EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. AN EXTRA FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ANNE KLEIN FROM ORANGE COUNTY
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND
I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN CLEVELAND AND
REMOVE THE CAP UNCLE THAT
FUNDING. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THE NEXT TO GO TO FOURTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME RECKLESS THE GIRL I
HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS AND THEN I
REQUEST THAT. EIGHTY SEVENTY
SEVEN BE REQUIRED TO HAVE THE
MONEY ALL OF THE CHILDREN THANK
YOU. IT TOOK TO THE CALLERS
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE. A PUBLIC
COMMENT TO ELEVEN THIRTY WHEN
WE WILL STOP AT THAT POINT ON
AND BEGIN THE VOTING PROCESS SO
IF YOU COULD JUST GIVE YOUR
NAME OF YOUR POSITION WILL GET
AS MANY AS WE CAN IN THE NEXT
TEN MINUTES. NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
TO IT AT FIFTEEN FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS CAMMY BACKER AND I'M
A MOTHER OF TWO AND A REGIONAL
ASSISTANT AT COMMUNITY MONICA
MONTESSORI SCHOOL IN ESCONDIDO
CALIFORNIA- AND I AND IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY SEVEN
AFTER REMOVE THE CAP ON SCHOOL
GROWTH FUNDING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. OUR NEXT CO
TWO FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A LEASE
GO DOWN AND THE MOTHER OF Q. AN
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA I AM
URGING YOU TO TWENTY YEARS
REMOVE THE CAP AND OPPOSE AB
SEVENTY SEVEN AND AMEND IT I
ALSO AM CALLING TO OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE HONOR
WHAT NUMBER ONE TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS RACHEL I'M
CALLING FROM KIT SO CAL NOW I'M
GOING TO OPPOSE A CAP ON
GROWING PUBLIC SCHOOL THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE ARE
THE NUMBER FOURTEEN OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOANNA
CHRISTIAN CONFIRM TENDER NATO
COUNTY AND AYE OPPOSED AB
SEVENTY SEVEN STRONGLY I ALSO
OPPOSED. EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. MEXICO TO FIFTEEN
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS REBECCA FROM AND I AM A
TEACHER HI TECH EXPLORE
ELEMENTARY IN SAN DIEGO I'M
CALLING TO OPPOSE AB SEVENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO FIFTEEN
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS WELL I MEAN I
PRACTICALLY AND I AM HELLO AB
FOR EVERYTHING FROM I THINK
HE'LL HAVE A GOOD EVENING NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE ARE TO
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE. MY NAME IS
HI HERE AT HOLIDAYS CALLING
FROM FORTUNE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AND I UPHOLD THE
EIGHTY A CAP ON GROWING PUBLIC
SCHOOL. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WE GO TO FIFTEEN SIXTY
THREE BUT- MY NAME IS JAMIE
BELL UP ALL AROUND FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND AYE OPPOSED
AB. SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THE
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE ARE THE
FIFTEEN SIXTY TWO GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACKIE HAD
FROM SANTA CLARITA AYE OPPOSED
AB SEVENTY SEVEN AYE OPPOSED
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT AND I HAVE
HEARD SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
THE NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO A
FIFTEEN FIFTY SEVEN GO AHEAD.
PLEASE THE MAN AB SEVENTY SEVEN
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE CAP ON
GROWING PUBLIC SCHOOLS THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS.
NEXT VIDEO TO THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS UNLIMITED AB SEVEN
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE ARE THE TEN
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NAME IS LETICIA SANCHEZ I'M A
TEACHER AND MOTHER FROM WITH A
PART CALIFORNIA PLEASE AMEND AB
SEVENTY SEVEN TO REMOVE THE CAP
ON SCHOOL GIRL THANK YOU MAX
WHAT. THE STUDENT THANK YOU.
NEXT TO WE WILL GO TO THIRTEEN
SEVENTY TWO THE BILL HAS. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS CHERYL AND
I'VE TAUGHT IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS MY OWN
CHILDREN HAVE ATTENDED
INDEPENDENT CHARTER SCHOOL BUT
WE DID NOT CONTINUE DUE TO
THEIR PRACTICES INCLUDING.
MARKING EVERY STUDENT PRESENT
EVERY DAY MA'AM IF I COULD JUST
pYOU'RE CALLING IN IN NO
POSITION PLEASE. SO THEREFORE
DUE TO THEIR PRACTICES I DO
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY SEVEN IN ITS
ENTIRETY GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. LEXERD A
FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE
NAY ON THE MOTHER A CUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND AYE OPPOSED
AB. SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO A FIFTEEN
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIX LINES OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS BEING A CAST
LOWER OF A TEN YEAR OLD FROM-
ORANGE COUNTY IRVINE CALIFORNIA
YES I'M AND EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
THREE MOVE THE COPLEY SCHOOL
GROWTH FUNDING. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO FIFTEEN
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME THE BAND ALVAREZ AND
WHO'S GOING MOTHER THREE
PREPAYMENT AB SEVENTY SEVEN TO
REMOVE THE CAP ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS AND GAME THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE HAD A FIFTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SO OVER MINOR I'M THE MOTHER AN
ORANGE COUNTY AND TO A CHILD
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS I WOULD LIKE
TO OPPOSE AB SEVENTY SEVEN AND
DID OF THE REQUEST FOR ANY
AMENDMENT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO A FIFTEEN
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING I AM MONIQUE NIGHT
MOTHER FOR AND PRAGUE GOOD
LEADER REPRESENTING HI
ELEMENTARY MASON BEEN DIEGO
STAND HERE AND CALL FOR
AMENDMENT OF EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
IN IT. ARTICLE GROW THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE GO TO
FIFTEEN NINETY SIX WE'VE GOT A-
HI MY NAME IS MELISSA CAR A
MOTHER OF THREE FROM LAKE
FOREST AYE OPPOSED EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN. AMENDED TO AGAINST THE
CAP ON SCHOOL FUNDING THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO FIFTEEN FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS NATALIE HALL THAT AND I'M
CALLING OUR CONNECTION
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL AND
LOCAL DISTRICT BY THE VALUES.
AND OUR JOB IS TO GIVE OUR
POWER IN POWER OTHERS THE USER
MOVES THE **** FAT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WEEK GO TO.
SIXTEEN OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS TRINA HEINOUS
OF THE LEADER OF THE A HER
MOTHER Q. I OPPOSE AB SEVENTY
SEVEN WITH A CAP ON WILL GROWTH
FUNDING THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
NEXT WE GO TO FIFTEEN EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTEEN EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GO TO THE
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WE
HAD A FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
FOR ELECTION AGAIN AND I AM SO
AB SEVENTY SEVEN. OKAY TOPICAL
GROW I ALSO CALLED EIGHTY
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO- TO SIXTEEN
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY
NAME IS DARLENE OUT PIZZA I
HAVE A MASTER'S DEGREE IN HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT SPECIALIZING IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION- I
OPPOSE AB SEVEN SEVEN
ESPECIALLY- I WANT TO ASK A MAN
REMOVE THE CAP ON SCHOOL GROWTH
FUNDING THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO A SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JEANINE THAT SAT AND I AM A
TEACHER IN A CHARTER SCHOOL AND
ALSO A MOTHER OF THREE.
CHILDREN I WANT YOU- ACT THAT
YOU WOULD NEED AND THEN AB
SEVENTY SEVEN AND REMOVED THE
CAP ON WILL GROWTH FUNDING
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
TO A TO FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS TRAVIS KAUFFMAN ROOSEVELT
PLAN AND I WILL- KONICA BLOWS
AB EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BUT AT THIS TIME THAT
WAS OUR LAST WITNESS IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER MODERATOR AND THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF THOSE WHO- WERE ABLE
TO GET TO THE Q. AND
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC COMMENT.
COLLEAGUES OF THEIR MEMBERS WHO
ARE NOT ON THE FLOOR COULD
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO GET
BEGIN VOTING. ON THE BILL
BEFORE US. I'M GOING TO BEGIN.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED
WITH VOTING AND WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH THE FIRST BILL AB
EIGHTY NINE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY IS THERE A MOTION.
THANK YOU MOTIONS BEEN MADE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB EIGHTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS MITCHELL FIVE
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN NO NIELSEN
NOBEL BILL I HAVE A YELLOW
COVER YOUR EYES DALI. DALI NOTE
THAT AWESOME AWESOME I HER
DAUGHTER OR TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
THEY BEHIND THE CHOIR. I
MELENDEZ MELINDA NO MONEY.
MONEY NINE MARLA MORE LIKE L.
L. BROWN NO HAN. AND I ROTH
ROTH AYE SKINNER BY SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI BYE
ACOSTA I. I IS THIRTEEN FIVE
SNOW THE MOTION CARRIES- WE'RE
GONNA TAKE I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON SB. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE PAID FAMILY LEAVE. WILL
MOVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY I'M SORRY SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN. WELL I HAVE A GYRO.
CAREER NO DOLLY. THE ONLY KNOWN
AWESOME AFTER A SUPPLY HER
TOTAL. HER TITLE NO LEYVA LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ MULLIN IS NO MONEY.
MONEY I MORE LOT MORE LIKE NO
MORALE WELL NO PAN AND I ROTH.
ROTH NO SKINNER. OUR SKINNER
AYE STERN STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI.
BECAUSE I. CENTER NIELSEN I
DON'T HAVE A NOW THANK YOU.
YEAH FIVE TEN KNOWS EIGHT. THE
MEASURE KERRY'S- WILL GET A
MOVE NOW TO AB SEVENTY SEVEN K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. THEIR
MOTION THANK YOU CENTER TITLE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
SEVENTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS MITCHELL BY
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN
AYE BELL BILL I HAVE A YELLOW
VIA AYE DOLLY. DALI KNOWN TO
RASA- ALSO I HER DAUGHTER HER
TITLE AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
MELINDA'S NO MONEY MONEY I'M
MORE LOT. MORE LUCKNOW MORALE.
ROUND PAN PAN I ROTH. ROTH I.
THANK YOU SKINNER. I AM SORRY
OKAY HOLD ON ONE SECOND LET'S
DO BOTH CHANGES ONCE HE
FINISHES THE ROLE ONE TIME
PLEASE SO YOU LEFT OFF AT US
SENATOR ROTH SENATOR ROBB WITH
HI SENATE ROTH AYE SKINNER. IN
OUR EYES STERN STERN AYE WAY
BECAUSE HE- BECAUSE HE HI.
NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW NIELSEN I
TO KNOW. THE STAFF THIRTEEN
EYES FIVE NOW THE MOTION
CARRIES. AB SEVENTY EIGHT FIVE
BANKS THEIR MOTION. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AB SEVENTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS CENTERS
MITCHELL BY MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN I FELL BILL I
HAVE A I DON'T. HAVE A AYE
DOLLY. ALI NOTE AWESOME.
AWESOME I HER DAUGHTER HER HER
TITLE NO LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
MULLIN DOES NO MONEY MONEY NINE
MORE LOVE. MORE LOOK NO MORALE.
MORRELL KNOWN PAN PAN HI ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER. STERN AYE
WITH HUSKY ACOSTA I. NICE
THIRTEEN FIVE NEAREST. I WANT
TO DOUBLE CHECK THAT VOTE
BECAUSE I THINK SENATOR HER
TITLE WAS A NO CORRECT YEAH SO
ON OKAY BUT I HAVE CENTER
NIELSEN IS THAT I GOT IT THAT'S
HOW WE GOT TO THIRTEEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MOTION CARRIES
THANK YOU. AB SEVENTY NINE
HUMAN SERVICES OMNIBUS TRAILER
BILL MOTION PLEASE. IT'S BEEN
MOVED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
SEVENTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS MITCHELL MITCHELL
AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN NOBEL.
BILL I A YEAH. HI DOLLY. DOLLY
NOTE AWESOME. AWESOME I HER
DAUGHTER HER TITLE AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. WHERE I AM
LINDA'S MELINDA'S NO MONEY.
MONEY NINE MORE LOVE MORE LIKE
NO MORALE. MORRELL NO PAN PAN I
BROUGHT ROTH AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN IOWA
KASKI ACOSTA I. I THIRTY FIVE
NOW THANK YOU THE MOTION
CARRIES A LIMITED A MOTION FOR
A. B. AB THE HEALTH BILL. IT'S
BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB AT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS MITCHELL BY
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN
NOBEL BILL I HAVE A YELLOW
HEAVIER I'D DALI. DALI NOTRE
AWESOME- ALSO I HEARD. HER
TITLE AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S NO MONEY. MONEY NINE
MARLA. MORE LIKE NO MORALE
MERLE NO PAN PAN HI ROTH. AYE
SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN STERN
I QUIT BECAUSE HE- WIECKOWSKI I.
AS A THIRTY NUYS FIVE NOW THANK
YOU THE MOTION CARRIES WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB AT ONE.
QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE WE HAVE A
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
AB AB ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
CENTERS MITCHELL BY MITCHELL
AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN NOBEL BILL
I HAVE A I DON'T HAVE IT ALL
AYE DOLLY. DALY NOTRE AWESOME
TO RUSSELL I HER TITLE FOR
TITLE I LEYVA. AYE MCGUIRE.
WHERE I AM THE LANDIS BELINDA'S
NO MONEY MONEY NINE MORE LOOK.
MORE LIKE GNOME AROUND. BROWN
NO PAN PAN AYE ROTH. I SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN HI WITH
HUSKY ACOSTA HI. FIVE THIRTEEN
KNOWS FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE MOTION CARRIES WE'RE GONNA
TRANSITION TO A. B. EIGHTY TWO
GENERAL GOVERNMENT WE HAVE A
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
AT TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NOBEL BILL I
DON'T HAVE A YOU KNOW I'D DALI
DALI NOTRE AWESOME- TO RUN SO I
HER TITLE FOR TITLE I LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE REQUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ BELINDA'S NO MONEY
MONEY NINE MORE LAW. MORE LIKE
NO MORALE. WELL NO PAN. PAN AYE
ROTH ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER
AYE STERN STERN HI WAY. ACOSTA
pYOU THEMOTION CARRIES AB AB
THREE HOUSING. WE HAVE A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
MITCHELL BY MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN NIELSEN NOVELL BILL I
HAVE A AT ALL. AYE DALI DALI
NOTRE AWESOME- TO RUSSELL I HER
TADA. A TOTAL AYE LEYVA THE
BEHIND THE CHOIR. MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S. MONEY MONEY NINE
MARLA. MORALE BROWN NO PAN CAN
I ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER ON
EASTERN STERN I WOULD BECAUSE
HE BECAUSE HE I. AT FIVE
THIRTEEN NOTES THREE THANK YOU
THE MOTION CARRIES A. B. EIGHTY
FOUR CAROL FERRIS CALPERS WE
HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AB AT FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS MITCHELL HI
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN. WELL I
HAVE A YELLOW. HI DOLLY DALY
KNOWN AWESOME ALSO ON HER TITLE.
HER TOTAL AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE REQUIRE ISLAND THIS.
MELENDEZ I MONEY MONEY NINE
MORE LUCK. MORALE HELLO PAN PAN
AYE ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER ON
EASTERN EARN I WITH HE BECAUSE
HE I. DID YOU RECORD OF OFFICER
TO NIELSEN AYE TONE TO THIRTY
NIELSEN. NOW CENTER NIELSEN NOW
YEAH. HAVE AYE AYES THIRTEEN
FLOORS NOW THE MEASURE KYRIE'S.
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT. THE
TRAILER BILL ON PUBLIC SAFETY
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB EIGHTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A CENTER
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NOBEL. I HAVE
A YELLOW. HI DOLLY THE ONLY
KNOWN TO RUSSELL ALSO ON HER
TAUGHT OF. I DON'T KNOW LEYVA
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE REQUIRE HI
MELINDA THIS BELINDA'S NO MONEY.
MONEY NINE MORE LAW OR LUCK NO
MORALE MORRELL NO PAN PAN I
ROTH ROTH AYE SKINNER ENTER ON
A STERN STERN ON A WHAT PASSKEY
ACOSTA I. EYES TWELVE NO SIX
THE MOTION CARRIES AB NINETY
TRANSPORTATION. WE HAVE A
MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB NINETY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
MITCHELL FIVE MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NOBEL BILL I
HAVE AAT ALL. AYE DALI. DALI
NOTRE AWESOME AFTER ALSO ON HER
TITLE FOR TITLE II LEYVA. LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S BELINDA'S NO MONEY.
MONEY NINE MORE LAW MORE LUCK
NO MORALE. GIRL NO PAN. AND
ROTH AYE SKINNER IN OUR AYE
STERN- STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI
MCCARTY I. THE ICE THIRTEEN
FIVE NOW THANK YOU THE MEASURE
KERRY'S AB NINETY TWO RESOURCES
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AB NINETY TO THE
MOTION S TO PASS CENTERS
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN.
BILLS AND NOBEL. LIKE A YEAH.
CAREER KNOWN DOLLY. THE ONLY
KNOWN AWESOME. TO WRESTLE I HER
DAUGHTER HER TAUGHT ON NO LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE WHERE I
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO MONEY
MONEY NINE MORE LOCK. MORE LUCK
NO MORALE. AROUND THOUGH PAN
AND I ROTH ROTH AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN IOWA
BECAUSE HE BECAUSE HE I. I
ELEVEN KNOW SEVEN. THE MOTION
CARRIES A BUCKET ASK MEMBERS TO
SPEAK INTO THEIR MIND WE'RE
ASKING THE MANY SECRETARY TO.
PUT IN A LITTLE EXTRA EFFORT
JUST TO HEAR YOUR VOTE ON FOR
THESE LAST SEVERAL SO IF YOU
COULD SPEAK UP AND INTO YOUR
MIND- NEXT UP COLLEAGUES IS. AB
NINETY FOUR SO MOVED EARNED CAN
INCOME TAX CREDIT WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR PAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB NINETY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS CENTERS
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN NO YES AND NO NOW. I
HAVE A AT ALL I HAVE A YOU KNOW
AYE DOLLY. THE ONLY KNOWN-
AWESOME AND ARE ALSO ON HER
TADA HI FOR TITLE I LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE BUT
I MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ NO MONEY
MONEY NINE MORE LOT MORE LIKE
GNOME AROUND. MORRELL NO PAN HI
CAN I RUN. HI SKINNER SKINNER
AYE STERN EARN HIGHWAY KASKI
ACOSTA NINE. THIRTY NINE FIVE
NOW THANK YOU THE MOTION
CARRIES AB NINETY FOUR HIGHER
EDUCATION WE HAVE A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB NINETY
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATORS MITCHELL BY MITCHELL
AYE NIELSEN. NELSON NOVELL BILL
I CAN I YEAH I DON'T HAVE IT
YET A AYE DALI DALI KNOWN
YOU'RE AWESOME TORONTO ON HER
TADA HI HER TOTAL AYE LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ BELINDA'S NO MONEY HI
MONEY I'M MORE A LOT. MORE LIKE
GNOME AROUND AROUND NO PAN. CAN
I RUN. I SKINNER FIVE SKINNER
AYE STERN STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI
HI ACOSTA HI. THIRTEEN FIVE
THIRTEEN FIVE THE MEASURE
KYRIE'S MOVING ON TO. AB ONE
HURDLE MOVED RURAL GOVERNMENT
TO WE HAVE A MOTION THANK YOU
DOCTOR FAN CALL THE ROLL AB ONE
HUNDRED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
CENTERS MITCHELL HI MITCHELL
AYE NIELSEN BILL NELSON NVELL.
I HAVE A YELLOW BY COMING INTO
AYE DOLLY DELI I- ALSO- ALSO I
OR THE OTHER HI OR THE OTHER ON
A LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
OUR ONLINE LINDA'S. MELINDA'S I
MONEY. MONEY NINE MORE A LOT.
MORE LIKE ONLINE AROUND. CAN
AND I ROTH AYE SKINNER ARE YOU
CAN ARE ON EASTERN STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI HI MY KASKI NINE. I
SIXTEEN KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE
KERRY'S AB ONE I'LL SO MOVE
TELL SAVERS THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
ONE INTO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
CENTERS MITCHELL FIVE MITCHELL
I. NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NOBEL.
WELL I HAVE A AT ALL HI HI
DOLLY. DINO THUNDER AWESOME-
ALSO I HER TADA HI FOR TOTAL
AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
I'M LINDA THIS MELENDEZ NO
MONEY NINE MONEY NINE MORE A
LOT MORE LIKE GNOME AROUND. ALL
NO PAN AND HI ROTH. AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI HI ACOSTA HI. IT'S A
THIRTEEN I FIVE NOW THE MEASURE
KERRY'S AB ONE OH THREE I'LL
MOVEMENT INSURANCE MOTION BY
DOCTOR PAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
AB ONE AT THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS CENTERS ITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN AYE
NIELSEN AYE AND THEY'LL- MAKE
OF A AT ALL HI. HI DOLLY.
DAWALY ITER AWESOME TO RUSSELL
ON HER TADA HI FOR TITLE I
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
REQUIRE I AM. MULLIN DESIGN
MONEY MONEY NINE MORE LOT. MORE
LIKE AYE MORALE HI I CAN TEN HI
RON ROTH AYE SKINNER. IN OUR
ONLINE STERN STERN AYE WHAT
KASKI HI ACOSTA AT AYE AYES
EIGHTEEN OH ZERO. THE MEASURE
CARRIES AB ONE OH FIVE SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEM MOTION BY PAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB ONE OF
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
MITCHELL FIVE MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NOVELL. WELL
I CAN I YEAH I DON'T FIVE FIVE
DOLLY I GET INTO THESE- ASA.
AFTER ALSO I HER DAUGHTER BY
HER TOTAL AYE LEYVA HI LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE. REQUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ NO MONEY HI
MONEY NINE MORE LOCK. MORE LOOK
NO MORALE. AROUND THE OIL PAN
PAN AYE ROTH. AYE SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN IN IOWA KASKI
HI BECAUSE HE ON. WITH THE
DALAI WOULD BE RECOGNIZED FOR.
YES WE'RE ON ONE OH FIVE SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEM I MEAN NO.
DOLLINGER. THIRTEEN EYES NO
FIVE. THE MOTION CARRIES A
FINAL BILL FOR THE EVENING AB
ONE NIGHT OF MOVED TO THE STATE
EMPLOYMENT STATE BARGAINING
UNIT AS IDENTIFIED ON THE
AGENDA WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
PAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB ONE
NINETEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATORS MITCHELL BY MITCHELL
AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN NOBEL WELL
I HAVE A AT ALL BY KABITA AYE
DOLLY SO THE ONLY KNOWN- ALSO-
ALSO I HER TOTAL HI FOR TOTAL
AYE LEYVA. AYE LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. WHERE I AM THE LINDA.
MELINDA'S NO MY- HI MONEY I'M
MORE LOCK. MORE LOOKING MORALE.
MORALE NO PAN HI CAN I ROTH
ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI.
MAKOVSKY I. IT'S A THIRTEEN
EYES FIVE NOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE MOTION CARRIES. LIKE
TO THANKS- EXTENDED THANKS TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY AS WELL AS THE MEMBERS OF
THE PART OF FINANCE IN LA WHO
TESTIFIED WHICH EARLIER IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN THE WRITING TO
THE BUDGET SUB TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
THIS EVENING THE SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE STANDS
ADJOURNED.